ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERONE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BARRICADE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO
BURKE CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI
CANSON TO. COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE WE MOAN. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE JEAN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN RIVER PETTY OSHA OR
NEXT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. THE
EVENTS OF THIS YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY HAVE CHANGED THE WORLD.
HEARTBREAKING ACT OF SELFISH
ARROGANCE HAVE MOVED ME TO
DESPAIR. BY COUNTLESS ACTS OF
HUMAN KINDNESS AND CARING
CONTINUE TO RESTORE MY WHOLE.
WHEN THE WHOLE WORLD FACES A
PANDEMIC OUR WISDOM OUR EYES
OPEN TO SEE THAT THERE ARE NO
BORDERS. WE ARE ALL A PART OF
ONE HUMANITY. WE NEED TO
PROTECT EACH OTHER. TO HELP
EACH OTHER AND TO CARE. MY
HUSBAND BOB AND I OFTEN SHARED
WITH TEENAGERS R. ONE GUARANTEE
IN LIFE. IT IS THIS. IF WE LIVE
SELFISHLY SL CENTER WE WILL
FAIL AND EVERY LOVE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE WILL EVER
HAVE. WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR ONE
GUARANTEED TO THIS. IF WE LIVED
SELFISHLY AND SELF CENTERED. IF
WE LIVE WITHOUT CARING AND
KINDNESS WE WILL LOSE OUR
HUMANITY. ALTHOUGH WE CLOSE THE
ASSEMBLY SESSIONS FOR THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY. THERE IS STILL
MUCH TO DO. MUCH WE MUST ENDURE
AND OVERCOME. AMERICA IS STILL
AN AMAZING DREAM IN PROGRESS.
BOB AND I KNOW THAT FOR TO
JAPANESE AMERICAN BUDDHIST
CLERGY TO SERVE AS THE
CHAPLAINS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY. IT'S TESTIMONY
THAT THIS AMAZING DREAM
CONTINUES TO UNFOLD. LET US ALL
CONTINUE TO BE CARETAKERS A BAD
DREAM. WITH WITH THEM EYES OPEN
WE SEE THAT EVERY MOMENT OF
LIFE IS WORTH ITS WEIGHT IN
GOLD. NAMAMI DOUBLE THE WHAT
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AS SHE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
KALRA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
STATE. YEAH A LITTLE. ALL THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S THIS SERVER
SACRAMENTO JUNE ELEVENTH TWO
TWENTY CINEMA NINETY ONLY
AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE THE SIMPLY BECAUSE
CHEAPER TO AT THE ASSISTING
DAVID ON THE READING THE CALLED
ASSUME MEMBER WHICH MOVE THE
COURT THE SIM MOTION TIME NOT
OF IBM SUPPORT HIM DIRECT SO OF
AN ARM'S ADORE MR CALL MOVES
AND MISS SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE. DISPENSED
PRESENTATION SEVENTY THERE ARE
NONE ENTERED AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR ILLNESS IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
FOR MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM FRAZIER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANDY VOEPEL.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY ALLOWS THE SPEAKER TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS PATTERSON MAYES FLOOR
AND ALONE. TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX D. THE ONE DAY WAIT. FOR
AMENDED BILLS TO ALLOW FOR
MANAGERS TO TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY THREE SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE HILL. ITEM FIFTY EIGHT S.
B. TWO SEVENTY FIVE PAN ITEM
SIXTY TWO SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
SKINNER AND OUT OF SIXTY THREE
SB EIGHT OH THREE BELL. MR
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR THE
MISSPEAK REPORTING INSTANCE
ENOUGH FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
MISTER FLORA IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT MISTER
CALDERON MOVES. AND MR BONTA
SECONDS. ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. A
MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN I. MR FLOOR AS ASKING FOR NO.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES ON
THE SUSPENSION OF THE RULES.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. AND MISS WALDRON
AND MR FLOOR ASKING FOR NO.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL. CALVET EYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS ELEVEN THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY ROLLS NINETY SIX SIXTY
THREE TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
IN ORDER THEM TO THIRD READING
FILED A LAWSUIT REMEMBER TEAM
TO TAKE THEM UP TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE FILE. THOSE BILLS ARE
SB ONE FIFTEEN SENATE BUDGET SB
EIGHT FIFTEEN SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE SB A
TWENTY SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE SB A TWENTY
TWO SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
SB TWENTY FOUR SB TWENTY SEVEN
SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE AND SB
THIRTY TWO. ALL SENATE BUDGET
OFFICE CURFEW COMMITTEE MISTER
FLORES ARE WE OBJECT WITHIN
THEIR WITH WILLIAMS CONSENT
THAT'S ROLL CALL VOTE MISTER
FLORA IS WITHHOLDING MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR BONTA
SECONDS. ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. CALDERON CHASSIS FOR
RIVAL MISTER FLORA NO THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. MISTER CALDERON
TESTING PER NINE MISTER FLORA
NO. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FORTY FIVE NOTES
ELEVEN. THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS VIA PLEASE HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. YEAH. ONE MISTER
CALDERON YOU WERE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS SOON TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO. I REFRAIN THE
FOLLOWING BILL THE COMMITTEE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO WHICH I
JUST SAID. AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
SANTIAGO TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE NOW MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M GONNA MISS
THIS I MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO ME
TODAY AND ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
UPON CALL THE CHAIR TO HEAR THE
FOLLOWING BILLS SB FIFTY ONE
RAZA. AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX AM
THIAGO IN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. NOW MEMBERS I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM OR
TAKE YOUR SEATS I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON WE ARE AT
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MISTER
PATTERSON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS-
AS YOU CAN SEE- REVEREND PADDY
AND REVEREND BOB ARE HERE. AND
I WOULD DOUBT ASK FOR YOU TO
JOIN IN. REMEMBERING CHARLES
HIROSHI EITHER. EDYTA PATTY'S
DAD PASSED AWAY. AND WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY TODAY
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE ALL HERE AND THAT THAT
PATTY AND BOB COULD. WATCH C.
N. HERE- HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE. THE LEGACY OF YOUR
DAD. AB BORN SEPTEMBER FIRST.
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO. HE
REMAINED A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
THE FRESNO AREA AND ONLY
LEAVING WHEN PEOPLE OF JET A
JAPANESE ENTRUST ANCESTRY. WERE
INCARCERATED DURING WORLD WAR
TWO. AND FROM THOSE NOTORIOUS
CAMPS. ONE IN JEROME ARKANSAS.
CHARLES WAS DRAFTED INTO THE
UNITED STATES ARMY. AND HE
SERVED IN FRANCE AND GERMANY.
AFTER THE WAR HE WAS HONORABLY
DISCHARGED RETURNED TO SETTLE
WITH HIS PARENTS AND FOUR
SIBLINGS IN FOWLER CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WAS HERE AMONG THE
GRAPEVINES THAT HE MET THE GIRL
THAT WOULD BECOME HIS WIFE JEAN
GATHER THEY WOULD HAVE THREE
CHILDREN WHILE ATTENDING
GRAPEVINES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE FAMILY FOR OVER. SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS. HE LOST HIS WIFE
AND HIS BEST FRIEND OF FIFTY
ONE YEARS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. ALTHOUGH HIS FAMILY
CONVINCED HIM I SUSPECT
RELUCTANTLY TO STEP DOWN FROM
THE TRACTOR AT AGE EIGHTY. HE
NEVER STOPPED PLANTING SEEDS IN
THE HEARTS OF HIS FAMILY. MOST
IMPORTANTLY HE TAUGHT THEM HOW
TO LIVE ALWAYS DOING THE VERY
BEST THAT THEY COULD. HE WAS AN
UNASSUMING MAN WHOSE QUIET
PRIDE WAS ALWAYS IN HIS FAMILY.
HE LEAVES BEHIND THREE CHILDREN
REVENUE PATTY HER HUSBAND
REVEREND BOB. DIE AND HE AND
HER HUSBAND DENNIS AND DR RICK
WITH HIS WIFE DR STACY EAT IT'D-
AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN DR TREVOR
AND WIFE DR ALY RESET AND GAVAN.
AND SO MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF HIS
FAMILY AND HIS LOVED ONES WOULD
YOU PLEASE JOIN ME IN. A
RECOLLECTION OF THIS LIFE WELL
LIVED AND IN MEMORY OF CHARLES
ROSHI HEATED. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISS BATTERSON.
THANK
YOU MEMBERS. AND TODAY. WE
RECOGNISE AN ESTEEMED MEMBER OF
OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL DIANE BOYER BY. MS BOY
LEVINE AS SERVICE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL FOR OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS
AND WILL RETIRE IN OCTOBER. WE
WELCOME HER FAMILY MEMBERS IN
THE GALLERY WE HAVE HER HUSBAND
HARRY SISTER PATRICIA. HER STEP
DAUGHTER ANGELA. ANGELA'S
HUSBAND JEREMY AND DAUGHTER
SKYLER HER STEP DAUGHTER JENNY
KENNEDY HER HUSBAND KEITH AND
THEIR DAUGHTER GRACE AND SON
JACK LET'S WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. FOR MORE THAN
A CENTURY. THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL HAS
ASSISTED THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR BY PROVIDING
NONPARTISAN LEGAL SERVICES
RELATING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. SO MUCH OF OUR WORK
HERE IN THE CAPITAL INVOLVES OR
MUST FLOW THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL AS
LEGISLATORS WE ARE MOST
FAMILIAR WITH LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL'S WORK IN DRAFTING
AMENDING BILLS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS AND RESOLUTIONS. MS
MOYER LEVINE AND HER DEPUTIES
ALSO RENDER LEGAL OPINIONS ON
ISSUES OF CONSTITUTIONALITY
STATUTORY INTERPRETATION AND
OTHER LEGAL MATTERS. SHE ALSO
OVERSEES THE LEGISLATIVE DATA
CENTER WHICH PROVIDES ESSENTIAL
TECHNOLOGICAL SERVICES TO BOTH
HOUSES HER STAFF ENSURES THE
SECURITY AND ACCURACY OF OUR
ELECTRONIC VOTING SYSTEM HERE
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. TO PAY
TRIBUTE TO MISS BOYER BY WE
WILL BEGIN WITH A SHORT VIDEO.
AND THEN HEAR REMARKS FROM
SELECTED MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
PLAY THE VIDEO. TODAY I HAVE
THE DISTINCT PLEASURE OF TAKING
UP THIS RESOLUTION TO DESIGNATE
MS DIANE BOY YOU'RE FINE. AS
THE FIRST WOMAN LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
NINETEEN YEAR HISTORY OF THIS
OFFICE. THIS WILL BE THE TENTH
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL SHE'S TRULY
A QUALIFIED SHE'S BEEN IN THAT
OFFICE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WE BELIEVE THAT SHE'S
GOING TO TRY TO HELP TAKE THIS
ASSEMBLY INTO. THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. FOR THE OFFICE OF
ELECTOR FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES PLEASE REPEAT AFTER ME.
IT IS. TO INTRODUCE TO YOU. THE
FIRST WOMAN LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
THAT WE DIE AND MORE YOU.
WE
WILL NOW RECOGNIZE MEMBERS TO
SPEAK. MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'VE ALREADY
TEXTED HER WESTERN ASKING WHAT
THE HELL HE WAS WEARING AN
ASSET VIDEO ALL RIGHT USUALLY
WHEN DIANE AND I TALKED IT'S
UNDER ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
AND WE'RE THE ONLY ONES IN THE
ROOM SO IT'S UNUSUAL TO TALK-
TO HER TO SEE HER WITH OTHER
FOLKS IN THE ROOM. BUT I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE HER ON HER
RETIREMENT SHE HAS GIVEN SO
MANY YEARS TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO MUCH SACRIFICE
AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE HER
FAMILY WHO I KNOW HAS BORNE THE
BRUNT OF A LOT OF THAT
SACRIFICE IN TERMS OF TIME AWAY
FROM. AWAY FROM FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES I'M GLAD TO KNOW
THAT SHE'S GOING TO SPEND- THEN
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS WITH
YOUR FAMILY AND WITH ALL THE
ACTIVITIES THAT SHE- CHERISHES
THERE ARE A LOT OF IMPORTANT
THINGS- THE WIN ACROSS DIANE'S
DESK OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
DECADES INCLUDING THE TIME-
BEFORE I CAME INTO OFFICE. BUT
JUST IN THE CURRENT SESSION-
DI<c.cyan> I HAD TO DEAL WITH MUCH</c>
MORE THAN JUST PROVIDING
LANGUAGE FOR LEGISLATION WE
WORK TOGETHER TO HELP ESTABLISH
THE WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT AND
THAT'S I THINK WHERE WE
PROBABLY SPENT THE MOST TIME
TOGETHER INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND HELPING TO CHANGE
THIS- INSTITUTIONS CULTURE HER
INPUT WAS INCREDIBLY CRITICAL
ON THAT AND AROUND SO MANY OF
THE ISSUES- DURING THAT TIME.
MORE RECENTLY WE HAD TO TACKLE
THE WAY IN WHICH WE GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE THE CURRENT PANDEMIC
MADE AS USUAL IMPOSSIBLE FOR
HER ARE FLEX AND HER GUIDANCE
HAVE BEEN NEEDED RIGHT UP UNTIL
THIS VERY WEEK- WHEN SICKNESS
CONTINUE TO THROW US CURVEBALLS
AS AN INSTITUTION. TODAY WE
THANK DIçN FOR ALL THOSE
YEARS OF LEGAL COUNSEL WHICH
SHE HAS BEEN- WHICH SHE'S BEEN
SCRUPULOUS ABOUT GIVING. AND A
NONPARTISAN WAY. EVEN THOUGH
THERE WERE TIMES WHEN BOTH SAY
PROBABLY WISH THAT SHE WOULD BE
PARTISAN- WE'RE IN A CHAMBER IN
WHICH PUBLIC SERVICE IS THE
UNDERLYING PRINCIPLE AND DIANE
BEUERLEIN HAS BEEN A MODEL. OF
PUBLIC SERVICE SO THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK AND CONGRATULATIONS.
AND MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN THE FEW WORDS THAT I
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT MS BOYER
VINES INCREDIBLE RECORD OF
SERVICE IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE
TO SUM UP ALL THAT SHE IS MEANT
TO THIS BODY AND TO OUR STATE.
AS THE FIRST WOMAN TO SERVE AS
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL DIANNE HAS
BEEN A TRAILBLAZER AND A ROLE
MODEL FOR ALL OF US DIANNE HAS
OVERSEEN THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL AN LDC
WHILE SERVING ON MULTIPLE LAW
COMMISSION'S LECTURING AROUND
THE WORLD AND HOLDING AN
ADJUNCT PROFESSORSHIP AT THE
MAJORITY SCHOOL OF LAW. DIANNE
PENNA MICE'S GRACE UNDER
PRESSURE JUGGLING ALL THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND MORE WITH
CLASS KINDNESS IN THE UPMOST
PROFESSIONALISM. UNDER DIANNE
STEWARDSHIP THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL HAS LIVED
UP TO ITS MISSION TO PROVIDE
NONPARTISAN CONFIDENTIAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE LEGISLATURE.
PERHAPS HER GREATEST LEGACY
WILL BE THE SCORES OF YOUNG
ATTORNEYS THAT SHE HAS MENTORED
AND MOLDED THROUGH EACH OF THEM
DIANE'S PUBLIC SERVICE WILL BE
CARRIED FORWARD DIANNE WE OFFER
YOU OUR GRATITUDE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON AN
INCREDIBLE CAREER THANK YOU.
AND MR COOLEY YOU TOO ARE
RECOGNIZED. I AND IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE HERE ON THIS DAY I GUESS
I WANT TO TURN AROUND SO I HAVE
TO LOOK AT YOU. TO RECOGNIZE
YOU FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTION
DESTITUTION. YOU KNOW DIANA
DIRE OF A SIMILAR ERROR WE AND
THREE WE'RE GOING TO THE BAR IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES. YES
CERTAINLY YOU UNDERTAKE THAT
WITH THE VISION OF JUSTICE. AND
OF. CONTRIBUTING TO THE VERY
FABRIC OF SOCIETY THAT IS WHAT
IMPELS PEOPLE GO TO LAW SCHOOL.
AND IF YOU'RE YOU FOUND
YOURSELF IN THE INSTITUTIONAL
LEGISLATURE. WHERE YOU ACTUALLY
HAD A DIRECT HAND IN THAT. AND
I WILL SEE IT IN THE FALL OF
BILLS AND AMENDMENTS AND-
EVERYTHING THAT GETS PLOWED
THROUGH HERE BUT DIANA'S BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE COMMISSION
ON UNIFORMS ST LOS. SO IF WE
YOU LAW AS A FOUNDATION OF
SOCIETY THAT SHE HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CALIFORNIA IS.
VERY FOUNDATIONS SHE HAS BEEN A
NATIONAL LEADER IN THAT. AND IN
DELIBERATION AND CARE AND
MODELING THOUGHTFUL DEVELOPMENT
ALONG TO KEEP TRACK OF THE
TIMES. I LAUGH TO HEAR SPEAKER
HERB WESSON TALK ABOUT. THE
HOPE THAT- MORE VINYL TAKE THE
ASSEMBLY INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ARE HIS AMBITIONS WERE
NOT WIDE ENOUGH SHE WAS
ACTUALLY VERY INSTRUMENTAL
BECAUSE OF THE TECHNOLOGY PIECE
ALLEGED COUNCIL OF GETTING US
THROUGH THE TRANSITION OF Y.
TWO K. WILL REMEMBER ALL THE
AGITATIONS RATHER THAT. SHE WAS
A PART OF MOVING THE
LEGISLATURE ACROSS THAT
BOUNDARY IN HER PROFESSIONAL
CAREER WHEN I STARTED WE HAD
IBM SELECTRIC SO NOW WE HAVE SO
MUCH TECHNOLOGY. THAT WORKS TO
SUPPORT THIS PROCESS WE ARE
SEEING AMERICAN DEMOCRACY THIS
DELIBERATE OF DEMOCRACY UNDER
STRESS AT THIS MOMENT. AS
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFICULTY ARRIVING
AT COMMON UNDERSTANDINGS. AND
SO THIS ROLE OF TECHNOLOGY. IN
THE SUPPORT OF OUR LAW MAKING
IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL. AND THEN
OF COURSE SHE HAS BEEN MY GREAT
PARTNER ON THE ANNEX PROJECT.
AND FROM THE BEGINNING WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT WHEN THIS
BUILDING WAS COMPLETED IN THE
EIGHTIES. THERE WERE FRICTIONS
BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES OF
RELATED TO JUST A FAIR. TAKE
ACCOUNT OF EACH OTHER'S YOU AND
WORK TOGETHER AND DIANNE IN
ADDITION TO THE LAW AND THE
CONTRACTING AND PUBLICIDADE OF
OUTSTANDING LEGAL TALENT TO
SUPPORT OUR BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT. HAS BEEN
INDISPENSABLE PARTNER AND JUST
KIND OF HELPING KEEP THE LINES
OF COMMUNICATION GOING. SO
LONG. BUT JUST A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF PEOPLE. IN
THIS PERFECT CORPORATE THE
STATE CAPITAL HAS MADE HER JUST
AN INDISPENSABLE PARTNER. SO
DIANA'S YOU UNDERTAKE THIS WELL
DESERVED CHANGE OF LIFE. IT IS
A GREAT HONOR TO HAVE SERVED
WITH YOU TO SEE THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE AND I GUESS MY LAST
MESSAGE POINT. SHE IS SUPPORT
THE WORKABLE OVERSIGHT BOTH IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
OVERSIGHT GUIDE. WITH HER STAFF.
BY THE NINETEEN NINETIES WE HAD
A VERY SERIOUS DEVELOPMENT
INVOLVING AN INSURANCE COVER
FOR THE LEAD TO EXTENSIVE
HEARINGS. AND I AM MORE OF MINE
IN HER ROLE AS CHIEF COUNSEL AS
A DEPUTY PROVIDING GREAT
SUPPORT FOR THAT. AND IT'S AN
AUDIBLE FACTOID BY ACTUALLY NO
TWELVE NINE TWENTY ONE OF THE
INSURANCE CODE. WAS A PROVISION
DEALING WITH THE OFFICES FIRST
COMMERCIAL WHICH STOOD
UNCHANGED FOR MORE THAN A
CENTURY. UNTIL UNDER HER
ADMINISTRATION WE NEEDED TO
TAKE THAT BECAUSE OF LESSONS
LEARNED WHICH IS A LARGE PART
OF YOUR WORKERS SO MANY FRONTS.
SO IN ORDER TO. SEE YOU HERE
WITH YOUR FAMILY OR HUSBAND.
AND TO COMMEND YOU ON A GREAT
WORKER SERVICE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR COOLEY I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE MS LIMóN FROM MR
GLORIOUS DESK IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THIS IS MISTER
CHAMBER. CORRECTION FROM MY
DESK IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
MS THE MOMENT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE WHEN THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I AM HONORED TO HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
OUR OUTGOING LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL MISSED I AM BOY LEVINE
FOR HER YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE
TO OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY. AS
OUR STATE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
DIANNE HAS NOT HESITATED TO
TAKE ON HARD ISSUES. INCLUDING
ONE THAT'S BEEN VERY IMPORTANT
AND MEANINGFUL TO THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. AMONG THE MANY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY LEGAL ISSUES
OVER THE YEARS THE MOST RECENT
IS THE CREATION OF THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT WITHIN
THE OFFICE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL. EATING AN AVENUE FOR
ALL IN THIS BUILDING AND
OUTSIDE TO COME FORWARD WITHOUT
FEAR OF RETALIATION. THEY AND
DIANE'S EFFORTS AND COMMITMENT
TO THE LEGISLATURE LEAVE A LONG
LASTING IMPACT WITHIN OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. SHE HAS
WORKS TO BE AN ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN HELPING THEM ADVANCE IN
THEIR CAREERS. AND AS A
PARTICIPANT AND SUPPORTER OF
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA DIANNE
HAS SERVED AS A MENTOR TO WOMEN
MOTIVATING AND INSPIRE THEM TO
RETIRE ASPIRATIONS AND HAVE
KNOWLEDGE COMPETENCE AND THE
CONNECTIONS TO ACT TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING AND THANKING
DIANE WHERE VYING FOR HER
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE AND DYNAMIC LEADERSHIP
AS OUR STATE'S FIRST WOMAN TO
SERVE AS LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
AND HOPEFULLY NOT THE LAST.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
MEMENTOS FOR EXAMPLE YOUR VINE
BUT BEFORE WE PRESENT THEM TO
HER I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MISS DIANE BOYER VYING FOR YOUR
REMARKS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M GONNA TRY TO DO THIS
WITHOUT GETTING EMOTIONAL
THOUGH IF MY DAUGHTER IS
WATCHING SHE DOESN'T THINK
THAT'S POSSIBLE FOR ME TO DO
THAT. AND SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT VERY SWEET SENDOFF
OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO I
STARTED IN THIS BULDING AS AN
INTERN AND THEN SENATOR ROBERT
PRESLEY'S OFFICE- AND IT LED TO
A CAREER AS A LEGISLATIVE
LAWYER WHICH TO BE HONEST IS
THE BEST CAREER I THINK ANY
LAWYER CAN HAVE. FOR THE LAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS I'VE EVER SEEN
IN THE OFFICE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL WITH THE PROFESSIONAL
STAFF WHO STRIVE EVERY DAY. TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE BEST
CLIENT IN CUSTOMER SERVICE. I
COULDN'T BE PROUDER OF THE
STAFF. OF THE OFFICE AND THE
WORK OF THE OFFICE. IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE THE HUNDRED
TWENTY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ALL OF YOUR
STAFF. IN MY OPINION YOU ARE
THE HARDEST WORKING PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO PROVIDE THE BEST
PUBLIC POLICY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY. IT
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
THANK MY FAMILY UP IN THE
GALLERY. AND MY FAMILY WHO'S
WATCHING REMOTELY INCLUDING MY
SON IN SAN FRANCISCO AND MY
DAUGHTER AND HER HUSBAND IN
TORONTO. AND IF THEIR LOVE AND
SUPPORT THAT ALLOWED ME TO.
STAY TILL THREE IN THE MORNING
MANY NIGHTS IN A ROW IN THIS
BUILDING SO I THANK THEM BUT I
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST OF LUCK
GOING INTO THE NEXT SESSION AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE LOVELY
SEND OFF.
IN APPRECIATION OF
HER SERVICE WE HAVE SEVERAL
MEMENTOS FOR MISS BOYER VINE
THE SPEAKER REPUBLICAN LEADER
WALDRON ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMONT WILL
PRESENT THEM NOW IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. NO WHERE YOU KNOW
YOU SERVE BOTH HOUSES- BUT WE
KNOW WHERE YOUR FAVORITE- I
WOULD CATCH YOU SEVERAL
MEMENTOS. WAS UP ALL NIGHT
MAKING THIS FOR YOU.
WE ALSO
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL CRYSTAL GAVEL.
IT'S A VERY HEAVY SO.
AND ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY WE HAVE A RECOGNITION
FOR YOU AND WE WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT BOTH HOUSES ARE THINKING
OF YOU AND YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY. YEAH.
I THINK IT IS VERY FITTING
THAT. ARE LISTED COUNCIL SHOULD
HAVE A LISTING COUNCIL
RESOLUTION. DRAFTED THE REPAIR
AND OF COURSE THIS IS
REPRESENTS A PROTEIN AMERICANS
SERVICES PICKERINGTON AND OF
COURSE ALL THE REST OF US. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
OPERATE SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETEEN AND SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. ALL THE
HAVEN'T READ AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO START AT THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. THIS IS SENATE-TV
THIRD. THE SENATE THIRD READING.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
MISSED LIMóN TAKE HER ITEMS UP
IN THE WELL OF THE ASSEMBLY
THIS IS SENATE THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX S. B. NINE
FIFTEEN CORPORATE. SENATE BILL
NINE FIFTEEN BY CENTER LIVE ON
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO MOBILE
HOMES. MISSOULA MONT. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERSSB NINE
FIFTEEN WOULD CREATE A
PROTECTIVE PROCESS FOR MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY COVERED NINETEEN BY
PREVENTING THE MANAGEMENT OF.
MOBILE HOME PARKS FOR
TERMINATING OR ATTEMPTING TO
TERMINATE THE TENANCY AFFECTED
RESIDENTS. THERE CALIFORNIA
STATE FIRES ASSOCIATION HAS
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION HAVE
REGISTERED THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE FIFTEEN. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS LAMONTAGNE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
RIGHT NOW. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
MISTER MOM WAS THE
CALL MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE WITHOUT OBJECTION TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX. THIS IS FILE
ITEM. SIXTY SIX. SB NINE AWAIT
FOR THE CORPORATION SENATE BILL
NINE AWAIT BY CENTER RAKOWSKI
INOCULATING THE DEBT COLLECTORS.
MS LIMóN YOU MAY GET OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
NINE OH EIGHT WHICH DOES
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA USED
TO DO AND SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
TO REINSTITUTE A LONG TIME AGO
LICENSE AND LICENSE THE DEBT
COLLECTION AND DEBT BUYING
INDUSTRIES WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD CONSUMER LAWS ON THE BOOKS
REQUIRING FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. THESE LAWS DO LITTLE TO
STEM THE BAD BEHAVIOR THEY
PROHIBIT IMPORTANTLY THE AUTHOR
HAS WORKED REALLY HARDALL YEAR
WITH THAT COLLECTED AGENCIES
AND DEBT BUYING INDUSTRIES AND
CAN SAY TO YOU THAT THESE
INDUSTRIES ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE OH EIGHT SB NINE OH IT
WILL ADD TO. THE CALIFORNIA TO
THE LIST OF THIRTY FIVE OTHER
STATES THAT REQUIRE A LICENSE%
IN ORDER TO COLLECT ON CONSUMER
DEBT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MOM.
SAYING NOTICE KASHER TO BET ON
THE ITEM CORPORAL. SACRAMENTO
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT.
ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. BURKE
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN S. B. TEN
FORTY NINE. CORKERY SENATE BILL
TEN FORTY NINE BY CENTER GLAZER
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MS BARRICADE AND-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
MORNING SAM PRESENTING SB TEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATORS STEVE
GLAZER WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE CITY AND COUNTY TO PROPOSED
TO IMPOSE A FINE OF UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR A
VIOLATION OF SHORT TERM RENTAL
ORDINANCE CURRENTLY THE MAXIMUM
FINE IS ONLY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THEIR SHORT TERM
RENTALS OFFER A WAY TO IMPROVE
TOURISM AND EARNED OWNERS EXTRA
MONEY THERE DEFINITELY BEEN
SOME BAD ACTORS ON THE PLATFORM
IN THE LAST HALF OF TWENTY
NINETEEN FORTY TWO PEOPLE WERE
SHOT INSIDE OR JUST OUTSIDE A
SHORT TERM RENTAL PROPERTY
NATIONWIDE. IN SEVENTEEN PEOPLE
DIED PERHAPS THE WORST OF THESE
TRAGEDIES OCCURRED IN MY
HOMETOWN OF ORINDA WHERE FIVE
PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN A TRAGIC
EVENT AT A SHORT TERM RENTAL.
SB TEN FORTY NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO GIVE CITIES
AND COUNTIES THE POWER TO
ENFORCE THEIR LAWS IN A WAY BIG
WILL GET THE ATTENTION OF THOSE
WHO ABUSE THE RIGHT TO RENT OUT
THEIR HOME IN THIS WAY. THIS
BILL IS THE RIGHT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK IS BACKING
HIM SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE- CORPORAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ALL TIED UP
HIGHS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX COVERAGE SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX BY CENTER-
BERGEN ACTIVATING THE CIVIL
PROCEDURE IN DECLARING HERE TO
SEE THE ROPES TECHNIC MEDIALLY.
MS REYES. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS BEFORE PRESENT
THIS BILL I WANT TO THANK THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR UMBERG. AND I WNT
TO THANK THE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
AND OF COURSE THE CO SPONSORS
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL.
TODAY I AM PRESENTING SB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX WHICH WILL ADAPT TO
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM THAT'LL
SOME OF THE MOST IMMEDIATE
COURT RELATED PROBLEMS. CAUSED
BY THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND SIMULTANEOUSLY BRING THE
COURTS CLOSER TO ADAPTING TO
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY TECHNOLOGY.
DUE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA COURTS HAVE
EITHER STALLED ALL SERVICE TO
CIVIL CASES. OR ARE OPERATING
AT A MINIMUM LEVEL IN THE FACE
OF THIS BACKLOG COURTS COURT
LEADERS ARE ANNOUNCING THEIR
INTENT TO DELAY MANY CIVIL
CASES. CALIFORNIA COURTS ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND A WAY TO
OPERATE THIS PANDEMIC AND MOST
BETTER UTILIZE TECHNOLOGY. IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THIS
ADAPTATION THE COURTS HAVE. BY
THE COURTS UGH CENTER AMBERG
HAS INTRODUCED LANGUAGE IN SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR REMOTE DEPOSITIONS
AND ELECTRONIC SERVICE BY
ESSENTIALLY. CODIFYING AND
FULLER FIND THE CALIFORNIA
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S EMERGENCY
RULES ELEVEN AND TWELVE AND
MAKING THOSE RULES PROMINENT.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
REYES SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. THESE ARE VITAL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. YEAH.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY AS FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THAT
BILL PASSES WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE. PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS FIFTY AND. FIFTY ONE. AS
WELL AS. FIFTY TWO. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE. AND. FIFTY
FOUR. WEARE ALSO GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE IN A FIFTY
FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIX MISTER DAVID CHIU. OUR.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SIX S. B. TEN THIRTY CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AN
ACCOLADE HOUSING IN MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR DECLARING THE
ZERO TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
MISTER DAVID CHIU. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER POLITICS IS THE
ANNUAL HOUSING OMNIBUS BILL
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
AND NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES
TO HOUSING STATUTE EVERY
PROVISION IN THIS BILL HAS BEEN
VETTED BY AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF
STAKEHOLDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE AND REQUEST.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE. THANK YOU MISTER XUSEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ADAM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CARAMON ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS TAKES
FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE CALIBER
IS FIFTY EIGHT KNOWSYOU'RE ON
THE URGENCY AS FIFTY EIGHT
NOTES HERE ON THE MEASURE. MR
CHIU PLEASE- CONFER WITH MISTER
CALDERON ON THE IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. REQUEST.
BEVERAGE
WE AND FILE ORDER ARE AT FILE
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN SENATE BILL.
ONE EIGHTY TWO. THIS IS DOCTOR
WOULD PARK OPERATIONS SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY TWO BY SENATE
JACKSON AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. DR WOULD
YOU MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
TO A BILL THAT ESTABLISHES
STATE FIRE STATEWIDE WILDFIRE
RISK RISK REDUCTION STANDARDS
FOR NEW DEVELOPMENTS APPROVED
IN OUR MOST FIRE PRONE REGIONS.
THE BILL DIRECTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONDITION NEW
DEVELOPMENTS ON IN OUR VERY
HIGH FIRE AREAS ON NEW
STANDARDS TO BE PROMULGATED BY
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
NEW STANDARDS WILL REQUIRE
DEVELOPERS TO DESIGN
COMMUNITIES AND FIRE SAFE
LAYOUTS HARD NEW CONSTRUCTION
WITH THE TECHNIQUES AND
MATERIALS KNOWN TO PREVENT FIRE
LOSS IN DESIGN SUPPORTING ROAD
AND WATER INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENSURE THE COMMUNITIES THAT CAN
ACCOMMODATE A ROBUST FIRE
RESPONSE WAS SAFELY EVACUATED
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE BILL ALSO
DIRECTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEVELOP RETROFIT PLANS FOR
EXISTING COMMUNITIES IN VERY
HIGH FIRES AT HAZARD ZONES AND
UNDER THIS BILL ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS IN THEIR
JURISDICTION WILL BE REQUIRED
TO UPDATE THE SAFETY AND
HOUSING ELEMENTS OF THE GENERAL
PLANS. TO INCLUDE COMMUNITY
SAFETY HOME HARDENING SAFE
CITING AND FIRE RESPONSIBLE SO
THAT THESE PLANNING DOCUMENTS
SERVE AS A BLUEPRINT FOR LONG
TERM FIRE SAFETY. AT THIS TIME
EXTREME FIRE RESTAURANT OUR
STATE IT'S TIME WE ADOPT
STATEWIDE APPROACH TO THE
PROBLEM THIS MEASURE DOES SO
CALM DOES SO COMPREHENSIVELY
AND RESPONSIBLY. AS A PART OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSOCIATION'S ARE FIRE SAFETY
COMMUNITY IS NOT OPPOSED BY
HOME BUILDERS AND DEVELOPERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I FIFTY
ONE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES ONE OF PASS TEMPORARILY
AND VIOLENCE FIFTY EIGHT AND.
FIFTY NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTY FIVE SIXTY SB SEVEN FORTY
ONE. CORRECT SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY ONE BY CENTER GALGIANI AN
ACCOLADE IN THE VITAL RECORDS.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MR BIGGER MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. OR PRESENTATION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE OF.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE NONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADEBAYO. WELL
CLOSE ROLL IDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS AIDS THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WHAT A PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE AND SIXTY TWO. PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR SB. EIGHT FIFTY TWO.
QUACKERY SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR PAN AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE. DR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE TWILIGHT
ZONE HERE TODAY SO- I RISE TO
PRESENT A SENATE BILL. EIGHT
FIFTY TWO. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE STATE TO CON PARTNER TO
MANUFACTURE INSULINAND OTHER
GENERIC DRUGS WITH THE INTENT
TO DESTRUCTIVE MADE WIDELY
AVAILABLE THIS POLICY IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER AS THE
COBIT NINETEEN CRISIS REVEALED
GLARING GAPS IN SUPPLIES OF
ESSENTIAL DRUGS. MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLIES WE SAW
THIS WITH PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT VENTILATORS BASIC
MEDICAL SUPPLIES LIKE SWABS IN
TUBES NECESSARY PROTESTING EVEN
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THIS BILL
WILL INCREASE COMPETITION IN
THE GENERIC PRESCRIPTION DRUG
MARKET LOWER PRICES AND ADDRESS
SHORTAGES IN THE MARKET.
SETTING UP A STRUCTURE IN WHICH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS ITS
OWN DRUG MANUFACTURING
CAPABILITY WILL ALSO HELP
PREPARE THE STATE FOR THE NEXT
PANDEMIC THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. ADDUCT WHAT THE SCENE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT EYES FIFTY
NOTES FOR. THE MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE S.
B. EIGHT SIX FIVE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY FIVE BY
CEDAR HILL AND ALKYLATING TWO
EXCAVATIONS. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HILL SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MAKES
COMMONSENSE CHANGES TO THE CALL
BEFORE YOU DIG LAW THAT WILL
STRENGTHENED SAFELY BACK
EXCAVATION PRACTICES IN OUR
STATE. DECADES OF NEGLECT AND
GROSS MISMANAGEMENT HAVE LEFT
THE STATE WITH AN UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEM THAT
TAKES FAR TOO MANY LIVES EACH
YEAR. THE DIG SAFE BOARD WAS
ESTABLISHED TO TACKLE THAT
CHALLENGE HEAD ON BY CREATING
PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE THE RISK
OF UNDERGROUND EXCAVATION.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE BOARD
BEGAN CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS
INTO DIG AND EVENTS. BUT THEY
CANNOT BE PROACTIVE IN THEIR
WORK WITHOUT THE PROPER DATA.
ROCKED OF BOARD COULD PERFORM
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS ON
EXCAVATION TICKET DATA AND USE
THOSE FINDINGS TO EFFECTIVELY
TARGET EDUCATIONAL EFFORTS.
PREVENTING DAY AGAINST DAMAGES
AND NEEDLESS LOSS IN THE
ABSENCE OF THIS DATA WE ARE
LEFT WITH THE BOARD THEY CAN
ONLY REACT TO THE LATEST
EXCAVATION TRAGEDY. SB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE EQUIPS THE BOARD
WITH THE TOOLS AND DATA THEY
NEED TO SUCCESSFULLY CONTINUE
THEIR VITAL WORK AND IT ENSURES
THAT IN THE MIDST OF A NOISY
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT THAT
OTHERWISE RICOCHETS FROM ONE
CRISIS TO THE NEXT. THE BOARD
CAN MAINTAIN THEIR SINGULAR
MISSION OF UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY THIS BILL
ALSOREQUIRES OPERATORS TO MAP
NEW SUB SERVICE INSTALLATIONS
pDIG SAFE BOARD TO AN OFFICE
THAT HOLY ALIGNS WITH THEIR
MISSION THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. SB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE HASN'T
RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES IN THE
SENATE FOR THE ASSEMBLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN C. NOTIFICATION
OF A PURPLE OPENER ALL. SORRY
BOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE ROLL
CALL VOTE AYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE
DISPENSE OF FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
THIS IS FILE ITEM. SIXTY SEVEN.
SB TEN SIXTY FOUR CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACCOLADE IN
THE PRISONS MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
STATE LAW PROHIBITS THE USE OF
UNCORROBORATED TESTIMONY DURING
CRIMINAL TRIALS AND BARS
CONVICTIONS BASED ON
UNCORROBORATED INFORMATION FROM
IN CUSTODY INFORMANTS. HOWEVER
UNCORROBORATED INFORMATION BY
INCARCERATED INFORMANT IS
CURRENTLY USED AND ENTERED INTO
CONFIDENTIAL PRISON FILES WHICH
CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT PAROLE
HEARINGS AND JUSTIFY DISCIPLINE
BY CDCR. THE CURRENT SYSTEM
DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
ACCUSATIONS TO BE PROPERLY
DISCLOSED TO THE ACCUSED
INDIVIDUAL. SB TEN SIXTY FOUR
APPLIES THE SAME PRINCIPLES TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS BY
PROVIDING DUE PROCESS AND
PROCEDURES FOR USE OF
INFORMATION GATHERED BY CDC
SPECIFICALLY SB TEN SIXTY FOUR
TIGHTENS THE RELIABILITY
COMPONENT TO CITIES YOU ARE
ALREADY HAS IN PLACE. PROHIBITS
CDC ARE AND THE PAROLE BOARD
FOR MAKING DECISION ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS BASED ON
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT
CORROBORATED NOR RELIABLE. AND
REQUIRES IF CDCR OR BPH USED TO
USE A CONFERENCE INFORMATION
THEIR QUEUES INDIVIDUAL AND
THEIR ATTORNEY MUST RECEIVE A
SUMMARY NOTICE INCLUDING THE
DESCRIPTION DATE LOCATION AND
MORE OF THE PROPOSED CLAIM
PROVIDED BY A CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANT. THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
CONCERT CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS
IDENTITY. THE MOST RECENT
MEMBERS ADDRESS POLICY AND JUST
CONCERNS RAISED BY CDCR THE
BORDER PATROL HEARINGS AND A
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
WITHOUT. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA. SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS OF THEIR
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
MISTER KALRA MOVES TO
CALL. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP DR WEBER'S ITEM FOR
WHICH WE PASS TEMPORARILY. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. S. B.
THREE SIX NINE. THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE PRISONERS DR
WEBER MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU
SENATE BILL THREE SIX NINE THE
CALIFORNIA RE ENTRY COMMISSION
MEMBERS NEARLY SEVEN MONTHS AGO
THE FIRST COVERT CASE FOUND IN
ITS WAY TO UNITED STATES AND
NOTHING HAS BEEN THE SAME SENSE
BUT WE SHOULD NOT FORGET THAT
EVEN BEFORE THIS MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE WITH
HOMELESSNESS OBTAINING HEALTH
CARE FINDING A JOB AND MAKING
ENDS MEET. BUT THESE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE ONLY BECOME
MORE OF A MORE DIRE THIS IS
SPECIALLY INCLUDES CALIFORNIA'S
RE ENTRY SOCIETY AFTER BEING
RELEASED FROM PRISON OR OR JAIL
CALIFORNIAN THAT NATION'S
LARGEST REENTRY PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE EVERY
SOCIETY SERVING THEIR TIME
COMING HOME TO COMMUNITIES HIT
HARDEST BY THIS PANDEMIC BOTH
MORE MORALLY AND FINANCIALLY.
AS A RESULT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WILL COME HOME TO
A PLACE NO SAFER THAN JAIL OR
PRISON TO WHICH THEY ARE
CONFINED THE LONG TERM IMPACT
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
COMMUNITIES AND THE ECONOMY
WILL BE DEVASTATING MEMBERS
THAT IS WHY NOW IS THE TIME TO
TAKE ACTION AND ESTABLISH A
STATEWIDE COMMISSION OF EXPERTS
COMMUNITY LEADERS TO TACKLE THE
MYRIAD OF CHALLENGES FACING OUR
STATES RE INTO POPULATION. SB
THREE SIX NINE IS A CRITICAL
INVESTMENT IN OUR IN OUR
COLLECTIVE FUTURE AT A TIME
WHEN IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
SUCCESS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BIPARTISAN MEASURE
TO ESTABLISH. A CALIFORNIA RE
ENTRY COMMISSION. THEY YOU
WEBER SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. OR CALL THE ROLL. ALL
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS HEARD A DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL THE
TIME BUT I FIFTY TWO KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN
FILE ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT. S. B. TEN EIGHTY
FIVE CORPORATE SENATE BILL TEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY SU SKINNER AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN HOUSING
MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU AS SENATE BILL NINETY TEN
EIGHTY FIVE I'M SORRY I DON'T
HAVE MY GLASSES ON IS A DENSITY
BONUS BILL BY SENATOR SKINNER
IT'S A GOOD BILL- IMPROVES THE
USABILITY OF DENSITY BONUS LAW
WHEN IT COMES TO STUDENT
HOUSING BY ALLOWING STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECTS TO CONTINUE AT
LEAST 0% OF UNITS AVAILABLE
FOR LOWER INCOME STUDENTS BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR ONE INSTEAD OF A
CONCESSION EXTENDS PARKING
WAIVERS TO QUALIFYING HOUSING
PROJECTS WITHIN HALF A MILE
TRANSIT IT'S RISKY BUT WIDE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BOTH HOUSES
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISSISSAUGAS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. OR CALL THE
ROLL. OUR MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELCOME. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TYLER HIGHS FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE SB ELEVEN ELEVEN.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL ELEVEN
ELEVEN BY SENATOR DORADO AND
AFTER LEAVING THE JUVENILES.
THIS KAMLAGER THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL ELEVEN
ELEVEN WHICH AMENDS CALIFORNIA
LAW TO PERMIT YOU TO STAY IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES. PENDING
THE OUTCOME OF THEIR JUVENILE
COURT CASE UNTIL TWENTY ONE.
THIS CREATES A THOUGHTFUL
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING WHETHER
YOUTH AGES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE WHOSE CASES ORIGINATED IN
JUVENILE COURT SHOULD BE HOUSED
IN ADULT JAILS. THIS BILL
CREATES A PRESUMPTION FOR
KEEPING IT IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND REQUIRES THAT A
JUDGE DECIDE HETHER REDUCE OUR
YOUTH MAYBE MOVED. PROVIDES
GUIDANCE FOR A JUDGE'S DECISION
CURRENT LAW ACTUALLY PROVIDES
NO STANDARDS FOR THIS DECISION.
ALLOWS YOU TO BE MOVED TO AN
ADULT JAIL IF THE JUVENILE
FACILITY CANNOT SAFELY CARE FOR
THEM OR IF THE PHYSICAL SPACE
CANNOT ACCOMMODATE AN OLDER
POPULATION. SIMPLIFIES AND
CONSOLIDATES THE RULES FOR
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF YOU. I
OFTENTIMES YOUNG FOLKS ONE FAIR
HELD IN AN ADULT JAIL THEY NO
LONGER RECEIVE EDUCATION AND
WORK FOR SERVICES OR THE AGE
APPROPRIATE PROGRAMMING
AVAILABLE IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES THEY FACE AN AG
INCREASED RISK OF PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL ABUSE AND THEY SUFFER
WITH A HEIGHTENED SENSE OF
SUICIDE AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ARE OFTEN THE SAME YOU
THEIR TRANSFERRED BACK TO THE
JUVENILE FACILITY AFTER THE
DISPOSITION OF THEIR CASES.
AFTER SUFFERING DISRUPTIONS IN
THEIR EDUCATION AND PROGRAMMING
AND EXPOSURE TO EXTREME
VIOLENCE AND GANG ACTIVITY SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN HAS NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
QUELLED CLOSE ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE AS FORTY EIGHT NO
THREE. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
CORPORATIONS SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT BY CENTER WIENER
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
HOUSING MS BURKE GOOD
AFTERNOON- MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO IT HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW REQUIRED REGARDING A CITIES
DETERMINATION OF WHERE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS ARE ALLOWED
AS PERMITTED. USE WITHOUT A
CONDITIONAL USE OUR
DISCRETIONARY PERMIT IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT TIMELY ADOPTION OF
HOUSING ELEMENT BY REQUIRING A
LOCAL JURISDICTION TO ADOPT A
LEGALLY COMPLIANT HOUSING
ELEMENT WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS OF THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE MEMBERS NEARLY 70% OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA TAKE SHELTER EVERY
NIGHT ON THE STREETS THE
STAGGERING NUMBERS NOT ONLY
SHOW OF MORAL MORAL FAILURE BY
OUR STATE BUT ALSO DEMONSTRATE
THE POWER OF COMMUNITY
OPPOSITION TO EMERGENCY
SHELTERS. EVERY CALIFORNIAN
HOUSE ARE NOT DESERVES TO BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE CRISIS IT MUST BE SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TACKLED IN EVERY
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION I ABOUT. THANKS FOR
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR KNOWS
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. SEVENTY ONE. SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX THE
CORPORATION SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX BY CENTER ARCHULETA
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
HAZARDOUS WASTE. THIS IS HE
SAYS AND SPEAKER PRO TEM. THIS
PARA QUE HAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
PRESENTING SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
THE BILL DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
IN CONSULTATION WITH RELEVANT
STATE AGENCIES LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
DTIC THE WASTE INDUSTRY AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PROPER
MANAGEMENT AT THE DISPOSAL OF
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES. THESE
PROTOCOLS WILL BE FOCUSED ON
SAFE HANDLING DETECTION AND THE
SUPPRESSION OF FIRES
ORIGINATING FROM THESE
DISCARDED BATTERIES FURTHERMORE
SB ELEVEN SIX FIFTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES RECYCLING AND
RECOVERY IN CONSULTATION WITH
DGSE TO DEVELOP A GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT TO INFORM EDUCATE AND
INCREASE PUBLIC AWARENESS
REGARDING THE FIRE RISK FROM
IMPROPER DISPOSAL OF LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES. THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT THESE BATTERIES ARE A
FIRE HAZARD AND WE MUST DO
BETTER TO STOP THE FIRES THERE
CAUSING SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX LOOKS TO ADDRESS THIS
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A
DIVERSE GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING WASTE HAULERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX. THERE
IS PARA QUE HAN C. NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB
LAUREL. THE SERVER. ALL MEMBERS
OF A DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE. HI FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ONE
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY TWO SB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. CORRECT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY CENTER DRAWS OF AN
ACCOLADE A PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
MISTER COOPER YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
WILL ENSURE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE ACCURATE
AND TIMELY BARGAINING UNIT
INFORMATION WHICH THEY ALREADY
ENTITLED TO BY LAW LET ME
FULFILL THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
BARGAINING UNIT AS A WHOLE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE LAW WILL
SIGN THAT GRANTED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS ACCESS
TO NEW HIRE CONTACT INFORMATION
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THEIR
HIRE DATE. AND SPECIFIC
BARGAINING UNIT DATA AT LEAST
EVERY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
FOR EXAMPLE CICHLIDS ACCESS TO
WORKSITE AND OTHER NECESSARY
INFORMATION REGARDING NURSES ON
THE FRONT LINES THAT CRISIS
HEALTH CARE CENTERS
FIREFIGHTERS FIGHTING WILDFIRES
ACROSS THE STATE IN TEACHERS
CURRENTLY FACING THE
UNCERTAINTY OF WHERE WHEN AND
HOW SAFETY. THEY'LL RETURN TO
WORK. DESPITE THIS SOME PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS STILL CHOOSE TO
IGNORE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OR SEEN INACCURATE
OR OUT OF DATE INFORMATION.
SINCE MOST OF THE RECENT
REPORTING DEADLINE IN MAY OVER
HUNDRED EMPLOYEE EMPLOYERS
FILLED EVEN RESPOND TO THE
BARGAINING AGENT. WITH NO
CONSEQUENCES. MANY EMPLOYERS
IGNORE OR DISREGARD THE LEGAL-OBLIGATIONS THEY HAVE BOTH
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WE'LL
MAKE SURE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES DO A
BETTER JOB THE HEARING TO LAW.
IS BELOW THIRTY THREE
ESTABLISHES ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WITH PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
CURE THE PROBLEM AND RESPOND.
AS MEASURE CREATES NO NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IS SIMPLY INCENTIVIZE
IS COMPLIANCE WITH DISSING LAW.
ARE SPIFFY ASPIRIN I VOTE.
THANKS COOPER C. NOTIFICATION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLIP OF
THE ROLE. NUMBER RESERVE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS- TO VOTE.
OKAY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT.
BURKE WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY WINDOWS
TEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. SEPARATE SENATE
BILL TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS IN
ACTIVATING HEALING ARTS. THIS
BURKE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE PERCENT SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR DODD
RECENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR WERE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
OUR TECHNICAL NATURE SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR CHILDBIRTH
BY ALLOWING CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES TO PRACTICE WITHOUT
THE PERMISSION OF A PHYSICIAN.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A WELL
DELINEATED SCOPE OF PRACTICE
FOR ALL NURSE MIDWIFE TO
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY. NO
MATTER THE CARE SETTING SB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES A
FRAMEWORK FOR PHYSICIAN NURSE
MIDWIFE COLLABORATION ON WATER
IN HIGH RISK PATIENTS THEIR
MUTUALLY AGREED UPON POLICIES
AND PROTOCOLS AS PROTOCOLS
SPELLED OUT. HOW AND UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS MIDWIVES WILL WORK
WITH PHYSICIAN PARTNERS IN THE
INTEGRATED TEAM BASED MODE AND
INDICATE WHEN THEY WILL
TRANSFER CARE. UTILIZING THESE
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS IS A
NATIONAL NURSE WIFE MS. NURSE
AND MIDWIFE STAND SET FORTH BY
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF NURSE
MIDWIVES AND IS NOT SUPERVISED.
SUPERVISION NO LONGER MAKES
SENSE IT IS NOT DEFINED IN
CALIFORNIA STATURE IT IS
DIFFICULT TO ATTAIN IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE PATIENT. PHYSICIAN
TO BE. PHYSICALLY PRESENT
EXAMINE THE PATIENT SIGN A
REVIEW ANY CHARTS OR STE
OVERSEE PATIENT CARE ANYWAY.
SUPERVISION ALSO FORCES NURSE
MIDWIVES TO CONCENTRATE IN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WHERE
PHYSICIAN. PHYSICALLY PRACTICE
THIS REDUCES ACCESS
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL COUNTIES
AND LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND ABOUT.
DAVIS BURKE MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO COMMEND THE MEMBER FROM
INGLEWOOD FOR HER TENACITY ON
THIS ISSUE AS I KNOW THAT AND
SHE HAS PERSONALLY PUT IN YEARS
OF WORK INTO THIS AS WELL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MISS BURKE
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH AFTER
FIVE YEARS OF WORK I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
ABOUT. LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL TALLY THE VOTE AS
FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE THE PREVIOUS ITEM
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. FIVE
MINUTES KAMLAGER. CARBURETOR
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
BY CENTER STERN AND ACTIVATING
ANIMALS THIS KAMLAGER. GOOD
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS HEY THAT'S
BE ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE SEEKS TO
ADDRESS. RISKS POSED TO
CALIFORNIANS BY WILDLIFE
TRAFFICKING AND TRADE AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT TO
PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND
BIODIVERSITY. LIKE SARS AND
MURDERS POSTED NINETEEN HAS
ONCE AGAIN BROUGHT ATTENTION TO
HOW ANIMALS ARE HUNTED
TRANSPORTED AND SOLD. THOUGH
THE EXACT ANIMAL PATHWAY FOR
THE HUMAN CASE THE FIRST HUMAN
CASE IS STILL BEING TO. SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE A BILL
FOCUSED ON WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING
IN TRADE PROVIDE THE TOOLS
NECESSARY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH. AND WILDLIFE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM PUT DISEASE
ANIMALS AND TO PROTECT AN
IMPERILED ANIMALS FROM
PRACTICES DETRIMENTAL TO THEIR
SPECIES. THERE ARE SOME
PROVISIONS IN STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW AND REGULATION THAT SEEKS
TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THE
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
ANIMALS. THERE ARE HOWEVER GAPS
IN THIS FRAMEWORK. IN RESPONSE
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE GIVE
CDFW AUTHORITY ON THE WRITTEN
FINDING OF THE CDFW DIRECTOR TO
PRO ACTIVELY SUSPEND THE
AUTHORIZATION TO IMPORT A WILD
ANIMAL. SHOULD THERE BE A
SCIENTIFICALLY DETERMINE LINKED
TO AN OUTBREAK LIKE COVE IT.
WHERE WILD ANIMAL TO HUMAN OR
DO NOT A TRANSMISSION IS FOUND
TO BE THE SOURCE. SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE REVAMPS CDFW THE
CONSISTING AUTHORITY TO PUBLISH
AND LIST OF ANIMALS FROM THE
STATE REQUIRES THAT ANY
POTENTIAL LIST OF BANNED WILD
ANIMALS BE DEVELOPED A
REGULATION TO ENSURE FOR PUBLIC
INPUT. AND PROCESS TRANSPARENCY.
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE ALSO
SEEKS TO PROTECT CERTAIN
AFRICAN SPECIES FROM TROPHY
HUNTING BY PROHIBITING THE
POSSESSION OF NEW TROPHIES IN
THE STATE. SOME OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER SENATOR STERN'S BILL
TWO YEARS AGO THAT WAS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR MANY OF US
SUPPORTED IT. AN AFRICAN LION
AFRICAN LIONS LIFE SHOULDN'T BE
AND IT SHOULDN'T HIM TO BE A
DECORATION ON SOMEONE'S WALL.
AND THIS BAN WOULD APPLY TO A
NUMBER OF ENDANGERED OR
THREATENED ANIMALS INCLUDING
AFRICAN ELEPHANTS LIONS RHINOS
LEOPARDS PANGOLINS BABOONS AND
CERTAIN THE BREATH. THE AUTHOR
REPEATEDLY HAS AMENDED THE BILL
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY
OPPONENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THERE WAS
KAMLAGER MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- THE
AUTHOR MAY HAVE MADE AMENDMENTS%
BUT HE STILL HASN'T DEALT WITH
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM WHICH
IS THIS BILL IS COMPLETELY
UNENFORCEABLE. AND THAT IS WHY
THE GOVERNOR PREVIOUSLY VETOED
IT. BECAUSE YOU ARE MAKING
SUBJECT TO CIVIL PENALTY THINGS
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
AUTHORIZED- BY THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT- SO THE BILL STILL
UNENFORCEABLE AND LET ME BRING
UP ANOTHER CONSTITUENCY THAT I
THINK WE SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR FISHING GAME WARDENS.
WHO ARE ALREADY COMPLETELY
OVERTAXED IN THE STATE. WE DO
NOT HAVE THEY ARE SPREAD SO
THIN. WITH ALL DIFFERENT TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES AND MEANWHILE OUR
OWN WILDLIFE. HERE IN THIS
STATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE IN NEED OF THE GREATEST
PROTECTION. IN OUR GAME WARDENS
TO HELP ENFORCE THOSE LAWS. I
RIGHT NOW IN COLUSA COUNTY I
HAVE ONE GAME WARDEN TO COVER
THAT ENTIRE COUNTY IN THAT
ENTIRE AREA IN DEALING WITH
POACHING. AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
IT DID OCCUR THERE MEANWHILE
WE'RE GOING TO NOW FOCUS ON
ICONIC AFRICAN SPECIES. HEARING
CALIFORNIAN WHILE WHILE
POACHING IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW
IN OUR BACKYARD. AND QUITE
SIMPLY THIS IS A MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLAR MANDATE ON
THEM THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MANPOWER TO ENFORCE AND TO GO
pOUT AND DO INSTEAD WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING OUR FISHING GAME
WARDEN SO THEY CAN DO THE JOB
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
FOR OUR CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE.
NOT ADDING SOME NEW MANDATE
THAT AGAIN IS COMPLETELY
UNENFORCEABLE. SO I'D ASK YOU
MEMBERS TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
THIS DON'T RESPOND TO THIS.
JUST EMOTIONALLY WE ALL
OBVIOUSLY. FEEL FOR THESE.
THESE SPECIES AS WELL WE SEE.
DIFFERENT ABUSES- BUT WE'VE GOT
OUR WILDLIFE RIGHT HERE AT HOME
THAT NEED TO BE PROTECTED. AND
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PROBLEM.
FOR OUR FISHING GAME WARDENS
WHO HAVE WHO HAVE THAT DUTY TO
PROTECT THE SPECIES THANK YOU.
IT WAS GALLAGHER. MISTER COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE BUT CURRENTLY FACING
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA PANDEMIC ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY MASSIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT HERE THEY ARE
TODAY VOTING ON A BILL WHICH
WILL IMPACT THE ECONOMY OF
NATIONS THROUGHOUT AFRICA WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A BILL TO BAN THE
USE OF COBALT WHICH IS USED AND
WHAT YOUR VEHICLES THAT LITTLE
BLACK KIDS MINE IN AFRICA BUT
THIS. I THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY
WHAT THE BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE
WET MARKET AND IF YOU DON'T
KNOW A MET WHAT MARKETS ARE
THINK ABOUT LITTLE SAIGON'S
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND
ALSO- ARE CHINATOWNS THIS BILL
IMPACT EVERYTHING FROM ASIAN
MINORITY FIRST MARKETS TO RED
LOBSTER RESTAURANTS. A FISHING
GAME CAN FORCE IT TO TALK ABOUT
WE LIVE MARKETS WHAT MARKETS
THINK ABOUT OUR API COMMUNITY
YOU GO TO CHINESE RESTAURANT IT
REGULATES THAT. THAT'S WITHIN
THE BIG ISSUE THAT WITH THIS
WAS PUT IN FOR THAT- THING OFF
FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND WHY
NOW. FISHING GAME IS OVER
BURDENED THEY HAVE FOREIGN
OFFICERS. BETTER TO PROTECT THE
STATE MOSSOS OFFICERS ARE TIED
UP DOING MARIJUANA ENFORCEMENT.
A COASTAL ENFORCEMENT STILL THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS. WHEN OFFICE
GOTTEN ACTUALLY PURSUE THIS IS
IT IS VERY LOW YOU'RE ADDING
ALL OF THAT OUT NOT ADDING
ADDITIONAL BODIES. AND REALLY
THE BIG THING I'M NOT I'M NOT A
BIG HUNTER BUT HERE YOU HAVE
COUNTRIES FROM AFRICA SAYING
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WANT THE MONEY
THE MONEY HELPS OUR PEOPLE. THE
TRICKLE DOWN ECONOMY. AND IT
JUST IT JUST ON. ME THAT THE
PEOPLE. THEY THE SIERRA CLUB
MORE WORK ABOUT HIS. THEY ARE
KIDS OVER THERE THEY'RE
HARVESTING THE COBALT BATTERIES
THAT'S A REAL ISSUE. BECAUSE
NEVER TALK ABOUT THAT THEY
DON'T CARE ABOUT LITTLE BLACK
KIDS OVER THERE. THE CARE ABOUT
THE ANIMALS. LET'S TAKE CARE OF
THOSE KIDS FIRST THEY'RE ALL
DRIVING EV'S. I'M NOT NOT BANG
ON TV'S BUT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
EV'S. IN THE COUNTRY. AND 30%
OF THE COBALT IS MINED IN THE
CONGO IN SOUTH AFRICA. SO IF
YOU WANT TO CARE ABOUT
SOMETHING CARE ABOUT THOSE KIDS
COOKING ABOUT OTHER THINGS SO
IS THERE REALLY IS A REAL NEED.
ESPECIALLY THE WET MARKETS
MILLSTONE AT LAST I WAS IN
THERE LAST YEAR TO IN THIS YEAR
ON THE WEB MARKETS. SO DO WE
HAVE TIME FOR FIFTY WATER
FISHING GAME OFFICERS GOING IN.
TO MAKING SURE THAT YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT FISH OR LOBSTER. OR
CRAB IN YOUR TANK AND RUNNING
REPORT. THAT TIES UP OFFICERS
WHO WHAT ABOUT THE FRONT LINES.
DOING WITH COASTAL POLLUTION.
WATER POLLUTION FROM CANNABIS
AND OTHER THINGS. SO I REFER
ONE DON'T WANT FISHING GAME WHO
ARE VERY SHORT RIGHT NOW. IN A
RESTAURANT I DON'T THINK THE
PUBLIC ONCE IN A RESTAURANT.
THEY HAVE HIGHER EXPECTATIONS.
SO TO ME FOR SOME REASON
FARMING LIST YOU KNOW. START
CARE ABOUT PEOPLE'S LIVES IN
HIS LIFE. AND OTHER THINGS SO-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOTE ON
THIS. THERE WAS COOPER IS
BOERNER HORVATH IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES AND
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE- IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES OF.
VOICE SOME CONCERNS BUT I HAVE
TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THE
FOCUS OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE. IS ON DISEASED ANIMALS.
NOT HEALTHY ONE. ALSO IF THE
SANCTUARY WANTS TO BRING AN
ANIMAL SUFFERING FROM A
TREATABLE. OR NON CONTAGIOUS
DISEASE. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
A LOT OF THAT. THE GOAL OF
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE IS TO SURE
INSURE THAT DISEASED ANIMALS.
DO NOT SPREAD THIS DISEASE IN
THE STATE. IT'S THAT SIMPLE
COLLEAGUES SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THERE IS
BOERNER HORVATH MISTER KALRA IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTRESS
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS- TO THE CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY. SOME FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION- THAT I WOULD ARGUE
ARE PLAYING MORE ON EMOTIONS
AND ACTUALLY THE FACTS OF WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. OF THE
SUGGESTION THAT IT WOULD CLOSE
USE OR WHILE THAT EXIT
REPARATIONS AND MAKE IMPORTING
ANIMALS IMPOSSIBLE COULD NOT BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH. IN
EXISTING LAW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THE RULES
GOVERNING THE IMPORTATION OF
WILD ANIMALS. CDFW ALREADY
EXERCISED DISCRETION WHICH WILD
ANIMALS OR AUTHORIZING THE
STATE. THE ASSOCIATION OF ZOOS
AND AQUARIUMS IS THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR ZOO ACCREDITATION
DUE TO ITS HIGH STANDARDS FOR
CONSERVATION EDUCATION
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS. EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW AND
REGULATION ALLOW CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS ARE PERMITS FOR ACA
ACCREDITED ZOOS. NON ACA
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS GOING
TO SEE TO GET OF FOR AWAY. TO
BE TREATED LIKE A CA OCCURRED
ZOOS THAT'S ANOTHER SEVEN NOT
CHANGED ANYTHING. REGARDING
THIS WAIVER PROCESS FOR NON ACA.
ACCREDITED ZOOS- THOSE NON
ACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO
OBTAIN WILD ANIMAL PERMITS.
FROM CITY OF DERBY EVEN THE
EASY IS HE A CREDIT IS AFTER%
TEN WILD ANIMAL PERMISSION CDFW
FOR CERTAIN WILD ANIMALS. UNDER
EXISTING REGULATIONS SO LONG AS
TRANSPORTATION REQUIREMENTS ARE
MET A LOT OF THE CONVENTIONS
PORTED INTO AND OUT OF THE
STATE. DURING THE ONE YEAR THE
PERMIT IS VALID FOR WHAT THIS
BILL DOES REALLY- IS THAT THESE
NON AZ'S USER ASKING TO-
UNDERCUT EXISTING STATE LAW AND
CDFW RESTORED. AND PROVISIONS
AFTER SB SYLLABUS THIRTY FIVE
WHICH CONCERNED ANIMAL IMPORTS
FOCUS ON PREVENTING. THE IMPORT
OF ANIMALS WHICH CARRY DISEASE
THE GOAL THESE PROVISIONS ARE
IN PART OF THAT THE NEXT
PANDEMIC. THAT EXISTING LAW
ALREADY AUTHORIZES CDFW TO BARS
THESE DISEASE ANIMALS FROM THE
STATE HI FOR A DISEASE LIKE
OVER. SB LEVELS FIVE REVISED
DIRECTION DISSIDIA. AND
REQUIRES THE AUTHORIZATION TO
EMPLOY ANIMALS WILD ANIMALS
OCCUR THE DISEASES I'LL BE
SUSPENDED ON THE WRITTEN
FINDING THE CDFW. DIRECTOR
BASED ON SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE. I
DON'T AMENDED AS ELEVEN FIVE BY
STEPS TOWARDS THE- OF CAL. AND
CAL FROM THE IMPORT OF ALL
ANIMALS THAT TOO MUCH RISK UPON
HEALTH IS. NAY WILDLIFE AND I
DON'T IN. AND I CERTAINLY. FOR
YOUR I'VE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THANK YOU. THE FAMOUS
KALRA. THIS IS. NO OTHER MAY
SEEKING RE ON THE IS KAMLAGER
YOU MAKE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
RAISED BY SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IN MY
CLOTHES LIVE MARKETS UNDER
CALIFORNIA ARE STRICTLY. UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW ARE STRICTLY
DEFINED TO MEAN THE SALE AT A
RETAIL MARKET OF FROGS TURTLES
AND NON POULTRY BIRDS. THIS
BILL WOULD NOT IMPACT LOCAL
SLAUGHTERHOUSES. IT DOES NOT
AFFECT ANY AND ALL ANY ANIMAL
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT
LIVE MARKET. SIMILAR TO THE
PREVENTION OF SALE OF DISEASED
CATTLE SWINE AND CHICKENS THESE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
ANIMAL FRESHLY KILLED FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION. POSE NO THREAT TO
HUMAN HEALTH AND AS WE HAVE
MOVED THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC I
THINK IT SHOULD BE INCREDIBLY
CLEAR THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ARE NOT. BRINGING
IN ANIMALS WHO MAY HAVE
DISEASES THEY'VE BACK COULD
METASTASIZE INTO ADDITIONAL
STATE AND NATIONAL PANDEMICS.
WE KNOW THAT LARGE NUMBERS OF
WILD LIVE ANIMALS ARE IMPORTED
INTO CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR. AND
WHILE THERE IS SOME EFFORT TO
ENSURE THEY DO NOT KERRY
SYNODIC DISEASES IT IS NOT
COMPREHENSIVE OR COORDINATED
WHICH IS WHAT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE ATTEMPTS TO DO. I ALSO
WANT TO SHARE THAT S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE ONLY APPLIES TO
TRUMP IS LAWFULLY IMPORTED INTO
THE UNITED STATES AFTER JANUARY
TWENTY ONE. AND ANY VIOLATION
OF THESE PROVISIONS WOULD ALSO
BE A FEDERAL OFFENSE
INDEPENDENT OF S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS WHERE THE
ENFORCEMENT WOULD COME IN. CDFW
COULD PERIODICALLY CHECK THE
FEDERAL DATABASE FOR SPECIES
COVERED UNDER THIS BILL FOR ANY
THAT WERE IMPORTED BY
INDIVIDUALS WITH CALIFORNIA
ADDRESSES. AND LASTLY I WANT TO
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM L.
GROWS I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
YOU. ENVIRONMENTALISTS SHOULD
BE. ASKED CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AS CRIMINAL THEY
SHOULD BE ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ISSUES AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL I'M
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD ALSO STEP
UP AND STEP IN FRONT OF ISSUES
RELATED TO PUBLIC TRIAL POVERTY
AND ISSUES RELATED TO YOUNG
BLACK CHILDREN SO I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH YOU
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL WOULD WANT
TO ENGAGE WITH YOU NEXT YEAR TO
WORK ON THOSE ISSUES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS KAMLAGER
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. YEAH. YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS HER. DESIRED OF THE.
MS KAMLAGER WAS A CALL. YEAH MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE MOVE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR SB TWO
NINETY TWO RUBIO AND ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT SB TWENTY
NINE THEY'RE ALSO TO THE IN
ACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW MEMBERS TO TAKE UP TO
ITEMS ON SECOND READING TODAY
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON.
TO TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
EIGHT ONE NINE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE AND
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES TO TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN BRADFORD. WITHOUT.
OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE CONCURRENCE
ITEMS WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
ON ITEMS THREE AND FOUR MOVING
THE FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE AND OTHERS
AND I BELIEVE IN THE MOBILE
HOMES IT'S JUST ON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS THE
SAME MOBILE HOME BILL THAT WE
GOT OFF THE FLOOR EARLIER
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT A LOCAL
CONTROL PRINT PROVISION THAT
ENSURES EQUAL APPLICATION OF
LOCAL RENT STABILIZATION
ORDINANCES I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR STAND
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO THERE TO
VOTE.
MR SOME OF THE CALL.
IN A
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED BISA MEMIKIRKAN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
DR BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAK TO A MEMBER.
MEMASTIKAN THE SENATE AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED DIRECTLY WORKING
GROUP. WORK IN COORDINATION
WITH THE STATE'S FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN INTO CARS
STATE AGENCIES TO HELP THE
ECONOMIC DAMAGES AND FINANCIAL-
LIABILITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
CURRENT AND FUTURE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR COMPONENTS ON THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU DR
CORRECTING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A THIRD VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO THEIR TO VOTE. YEAH
YEAH. ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF
A. OKAY.
BECAUSE.
WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TO SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT IT'S
YOUR CAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT AB THIRTY
TO SIXTY YEARS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. LAST TIME I WAS
HERE THEY ALL TOLD ME TO GO
WORK ON THIS AND I WORKED ON
IT. AND IN FACT IT RETURNS TO
THE ASSEMBLY. A SHELL OF ITS
FORMER SELF HOWEVER IT'S AN
IMPORTANT SHALL ANOTHER DEALS
ONLY WITH THE RIGHT TO RECALL
AND RETENTION THIS ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA WORKERS HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF DUE TO THE COLD
NINETEEN CRISIS. TO RETURN TO
THEIR JOBS ONCE THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE AGAIN THIS BILL DOES
NOT IMPACT SMALL BUSINESS IT
ONLY APPLIES TO LARGE HOTELS
PACIFIC AIRPORT EMPLOYERS
EVENTS CENTER THE BUILDING
SERVICES. THESE ARE SOME OF THE
HARDEST HIT INDUSTRY TO THE
PANDEMIC RESULTING IN MORE THAN
ONE THIRD OR MORE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES BEING LAID OFF THESE
WORKERS NEED ASSURANCES OF
THEIR JOBS WE NEED TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. IF THEY WANT
BUSINESSES REOPEN AND THAT
PANDEMIC RELATED LAYOFFS ARE
NOT USED AS AN EXCUSE TO ENGAGE
A PREJUDICIAL UNWARRANTED
TERMINATIONS. THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THE LAID OFF
WORKERS WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY GETTING BACK THERE
JUST SAME JOB ONCE OUR EMPLOYER
BECAUSE WE HIRE. TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED HERE AND IN THE
SENATE WE REMOVED FROM THE BILL
ALL PROVISIONS INCREASING PAID
SICK LEAVE ALL PROVISIONS
INCREASING UNPAID JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE. ALL PROVISIONS OF MANY
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO
ENFORCE THE RIGHT TO RECALL
OVER TO RETENTION PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL WERE ALSO REMOVED AND
THERE'S A RIGHT TO CURE- THIS
BILL IS AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT. PROTECTING WORKERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
AMONG THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES DURING THIS
COMPRISES BOB YOU KNOW WORKERS
LOW WAGE WORKERS IMMIGRANT
WORKERS. THESE DISPLACED
WORKERS HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING.
COMPLETELY BEYOND THEIR CONTROL
NOT BUT OF CORPORATE. OR
DISCIPLINE. THESE WORKERS ARE
CREATE THIS QUITE. THIS BILL
GET. BACK TO THEIR JOBS AND
CRISIS ENDED AND PART OF OUR
STATES SECOND RECOVERY. I
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOU I. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
HOUSTON.
MR COLUMN IN THE CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE IN A HOUSING. ZERO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE BILL WILL
CLARIFY HOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CAN UTILIZE THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT. TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICT EMPLOYEES
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE. THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
THIS WORKABLE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM SPEAKER I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE HOUSING SOLUTIONS
THAT'S NOT ONLY CREATIVE BUT
INNOVATIVE AS WE SEE THAT
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE NUMBER
ONE CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
GET HOUSING BUILT AND BUILT
QUICKLY I SUPPORT AB THREE
THREE. ZERO EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISS CLARK SILVA SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL. OPEN THEIR ALL.
MEMBERS VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
GO TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WILK- MOVE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS TO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED IN
LIVING IF FILE ITEM NINE. AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO AN
ACCOLADE IN THE FOOD. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY
THREE SIX IS BACK FROM
CONCURRENCE THIS IS A SUPER
AWESOME BILL THAT WILL MAKE
YOUR FOOD DELIVERY THAT MUCH
SAFER ALL THE OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN REMOVED AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST IN MY BOOK. THANK YOU
MISS CORREOS IN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THEIR TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THIRTY TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
IF CAREER MOVE THE CALL.
MOVING A FILE ITEM TEN AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
AN ACCOLADE IN THE CANNABIS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. WAR THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER NUMBER AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN CLARIFIES
WHAT IT MEANS TO PROVIDE A
CANNABIS PRODUCT TESTING NEEDS
FINAL FOR SENATE AMENDMENTS
PRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
CHAPLAIN ALBUMS FROM. I WAS OF
THE LAST YEAR I'VE THE- THANK
YOU MISTER CAR THE HEARING
FURTHER ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESERVE IT.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW YOU
VOTE I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
NINETEEN OH SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ SUMIKO NINETEEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND OTHERS
AND I BELIEVE IN THE PEACE
OFFICERS THIS IS FILE IF YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS IS A
BILL I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS
REMEMBER THE HEADLINES THAT WAS
DEALING WITH PREGNANT
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS- THIS
BILL SEEKS TO RECTIFY THAT
SITUATION IN THOSE PROBLEMS BY
REQUIRING CDC ARE TO OFFER
LIGHT DUTY ASSIGNMENTS FOR
PREGNANT CORRECTIONAL. OFFICERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK MISTER SALAS.
SEEING AND HEARING FURTHER TO
ON THEM THE COLOR WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT. THE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AN ACT RELATING
TO MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IS
SIMPLY REQUIRES DISCLOSURE OF
ALL THE INGREDIENTS AND ALL
NATURAL PRODUCTS- THIS BILL.
HAS WIDE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
LEFT THE SENATE WITH NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN.
I BOUGHT. THANK YOU MISS GARCIA
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. GO THROUGH
THERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALITHA EYES FORTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVIE IF I ITEM AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE SEWERS SUICIDE PREVENTION
IT'S AROUND US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SPEAKERS A- AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE IT IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE AB TWENTY
ONE TWELVE ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE OFFICE. OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS EASE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THIS OFFICE
AND REDUCE POTENTIAL CLASS. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR RAMA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IN THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS. ARTIFICE.
FONG MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A-
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE ICE FIFTY NEW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN THE UNIFIL ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO COVER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS NONE OF
THEM IS TO AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN REFLECT A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL INPUTS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ON THE PROPERTY
MANAGED HEALTHCARE INCLUDING
ONE HEALTH PLANS INSURERS MUST
SUBMIT REPORTS TO DEPARTMENTS
AND WHEN REPORTS ARE POSTED
ONLINE ADDITIONALLY AMENDMENTS
OUT A LIMITED ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT EXEMPTION UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR D. EASE
IMPLEMENTATION TIMEFRAMES AND
REMOVE THE TO THE REQUIREMENT
FOR DEPARTMENTS PRESENT. THAT
COVER CALIFORNIA HEARINGS
INSTEAD MAKES A DISCRETIONARY
AS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
OPPOSITION'S REQUEST TO CLARIFY
AN INCONSISTENT THAT DEFINITION
THE BILL A WORK ON OTHER
TECHNICAL ISSUES THERE'S
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY AROUND
HEALTHCARE COST PROJECTIONS IN
THE WAKE OF A NINETEEN AND
INSPECT ON HEALTH INSURANCE
RATES POLICYMAKERS AND
PURCHASES IN A COMPLETE PICTURE
OF OUR STATE'S HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKETPLACE TO SHED LIGHT ON
HOW CONSUMERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE PURCHASING
HEALTH COVERAGE. WITH THAT
RESPECT THE ASTRODOME THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER. DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF THEIR TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS WHO DESIGN A. ON
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES. FORTY ONE. YEAH.
ALLERGEN CONTENT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE
EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS FOURTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN. WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS
AREA AN ACCOLADE IN THE
CLINICAL LABORATORIES. MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ON THOSE
WHO DESERVE A- HOME MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALITHA
HIGHS FIFTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED IN.
MOVING THE FILE ITEM. SEVENTEEN
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY ANOTHER
SNACK LIVING A PAROLE MISTER
CARTER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS OUR
PAROLE REFORM MEASURE BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS ADOPTS
NATIONWIDE BEST PRACTICES TO
IMPROVE OUR PAROLE SYSTEM THIS
BOOK IS ON MAKING SURE AND
PEOPLE ARE I READ RE RELEASED
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR ALL WE
CAN HELP THEM REINTEGRATE BACK
IN THE COMMUNITIES BY DOING
THINGS LIKE. GO TO COLLEGE-
SERVING AS A VOLUNTEER WE'RE
GOING THROUGH A DRUG REHAB
PROGRAMS THEY CAN THEY CAN
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME ON
PAROLE BY SUCCEEDING IN THIS
CERTAINLY HELPS US ADDRESS THE
ISSUES WITH THAT CASE LOADS AND
MAKES OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER. AS
WELL THIS BILL AS TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND- JOINS UP WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ESCONDIDO ON
HER MEASURE AND SHE CERTAINLY
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT NEXT
THANK YOU ASK YOUR ABOUT. THANK
YOU MISTER CAR MISS WALDRON YOU
ARE A- THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ARE RISE AS A CO
AUTHOR. OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THIS BILL IS
BIPARTISAN IT MANIFESTS WHAT
SHOULD BE THE GOAL OF PAROLE TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS INTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY SUCCESSFULLY. NOT JUST
TO BE A PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE
SOMEONE IS FULLY FREE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS AND MOVE
FORWARD. INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE
ON PAROLE TO PURSUE EDUCATION
AND PARTICIPATE IN REHAB
PROGRAMS WILL REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. WHILE GIVING THEM
THE SKILLS NECESSARY FOR A
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY IS NOT WORTH
SUPPORTING. IRETON IVEL. THANK
YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALITHA EYES FORTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME. IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA'S LAW
THAT REQUIRES A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO CERTIFY A
U. OR T. VISA FORM. FOR
UNDOCUMENTED VICTIMS OF CERTAIN
CRIMES AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SENATE AMENDMENTS FOR
CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
ZERO NO VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS I. AUS THE TO VOTE I ON
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX TO
STRENGTHEN THE OVERALL PUBLIC
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IMMIGRANT
CONVICT COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
RAZ SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I FORTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
AGO TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
ACCOLADE THE CONTRACTS. MISTER
MANGE I KNOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE MINUTES TAKEN IN
THE SENATE AGREE CHAPTER TO
MAKE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING.
LANGUAGE THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE FOR SENIORS ESPECIALLY
IN THESE TIMES THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. THAT
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONVERTED LEVINE A FILE ITEM
TWENTY AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
OF BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND
ACKERLEY IN OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT IS BACK FROM SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ARE CLARIFYING IN NATURE IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN HARMONY WITH
CURRENT LABOR LAW I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
CONCUR IN AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISS BURKE THINKING HEARING
THERE FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FORTY NINE NEW
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE MAYBE TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME MIDDLE TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND OTHERS AND ACT LIKE
YOU KNOW HOMELESSNESS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL REQUIRES STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EXPENDITURES
OF STATE HOMELESS FUNDING ON A
THANK THE MORE THAN TWENTY
BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS WHO HAVE
JOINED US TO DEMAND. GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN HOW WE ARE SPENDING CRITICAL
HOMELESS DOLLARS THIS BILL
PASSED THE SENATE WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR GABRIEL SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF IT.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THOSE EYES FIFTY FOUR
NEW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONVERTED WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO. MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE AB THIRTY TO FORTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AN ACT
RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH. IS
THERE WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE BILL CLARIFIES
THAT COUNTIES CAN UTILIZE
TELEHEALTH TO CONDUCT FIFTY ONE
FIFTY AND FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE.
INVOLUNTARY HOLDS EVALUATIONS
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY BOTH
THECALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND NOT BE
CALIFORNIA THE BILL HAS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY TODAY AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS PROTECT TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I FIFTY NINE NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN PARDON WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEMS TWENTY FOUR THROUGH.
TWENTY SIX. WILL MOVE. WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY AVAILABLE
TWENTY SEVEN TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL EAT NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS AND
CLEARING YOUR ZERO STICK THANK
MEDIALLY. HELLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
HELPS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES
BUT THERE'S ACTIVISION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DO THEIR TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I FIFTY EIGHT NEWS HERE ON
THE MEASURE ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY SENATE
AMENDMENT ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE
ITEMS TWENTY NINE THREE THIRTY
THREE MOVING A FILE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
NEWSPAPERS. THIS RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER FOR- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB THREE
THREE TWENTY THREE HERE TODAY.
MEMBERS MANY NEWSPAPERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FEELING THE
DEMISE OF NEWSPAPERS WILL MEAN
MANY LOST JOBS AND WILL LEAVE
MANY COMMUNITIES WITHOUT LOCAL
JOURNALISM. IN THE BAY AREA
WHEN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE AND EXAMINER WERE
MERGED IN TWO THOUSAND THERE
WERE OVER SIX HUNDRED PORTERS
TODAY THERE IS ONLY A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY. AS WE KNOW IT
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY DEPENDS
ON A WELL INFORMED
CONSTITUENCY. AS AN IMMIGRANT
TO THIS COUNTRY THAT REPRESENTS
EXTREMELY DIVERSE. AND
EXTREMELY DIVERSE SECTION IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY I AM
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF ETHNIC MEDIA.
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO ASIAN
AND OTHER ETHNIC AND NICHE
PAPERS COULD. BE THE FIRST TO
GO IN ADDITION SOME COUNTIES IN
THE STATE MAY BECOME NEWS
HAZARDS WITH NO PAPER OF
RECORD. JUSTIN MY DISTRICT
ALONE I AM AWARE OF AT LEAST
FORTY SIX ETHNIC NEWSPAPER
PUBLICATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES IN MY COMMUNITY. IN
FACT MY FATHER WHO IS NOT EIGHT.
EIGHTY YEARS OLD HAS EVENTUALLY
RELIED ON THE OPINION OF HIS
PRIMARY SOURCE OF NEWS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS HE'S NOT GOING TO
TRANSITION TO GOOGLE FOR NEWS.
NOW THAT ALL OF THE CONTACTS IS
GOING ON IN THE BACKGROUND THE
NEWSPAPERS ARE FACING AN
ADDITIONAL AVERAGE INCREASE OF
85% AND DISTRIBUTION COSTS IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE DOES
NOT EXTEND EXEMPTIONS. FROM AB
FIVE TWO NEW CARRIERS. I HAVE
HEARD FROM MANY SMALL
PUBLICATIONS THAT THIS COULD
FORCE PAPERS TO ABANDON THEIR
CONTRACT DELIVERY MODELING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT NEWSPAPERS THE LOSE
TOUCH WITH GOVERNMENT BUSINESS
EDUCATION AND NEIGHBORS. AGAIN
TO USE MY PARENTS AS AN EXAMPLE
COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS PLAYED A
HUGE ROLE. IN KEEPING THE
COMMUNITY OF THE CITY OF BELL
INFORMED ON CORRUPTION ISSUES
WERE. WHICH WERE PLAGUED OF
PLEADING AND CITY HALL AT THAT
TIME. COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS AND
ETHNIC MUSIC PLAYED A HUGE ROLE
IN EXPOSING THE CORRUPTION.
THAT WAS TAKING PLACE ALLOWING
RESIDENTS TO RESTRUCTURE THE
CITY COUNCIL AND RESTORE PUBLIC
TRUST. MEMBERS THIS IS WHY SB
THREE TWENTY THREE IF YOU'RE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY. FIRST
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE WILL
EXTEND THE NEWSPAPER CARE
EXEMPTION FROM DYNAMIX
TEMPORARILY. UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY TWO. A
LANGUAGE HERE CONCERNING
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS IS IDENTICAL
TO AB ONE SEVENTY FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH PROVIDED A WHEN
YOU'RE EXEMPTION. WE ARE SIMPLY
PUSHING THIS BACK ON TO ONE
MORE YEAR. THE EEMPTION
INCLUDED INCLUDED IN AB THREE
TWENTY THREE CONSIDERED THE
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP. THE PANDEMIC
HAS PLACED ON THESE THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY ON TOP OF
THE ALREADY DIMINISHING SALES
AND REVENUE IS. EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT THE EXTENSION DOES
NOT ALLOW THE NEWSPAPERS TO
ESCAPE THE CURRENT LIABILITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO DELIVER
DRIVERS UNDER THE BARREL
STANDARD. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER I AM AN IMMIGRANT TO
THIS COUNTRY THE REPRESENTS AN
EXTREMELY DIVERSE SECTION OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. I AM
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF ETHNIC MEDIA.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING DYNAMIC MEDIA OPTIONS
AVAILABLE IN A HOST OF
LANGUAGES. NOBODY GOES TO THE
SAME PLACE FOR SOURCES OF NEWS
AND INFORMATION AND I AM
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
KEEPING COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS
AND EPIC MEDIA. VIABLE AND
WIDELY AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO MISS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
WANT TO START BY SAYING I
UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT LOCAL
JOURNALISM AND IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT IT PLAYS IN KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITIES INFORMED DURING
SUCH CRITICAL TIMES TONIGHT
SUPPORT ETHNIC MEDIA. IT'S
VITAL FOR MY DISTRICT AS WELL.
BUT THIS DOESN'T JUST COVER
ETHNIC MEDIA ARE SMALL PAPERS
THIS COVERS EVERY SINGLE
NEWSPAPER CARRIER. I CAN NEVER
CONDONE OR SUPPORT AN
UNSUSTAINABLE BUSINESS MODEL
THAT OPERATES AT THE EXPENSE OF
LOW WAGE WORKERS. TODAY I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
MEANS FOR NEWSPAPER CARRIERS
AND I WANT TO DO THAT BECAUSE
NOBODY ELSE IS SPEAKING UP FOR
THEM. THEY HAVE NO LOBBY. THEY
HAVE NO UNION. THEY HAVE NOBODY.
TO REPRESENT THEIR VIEWS. THESE
ARE WORKERS FROM I CAN. AND
THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO GET BY.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY DISINGENUOUS TO
SUGGEST THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
ANYTHING BUT EMPLOYEES OF THE
DISTRIBUTION COMPANIES THEY
WORK FOR. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE MY WORD FOR THAT YOU CAN
TAKE EVERY COURT CASE IT'S BEEN
DECIDED SINCE THE NINETEEN
FORTIES IT HAS BEEN DECIDED ON.
BEHALF OF THESE WORKERS. THESE
ARE WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS OVERWHELMINGLY LOW
WAGE WORKERS HAVE TO GET UP IN
THE EARLY HOURS OF THE MORNING
SOMETIMES AS EARLY AS MIDNIGHT
TO DELIVER NEWSPAPERS. ON
AVERAGE THEY MAKE THREE DOLLARS
AN HOUR. HE ARRIVED AT A
DISTRIBUTION CENTER SPEND TWO
TO THREE HOURS ASSEMBLY TO
PREPARING NEWSPAPERS FOR THEIR
DELIVERY ROUTES. THEY MUST
PACKAGE NEWSPAPERS WITH
SPECIFIC DIRECTIONS MUST
DELIVER THE PAPERS WITH
SPECIFIC INSTRUCTIONS. OR BE
SUBJECT TO FINES AND PENALTIES.
IN ONE INSTANCE ONE WOMAN WAS A
PAID ABOUT TEN CENTS PER PAPER
DELIVERED. BUT SHE WAS FINED A
DOLLAR IF YOU DELIVERED IT
INCORRECTLY. NEWSPAPER CARRIERS
HAVE TIME RESTRICTIONS AND
DEADLINES TO MAKE THE
DELIVERIES. FOR EXAMPLE A PAPER
MUST BE DELIVERED BY FORTY FIVE
AM ON WEEKDAYS AND SIX TO SIX
THIRTY ON SUNDAYS. THEY DO NOT
HAVE ANY FREEDOM OVER THEIR
WORKING HOURS AND CONDITIONS OR
THE MANNER IN WHICH THEY
COMPLETE THEIR JOB. LADIES
GENTLEMEN THERE IS NOTHING
ABOUT THIS WORK THAT SUGGESTS
THAT THESE ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THESE ARE THE CLASSIC
DEFINITION OF AN EMPLOYEE. AND
I'M OKAY WITH THE FICTION THAT
WE NEED TO JUST CONTINUE THIS
ANOTHER YEAR. TO ALLOW
NEWSPAPERS TO GO FORWARD. BUT
I'M NOT OKAY WITH SAYING ARE
PRETENDING. THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO EVEN WITHHOLD THE
BRELO STANDARD. FOR ANYONE THAT
READ THE DYNAMAX CASE THIS IS
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF WORKER THE
DYNAMICS WAS TRYING TO GET OUT.
I'VE FOUGHT OVER THE YEARS TO
TRY TO ENSURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
EXEMPTION WE PUT INTO AB FIVE
FIT INTO THE CATEGORIES. IN
INTO THE RATIONALE THE DYNAMICS
USED. THIS IS JUST THE OPPOSITE
OF THAT. IF THESE WORKERS ARE
SICK THEY HAVE TO MISS A DAY
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE TO FIND A
REPLACEMENT AT THEIR OWN
EXPENSE. ARE THEY BREACH THEIR
CONTRACT AND MUST PAY A FINE.
THE PLIGHT OF THESE WORKERS IS
WHY SPRING COURT UNANIMOUSLY
ISSUED THE DYNAMICS DECISION IN%
A BIPARTISAN WAY. IN THIS ISSUE
PREDATES DYNAMAX EVEN THE MOST
EGREGIOUS SITUATION THE BURRELL
STANDARD HAS ACTED AS A BARRIER
PREVENTING THESE WORKERS FROM
ACCESSING THE BASIC EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS THEY HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN ENTITLED TO. SINCE THE
NINETEEN FORTIES NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS HAVE HAD TO GO TO
COURT IN INTER YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS OF LITIGATION. IN
ORDER TO BE DEEMED TO
MISCLASSIFIED WHICH EVERY
SINGLE TIME THEY HAVE BEEN IN
TO GET ANY KIND OF RELIEF. THE
STANDARD THAT REQUIRES WORKERS
TO BE TIED UP IN LITIGATION FOR
YEARS IN ORDER TO ACCESS A
BASIC MINIMUM WAGE IS A
FAILURE. WE SAT HERE NEARLY A
YEAR AGO IS THE INDUSTRY
COMMITTED TO TAKING THE EXTRA
YEAR TO FULLY COMPLY WITH A
COURT REQUIREMENTS OF. EIGHTY
FIVE. IT HERE WE ARE AGAIN. AND
WITH NO EVIDENCE THAT THERE'S
BEEN ANY EFFORT TO MADE TO
PROPERLY CLASSIFY THESE
WORKERS. IN I WOULD ARGUE THERE
SIMPLY RUNNING OUT THE CLOCK.
IT'S OKAY I UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE IN THE SENATE AND SOME
FOLKS WANT TO PASS THIS BILL I
UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURE OF THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY. GOD KNOWS%
ALL RIGHT A LOT OF UP AS IF WE
DON'T DO THIS. BUT HAVING BEEN
SUBJECT TO THOSE OP ED ALL YEAR
LONG. AND THEY HAVE BEEN CALLED
OUT BY NAME IN THIS OFFICE ALL
YEAR LONG I'LL SAY THIS. I WILL
SLEEP WELL TONIGHT. BECAUSE A
GROUP OF INDIVIDUAL WORKERS WHO
HAS NOBODY TO SPEAK FOR THEM IT
NEVER HAS IT'S NOT TO GET MY
VOTE ON THIS BILL. RESPECTFULLY
ASK ABOUT. THANK YOU RISK AND
SALAS MR MERECE SU CHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH I A
OF. COMPLETELY RESPECT THE
AUTHOR THE CHAMPION OF AB FIVE.
AND YOUR CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
THE WORKERS. I DON'T KNOW WHY I
HAVE TO ADMIT I DON'T KNOW AS
MUCH ABOUT. THE DETAILS OF THE
BUSINESS MODEL AND WHAT
CONVERSATIONS YOU HAVE HAD. TO
TRY TO HELP THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY WHAT I DO KNOW. IS
THAT- THERE THERE IS A THERE IS
A GREAT COMMUNICATOR FOR MY-
AND IN THE SOUTH BAY AREA LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THE EASY READER-
AND- YOU KNOW THEY THEY THEY
THEIR THEIR AD. REVENUES HAVE
DROPPED DRAMATICALLY DURING
THIS TWELVE AND NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND THEY HAD TO LAY
OFF ALL THEIR EMPLOYEES. YOU
KNOW THEY THEY THEY- UNDER
THEIR EXISTING BUSINESS MODEL
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS PANDEMIC.
YOU KNOW THEY THEY HAVE HAD TO
LAY OFF ALL EMPLOYEES I HAVE
ANOTHER. GREAT ETHNIC NEWSPAPER
THE RAFI SIMPLE THE OLDEST
JAPANESE AMERICAN NEWSPAPER IN
THE UNITED STATES. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
AND SO. YOU KNOW. AGAIN I.
RESPECT YOUR YOUR YOUR
CHAMPIONING THE CAUSE OF THE
WORKERS. BUT WE NEED TO HELP WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITY. NEWSPAPERS
ARE AT THE NEWSPAPERS. TO
SURVIVE AND SO YOU KNOW. I
WOULD LOVE TO BE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION- BUT- FOR TODAY
THAT IS THE REASON WHY I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. OKAY. EXCUSE ME
I APOLOGIZE MISS REVIEW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO AND I HEAR EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I'VE WORKED
VERY HARD WITH THE CHAIR OF
LABOR SO THAT WE CAN PUT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES ARE IN
REGULAR CHECK INS SO THAT ARE
THE PIECE THAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT HOLDING BOTH
THE NEWSPAPERS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THEIR PROMISE HAS BEEN IN PLACE
AND I COMMIT TO WORKING THROUGH
THE YEAR WITH THE CHAIR OF
LABOR SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT
HAPPEN SO I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND I AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU MISS RIVERA NOW
THE CAR WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE A VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS TO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
RECESS UNDER THE CALL OF THE
SPEAKER FOR LUNCH WHICH ENABLES
YOU ALTER TURNED HER OFFICES
AND HAVE LUNCH SAFELY. BUT WE
ASK THAT YOU NOT LEAVE THE
BUILDING AS WE WILL CALL YOU
BACK TO THE FLOOR WHEN THEY'RE
READY TO RESUME BUSINESS. ALSO
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON CALL OF
THE CHAIR IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO
TO. MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AT. TWO
THIRTY. MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AT TWO
THIRTY.
MEMBERS WILL BE
RECONVENING SHORTLY PLEASE COME
TO THE FLOOR WAS START WORKING
THE DAILY FILE- COMING IN FOR
WILL START VOTING HERE SHORTLY.
THE.
MEMBERS WE WILL ENTERTAIN
VOTE CHANGES AT THIS TIME IF
ANYONE HAS THE CHANGES YOU CAN
RAISE OR MIKE AND YOU WILL BE
RECOGNIZED. DR CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE
STEVEN CHOI VOTE CHANGES AB.
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED. NO TO NOT
VOTING. THAT IS WHY WE REPEAT
THE VOTE CHANGE PLEASE SHIVAN
FOR YOU FOR CHANGE A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED NOTE TO NOT
BOARDING. PRO CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI ASSEMBLY WILL
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED NO TO NOT
VOTING. IT'S WORKABLE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER CALDERON JEFF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK SILVA S.
B. NINE ZERO EIGHT I DO NOT
VOTING. QUICKSILVER SOME PEOPLE
NINE AWAIT I TO NOT LOADING.
AND AFTER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AGAIN YOU ONE MORE VOTE CHANGE
I HAVE ONE MORE. GO AHEAD SIR.
YEAH AB. THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT
NORTH FULTON ACCORDING. CHOI
ASSEMBLY GO THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT NO TO NOT VOTING. DR PARK
YOU CAN RECOMMEND TO THE CREDIT
CHAMBER FOR A VOTE CHANGE HOLD
AB THIRTY THREE AWAY. NO HI. IS
COMMON ASSEMBLY GO THIRTY THREE
OH EIGHT NO TÁI. THIS CALM
ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. KAMLAGER S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX NO HI.
KAMLAGER SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
MEMBERS IT
IS A MERE NINE HOURS TO
MIDNIGHT WE WOULD APPRECIATE
YOU RETURNING TO THE FLOOR SO
WE CAN COMMENCE THE ASSEMBLY'S
BUSINESS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE CONCURRENCE
ITEMS. AGAIN WE WILL START WITH
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
IN THE FIRE PREVENTION. THIS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS- THIS BILL IS MY
DEFENSIBLE SPACE BILL THAT
SEEKS TO ESTABLISH IN THE CODE
A NEW OF A VERY IMPORTANT
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. OF CODE
SECTION FROM ZERO TO FIVE FEET
OF STRUCTURES THE SENATE
AMENDMENT SPECIFIES A STRUCTURE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE M.
RESISTANCE ZONE WILL ALSO
INCLUDE ANY ATTACHED DECKS IT
REQUIRES CAL FIRE TO NOT CHANGE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
PRACTICES ARE FORMS FORSMAN. TO
IMPLEMENT THE ZONE UNTIL THE
DIRECTOR MAKES A WRITTEN
FINDING THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
AFFORD TO DO SO IT SPECIFIES A
REGULATIONS AND UPDATES TO THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT TO ESTABLISH THE EVER
RESISTANCE ZONE. ARE CONTINGENT
UPON APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE SO AGAIN THAT WE
CAN AFFORD IT AND ADDRESSES
CHAPTER IN ISSUES WITH SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT THIS BILL
HAS A BROAD COALITION SUPPORT
INCLUDING FIRE SAFETY COUNCIL'S
FIRE CHIEFS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS BUSINESS
GROUPS AND UTILITIES. WHO ALL
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO HELP REDUCE LOSSES
AND SAID I AM PROTECT LIVES
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE TO CONCUR IN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. HONORS. THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR VOTE. OUR
MEMBERS ARE THERE TO VOTE.
OUR
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. OKAY BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE IS FORTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN. MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THREE
SIXTY NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM IN INTERNET MEDIA AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
CLEARLY OR SEE THEIR UPS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR HANSEN
CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER SIR MEMBER AB
THIRTY THREE SIX EIGHT NINE.
WILL CONFERENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS. BETWEEN THE
TRAINING REQUIRE AND OF THE
LABOR COLD FOR CHILD ACTORS.
AND THE TRAINING REQUIRED FOR
ALL EMPLOYEES IN THE GOVERNMENT
COAT. THIS AMENDMENT IS
TECHNICAL IN NATURE THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR CHIU SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A
THIRD OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. HOW LONG
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
WELL NEVER MIND. THIS REQUIRES
FIFTY FOUR AS AN URGENCY ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
FOR THE. OUR MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO VOTE THIS REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR. MR TO MOVE THE CALL.
THE VERY. OKAY. WE HAVE THE
FRIENDS WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. THREE OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS MEASURE WILL
CREATE GREATER EFFICIENCY WITH
OUR STATE RESOURCES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COMMUNICATION CROSS THE BOARD.
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS BY
ESTABLISHING A CENTRALIZED
STATE OFFICE TO END
HOMELESSNESS. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE INCORPORATE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ADDRESS COST
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND INCLUDE CHAPTER NOW AND
OTHER TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION BECAUSE
HOMELESSNESS. IS BOTH IN URBAN
AND RURAL ISSUE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS RIVAS
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED IN THERE TOMORROW. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
OUR MEMBERS VOTED AS I HEARD
ABOUT THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD ABOUT
THIS. FORTY ONE. THE CLERK WILL
HELLO THE ROLE AND THOSE EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS FOR SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN. WE
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX AND THIRTY
SEVEN AND MOVED TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA AND OTHERS AN
AGGRAVATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. MISTER GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT TO
YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE A BILL THAT WOULD BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR THE SAN
DIEGO REGION. ASK FOR THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO
PARTNER WITH THE UNITED STATES
NAVY ON IMPORTANT REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECT. FIRST AND FOREMOST
THIS BILL WILL STRENGTHEN THE
NAVY'S PRESENCE IN AMERICA'S
FINEST CITY CITY. EQUALLY
IMPORTANT THIS BILL WILL
FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
A CENTRAL MOBILITY HUB TO
CONNECT DIFFERENT TRANSIT
ROUTES ALL AT ONE PLACE ALONG
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT OF
NEEDED HOUSING WITH COMMERCIAL
AND RETAIL SPACE. AND FINALLY
THIS BILL WILL FACILITATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AN AIRPORT
CONNECTOR TO- TO THE SAN DIEGO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT NO LONGER
WHERE A LOCAL AIRPORT B. ONE OF
THE FEW MAJOR AMERICAN AIRPORTS
THAT DIRECT RAIL. CONNECTION TO
THE DIRECT RAIL SYSTEM. AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
CONTAINS SEVERAL SEEK WAS
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN POOR AND OTHER
MAJOR PROJECTS IN EXCHANGE THIS
BILL REQUIRES NUMEROUS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LABOR
CONDITIONS INCLUDING GREENHOUSE
GAS NEUTRALITY. 25% VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED REDUCTION AND
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PROJECT A
TEAM LEAD GOLD CERTIFICATION.
MEMBERS THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
FIVE THOUSAND EXISTING NAVY
JOBS IN THE SAN DIEGO. AREA FOR
POTENTIAL RELOCATION ABROAD. IT
CREATE A TWENTY CENTURY TRANSIT
SYSTEM IN SAN DIEGO AND PROVIDE
SOME DESPERATELY NEEDED
STIMULUS TO OUR LOCAL ECONOMY
THAT IS SUFFERING UNDER THE
EFFECTS OF COLLUDED NINETEEN.
ALL THIS WITHOUT ANY NEED FOR
STATE FUNDING. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE THE CHAIR
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
FOR HER AND HER STAFF
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS BILL.
MEMBERS ARE PROUD. IF WE ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE OF. THANK YOU
MISS THEIR GLORIA SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. OKAY IN
PALM MEMBERS THOSE WHO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLERK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE IS FORTY
NINE NEWS ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING THIRTEEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER SB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO WAS BAK ON
CONCURRENCE THE BILL CLOSES THE
LOOPHOLE. THAT ALLOWS HOAS TO
PROHIBIT HOMEOWNERS FROM
RENTING OUT THEIR HOMES BASED
ON OPPOSITION CONCERNS AT HIGH
RATES OF RENTALS COULD LEAD TO
HOAS OR INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS
RECEIVING WORST LENDING TERMS
FROM THE FEDERAL HOUSING
ADMINISTRATION OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
I AMENDED THE BILL IN THE
SENATE TO ALLOW HOAS TO CAP
RENTALS AT 25% OF THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF HOMES IN
DISSOCIATION. IN ADDITION WE
HAD TO ADD A CLEANUP LANGUAGE
TO ADDRESS CHAPTER OUT ERRORS
MADE LAST BETWEEN THREE EIGHTY
YOU ILLS AB SIXTY EIGHT AB AT
ONE S. B. THIRTEEN. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER TANK THINKING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERY GOOD. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
OUR MEMBERS VOTED ALREADY VOTED.
SQUIRES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE.
PALMER
THIRTY THIRTY VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. THE CALL.
OKAY.
MEMBERS WE ARE PREPARED
TO TAKE UP THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL I NOTICED AN ABSENCE OF
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR IF YOU ARE
IN YOUR OFFICES PLEASE RETURN
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR TO JOIN
US AS WE ARE CONTINUING TO DO
THE ASSEMBLY IS BUSINESS.
MISTER MONTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEND TO TAKE UP
THE FOLLOWING BUDGET COMMITTEE
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB ONE OH
SEVEN AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO AND A BE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX. MISTER
KALRA THE MINISTRY- WE OBJECT
WITH OR WE WOULD HOLD THE
HAMSTER SENT US FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER FOR. WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THE MOTION SECOND THE- MISTER
GLORIA SECONDS. WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE MOTION
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
NUMBER THIRTY TWO THIRDS VOTE
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL MOTION MR
BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
MOTION MEMBERS. MR BONTA IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MR FLOOR
IS ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ALREADY VOTED.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL MOTION. MR
BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MR FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. ON AVERAGE VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE
GUYS FORTY TWO KNOWS WELL THE
MOTION PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THESE WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
MATTERS. WE WILL START WITH AB
ONE OH SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SHOW ME TWO ONE OH SEVEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACCOLADE THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER KING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS OUR- BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. SO THIS IS A LOT OF THE
TIME THIS IS OUR GENERAL
GOVERNMENT AUGUST CLEAN UP
BILL. THIS REQUIRES THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO
CULTIVATE WITH THE TREASURER TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
FOR A CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
IMPROVEMENT TAX STRUCTURE
PROGRAM FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE THIS WAS ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PUT OUT TO TRY TO RAISE REVENUE
DURING THIS TIME OF COVE IT. IT
ALSO REQUIRES THE DIRECTOR OF
THE EDT TO PULSARS WEBSITE
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED INCLUDE
THE NUMBER OF UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION BENEFITS CLAIMS
PAID THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS FOUND
TO BE INELIGIBLE SINCE MARCH
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THIS
REQUIREMENT WOULD BEGIN
SEPTEMBER FOURTH. TWENTY TWENTY
THROUGH JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT ALSO CODIFIES THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
EXTENDS TO MARCH THIRTY FIRST
THE TWO YEAR DEADLINE BY WHICH
A COUNTY BOARD IS REQUIRED TO
RENDER A FINAL DETERMINATION ON
THE PROPERTY TAX PER
APPLICATION FOR REDUCTION-
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL SB EIGHT ONE FIVE FOUR
EIGHT FOUR AB ONE OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU MR CHANG MR OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN FRONT OF
A CHAMBER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE OH SEVEN. COLLEAGUES WE
HAVE PASSED MANY BILLS OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS TO GIVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS MORE FLEXIBILITY
IN THEIR DEALINGS WITH
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES CROSSED BY THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS HOWEVER THIS
TRAILER BILL DOES THE OPPOSITE
IT GIVES GOVERNMENT MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN DEALING WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS AT THE EXPENSE OF
THE TAXPAYERS WILL LOOKED AT
US. THIS TRAILER BILL EXTENDS
THE DEADLINES FOR PROPERTY TAX
APPEALS BOARDS ACROSS THE STATE
TO HEAR APPEALS FILED BY
TAXPAYERS AND IT DOES SO
RETROACTIVELY. UNTIL MARCH OF
THIS YEAR. THERE IS NO REASON
THESE OF BOARD CAN'T REMOTE AS
HAVE BEEN DOING TO TRY AND
CLEAR THIS BACKLOG. AND THERE
IS NO REASON WHY ARE TAXPAYERS
SHOULD HAVE TO WAIT AN EXTRA
YEAR TO HAVE THEIR CLAIMS
ADJUDICATED. ANOTHER TROUBLING
THING THAT'S CONTAINED IN THIS
TRAILER BILL IS THAT IT DIRECTS
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TO
PREPARE A PROGRAM WHERE TAX
VOUCHERS ARE SOLD WITH
PRESENTATION AHLERS THAT ARE
CONFUSED ED SATISFACTION OR
FUTURE TAX DEBTS. THIS IS YET
ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO USE
BORROWING. TO FINANCE OR
DEFICIT THIS YEAR AND WILL ONLY
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO SOLVE
BUDET DEFICITS IN THE FUTURE I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU MR
OBERNOLTE SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
ASSERTING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. KIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THURMOND. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED
ALREADY VOTED. ON MEMBERS THOSE
WHO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I FORTY SEVEN NEWS
FOURTEEN IS MEASURE PASSES.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN. MOVING TO WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME AGO
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
MACULATUM FEES AND MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER KING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF TO LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS- DISPROPORTIONATELY
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO COME INTO
CONTACT WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE REPEAL OF
TWENTY THREE CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES LIKE PUBLIC
DEFENSE BOOKING IN PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES THESE ARE
NOT CRIMINAL FINES WE ONLY
REPEALING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES IN ADDITION THE BILL
PROVIDES SIXTY FIVE MILLION AND
BACKFILL TO KELLY'S. FOR LOST
REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
REPEAL FEES WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
FOR A BI EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR TANG. MR OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE FRONT
OF THE CHAMBER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES ARISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE THIS TRAILER BILL WILL
REPEAL THE COLLECTION OF MANY
OF THE CRIMINAL COURT FEES
COLLECTED BY COURTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT POVERTY
SHOULD NOT BE CRIMINALIZED
HOWEVER THIS BILL FAILS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR PURPOSE BECAUSE
MOST OF THESE FEES AND THE BILL
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
ALREADY MEANS TESTED. THAT
MEANS THAT IMPOVERISHED PEOPLE
ALREADY DO NOT PAY THESE FEES
ANNA DISALLOWING THE COLLECTION
OF THESE FEES WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING IS PREVENTING
COUNTY FORTS FROM COLLECTING
THESE FEES FOR PEOPLE WHO CAN
PAY THEM THAT IS NOT ONLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO THE INTENT
OF THE BILL BUT ALSO UNFAIR TO
THE COURTS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
DEPEND ON THESE FEES TO PERFORM
THEIR SERVICES I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OVER AND-
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
KING WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
CLERK WILL OPEN RURAL. MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE. OUR
MEMBERS ARE REQUIRED TO VOTE.
CONTACT THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THERE ALTHOUGH IN TALLY THE
VOTE I FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FOURTEEN SENTIMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN. WE WILL NOW TAKE
A WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACRYLATE IN THE CANNABIS
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. PROVIDES THAT ONLY
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS TO
THE CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS
PANEL THE TO RESIDE IN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AT THE TIME
OF THEIR APPOINTMENTS. IT ALSO
PROHIBITS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION FROM INCREASING
THE EXCISE TAX MARKETING
CULTIVATION TAX INFLATION
ADJUSTMENT ON CANNABIS FOR ONE
YEAR PROVIDING MUCH READ NEEDED
RELIEF FOR MANY OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WHO CAN'T ACCESS. MANY
OF THE FEDERAL TAX RELIEF OR
LOAN PROGRAMS THAT EVERYONE
OTHER EVERYONE ELSE CAN. THEY
ALSO PROHIBITS THE BORDER STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS FOR
MAKING GRANTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE BOTH.
SAID THAT A BAND BOTH INDOOR
AND OUTDOOR COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION OR HAVE BEEN IN THE
RETAIL SALES OF CANNABIS OR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR CHANG MR OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THAT A SPEAKER
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THIS BILL WILL
STABILIZE CANNABIS TAX RATES IN
CALIFORNIA. BY POSTPONING THEIR
ADJUSTMENT UNTIL NEXT JULY.
THIS IMPORTANT CHANGE WILL HELP
OUR LICENSE BUSINESSES BETTER
COMPETE AGAINST THEIR
UNLICENSED COUNTERPARTS IN THE
BLACK MARKET WHICH IS A PROBLEM
THAT'S BECOME INCREASINGLY
SERIOUS IN THE STATE. AYE ARJUN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
OBERNOLTE MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AS WELL
JUST STATED THIS BILL FREEZES
THE ONE YEAR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENTOF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION REPORTED TO
INCREASE THE MARKET RATE. FOR
PURPOSES OF CALCULATING THE
STATE'S CANNABIS EXCISE TAX
INCREASE THE CULTIVATION TAX
FOR INFLATION. TO BE CLEAR THIS
PROPOSAL EITHER INCREASES OR
DECREASES TAXES BUT WILL FREEZE
THE EXISTING RATES UPON WHICH
THE STATE TAXES ON CANNABIS ARE
CALCULATED. IT'S SUPPORT TO
NOTE THAT THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
DID NOT QUALIFY FOR ANY FEDERAL
RELIEF PROGRAMS. UNDER STILL
UNABLE TO TAKE STANDARD
BUSINESS DEDUCTIONS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. BEIJING ALREADY
BURDENSOME STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES UPWARD OF 50% AND MORE
UNPREDICTABLE MARKET THE NEVER
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED CERTAINTY
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
STABILITY AT A TIME WHEN THE
INDUSTRY NEEDS OF MOST TO FIGHT
AGAINST THE BLACK MARKET THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WALKING.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
KING WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIRDS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. IN
FROM THE WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE WILL NOW
TAKE UP OF WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ. ILLEGAL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACCOLADE AND TAXATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX EXPANDS THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. TAKE ANY OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUAL WITH THE
FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AN ITEM.
THIS BUILDS UPON EARLIER
ACTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TAKEN TO EXTEND THE CALLIE
ITC TO THESE TAXPAYERS IF
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE WITH A YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT. IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT THIS WILL ALLOW
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
TAX FILERS TO RECEIVE THE CALL
THE A TO SEE BENEFIT. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THESE
ARE WORKING INDIVIDUALS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO IF THEY WERE
UNEMPLOYED OR HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF CANNOT ACCESS OR FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
SO WE THOUGHT DURING THIS VERY
TODD CHALLENGING TIME OF A
COVERT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE WORKING. AND
REALLY ADDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY HAS EVERY RIGHT AND THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT PROGRAMS IN OUR
STATE THE CAL THE ITC. WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON A.
B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX THANK
YOU MR CHANG MR OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX. THIS
TRAILER BILL EXTENDS THE EARNED
INCOME TAX PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LACK A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER BUT INSTEAD
HAVE. AN INDIVIDUAL. TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. UNLIKE
OTHER ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS THE
EITC IS A REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT
THAT MEANS TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TAX LIABILITY
YOU GET A CHECK BACK FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. WHICH CREATES A
POWERFUL INCENTIVE FOR FRAUD
AND ABUSE. RIGHT NOW THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD GUARDS
AGAINST THAT FRAUD AND ABUSE BY
COMPARING RECORDS FROM THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE USING
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS TO
MATCH UP FILERS WITH EARNINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE IRS DOES NOT
ACCEPT ITUNES ONLY SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS OF THIS
SAFEGUARD WILL NOT BE
AVAILABLE. FURTHERMORE I TENS
PERIODICALLY EXPIRE SO EVEN
USING STATEWIDE DATABASES TO
TRY AND MATCH UP EARNINGS
AGAINST FILERS WILL BE
PROBLEMATIC. THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD ITSELF HAS RAISED SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PRACTICE
SAYING THE FRAUD AND ABUSE OR
WILL FRAUD AND ABUSE WILL BE
LIKELY TO INCREASE SHOULD WE
TAKE THIS STEP I ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MR. OBERNOLTE DR
EMILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THIRTY
ONE ALSO AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SIX AND I'M PROUD THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ANSWER THE CALL.
FOR EQUITY AND TO MOVE
PURPOSELY AWAY FROM POLICIES
THAT INADVERTENTLY OR
INTENTIONALLY CAUSE HARM. THE
FULL INCLUSION OF ITEMS INTO
CAL EITC WILL HELP US TO
BALANCE THE SCALES OF ECONOMIC
JUSTICE FOR FAMILIES. WHO UP TO
THIS POINT HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT
OF RECEIVING TAX CREDITS FOR
THEIR LABORS. THIS WILL PUT
MONEY BACK IN THE POCKETS OF
ALL WORKING FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
AT A TIME WHEN THEY NEED IT THE
MOST. THIS WILL BE A WELCOME
RELIEF AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS PETUNIA OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I'M NOT A
SPEAKER I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS THIS HAS BEEN A PRIORITY
FOR US FOR YEARS NOW AND I AM
SO GRATEFUL TO BOTH THE-
CHAIRED THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND OUR SPEAKER TO REALLY
LOOKING OUT FOR TAX PAYING
CALIFORNIANS THAT'S WHAT THIS
SAYS THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
PAY THEIR TAXES EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND ARE DENIED THE RELIEF
AND TAX CREDITS AT OTHER
WORKING CALIFORNIANS GET. IT
HAS BEEN A LONG ROAD IT IS
UNFAIR WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO RIGHT NOW ARE
DEEMED ESSENTIAL WORKERS THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO WHO ARE WORKING
ON OUR FARMS IN AND I AM
HELPING CLEAN UP AFTER US AND
IT'S TIME WE ENSURE THAT
TAXPAYERS ALL HAVE THE SAME
RELIEF AND THESE I TEND I'M
FILERS HAVE THAT RELIEF AS WELL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER MISTER KING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. WHERE TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. AT THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELEVOTE I
FIFTY WHO KNOWS FIFTEEN
SENTIMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE SB ONE
FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTEEN BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET MAKING
APPROPRIATION OR FORTY TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUT BUDGET
BILL. THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB ONE FIFTEEN AMENDS
THE TWENTY TWENTY. BUDGET TO
INCLUDE CHANGES THAT REFLECT
UNEXPECTED CALLS ALLOWS FOR
EXTENDED ENCUMBRANCES OF
EXISTING FUNDING CORRECTS
TECHNICAL ISSUES THE MISTAKES
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY. BUDGET
ACT THE BILL CONTAINS A FEW NEW
MAJOR PROVISIONS ONE IS A SIXTY
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR.
EXPENDITURE FOR OUR REGION
ASSISTANCE TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
DURING THIS TIME OF COVERT IF
THEY ALSO INCLUDE THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSFER TO THE
SMALL BUSINESS HIRING TAX
CREDIT FUNDS. TO REALLY HELP
ASSIST MANY OF THE STRUGGLING
SMALL BUSINESSES HERE IN OUR
STATE. THE BILL ALSO
APPROPRIATES TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY POINT SIX MILLION IN
BOND FUNDS TO ACCELERATE THAT
SPENDING SO THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
TO WORK IMMEDIATELY. IN A
PROVIDES THE FOLLOWING SPECIAL
FUND APPROPRIATIONS A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CLEAN WATER A HUNDRED THREE
POINT THREE MILLION FOR INFILL
HOUSING. AND FIFTY ONE FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THE
BILL ALSO INCLUDES PROVISIONS
TO ALLOW THE FUNDING OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR THE
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
PROVIDERS WITHIN EXISTING
FUNDS. IF AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION IS ENACTED- WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR SB
ONE ONE FIVE THANK YOU MR CHANG
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THAT A SPEAKER RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE FIFTEEN. THIS BILL
MAKES A WIDE VARIETY OF CHANGES
TO BOTH THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY
STATE BUDGET AND THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE STATE BUDGET. THESE
CHANGES ARE LARGELY.
SUPPORTABLE ORIGIN I'VE A-
THANK YOU MISTER. OBERNOLTE
RANDY WRECKING. MATTER SPEAKER
IN MY- I RISING SO OF SB ONE
FIFTEEN AND ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT HAS GONE INTO INVESTING IN
RESOURCES. WHICH PROACTIVELY
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. LONG
STANDING SYSTEMIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL INEQUITIES HAVE PUT OUR
IMMIGRANT AND COMMUNITY OF
COLORS AND AN INCREASED RISK.
OF GETTING SICK AND DYING FROM
COVERT NINETEEN. TO ACHIEVE
HEALTH EQUITY. BARRIERS MUST BE
REMOVED SO THAT EVERYONE HAS A
FAIR OPPORTUNITY TO BE AS
HEALTHY AS POSSIBLE. THAT IS
WHY I AM PLEASED TO SEE SB ONE
FIFTEEN ALLOCATES FUNDS. TO
INVEST IN COMMUNITY OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND HELP PROTECT OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR STATE.
DEVELOPING COMMUNITY BASED
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO ARE
MOST AFFECTED BY COLLUDED.
RECOVER FROM COVE IT IS SIMPLY
THE RIGHT THING FOR US TO DO. I
URGE AND I'VE A- THANK YOU SEEN
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE VERY VOTE.
WELL DOES THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE. MOVING TO
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE SB
EIGHT TWENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISS
MADAM SPEAKER S. B. A. TWENTY
IS OUR EDUCATION CLEAN U
TRAILER JUST TO GIVE YOU COUPLE
HIGHLIGHTS YOU RECALL THAT.
MANY OF THE SCHOOLS THAT HAD A
GROWING- CLASSROOM POPULATION
HAD CHALLENGES REGARDING OUR
CURRENT BUDGET WHICH HELD.
WHICH HELD LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HARBORS SO WE'RE
TAKING AND MAKING SOME CHANGES
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE SCHOOLS
WITH GROWING POPULATIONS ARE
GETTING THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THEY NEED WE ALSO
AMENDED AND MADE AMENDMENTS TO
THE CLUE. OF FUNDING AND
TIMELINE FLEXIBILITY TO THESE.
DISTRICTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
DURING THIS CALL THE PANDEMIC
THAT THEY CAN. HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED TO OPEN
BACK UP. IT ALSO CLARIFIES
VARIOUS. BUDGET ACT CHILD CARE
POLICIES APPROPRIATIONS TO
INCLUDE THE MEASURE THE
PROVIDERS ARE HELD HARMLESS BUT
THEY WERE ALSO OUR FAMILY FEE
WAIVERS IN PARIS SIGNATURE
POLICIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WAS CLARIFIED. WE ALSO-
INCREASE THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION FOR COVERT
CLOSURE IN SUMMER MEALS%
PROGRAM. I HAVE FROM ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
CARES ACT FNDING TO A TOTAL OF
A- HUNDRED NINETEEN NINETY TWO
MILLION IN KERR'S RE FUNDING.
RESULTING IN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL
MEALS DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
AYE VOTE ON S. B. EIGHT TWENTY.
THANK YOU MR KING MR OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AS BIGGER
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
TWENTY. I THINK EVERYONE IN
THIS CHAMBER WOULD AGREE THAT
IT MAKES SENSE. TO HOLD OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HARMLESS. WHEN
IT COMES. WHAT IT COMES TO
DECLINES IN ENROLLMENT RELATED
TO THE CORONAVIRUS PRICES.
HOWEVER THIS BILL GOES BEYOND
THAT AND UNFAIRLY DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST CHARTER SCHOOLS WHO
COULD NOT HAVE FORESEEN THE
IMPORT THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
THAT THEY'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING
AS ROADS ALL TO CORONAVIRUS. IN
ADDITION THIS TRAILER BILL SAYS
THAT NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS ARE COMPLETELY
INELIGIBLE FOR ANY ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FUNDING WHICH IS
COMPLETELY NONSENSICAL SENSIBLE
BECAUSE THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE THE BEST POSITIONED. TO
ENSURE STUDENT SUCCESS
ENVIRONMENT WHEN OUR SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED DOWN. COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL VIOLATES THE BASIC
PREMISE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
FUNDING SHOULD FOLLOW THE
STUDENT I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU MR OBERNOLTE MR KILEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS BILL DOES MAKE
SOME IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PRIOR
EDUCATION FINANCE BILL BUT AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR
POINTED OUT. IT DOUBLES DOWN ON
THE OVERT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS I MADE MY-
FEELINGS ABOUT THAT VERY CLEAR
BEFORE SO I'LL JUST GIVE YOU
THE SHORT. VERSION RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS THAT THIS THIS. IS A-
INDECENT AND ALTOGETHER
IMPROPER PLEASE VOTE NOW. THANK
YOU MISTER KILEY MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT OUR
BUDGET CHAIR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
TALKED ABOUT THIS IS A CLEAN UP
TO THE- JUNE BUDGET ACCORD THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT HERE. AND OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON WHO IS
NOT HERE TODAY. WITH THE ILL
FAMILY MEMBER TALKED ABOUT IN
HER DISTRICT THERE IS A
DISTRICT AND HOW A LOT OF BAY
AREA GROWTH. THEY WERE PLANNING
LITERALLY TO DOUBLE THEIR SIZE
OF THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
NEXT. CALENDAR YEAR. AND THEY
WOULD HAVE A TREMENDOUS HARM BY
NOT GETTING ADEQUATE FUNDING.
SO WE DECIDED THAT WAS A FLAW
WE WANTED TO FIX. UP IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THE ENTIRE ISSUES
THAT'S BEING BROUGHT UP. IT
WOULD BE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND THERE'S NO MAGIC
TO FERRY HANDING AROUND MONEY
HERE THAT MONEY WE HAVE TO COME
FROM SOMEWHERE. SO I ASKED THE
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THIS. YOU
WANT TO TAKE THOSE DOLLARS IN
YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT OVER HERE
BECAUSE WHAT WE DID. LAST
SPRING WE ASK NOT THE TEACHERS
WE ASK THE WHOLE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY. SCHOOL DISTRICT
SCHOOL BOARDS ACCESS THE
BUSINESS OFFICERS WHAT'S THE
BEST THING WE COULD DO TO HOLD
SCHOOLS HARMLESS THEY SAID DRAW
A LINE IN THE SAND. AS FAR AS
PICK A DATE AND WILL PICK THAT
TIME TO FIND SCHOOLS AT THAT
LEVEL. THAT WAS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE COVER NINETEEN CRISIS
WHICH WE HAVE TO LIVE WITHIN
OUR MEANS AT OUR STATE BUDGET
WE CAN'T PRINT MONEY I GUESS WE
COULD TAKE MONEY FROM THE
RESERVE THE RAINY DAY FUND BUT
WE NEED TO. AS THAT'S BECAUSE
THE VICE CHAIR SAID WE NEED
THAT MONEY FOR NEXT YEAR'S
DEFICIT SO THIS WAS. A
RESPONSIBLE DECISION IT'S NOT
DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST CHARTER
SCHOOLS THERE ARE MANY CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE A HOLD
HARMLESS FOR THE- CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS THIS JUST
SAYS THAT WE WANT TO FOCUS ON.
THE PLANNED GROWTH NOT THE
REALITY OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH-CO THAT HOPEFULLY WILL BE OUT
OF COPING IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
WE'LL GET BACK TO FUNDING BUT
THIS WAS A WAY TO MAKE SURE OUR
SCHOOLS STAY AFLOAT. WE DON'T
HAVE OUR SCHOOL WE DON'T HAVE
MORE OF A SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
GOING THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCESS ASK YOUR AB THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY A MISTER
VARYING YOUR- THANK YOU MADAM.
COLLEAGUES I DON'T LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS- TRAILER
BILL. AMENDS THE SCHOLARSHIP-
KIDS INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
SAVINGS PROGRAM- TO IN. IMPROVE
UPON THE EXISTING PROGRAM THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED ONLY TWO YEARS
AGO. TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CHILD IS COUNTED AND ACCOUNT.
IS SET UP FOR THEM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK WITH
THAT IMPROVEMENT AND ALSO HELP
THIS PROGRAM VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
KING WOULD YOU LIKE TO US.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I. FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
THIRTEEN MEASURE PASSES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
LIMóN MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DO
ATTRIBUTES. THE ONE AND ONLY
TODD GLORIA. WE WILL FIRST
RECOGNIZE MISTER BERMAN ON THIS
FOR YOU MISTER BERMAN. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. TODD MY DUDE.
TODD FIRST CAME INTO MY LIFE.
THE SAME WAY HE CAME IN A MANY
OF YOURS. AT THE FIRST CAUCUS
LUNCH THAT WE HAD. THIRTY SIX
HOURS AFTER POLLS CLOSE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. I'M SITTING
THERE. I HARDLY SLEPT IN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS. TRYING TO
PLAY IT COOL I BARELY KNOW
ANYONE IN THE ROOM PRETTY MUCH
IN ALL OF THE WHOLE SITUATION.
AND UP POPS TODD. LOOKING LIKE
A MODEL. ANY GIVES A MEMORIZED
FIFTEEN MINUTE TRIBUTE TO THE
SPEAKER. COOL CALM COLLECTED I
WAS STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PRONOUNCE THE SPEAKERS
LAST NAME. WAS IT RENDON
RENDELL OWN. BUT WHEN TODD SAT
DOWN THIRTY MINUTES AFTER HE
BEGAN. I KNEW HE'D BE A LEADER
IN OUR CLASS. A FEW DAYS LATER
TODD AND I WERE SITTING IN THE
LOBBY OF THE CITIZENS HOTEL OF
THE CITIZEN HOTEL. WAITING FOR
OUR BAGS TO COME OUT. I LOOK
OVER AT TODD ANY WITHOUT A CELL
PHONE PLUGGED INTO HIS LAPTOP
SET UP A SATELLITE PHONE ON HIS
RIGHT AND AN ESPRESSO MACHINE
ON HIS LEFT. ALL I HAD WAS MY
CELL PHONE AND 5% BATTERY. IN
THAT MOMENT I TOLD MYSELF MARC
JUST DO WHATEVER TODD DOES THIS
GUY'S A PRO. BUT IT'S TIME I
QUICKLY BECAME CLOSE FRIENDS I
REALIZED SOMETHING THAT
ABSOLUTELY BLEW MY MIND. TODD
GLORIA IS A BETTER PERSON ON
THE INSIDE MANY IS ON THE
OUTSIDE. AND IT LOOKS GOOD ON
THE OUTSIDE. TODD IS SINCERE
SMART AND SELFLESS. HE IS KIND
CARING AND COMPASSIONATE. HE'S
ALWAYS PAYING ATTENTION TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE FLOOR
AND YOUR BILL IS STRUGGLING TO
GET TO FORTY ONE VOTES HILL
IMMEDIATELY SHOW UP AT YOUR
SIDE ASKING WHOSE VOTES HE CAN
HELP YOU GO GET. EVEN IF HE'S
PERSONALLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
SPENT THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF
THE YEAR STAYING AT THE SHARED.
ONE DAY I COMPLAINED TO TALK
ABOUT HOW SOME OF THE BATHROOM
DOORS IN THE HOTEL OR ON
SPRINGS. IN THE DOORS DON'T
STAY OPEN. A FEW DAYS LATER I
WALKED INTO MY OFFICE. IN ON MY
DESK WITH A RUBBER DOOR STOP.
IN A NOTE FROM TIME. SPEAKING
OF THE SHARED AND- IT WAS THERE
THAT I ALSO LEARNED. THAT TODD
LITERALLY WAKES UP IN A SUIT
AND TIE. HAIR GELLED A PETUNIA
IN HIS LAPEL. LOOKING LIKE A
MILLION BUCKS. I WOULD STUMBLE
UP TO THE BREAKFAST LOUNGE IN
THE MORNING. JEANS AND A
SWEATSHIRT HAT TALK BELOW AND
WHEN THE ELEVATOR DOORS WOULD
SWING OPEN ON THE TWENTY SIXTH
FLOOR THE FIRST THING I'D SEE
IS TODD SMILING FACE. SUITED UP
MAN BAG IN HAND DONE WITH
BREAKFAST AND READY TO GO TO
THE CAPITOL THE WORK FOR HIS
CONSTITUENTS. AND YOU MIGHT
THINK THAT ANYONE WHO LOOKS
THAT GOOD MUST LOVE THE FINER
THINGS IN LIFE. YOU WOULD BE SO
VERY VERY WRONG. LAST YEAR
DURING A TRIP DOWN TO SAN DIEGO
FOR A HIGHER EDUCATION
CONFERENCE TODD PICK ME UP AT
THE HOTEL TO GO TO DINNER. I
SAID LET'S GO GET CHINESE FOOD
SOMETHING MY WIFE DOESN'T
REALLY LIKE SO WE DON'T NEED A
VERY OFTEN. I FIGURED TODD HE
OF EIGHT YEARS ON THE SAN DIEGO
CITY COUNCIL. INTERIM MAYOR.
AND THAT POINT THREE
REPRESENTING THE CITY- IN THE
COMMUNITY IN THE ASSEMBLY. HE
KNOW OF A GREAT PLACE TO GO. HE
SAID HE HAD A PLACE IN MIND. IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES LATER WE WERE
SITTING DOWN AT A SMALL
AUTHENTIC CHINESE RESTAURANT.
YEP JAMES. EVERY SINGLE TIME IN
THE LAST FOUR YEARS THAT I'VE
SEEN TODD SMILING FACE OR THIS
YEAR HIS SMILING FACE I HAVEN'T
MEDIALLY FELT BETTER NO MATTER
WHAT OTHER MEN IS GOING ON
AROUND US. TODD I AM SO SAD I
WON'T SEE YOU EVERY DAY UP HERE
BUT I CAN'T WAIT TO VISIT YOU-
IN THE MAYOR'S OFFICE IN SAN
DIEGO ALL MISSING. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN NOW BECAUSE WE ARE
CELEBRATING THE WITH HIMSELF.
WE HAVE TO MOVE PAST THE NEXT
BIGGER BECAUSE SHE'S NOT HERE
YEAH. TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
INTERMENT THERE ARE ZERO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. WHERE IS THAT
TODD AT. OF IRAQ I HAD A- AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW- TODD IS ONE
SASSY INDIVIDUAL. SASSY IS TO
SAY THE LEAST AND IF ANY OF YOU
HAD TO HAVE A CHANCE TO BE A
FLY ON THE WALL AT OUR EIGHT
O'CLOCK LGBT CAUCUS BREAKFAST
YOU WILL SEE THAT 95% OF THE
TIME IT'S JUST GOSSIPING. AND
5% OF THE TIME IS JUST GETTING
THROUGH SOME BUSINESS BUT- WE
WILL MISS TODD BECAUSE IT WAS
TIED THAT GETS US SO ENERGIZED
IN THE MORNING- WITH THIS
CONTINUING JOKES THAT HE'S HAD.
OF BUT HE HAS A VERY SERIOUS
SIDE HIM AS WELL. AND I SAW
THAT WHEN WE WERE MUCH YOUNGER
MAYBE ALMOST ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO I THINK NOW. IN
WHICH- IT WAS MYSELF A YOUNG
ELECTED OFFICIAL NAME ROBERT
GARCIA. AND A YOUNG MARE NAMED
CHRISTOPHER BALDING. AND THERE
WAS THE FOUR OF US CELEBRATING
IN LONG BEACH PRICE IN WHICH WE
ALL CRAMMED IN A SMALL HOTEL
ROOM BECAUSE WE CAN AFFORD. TO
BE IN SEPARATE ROOMS. SO THERE
WE WERE. TODD GLORIA NICE
SLEEPING ON THE FLOOR. TO SAVE
MONEY AND IT WAS DURING THAT
TIME WE START CHARTING OUT OF
POLITICAL TASK. THING WHERE WE
SHOULD WE ALL GO. AND TARGET
CONTINUALLY SAID MY HEART IS IN
THE CITY I WAS BORN IN. WHICH
IS THAT IN SAN DIEGO. BORN AND
RAISED FORTY TWO YEARS OF HIS
PRECIOUS LIFE. IN SAN DIEGO AND
IT'S NO WONDER THAT YOU SERVED
AS INTERIM MAYOR AT AN
IMPORTANT TIME BUT WE KNOW
THAT. YOU HAVE SUCH A DEEP
CHARACTER TO YOURSELF. A
SIMILARLY THERE IS A GROUPS
THAT GOES OUT TO DO EXERCISE
CLASS AT SIX AM IN THE MORNING.
HERE AND SURE ENOUGH IN BETWEEN
DIFFERENT SETS FOR ALL SETTING
UP TODD TO ANSWERING EMAILS AND
TWEETING. I SAID CAN YOU JUST
FOCUS FOCUS ON WHAT WE'RE DOING.
HE SAID I HAVE TO GET BACK TO
THIS CONSTITUENTS. WE THEN
WE'RE DRIVING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND I WAS DRIVING AND
SURE ENOUGH INSTEAD OF
LISTENING ON THE PHONE OR JUST
CASUALLY TALKING TO ME. YET AS
WELL NO CARDS PERSONALLY
WRITING THANK YOU NOTES TO
EVERYONE. THE CONSUMMATE PUBLIC
SERVANT AND SO TODD I HAVE
LEARNED FROM YOU- I KNOW WE
WILL FIND YOU IN. THE PLACES I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONTINUE SERVICE WE LOOK FOR TO
MUCH MORE HEADED FOR YOU. THANK
YOU MR LOW. MISLI MON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AS RUBIO STAFF THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I HAVE THE HONOR THAT IS
DEFINITELY A BITTER SWEET. ONE
TO SAY THE LEAST- TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ABOUT ONE OF MY
LEGISLATIVE PESKY'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA. I FIRST MET
TODD IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND IT
WAS TRULY LEGISLATIVE TESTY AT
FIRST SIGHT. WE MET AT THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES INFORMATIONAL
TRAINING HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I REMEMBER SITTING IN A
LARGE CONFERENCE ROOM.
SURROUNDING SURROUNDED BY
INSPIRING LEGISLATORS AND ONE
OF THEM ASKED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. AND ME NOT KNOWING
ANYONE IN THE ROOM LOOKED UP TO
SEE IF N. NAME ANYWAYS THINKING
WHAT I WAS THINKING AS I HEARD
THIS ONE MEMBER ASKED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. AND OF COURSE THE
FIRST IS THAT LOCKS WERE TODD
GLORIA. AND TAUGHT AND I
IMMEDIATELY CONNECTED AND WE
GAVE EACH OTHER A LOOK AS WE
HEARD FROM OUR NOW COLLEAGUE
LAURA FRIEDMAN. THE PRESENT.
AND YES TIME AND I HAVE BEEN
CONNECTED EVER SINCE THAT
MOMENT. THANK YOU LARA. HI I
HAVE GOT A CHANCE TO WORK
REALLY CLOSELY WITH TODD AND
GET TO KNOW HIM AS THE LEADER
THE LEGISLATOR AND THE HUMAN
THAT HE IS. AND I'VE LEARNED SO
MUCH FROM TODD. I'VE LEARNED
BOTH ABOUT WHO HE IS BUT ALSO
LEARN HOW TO BE BETTER
EVERYTHING I DO. TODD IS A
PERSON. THAT KNOWS A LOT ABOUT
HOW TO BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
ADVANCING EQUITY. LIKE THE ONE
TIME THAT OUR FRESHMAN YEAR
WHEN I WALKED INTO A MEETING I
SAT DOWN AND WAS IMMEDIATELY
GREETED WITH CITY HERE WITH THE
BIG BOYS MONIQUE. I LOOKED AT
ME. AND THE BOYS AND SAID RIGHT
ALL BIG KIDS AT THIS TABLE.
TODD IS ALSO SOMEONE WHO I'VE
LEARNED FROM WHEN IT COMES TO
BEING A LEGISLATIVE CHAMPION.
AND HAVING TO TRY TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. LIKE WITH HIS BILL AB
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN AT THIRTEEN
THREE YEARS TO GET OUT AND IT
WAS A FIGHT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE BROUGHT WITH HIM FROM SAN
DIEGO. THAT THE TRANSFERS H.
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
COULD BE SELF DETERMINING. IN
ESTABLISHING THEIR OWN FUNDING.
A LITTLE POLICY WONK BUT NONE
THE LESS IT SHOWS WHAT A TRUE
CHAMPION IS FOR A LOCAL
COMMUNITY. AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
TODD IS VERY PUNCTUAL. WE'VE
GOT IN HIS TEXT MESSAGES OR
CALLS. AND WE KNOW WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE TO BE ON TIME BUT
FOR MOST OF US WE STILL
STRUGGLE TO BE LIKE TAUGHT IN
THAT AREA. TODD IS A MAN OF
HUMILITY TRULY HE IS A MAN OF
THE PEOPLE AND I KNOW THIS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HANG OUT WITH
TALK ABOUT. YOU KNOW THAT HE'S
A SIMPLE GUY. AND PREFERS
MCDONALD'S AND JACK IN THE BOX
AMONG HIS FAVORITES PICKS TO
EAT. THAT MAKES HIM HAPPY AND
IT BRINGS A SMILE TO HIS FACE.
SPEAKING OF SMILES TODD IS THE
LEADER WHO CAN MAKE ANYONE
SMILE OR LAUGH. AND FOR THAT.
WE SOMETIMES REFER TO OUR TEXT
THREADS. PERHAPS SOME OF US
HAVE FORGOTTEN HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO HAVE THE ABILITY AND
SKILL TO HELP PEOPLE SMILE AND
LAUGH BUT A LOT OF US ALSO KNOW
THAT IN THE WORLD WE'RE IN IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE IT SEEMS WE'RE
CONSTANTLY ADDRESSING PROBLEM
AFTER PROBLEM AND THEY DON'T
AND- WE'RE LUCKY IF WE ARE ON A
TEXT THREAD WITH TODD. AND YOU
KNOW AT THE MOMENT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE MOST INAPPROPRIATE
TIME AND LAUGH OUT LOUD YOU
KNOW IT'S BECAUSE TODD HAD
SOMETHING SARCASTIC WITTY OR
HILARIOUS TO SAY. TADI IS ALSO
SOMEONE WHO KNOWS HOW TO
CONNECT WITH PEOPLE. I WATCHED
HIM THROUGH TIME AND HE WAS THE
FIRST IN OUR FRESHMAN CLASS TO
BE ABLE TO CONNECT WITH PEOPLE
IN THIS BUILDING. HE WAS THE
FIRST TO MEMORIZE THE NAME OF
EACH SERGEANT HERE BUT NOT JUST
THAT HE WAS THE FIRST TO KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT THEIR PERSONAL
LIFE. AND THAT WAS TRULY
EXTRAORDINARY. TODD IS ALSO
SOMEONE WHO IS INCREDIBLE AT
BUILDING AND LEADING TEAMS. I
HAVE MET MEMBERS OF THE TOP
SQUAD IN BOTH THE DISTRICT AND
THE CAPITAL AND THEY FOLLOW AND
LEAD WITH HIM IN WAYS THAT ONLY
SOME OF US COULD WISH. TODD IS
THE LEADER WHO OTHERS WANT TO
EMULATE. IN OUR FRESHMAN CLASS
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN TODD BECAME
THE MOST POPULAR ONE THE
FASTEST. HE WAS SO POPULAR THAT
THERE WAS INDEED IMMEDIATE
SPECULATION THAT PERHAPS ONE
DAY HE COULD LEAVE THIS HOUSE
BECAUSE HE WAS THE MOST
CHARISMATIC ONE AND WE ALL
WANTED TO FOLLOW. THANK GOD
START IT LET'S FACE IT TIME
ALSO HELPS US EMPIRE AND
INSPIRED TO LOOK AS GOOD AS HE
DOES. NOW I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
COMPETITION BETWEEN IAN
ADVANTAGE AND ROB IN TERMS OF
WHO HAS THE BEST HAIR BUT
TAUGHT IS DEFINITELY IN THE
RUNNING- IN TERMS OF BEST HAIR
AND FASHION. THERE'S SO MUCH TO
LEARN FROM TODD AND ALSO SO
MUCH THAT TODD HAS TO OFFER TO
CALIFORNIANS TO HIS COLLEAGUES
TO HIS FRIENDS. AND I DO WONDER
TO MYSELF IF THE PEOPLE OF SAN
NO HOW MUCH YOU HAVE TO OFFER.
AND HOW MUCH CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO MISS YOU LEADING THE
WAY. I KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA IS
NOT COMPLETELY LOSING AND SAN
DIEGO IS ABSOLUTELY GAINING BUT
YOU NEED TO KNOW HOW MUCH YOU
WILL BE MISSED. TODD I KNOW SO
MANY OF US HERE IS A LOOK
AROUND THE ROOM WOULD LOVE TO
BE HERE STANDING TO GIVE YOU A
TRIBUTE BUT THANKS TO IAN WE
WEREN'T ALLOWED TO. THIS IS
COMING I'M- LET ME THERE ARE
STILL MANY DOZENS OF MEMBERS
THAT WOULD LOVE TO RAISE THEIR%
MIKE AND ECHO HOW INCREDIBLE
YOU HAVE BEEN AND THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT YOU HAVE HAD
TO OUR CAPITAL COMMUNITY WE
WILL MISS YOU TODD AND WE ARE
THANKFUL TO YOU FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE CONTRIBUTED AND
EVERYTHING WE HAVE LEARNED FROM
YOU. GOOD LUCK IN SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU MISLI MON MISTER
GLORIA THE FLOOR IS YOURS. WHO
IS THAT GUY YOU GUYS ARE JUST
TALKING ABOUT. WHAT IS THE- I
WANT TO BE BRIEFED TO NOT
REPEAT NOT TO IN MY ASSEMBLY
CAREER THE WAY I STARTED WHICH
IS TALKING PER PLATE TOO LONG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR
NOT HOLDING THAT AGAINST ME ALL
THESE YEARS- I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MY DEAR FRIENDS-
FOR CALLING FROM PALO ALTO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CAMPBELL AND MY
COLLEAGUE. FROM THE LEADER. OR
SANTA BARBARA. BOTH WORK- WHO
ARE TRULY EXCEPTIONAL FRIENDS
THREE OF MANY EXCEPTIONAL
FRIENDS WHO I WILL TAKE WITH
ME. AS A LIFELONG ASSET THAT I
EARNED WHILE I WAS HERE BETTER
THAN ALMOST ANYTHING ELSE WE
COULD DO AND I THINK YOU GUYS
FOR STANDING SPEAKING. ON MY
BEHALF AND- PROSECCO IT OUT-
THE REAL ME WHICH IS I DON'T
GET IT TWISTED THIS IS FROM
GROUPON- ADD AT I DO LOVE A BIG
DONALD DRIVE THROUGH- ITS-
POINT ACCOUNT COMPLETELY- COME
ALIGNED WITH MY KIND OF PLANS
BUT NEVERTHELESS. THE PRICE IS
RIGHT AND I'M A GIRL ON THE GO.
SO I JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY- TO EXPRESS HIS
GRATITUDE- LEADING THE
LEGISLATURE AT THIS POINT- IS
BITTERSWEET FOR ME- I THINK MR
LOW WOULD SUBMIT IT WAS I WAS
WAY FOR HIM TO SAY THAT. IF I
HAD SOME. OF THE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ANY OF YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE CERTAIN LOCAL. YOU
ALWAYS THINK THAT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. IS THE BEST THING
EVER- BUT THEN YOU GET UP AND
YOU REALIZE THE IMPACT THAT YOU
CAN MAKE. AND WHAT I'VE
REALIZED IN TERMS MY BRACE OF
WHAT WE CAN DO IS A STATE
GOVERNMENT IS REALLY DONE THAT
FILE YOU AND SO I WANT
EXPRESSED. PRE FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO MY CONSTITUENTS THE
PEOPLE OF THE SEVENTY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. PEOPLE OF MY HOMETOWN
OF SAN DIEGO. I KNOW THE MAN
AND I CAN RELATE TO THIS.
CONFLICT TO THIS POINT ABOUT
THE FACT THAT. WE COME. MODEST
BACK. AND YET WE'RE HERE. AND I
ALWAYS THINK ABOUT THE PRIEST.
I HAVE FOR THE P. WHO ELECT ME.
I THINK THAT'S WHEN I WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND I HAD A-
TEACHER WHO SAID. THEY GAVE US
COULDN'T DO ANYTHING IN
POLITICS THE BILL IS ACTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE EXCLUDED YOU BECAUSE
THAT JUST WAS NOT. ALLOWED IN
THE PEOPLE OF SAN DIEGO
REPEATEDLY HAVE SAID THAT THAT
IS NOT THE CASE. AND THE JUDGE
YOU ON YOUR MERITS AND ON YOUR
SKILLS AND ABILITIES AND I'VE-
ALWAYS WALKED IN HERE. WITH THE
TREMENDOUS GRATITUDE TO THE
PEOPLE DESK OF THE BY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOR GIVING ME THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY. AND
REALLY IN MANY WAYS IS A
QUINTESSENTIAL SAN DIEGO STORY.
CONCEPTUAL CALIFORNIA SENATE
STORY. QUINTESSENTIAL AMERICAN
STORY. I THINK MY- AND THIS IS
WHERE AS MONEY SPENT I WANT TO
KNOW IS THAT SHE- SHOULD HAVE
THANKED HER HUSBAND AND HER
STAFF IT SHE THOUGHT ABOUT THE
START THAT IMMEDIATELY AFTER
SHE FINISHED HER COMMENTS- BUT
YOU KNOW HE'S GOT A FEW THINGS
ON HER LIST OF THINGS TO DO I
GUESS TO MIKE INTO TEAM ON-
YOUR BOSS LEGGIO IT YOUR WIFE
LOVES YOU. I'M HERE TO HELP.
FACILITATE. I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
MY STAY TO TALK SQUAD WHO ARE
WATCH IT JUST OFFICE AND
WATCHING FROM THEIR HOMES WELL.
I GUESS I'LL COME FROM THEIR
HOMES. YOU KNOW YOU GET MY
POINT THEIR INCREDIBLE TEAM OF
FOLKS WHO CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
PUBLIC SERVICE- IF I'VE HAD ANY
SUCCESS WHATSOEVER IT'S BECAUSE
THEY- ARE COMMITTED TO THIS
PROFESSION IS I AM COMMITTED TO
IT. AND I THINK ALL OF YOU SB
DRIVING ALL OF YOU YOU KNOW
THAT OUR STAFF TO WORK HARDER
THAN THEY EVER HAVE OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS. IT'LL TO
PHYSICALLY IN TIME WISE BUT
ALSO MENTALLY.AND SAID EVERY
MEMBER OF MY TEAM THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH. FOR ALWAYS MAKING ME
LOOK GOOD BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
FOR ALWAYS SERVING THE PEOPLE
OF SAN DIEGO AS WELL AS YOU DO.
I THINK IT'S- SPEAKER AND-
RENDON FORGET NOT HOLDING THAT-
THAT INITIAL SPEECH AGAINST ME-
GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY- TO BE
A PART OF THE FOURTEEN. IN TO
KEVIN TO- RB K. TO TASHA INTO
JESSE OUR SYSTEM LET'S- SENATE
FORTUNATE RECREATION. ASSISTANT
BUT- THE I THINK YOU FOR. BEING
A PART OF A TEAM THAT'S ALWAYS
BEEN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH. I WANT TO THANK SUPA- AND
HER TEAM AND THE CLERK STAFF-
WHO ARE EXCEPTIONAL TO WORK
WITH AN INCREDIBLE
PROFESSIONALS. INTERESTED LIKE
TO WORK WITH AS WELL AS OUR
CHIEF- CHIEF BUCKLEY. ON IN THE
SERGEANTS- WHO ARE. I THINK I
CAN SPEAK FOR EVERYONE ALSO
INCREDIBLE. CREW THAT WE CANNOT
DO OUR JOBS WITHOUT ALSO
REVENUE. OF HARRY AND PUBLISHED
AT WHO IS. TO SEE THEM TODAY
RIGHT IT'S BEEN TO A TO. HAVE
SEEN THEM THEIR EXCEPTIONAL
PEOPLE. LASTLY I JUST WANT TO
TAKE MY FAMILY- I KNOW HOW TO
PUT MY DAUGHTER WATCHING
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THEY ROLL-
AND I LOVE THEM I LOVE YOU
ADAM- I LOVE MY FAMILY THERE
THE REASONS WHY DO THIS WORK.
AND LASTLY I JUST WANT TO SAY
TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES- I RESPECT
EVERYONE OF YOU. I'M GRATEFUL
FOR WHAT YOU DO FOR THE STATE.
IS OFTEN UNHERALDED WORK I KNOW
YOU SACRIFICE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT TO BE HERE. AND I LEAVE-
THIS POSITION- CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE. BUT
LESS CONCERNED. YOU ARE HERE
AND I KNOW MANY OF YOUR HEARTS
I KNOW MANY OF YOUR SOULS AND I
KNOW THAT YOU CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE YEARS TO
COME YOU WILL DO THE WORK THAT
IS NECESSARY. TO TACKLE THIS
VIRUS TO PUT THIS ECONOMY BACK
TOGETHER. TO ADDRESS THE
INJUSTICES IN OUR STATE. AND I
JUST ASK WHEN YOU WORK ON THOSE
ISSUES HAVE TO ASK YOU TWO
THINGS. DON'T FORGET ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. THIS IS SO
QUINTESSENTIALLY THE CHALLENGE
OF OUR COMMUNITY THE STATE
CANNOT BE JUST A PLACE FOR THE
VERY WEALTHY CAN AFFORD TO LIVE
HERE IN A VERY POOR WHO ARE
TRAPPED HERE. WE HAVE TO HAVE A
PLACE FOR WORKING MIDDLE CLASS
PEOPLE IN THE STATE. VERTICALLY
THE MOST VULNERABLE THE
MENTALLY ILL. IN THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE BEHAVIOR HEALTH. FOLKS
YOU GUYS HAVE TO CONTINUE WORK
ON THIS AND PLEASE COUNT ON ME
TO HELP IN ANY WAY THAT I CAN.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD ASK
YOU. SHOW UP ON TIME WOULD YOU
PLEASE. VOTE ON THE TRAILER
BILL. DON'T TO THE NEXT WEAPON
EXPLAINED HOW SLOW THIS IS
GOING YET YOU WERE. TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES LATE TO THE FLOOR YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN VOTING THESE ARE
THINGS ARE. NOT EXACTLY
CONSISTENT AND- I JUST ON
BEHALF OF THAT PERSON I WANT TO
JUST PUT A SHOUT OUT. YOU
SHOULD BE. ON TIME. RIGHT
BEHIND. AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE NEXT WITH TO USE COLORFUL
GIFTS AND OTHER- WAYS TO GET
PEOPLE TO COME TO THE FLOOR
THAT'S A THAT'S A- THAT'S A
PROVEN TACTIC- LAST I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS IS NOT GOODBYE. I
HAVE ONE REMIND YOU ALL THAT. I
WILL INTEND TO COME BACK TO
SACRAMENTO FREQUENTLY TO MAKE
SURE THE SAN DIEGO'S GATES FAIR
SHARE. OF STATE RESOURCES- WE
MUST- IT WAS THE SECOND LARGEST
CITY IN THE TATE- NEEDS TO. BE
HEARD HERE IN THE- IN THE
CAPITAL. BUT I ALSO WANTED BY
CHILDREN NUMBER THEY SAID IT
WAS A TOURISM TOWN- AND WE LOVE
TO HAVE VISITORS. INTO YOU'RE
ALWAYS WELCOME IN AMERICA'S
FINEST CITY. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS HONOR FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I RESPECT AND LOVE
YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA AND NOT
JUST FOR TAKING THAT LAST
MOMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR-
FLOOR RUNS JUST ISTANTLY.
AFTER YOU LEAVE AS IT DOES NOW.
YOU KNOW THAT. ALL THE. USING.
FOR MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK SPEAKING CURRENT FILE
FILE ITEM THREE AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
COUNTIES. ELEVEN A FIVE THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS MEASURE
IS BACK HERE ON CONCURRENCE
THIS IS A BILL THAT DEALS WITH
OVERSIGHT OVER SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CERTAINLY WE KNOW THERE IS A
DESIRE IN OUR NATION OUR STATE
TO BRING ABOUT POLICE REFORM IN
THEIR OF GEORGE FLOYD BUT I
THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON WHAT. IS A SMART
POLICE REFORM THAT CAN BE
EMBRACED HI THIS BILL SIMPLY
WOULD CLARIFY AND CODIFY THAT
A. COUNTY MAY ESTABLISH AN
OVERSIGHT BOARD OR AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL POSITION AND I WOULD
STATE THAT THIS IS. LOCAL
CONTROL THE THOUSAND MANDATE
THEN THE STATES THAT THEY MAY
CREATE THEM EITHER BY THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS VOTE. OR BY A
VOTE OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
COUNTY THIS SIMPLY WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THESE OVERSIGHT
BOARDS CAN'T BE IGNORED BY THE
LOCAL SHERIFF WOULD GVE THESE
ENTITIES SUBPOENA POWER THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS FOR TECHNICAL
IN NATURE CLARIFYING THAT THIS
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WILL NOT HAVE. SUPERVISOR
POWERS JUST PROPER OVERSIGHT
WHY DOES THIS MATTER HERE IN
OUR COUNTY IN SACRAMENTO AND LA
AND ALAMEDA WE'VE SEEN WERE
SOME OF THE SHERIFFS WILL SAY
HEY ARE OVERSIGHT IS THE
ELECTION EVERY FOUR YEARS. WE
KNOW THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE ALREADY DO
THIS THE POLICE CHIEFS FRANKLY
DO THIS ON A REGULAR BASIS
THROUGH CITIES MANY OF OUR
COUNTIES OPERATE NOW AS
MUNICIPAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS
THIS IS A SMART REFORM. AND
THAT WE VOTED ON IT AGAIN LAST
YEAR AND I ASK. FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY WITH CONCURRENCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER TO. WAIT
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. OF A. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
OUR MEMBERS GO TO THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ADVOCATES
REQUIRES. FORTY ONE UHHUH
ACCORDING TO THE CALL. THE
MOVING THE FILE ITEM FOR AB
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TO FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN AND OTHERS AND ACT
WITHIN THE OIL AND GAS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SEE MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY
TWO FOURTEEN INCREASES CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR OIL SPILLS INTO
THE STATE WATER SENATE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALL
REQUIREMENTS TO INCREASE
INSURANCE REDUCE THE
DISCRETIONARY PENALTY AND MAKE
THE PENALTY ONLY AVAILABLE FOR
SPILLS OVER A THOUSAND GALLONS
AS A REMINDER THIS BILL IS ONE
THAT COMES AFTER A DEVASTATING
SITUATION IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND HAS ONLY BEEN USED
ONCE IN THE LAST TEN YEARS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISLI MON
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THERE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS GO TO THEIR VOTE.
REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. THE MOMENT
THE CALL.
WE WILL MOVE TO
CONCURRENCE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS ANOTHER
PERSON ACTUALLY THE CIVIL
ACTIONS THREE OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE.
SIX FIVE I WOULD ALLOW TRIAL
COURTS TO RECOVER THE COST OF
ELECTRONIC FILING REMOVING A
DISINCENTIVE TO OFFERING THIS.
TYPE OF SERVICE RECENT
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE GRANTED A
FEE WAIVER I'M NOT REQUIRED TO
PAY COURT OR VENDOR E. FILING
FEES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
RIVER SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTER TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
YEAH. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY VOTE I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONFERRED IN WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THOUSAND
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS ANOTHER SNACK LEADING TO
LEROY ANDERSON DAM AND
RESERVOIR AND CLEARLY- TO SEE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT IN THE-
HISTORY OF IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER- SO THIS IS AN
URGENCY BILL SEEKING TO
EXPEDITE PERMITTING
CONTRACTING. REQUIREMENTS IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE
CONSTRUCTION IMPROVEMENTS AT
LEROY ANDERSON DAM IN THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES IN THE BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- THIS. BILL TOOK
UP A LOT OF EFFORT TO- COME
TOGETHER AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
INVESTING IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED VERY. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO THE. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS SIXTY
KNOWS ONE OF THE MEASURE I
SIXTY KNOWS ONE ON THE URGENCY
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN. WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER. FIFTY FIVE. SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND ACRYLATE IN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MAKING
APROPRIATION OF FOUR
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
EACH YEAR THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE AUTHORS
AN OMNIBUS BILL WHICH PROPOSES
RELATIVELY MINOR NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO THE
LAWS AFFECTING LOCAL AGENCIES
POWERS AND DUTIES. COMBINING
SMALL STATUTORY CHANGES THAT DO
NOT WARRANT SEPARATE BILLS INTO
A SINGLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SAVES HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN LEGISLATIVE COSTS.
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE IS
THIS YEAR'S LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OMNIBUS BILL WHICH CONTAINS
FIFTEEN PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
BEEN VETTED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS CONSENSUS ON. EACH AND
NO AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR DRIVER.
THANK YOU WITH AGUIAR-CURRY
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VERIFONE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE TO VOTE. WHERE
TWELVE HELLO THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SIXTEEN OH ZERO
SENATE. MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS
WE WILL TURN TO CONCURRENCE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE ACR ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMORY AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CORPORATE
SAYING MEMORIAL HIGHWAY MR GRAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. ACR ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WILL DESIGNATE A
PORTION OF HIGHWAY THIRTY THREE
IN MERCED COUNTY AFTER CORPORAL
RONALD SINGH. THE NEW IN POLICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICER WHO WAS
TRAGICALLY SHOT AND KILLED IN
THE EARLY HOURS OF DECEMBER
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
DURING A ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP.
AFTER IMMIGRATING TO THE UNITED
STATES FROM FIJI KARPAL SINGH
BEGAN HIS CAREER LAW
ENFORCEMENT FULFILLED HIS DREAM
OF SERVING HIS FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS AS CADET WITH THE
TURLOCK POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND
LATER AS A RESERVE OFFICER FOR
THE MERCED COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. HE WAS WELL
RESPECTED SEVEN YEAR VETERAN OF
THE NEWMAN POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WHO ENJOYED THE HIGH REGARD OF
THE COMMUNITY AND SERVED AS A
ROLE MODEL FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. A MUCH LOVED
HUSBAND FATHER AND FRIEND
CORPORAL SAYING IS SURVIVED BY
HIS LOVING WIFE. HIS INFANT
SON. HAS EXTENDED LAW
ENFORCEMENT FAMILY. AND HIS K.
NINE PARTNER SAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR ONE TWENTY. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE THIRD VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN. MISTER KANSEN CHU IS
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM. THIRTY THREE AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THOSE EYES FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COULD. BERDAN ICE FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY.
MEMBERS
WILL TURN TO CONCURRENCE ITEM
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN HOUSING
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU- THIS BILLS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE MADE A COUPLE
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE SENATE BUT
IT ALLOWS FOR HIGHER DENSITY
HOUSING- ALLOWS FOR SOME
INCENTIVES ON LIKE.
ARCHITECTURAL AND- BASIS ON
DENSITY- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
BUILDINGS MAYBE DON'T HAVE TO
BE AS PRETTY YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE BOXES OF PETUNIAS OUT
THERE- BUT THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALES.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IN THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS VALUE THEIR TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CAN BE HEARD IN. WE WILL TAKE
UP FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AN
ACCOLADE IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT THIS IS DOWN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS EVERY YEAR
THEY- JUDICIARY COMMITTEE DOES
SEVERAL. ON THE BUS BILLS THIS
YEAR AND WHAT WE DID IN THE
SENATE SENT TO WAS FOR
EFFICIENCIES REASONS COMBINED
THEM. INTO ONE BILL THESE ARE
NOT CONTROVERSIAL ITEMS WERE
DOING CO CLEAN UP AND
ADDRESSING CHANGES IN VARIOUS
SEGMENTS OF THE CODE THAT NEED
TO BE. DEALT WITH I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ON CONCURRENCY
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR
STERN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THE ALL MEMBERS OF ADDRESS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALITHA I SIXTY KNOWS ONE
SENTIMENT ARE COMPARED IN.
I
DIDN'T MEAN TO STARTLE YOU
MEMBERS HOWEVER. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
MOMENTOUS BY TURNING TO THE
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. DON'T GET ME
WRONG WE'RE NOT LIFTING THE
CALL WE'RE JUST TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY.
SO MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
THE GERMAN TO MEMORY. MR MAYS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
A MEMBERS. AS OUR HOSPITALS
WORK HARD TO MEET THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC- THEY ARE
SADDENED TO WITH THE LOSS OF
ONE OF THEIR OWN. SUITE C.
DWAYNE DAUGHTER WAS KILLED IN A
CAR ACCIDENT NEAR HIS HOME IN
PALM DESERT. DUANE WHO TURNED
EIGHTY IN MAY LEAD THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS. BEFORE
RETIRING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
DWAYNE WAS A VISIONARY LEADER
AND A LIFE FORCE ALL ITS OWN. A
SON OF A KANSAS FARMING FAMILY
AND A MATH PROFESSOR BY
BACKGROUND DOING GOT HIS START
IN THE HOSPITAL FILL THE
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX WHEN HE
JOINED THE CAST THE KANSAS
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION THAT AS
ITS CEO. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE HE TOOK OVER THE REINS OF
THE MISSOURI HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WHERE HE SPENT TEN
YEARS BEFORE MOVING WEST TO
JOIN C. H. A. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. DWAYNE'S
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY CARE
FOR ALL AMERICANS NEVER
WAVERED. HIS STEADY HAND
STEERED CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS
THROUGH SOME OF ITS MOST
PIVOTAL MOMENTS. IN
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
EVOLUTION. HE OFTEN QUOTED CJ'S
VISION OF AN OPTIMALLY HEALTHY
SOCIETY AS HE RELENTLESSLY
PURSUED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. DATING BACK TO
THE CLINTON MINISTRATION THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES. HE WAS
NEVER HAPPIER THAN WHEN THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS FINALLY
PASSED AND SIGNED INTO LAW IN
TWENTY TEN. FOR THOSE WHO WORK
CLOSELY WITH LANE. HIS AND
WAVERING DEDICATION TO
HOSPITALS THEIR MISSION AND THE
SUCCESS WAS IN HIS DNA. EVEN
RETIRED RETIREMENT DWAYNE
SERVED ON SEVERAL HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS BOARD OF TRUSTEES. FOR
THOSE WHO NEED WHEN PERSONALLY
HE WAS KIND AND THOUGHTFUL. HE
NEVER FAILED TO ASK ABOUT YOUR
FAMILY AND HE WAS ALWAYS
REMEMBERED WITH THE SMALLEST
DETAILS. HE ALSO LOVE THE GAME
OF GOLF WHICH IS WHY HE RETIRED
MY DISTRICT. ARE MOST
IMPORTANTLY- THE LAST IN NEARLY
FIFTEEN YEARS OF HIS LIFE HE
ADORED HIS GRACIOUS AND
CHARMING WIFE DIANE. THE WOMAN
HE CALLED THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH DIANE. HIS CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN AS WE ADJOURN AT
THIS EVENING MAYBE DURING HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MR MAYOR. FIFTY NINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO
REMEMBER DONALD ANTHONY SKINNER
BETTER KNOWN AS TONY SKINNER.
TONY GREW UP IN OXNARD AND
LATER MOVED TO VENTURA. HE WAS
THROUGH AND THROUGH A CHAMPION
FOR WORKING FAMILIES AND UNION
RIGHTS ARE RESPECTED MAN TONY
FOLLOWED IN HIS FATHER'S
FOOTSTEPS BECOMING A UNION
MEMBER OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERS IBEW LOCALS NINE FIVE
TWO IN VENTURA WHERE HE LATER
BECAME PRESIDENT. NOT ONLY WAS
HE WELL KNOWN THROUGH HIS LOCAL
I. B. W. BUT HE WAS A KNOWN
LEADER ACROSS THE CENTRAL COAST
HE LED THE TRI COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. AS EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY TREASURE FROM VENTURA
TO LOS AT LAW SAMUS OBISPO
COUNTIES. FOR ANYONE RUNNING
FOR OFFICE TONY WAS THE GUY TO
TALK TO. HE ADVOCATED FOR THE
BUILDING TRADES AND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN
EVERY SPACE POSSIBLE. AND WHEN
THEY AND WHEN THE NEED CAME HE
MADE SURE TO PACK ALL PUBLIC
MEETING ROOMS WITH UNION
MEMBERS TO GET THAT MESSAGE
ACROSS. HE CARRIED MUCH PRIDE
IN THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
AT I. B. W. AND HE MADE SURE TO
INVITE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
TO THEIR ANNUAL GRADUATIONS TO
ENSURE WE SAW. THE VALUE OF
APPRENTICESHIPS. KNOWING WELL
THE NEED FOR SKILLED LABOR
FORCE HE CARRIED HIS EXPERIENCE
AND VISION FORWARD WHEN HE
FOUNDED ACE CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL
IN CAMERI TEN YEARS AGO. THE
SCHOOL FOCUSED ON CAREER AND
TECHNICAL EDUCATION
ARCHITECTURE CONSTRUCTION AND
ENGINEERING I WAS ALWAYS A
PART OF HIM IN SO MANY WAYS.
TONY PASSED AWAY SUDDENLY ON
AUGUST TWENTY FIFTH JUST FOUR
DAYS BEFORE HIS SIXTY SEVENTH
BIRTHDAY. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
SON MATTHEW SKINNER DAUGHTER IN
LAWS ALWAYS SKINNER AND HIS
SISTERS NANCY JEAN AND SKINNER.
TONY'S PASSING IS A TREMENDOUS
LOSS FOR OUR LABOR COMMUNITY
AND COMMUNITY AT LARGE ON THE
CENTRAL COAST. HE WILL BE
MISSED I ASKED THAT TODAY WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS LIMóN MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES THAT HAVE TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TURN TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE. SB FIFTY FOUR MS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ADAM SPEAKER. I RISE TO
PRESENT. LAWLER GONZALEZ. SORRY-I DIDN'T HAVE THE CLERK READ
YOUR ONE SECOND. SENATE BILL
FIFTY FOUR VICE CENTER ALLEN
AND OTHERS AND ACT WITHIN THE
SOLID WASTE. WE WERE SO EXCITED
WE JUMPED THE GUN. I RECOGNIZE
THIS IS ALICE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FIFTY FOUR THE COMPANION
MEASURE TO MY OWN BILL AB TEN
EIGHTY WHICH PASSED THE SENATE
YESTERDAY WITH TWENTY THREE
VOTES. WOULD INSURE CALIFORNIA
IS ON THE FOREFRONT OF REDUCING
POLLUTION FROM SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS.
ALL OF US ALREADY KNOW THERE IS
A PROBLEM WITH PLASTIC. WE SEE
THE COUNTLESS NEWS STORIES ON
MARINE LIFE DYING WITH STOMACHS
FULL OF PLASTIC WE SEE THE
LITTER IN OUR STREETS OUR LOCAL
LANDFILLS REACHING CAPACITY. IN
OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES
SPENDING FAR TOO MUCH ON THE
BUDGETS ON WASTE MANAGEMENT.
THAT'S WHY THEY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THE CURRENT PANDEMIC HAS
ONLY INCREASED AWARENESS OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC LIKE
UTENSILS BAGS AND CONTAINERS.
OF ALL OF OUR FAVORITE
TAKEOUTS. NO ONE IS SAYING THAT
THESE ITEMS DON'T HAVE TO USE
BUT WE ARE NOT BEING HONEST
WITH OURSELVES ABOUT THEIR END
OF LIFE AND IT'S PAST TIME TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. WITHOUT
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM WE WILL
CONTINUE TO THROW OUR SINGLE
USE PLASTICS AND THE RECYCLING
BIN. TO BE SORTED AND BALED.
BUT THEY WILL ONLY END UP IN
THE LANDFILL OR INCINERATED.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL WOULD TAKE
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
REDUCE WASTE. FROM SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING. AND
SPECIFIED PRODUCTS 75% BY
TWENTY THIRTY TO THROUGH SOURCE
REDUCTION RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING. AND REQUIRE THESE
ITEMS BE FULLY RECYCLABLE OR
COMPOSTABLE. BY TWENTY THIRTY
TO. HOW WE GET THERE WILL. BY
ROAD TAKE PROCESS IN
CONSULTATION WITH AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL. AS WELL AS
INCREMENTAL REQUIRED RECYCLING
RATES. BY HOLDING PRODUCERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACHIEVING THESE
GOALS WE WILL CREATE THE DEMAND
FOR OUR RECYCLABLES TO BE
TURNED INTO NEW PRODUCTS.
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL TO
ENCOURAGE IN STATE
MAUFACTURING AND DISCOURAGE
THE EXPORT OF MATERIALS HELPS
DRIVE US TOWARDS A PATH WHERE
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD NOT JUST IN
THE REDUCTION OF WASTE. BUT IN
GROWING OUR IN STATE RECYCLING
INDUSTRY THIS MEANS JOBS. JOBS
JOBS. BETWEEN THE TWO COMPANION
BILLS OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE HAD OVER TEN HEARINGS IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
INSPECT COUNTLESS HOURS WITH
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ALL SIDES WITH DIAMETRICALLY
OPPOSED VIEWS INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND CAL
RECYCLE. WE ALSO TOOK A HARD
THIS YEAR WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT
AND HOW TO CUT THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL DOWN FROM LAST YEAR REDUCE
COSTS AND GIVE BUSINESSES
RELIEF. LANGUAGE WORKED ON ALL
YEAR IN IN THIS FORM REDUCES
THE BILL FROM COVERING ALL
MATERIAL TYPES TO PLASTIC ONLY.
IN MORE CLEARLY EXEMPTS
NEGLIGIBLE AMOUNTS OF PLASTIC
AND PACKAGING SUCH AS CAPS OR
LABELS. IT GIVES TWO ADDITIONAL
YEARS TO PRODUCERS TO MEET THE
SPECIFIED RECYCLING RATES IN
THE BILL MEANING THAT A
PRODUCER WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO AN ACTUAL PENALTY FOR
FAILING TO MEET THE RECYCLING
RATE UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY. TEN
YEARS FROM NOW. BUT PLEASE
DON'T BE LULLED INTO THINKING
BECAUSE IT'S TEN YEARS FROM NOW
WE CAN PUT THIS OFF WE KEEP
PUTTING IT OFF EVERY YEAR. IT
PROVIDES RELIEF TO SMALLER
BUSINESSES BY CLARIFYING
EXEMPTION AND SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWERING THE MAXIMUM PENALTY
AMOUNT FOR SMALLER SIZED
PRODUCERS FROM FIFTY THOUSAND
TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. PER
VIOLATION. AT IT ADDS
CONSIDERATION OF AGRICULTURAL
CONCERNS INCLUDING AN EXEMPTION
FOR FARMERS A PACKAGE ON SITE
AND ADDITION OF A RE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE ADVISORY
PANEL AND VARIOUS PROVISIONS ON
FEDERAL REGULATIONS FOR FOOD
PACKAGING. IT CLARIFIES DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND CODE
RATHER THAN LEAVING IT UP TO
THE DEPARTMENT ADD SIGNIFICANT
SAFEGUARDS TO STEER TO STORE
CHIP ORGANIZATIONS INTO USING
OUR EXISTING COLLECTION AND
SORTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO THE
MAXIMUM EXTENT FEASIBLE
INCORPORATES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE LOGISTICS
OF THE MINISTRY FEET IN THE
BILL. AT THE END OF THE DAY NOT
EVERY COMPANY OR ORGANIZATION
IS GOING TO BE SATISFIED THAT'S
ALWAYS THE CASE BECAUSE SOME
SIMPLY DON'T WANT TO CHANGE THE
STATUS QUO AND ARE GOING TO USE
A PANDEMIC AS AN EXCUSE TO KEEP
WAITING ON A SOLUTION THAT IS
NOT COMING IN. THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE WAYS
THEY'RE PUTTING OUT INTO OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR COMMUNITIES
SB FIFTY FOUR DEMANDS AND THAT
PRODUCERS FINALLY BECOME PART
OF THE WAY SOLUTION. THAT
CONSUMERS HAULERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN HAVE BEEN
TRYING THEIR BEST TO COMBAT.
BUT CANNOT KEEP UP WITH WITHOUT
THE MISSING LINK I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT WE CAN ACT OR
WE CAN WAIT FOR A PROPOSITION
TO BE PUT ON THE BALLOT IN
PASSED BECAUSE IT WILL PASS WE
CAN HAVE A HAND IN WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE OR WE CAN ALLOW
OTHER PEOPLE TO DO IT. FOR US I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
MISSED FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU KNOWS HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE GET A
HANDLE ON PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN FACT IN THE
WORLD WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
HEARTBREAKING PHOTOS OF DEAD
SEA ANIMALS WE ALL HAVE TO
EXPLAIN TO OUR CHILDREN. WHY
THIS COULD BE MORE PLASTIC IN
THE OCEAN BY THE TIME THEY GROW
UP AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE FISH
IN THE OCEAN. WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS A PRODUCT THAT IS ETERNAL
THAT DOESN'T BIODEGRADE. THAT
IS LITERALLY KILLING PARTS OF
OUR PLANET. AND I WILL TELL YOU
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AS SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED ON
THIS BILL IN MY COMMITTEE FOR
THE PAST YEAR. THIS BILL IS
ALSO AN EXAMPLE OF A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF COMPROMISE. OF AN
AUTHOR WHO HAS SPENT. HOURS AND
HOURS AND HOURS SPEAKING TO THE
BROAD OF OUR GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THIS ISSUE. I HAVE SPENT
HOURS TALKING TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUE. AND I CAN TELL YOU A FEW
THINGS. YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
BY MAKING EVERYBODY COMPLETELY
HAPPY IT'S JUST NOT GONNA
HAPPEN. LET ME TELL YOU WHERE
WE WERE A YEAR AGO WITH THIS
BILL. WE HAD A LOT OF MEMBERS
WHO SUPPORTED INDUSTRY. AND
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE FOR IT. WE
ALSO HAD A LOT OF MEMBERS WHO
CONSIDER THEMSELVES
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND FROM AND-
AKAN. WHO DIDN'T TO VOTE FOR IT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T THINK IT
WENT FAR ENOUGH. I THOUGHT IT
WAS TOO BROAD. THEY THOUGHT
THAT IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
ENFORCE. SO YOU REALLY HAD A
BILL THAT HAD A LONG WAY TO GO.
WHERE ARE WE TODAY. WE ARE NOW
WITH THE BILL THAT'S BEEN
WORKED ON BY PROFESSIONALS IN
THIS AREA BY EXPERTS IN THIS
ARENA. WITH AN EYE TOWARDS
BEING PRACTICAL. BEING WORKABLE
BEING FAIR. BUT HAVING OFF
RAMPS. AND SPEED BUMPS FOR
INDUSTRY TO GIVE THEM TIME TO
COMPLY. A BILL THAT IS
ENFORCEABLE THAT'S NERO TO ONLY
PLASTICS IN ONLY THE TIME OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT PLASTICS. A
BILL THAT ACTUALLY HAS A
CHANCE. TO WORK AND DO
SOMETHING AND TO SET A STANDARD
FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY TO
FOLLOW. WELL THAT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN. IF WE KEEP SAYING THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ACT IF WE
KEEP SAYING. THAT WE'RE GOING
TO WAIT FOR SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK IS PERFECT YOU KNOW WHAT.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET TO
WHERE EVERY GROUP THINKS IS
PERFECT IN THIS BUT WHAT YOU
CAN GET TO IS SOMETHING WHERE
WE FINALLY. TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY. IN THIS STATE
OF. THE STATE FOR THIS PRODUCT.
I COME FROM MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT AS A LOT OF YOU DO
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
WHAT'S AND EVERYONE'S GOING TO
TALK ABOUT COST ON THIS COST
INDUSTRY COST EVERYONE YOU KNOW
WAS PAYING THE FULL COST. OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA. TAXPAYERS THAT TO.
ANY OF YOU OF THE MUNICIPALITY-
LOCALITY THAT HAS ITS OWN
LANDFILL IS MY CITY DOES. KNOWS
THAT IF THE PEOPLE IN THAT
COMMUNITY WHO PAY EVERY SINGLE
TIME. FOR THE DISPOSAL OF THIS
PRODUCT FOR POLLUTION CLEAN IF
ANY OF YOU WERE ON THE COAST
LINE KNOW THAT YOU ARE PAYING
FOR THE POLLUTION. THAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THE IMPACTS TO
TOURISM THAT YOU HAVE TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS OF YOUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT WHY THIS
PLASTIC POLLUTION ALL OVER THE
BEACH. THE INDUSTRIES TO SHIP
THIS INTO OUR AREA. THEY PAY
NONE OF THAT. THEY DON'T PAY A
DIME THEY'RE OFF THE HOOK. THEY
SAY THAT THERE'S COSTS INVOLVED
TO THEIR CONSUMERS YOU KNOW
WHAT RIGHT NOW THERE'S COST TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN REAL
DOLLARS THEY ARE PAYING FOR
THAT. INDUSTRY HAVE TO TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY AND WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE IS THE
BARE MINIMUM USE RECYCLED
CONTENT. USE IT. YES MAYBE
RIGHT NOW THIS PENNIES MORE TO
USE IT BUT THAT'S MONEY THAT'S
GOING TO BE SAVED BY YOUR
TAXPAYERS WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
TO PAY FOR THE COLLECTION OF
THAT MATERIAL IN THE DISPOSAL
OF THAT MATERIAL. I'VE GOT A
LOT OF REALLY WANT KEY POINTS I
CAN GIVE YOU ABOUT HOW THIS
CREATES JOBS WHICH WE ALL KNOW-
ABOUT A SEVENTY FIVE ACHIEVING
A 75% RECYCLING. TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT. HOW THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS GOING TO BE CREATED BY THIS
AND CREATING MARKETS I COULD
TALK TO YOU AGAIN ABOUT HOW
THEY'VE EXEMPTED BOTTLE BILL
CONTAINERS THEY'VE EXEMPTED
EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR PLASTIC
THE TALK I TALK TO YOU ABOUT
HOW THEY'VE EXEMPTED RETAILERS
LIKE AT SEA THE SMALL PEOPLE
THE ONLINE RETAILERS THAT ONLY
FACILITATE SALES BETWEEN THIRD
PARTIES. THAT THE EXAM
PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE- THAT
THAT ARE IN CONFLICT WITH
FEDERAL LAW AND GUIDANCE
ESPECIALLY ABOUT AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS THEY ALSO HAVE CAL
RECYCLE LOOK AT FOOD RATE WAYS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
PRACTICAL AND DOABLE BUT THERE
IS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ON
AND ON AND ON INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
ACCOMMODATED AT EVERY SINGLE
TURN WITH AMENDMENTS WHAT
WHAT'S IN THIS BILL. WE CAN ALL
COME UP WITH REASONS WHY WE
DON'T WANT TO SUPPORT THIS BUT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT I'M
GONNA HOUSING WAS TO COME UP
WITH REASONS WHY YOU CAN'T
SUPPORT IT. I WORRY DEEPLY
ABOUT THE PLANET MY CHILD THAT
MY LITTLE GIRL IS GOING TO
INHERIT. WE DON'T CAN'T AFFORD
TO SAY NOTHING TO NOT TRY WE'VE
GOT YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
TO REFINE THIS AND MAKE THIS
WORK WE'VE GOT A BE BRAVE
ENOUGH TO TAKE THAT FIRST STEP.
I IMPLORE YOU. FIND A WAY TO
GET TO OUR TODAY BECAUSE IT'S
INCONCEIVABLE THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN'T. CAN'T BE THE ONES TO
START DEALING WITH SOMETHING
THAT IS IMPACTING OUR
COASTLINES IN OUR COMMUNITY SO
DEEPLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN. MISTER
KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY FOUR. AND I
KNOW THAT WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
TO DO RECYCLING HERE IN THE
STATE WE- COULD NEVER REALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW FAR WE'VE COME
BUT ALSO IN MANY WAYS HOW FAR
WE HAVE YET TO GO. IN FACT
REALLY WOULDN'T WE STARTED
RECYCLING- IN THE SEVENTIES YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE WERE REALLY
FOCUSED ON WE'RE FOCUSED ON
PAPER PRODUCTS. IN PRIMARILY
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS. WELL NOW
DURING THIS TIME OF KOBE I KNOW
MANY OF US ARE DOING TAKE OUT I
KNOW MANY OF US ARE USING-
THESE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PRODUCTS AND LIKE MOST OF US
WHO HAVE CURBSIDE RECYCLING WE
EAT OUR WE ARE TAKE OUT. CLEAN
OUT THE PLASTIC CONTAINER THE
THROW IT INTO. OUR BLUE BIN.
AND I THINK OUR MIND WE THINK
THAT WE'VE DONE OUR JOB. WE'VE
RECYCLE. WELL THE IRONY IS.
ONLY 9% OF WHAT'S IN OUR BLUE
BIN IS REALLY. IN RECYCLE AT
ANY GIVEN TIME NOW MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THOUSAND OAKS WE JUST
PASSED A BILL TO. REALLY WORK
ON THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER PARTY
WHICH IS WHY THAT'S EXEMPTED IN
THIS BILL TO REALLY ENCOURAGE
MANUFACTURERS TO TAKE GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY TO RE USE THE
PLASTIC THAT THEY'RE PUTTING
INTO OUR ENVIRONMENT. BUT SB
FIFTY FOUR IS ANOTHER KEY
PIECE. OF THAT SOLUTION.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW ALL THOSE
TAKE OUT CONTAINERS THAT WE SAY
OH THIS IS PLASTIC. WE THINK WE
CAN GO RECYCLE IT. DOESN'T
RECYCLE. USED TO GO TO CHINA
BECAUSE CHINA WAS BUYING A
PLASTIC. THE CHILD A COUPLE
YEARS AGO SAID YOU KNOW WHAT WE
GOT IN THE PLASTIC HERE. THE
FROM OTHER PARTS OF WORLD ONE
UP ON YOUR PLASTIC ANYMORE. SO
YOU KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING. IT'S
GOING INTO THE LANDFILLS. IS
NOT GOING TO BEING RECYCLED AT
SOME RECYCLING PLANT IN THE SKY.
IT'S GOING INTO YOUR LOCAL
LEVEL. AND IF YOU THINK AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BURBANK
ELOQUENTLY PUT IF YOU THINK
THAT IT COMES AT ZERO COST TO
US. RIGHT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
ALL THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WE
HAVE WHEN WE BY- MATTRESSES
WILL WE HAVE MANY FACTORS THAT
REALLY HELP MAKE SURE THAT THIS
pALL THE PLASTIC PRODUCERS THERE
IS NO. PRODUCER A MANUFACTURER
SPOTS ABILITY THERE. THERE IS
NO FEE FOR THE COST TO OUR
SOCIETY FOR US. AS WE USE IT IN
CONSUMERS WILL HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DISPOSE OF IT. BUT
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT SOME OF
THOSE COSTS. REALLY ME. YOU
KNOW WHAT ONE STUDY IN ORANGE
COUNTY FOUND THAT. RESIDENTS
COULD SAVE A HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
SUMMER MONTHS JUST BY NOT.
DESPITE NOT. JUST BY NOT
LITTERING AND FOR ALL THIS
TRASH OUT ON THE STREETS. AND
IN FACT. ACROSS THE STATE MANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SPENDING
UPWARDS OF OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS JUST TO CLEAN
UP AND TO PREVENT LITTER. IN
THE STREETS. SO WE CAN DO OUR
PART TODAY. THE BEST WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NOT TRASH
ON THE STREETS IS TO NOT USE
THAT PRODUCT. TO BEGIN WITH.
THE MEASURE THAT WE HAVE A
PRODUCT THAT IS DISPOSABLE THAT
IS COMPOSTABLE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS MUCH BETTER
FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT. YEAH I
THINK AGAIN LET US NOT HAVE THE
PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD. BECAUSE FTEN TIMES
THAT'S WHAT WE ALWAYS HEAR
THESE REALLY THESE LEGISLATIVE
DEBATES WE HAVE CUT TO THE END
OF THE LAST NIGHT OF SESSION.
EVERYTHING IS WILL THIS BILL IS
NOT GOOD ENOUGH THIS BILL IS
NOT GOOD ENOUGH THIS IS NOT
GOOD ENOUGH THE STAFF BECAUSE-
THERE WERE THREE PROPOSALS AND
ALTERNATIVES. OFFERED THIS IS
THE ALTERNATIVE. THIS IS THE
PROPOSAL. THE OTHER INDUSTRIES
REALLY HAVEN'T COME FOR THE
SAID HEY HERE'S ALTERNATIVE
HERE'S WHAT WE THINK WE SHOULD
BE DOING HERE ONCE YOU TRY IT
THIS WAY WHAT OFTENTIMES WE
KNOW IT'S POLICYMAKERS WE ARE
STRUGGLING BY OURSELVES IN
NEGOTIATING AGAINST OURSELVES.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL IS A MUCH
NEEDED BILL IT IS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY. NARROWED THE
FOCUS ON PLASTICS. AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE TIME IS NOW TO
PASS SB FIFTY FOUR WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR TANG MISTER MURATSUCHI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY FOUR AND I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN DIEGO AND FROM BURBANK
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL YOU KNOW.
FOR ME. AS A FATHER. A LOT OF
TIMES I. STRUGGLE TO JUSTIFY
HOW MUCH TIME I HAVE TO SPEND
UP HERE AWAY FROM MY FAMILY BUT
THE YOU KNOW WHAT IT ALWAYS
COMES BACK TO FOR ME IS HOW.
YOU KNOW IS MY WORK HERE GOING
TO MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE. FOR MY DAUGHTER. YOU
KNOW THIS PLASTIC POLLUTION.
CRISIS IS TRULY A GLOBAL
CRISIS. MAY WE HAVE SO MUCH
PLASTIC ACCUMULATED. IN THE
OCEAN THAT IS FORMED IT'S OWN
ISLAND. WE HAVE SO MUCH PLASTIC
THAT IS POLLUTING AND ENDING UP
IN OUR WATERWAYS ON OUR BEACHES
THAT IT'S YOU KNOW. IT DOESN'T
BIODEGRADE IT IT IT JUST
CRUMBLES AND ENDS UP IN OUR
WATER SUPPLY IN OUR IN OUR IN
OUR FOOD SUPPLY THERE IS
PLASTIC IN OUR FISH AND OUR
FOOD SUPPLY THAT'S HOW BAD THIS
PLASTIC CRISIS IS BECOMING.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO LEAD THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD AND
FIGHTING THIS GLOBAL CRISIS OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION. AND I AM
PROUD TO JOIN THIS EFFORT WITH
SB FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISS
AMERICA FIFTEEN MISTER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I TO WANT TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT OF- THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL SB FIFTY FOUR-
PLASTIC GOT POLLUTION IS AN
ISSUE THAT- MANY OF US IN THIS-
IN THIS CHAMBER HAVE WORKED ON
CERTAINLY I HAVE WORKED ON FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW IN MY LITTLE.
SUBSPECIALTY OF THE PLASTICS
WORLD AS MICROPLASTICS IN THE
MEMBER FROM THE SOUTH BAY WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT IT WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE GOOD SOLUTIONS
RIGHT NOW FOR MICROPLASTICS THE
CLOTHING THAT. MANY OF US ARE
WEARING SHED PLASTIC. THAT A
DOWN INTO OUR WATERWAYS OUT
INTO THE OCEAN AND ARE CONSUMED
BY FISH AND IT'S BECOMING PART
OF THE ECOSYSTEM. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT AND THAT WE MUST PLASTICS
THERE. ARE CHEAP TO PRODUCE AND
THEY'RE EVERYWHERE THEY'RE
EVERYWHERE. SO I IMPLORE YOU
TO. VOTE FOR THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE WHICH WILL
MAKE CALIFORNIA NOT JUST AS A
NATIONAL LEADER AS ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS MENTIONED CALIFORNIA
WILL BE THE INTER NATIONAL
LEADER ON THIS IF WE PASS THIS
BILL IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I
ASK THAT FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SB FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU MR ROOM
MR COOLEY ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I WAS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL LAST
FALL WAITED FOR ON THIS FLOOR.
I FEEL LIKE. I'M GETTING TOO
DARN OLD. THIS BILL HAS
PRODUCED AN INTERESTING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME. LAST YEAR
PRODUCES EXPERIENCE IT BROUGHT
ME TO MY YOUTH I REMEMBER
CAMPING WITH MY FAMILY WHICH
MEANS MY MOM DAD THREE BROUGHT.
UP INTO AS A LITTLE BOY. AND I
REMEMBER MY FIRST EXT OF MAD
MAGAZINE WAS THIS SCRAP OF A
MAD MAGAZINE BLEW THROUGH OUR
CAMPSITE. AND I STARTED LOOKING
AT. AND IT WAS A CARTOON. ABOUT
TRASH. AND THE AND THE THRUST
OF THIS LITTLE MAD MAGAZINE
CARTOON WAS ABOUT THE GRAND
CANYON. WAS GONNA FILL UP
BECAUSE OF ALL THE TRASH. NOT
COURSE THAT'S JUST A LUDICROUS
NOTION TO THINK THAT THE GRAND
CANYON WOULD FILL UP. WHEN
YOU'RE SIX OR SEVEN I WAS AN
ASTONISHING IDEA. TO THINK THAT
THERE COULD BE SO MUCH TRASH IN
A WORLD OF SOMETHING. THAT EVEN
I KNEW ABOUT. COULD BE IMPAIR.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT PLASTICS OF COURSE IS THE-
THERE'S ALMOST NO PRODUCT. I
GUESS I CAN'T SAY THAT IN A
ROLE IN THE WORLD THE INTERNET
BUT THERE ARE FEW PRODUCTS IN
THE WORLD. THAT ARE SUCH A
MARVEL. OF HUMAN INNOVATION.
CREATIVITY THE ABILITY TO FIND
SOMETHING WHERE NO ONE EVER SAW
BEFORE. THE WHOLE ALL THE WE
HAVE IN THE WORLD THE RISE FOR
PLASTICS IT'S A BY PRODUCT OF.
APPLIED SCIENCE CHEMISTRY HUMAN
INGENUITY. AND SO I FIND IT.
THE FACT IS IT'S DNA. THAT WE
ARRIVE AT THESE THINGS BECAUSE
OF THE MARVELS OF HUMAN
INGENUITY WHY NOT BRING THAT TO
BEAR AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
POLICY ON DEALING WITH THIS
PROFUSION. IN THE WORLD. I HAVE
FIVE GRANDKIDS RANGING FROM TWO
TO TEN. THIS IS A MATTER THAT.
WILL AFFECT THEIR LIVES THIS IS
ACTUALLY A MATTER OF THAT THIS
IS A POLICY ERROR WERE
CALIFORNIA. CAN REACH. A CROSS
OUR STATE. CROSSED OUR NATION
ROSS THE BLOW TWO PATHFINDER.
SOLUTIONS TO WHAT IS
INCONTESTABLE A PROBLEM. SO I
AM PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. I THINK THERE ARE
SOME THINGS IN LIFE THAT.
APPEAR IMPOSSIBLE UNTIL YOU
JUST UNDERTAKE TO DO IT. AND
YOU PUT YOUR HEAD DOWN TO START
WITH YOU KNOW AND I THINK THAT
IS THIS ISSUE I THINK THAT IS.
THIS TIME. AND. LAST WEEK I
READ A QUOTE DURING THAT WAY
TOO LONG REFLECTION AT THE
START OF SESSION. THE PROBABLY
ZIPPED BY EVERYBODY BUT IT WAS
AN HONOR OF AN ARCTIC EXPLORER.
WHO TRAVEL TO NORTH POLE WITH
COMMODORE PERRY. MATTHEW HENSON.
AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
WHAT WHAT THE VIEW OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN DOCTORS FOR MATTHEW
HINDERS HANSON SAID ABOUT. LIFE
AND PEOPLE. BECAUSE I'M A
INVOKE HIS WORDS. FOR MORE THAN
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO ON THIS
DEBATE. LIFE IS GROWTH LIFE IS
PROGRESS IN PROGRESS DEPENDS ON
NEW IDEAS. WITHOUT THE ADVENT
OF NEW IDEAS WE SHOULD STILL BE
RIDING AND STAGECOACHES. AND
READING BY THE LIGHT OF TALLOW
CANDLES. GREAT IDEALS OF THE
GLORIA VAN ALONE. QUOTED
MATTHEW HENSON. NOR THE
CREATURE COULD HAVE THEM ONLY
MAN CAN GET A VISION AND AN
INSPIRATION WILL LIFT HIM ABOVE
THE LEVEL OF HIMSELF. AND SEND
THEM FORTH AGAINST ALL
OPPOSITION OR ANY DISBURSEMENT.
TO DO AND TO DARE AND
ACCOMPLISHED WONDERFUL AND
GREAT THING FOR THE WORLD AND
FOR HUMANITY. COLLEAGUES THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE IT IS
A PRODUCT OF HUMAN INGENUITY
AND I THINK IT'S PAST TIME THAT
HUMAN INGENUITY BE CONCENTRATED
ON TRYING TO MAKE. PROGRESS ON
IT. AND THEREBY ESTABLISHING
THAT. THE IDEALS OF DEMOCRACY
ERROR EXPRESSED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ARE WORKING ON A
BETTER FUTURE FOR ALL THOSE ON
THIS PLANET- TO RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CROWLEY MISTER STONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS WE HAVE
BEEN LIVING WITH THE MYTHOLOGY
FOR DECADES. AND THAT MYTHOLOGY
IS THAT OUR TRASH PROBLEMS
STARTED WITH THE LITTER
PROGRAMME IN THE FIFTIES AND
SIXTIES AND THE MYTHOLOGY
THAT'S BEEN DRIVEN BY THE
INDUSTRY IS THAT OUR TRASH
PROBLEM IS OUR FAULT AS
INDIVIDUALS AS LITERATURES AND
YES THAT IS A COMPONENT. BUT IT
IS SO MUCH MORE EXTENSIVE. AND
COMPLICATED THAN THAT AND IF WE
STILL BUY INTO THAT MYTHOLOGY
WE MISS THE POINT THAT WE HAVE
NOT BROUGHT ALL PLAYERS INTO
THE EQUATION ON HOW WE DEAL
WITH TRASH WITH WASTE AND
ESPECIALLY WITH PLASTIC. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS CREATE THE
FRAMEWORK. TO HAVE
MANUFACTURERS PRODUCERS
PACKAGING PACKAGERS ALL BE A
PART OF SOLUTIONS TO REDUCING
PLASTIC IN OUR ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS WHAT IS SO IMPORTANT HERE.
AND IF EVERYONE THROUGH THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN. REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF PLASTIC THAT NGUYEN IN THE
PACKAGING THAT WENT INTO
PRODUCTS. TOOK RESPONSIBILITY
FOR WHERE THAT PLASTIC DOES AND
NOT JUST PUT IT ON TAXPAYERS
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE IN THE END
FOR WASTE MANAGEMENT AND FOR
CLEAN UP. BUT CAME UP WITH REAL
SOLUTIONS AND WE TO CREATE
MARKETS FOR THE PLASTICS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. AND SET HIGHER
EXPECTATIONS FOR HOW WE'RE
GOING TO USE PLASTICS AND POST
CONSUMER CONTENT THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT GETTING RID OF
PLASTICS ALTOGETHER
UNFORTUNATELY I WOULD LOVE TO
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
SINGLE USE CONTAINERS AND
SINGLE USE PLASTICS THAT WE
SEEM TO BE ADDICTED TO. THAT'S
NOT THE POINT OF THIS BILL
HOWEVER THIS BILL IS THAT
FRAMEWORK THAT WE CAN ENGAGE
ALL SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY AND
THE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM. AND
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE PLAYS
THEIR PART AND THOSE WHO ARE
MAKING PROFITS OFF OF THIS
THESE PRODUCTS THOSE WHO ARE
USING THESE PRODUCTS AND THOSE
ARE THROWING AWAY THESE
PRODUCTS ALL HAVE A ROLE IN
REDUCING PLASTIC IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS SO CRITICAL. THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS SOMETHING WE MUST
PASS HERE TODAY AND MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS SHOWING THE
REST OF THE WORLD WHAT WE CAN
DO AND WE CAN ALL TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY ACROSS ECONOMIC
SECTORS FOR OUR TRASH PROBLEM
OUR WASTE PROBLEMS AND THIS DID
DETRIMENTAL PROBLEM OF PLASTIC
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU
MR STERN IS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I GREW UP
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES I AM
OF THE CAPTAIN PLANET
GENERATION. I GREW UP WHEN I
WAS A JUST ABOUT NINE OR TEN
YEARS OLD I WAS ABLE TO GO TO
MY FIRST EVER CAMPING TRIP ON
CATALINA ISLAND I HAD NEVER
BEEN. I IT WAS A MARINE BIOLOGY
CAMP WHERE I FOR THE FIRST TIME
I SAW A TURTLE. THAT WAS
COMPLETELY MISSHAPEN. BECAUSE
THEY HAD GOTTEN TIED. IN RIGHT
AROUND THE VALLEY. WITH THE-
WHAT IS SIX SODA. PLASTIC
CONTAINER THING IS THE GUY WITH
THE CIRCLES. AND I LEARNED FOR
THE FIRST TIME THAT IT WAS MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS A YOUNG CHILD
TO GO HOME AND CUT. BILL SIX.
US CIRCLES THE PLASTIC BECAUSE
OF THE IMPACT THAT IT HAD. ON
OUR MARINE LIFE THAT CHANGED
ME. AS A YOUNG GIRL AND I WENT
BACK HOME. TO MY WORKING CLASS
FAMILY IN EAST LA. LATINO
IMMIGRANT HOUSEHOLD. PERHAPS OF
THE ORIGINAL OF RECYCLERS OF
CONTAINERS BECAUSE TO GO TO ANY
OF THE KITCHENS OF ANY GALLETAS
HOUSING YOU OPEN UP A BUTTER
CONTAINER IT MAY NOT BE BETTER
IT MAY BE FRIJOLES MAY FOR SON
SOMETHING. BUT THAT IS WHAT WE
DO WITH THE COMMUNITY. I AM
SOMEONE RE WASHES THE BLOOD
BAGS. I AM SOMEBODY THAT TRIES
TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITY. TO
DO WHAT I CAN. TO CONSERVE. AND
TO HELP SAVE OUR ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN AS A NINE YEAR OLD WHEN I
CAME BACK HOME TO MY FAMILY. MY
MOM AND DAD. ENCOURAGED THAT I
DO THE BEST THAT I COULD TO
RECYCLE. AND WHEN THIS BILL
CAME UP LAST YEAR. I LEARNED
THAT EVEN WHAT I THOUGHT I WAS
RECYCLING. I WASN'T REALLY
RECYCLING BECAUSE- BECAUSE
WE'RE ALREADY CONTAMINATED I
LEARNED THAT WHEN YOU BUY A
PIZZA BOX. AND YOU THINK IT'S
CARDBOARD AND YOU PUT IN YOUR
RECYCLING BIN IT ACTUALLY
CANNOT BE RECYCLED. BECAUSE
THEY DON'T IT'S ALREADY
CONTAMINATED. SO THE PUBLIC AND
I THINK A LOT OF US IN THIS
ROOM. FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHAT WE
THINK RECYCLING IS. BUT TO BE
QUITE HONEST. WE ALL NEED A RE
EDUCATION ON WHAT THAT IS AND
HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK ON
REAL ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT
HAVE A REAL IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
ACROSS THE NATION AND BE A
LEADER IN THE WORLD. I'M PROUD
TO BE A CO AUTHOR. I THINK THAT.
YES THERE ARE ISSUES THAT WE
NEED TO RESOLVE THERE IS
FUNDING THERE NEED TO BE PUT IN
PLACE. WE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. SO I AM HERE TO
SAY THAT EVEN WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES. WANT TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD AND HAVE CLEAN AIR
CLEAN WATER CLEAN OCEANS. AND
IT'S NOT FAIR THEY WHEN YOU
GROW UP IN THE INNER CITY. AND
YOUR MAYBE IN THIRD GRADE YOUR
FIRST EXPERIENCE AND THE BEACH
IS TO CLEAN IT UP. I REMEMBER
BEING LITTLE. GROWING UP IN
EAST LA GETTING ON A SCHOOL
BUS. GOING TO CABRILLO BEACH TO
CLEAN IT UP. THERE WAS PLASTIC.
THEIR CIGARETTES THERE WAS ALL
KINDS OF TRASH.WHY IS IT THAT
THE EXPERIENCE OF A YOUNG GIRL
FROM THE INNER CITY. SHOULD BE
CLEANING UP A BEACH. THAT'S NOT
THE TYPE OF COMMUNITY THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE IT IS NOT THE TYPE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE SHOULD BE
AND WE ARE ALL ENTITLED AND
HAVE A RIGHT. TO HAVE A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT FREE OF POLLUTION
AND FREE OF PLASTIC IN OUR
OCEANS. THANK YOU. IN THIS ROOM
IS KAMLAGER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
FOUR AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR. YOU
KNOW WE OUR COUNTRY OUR PLANET.
HAS BECOME BLOATED FROM PLASTIC.
I MEAN WE ARE ADDICTED TO IT.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO PUT SOME
REAL SKIN IN THE GAME. IF WE
ARE GOING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. IT IS TAKING OVER IT IS
TAKING OVER OUR LAND IT IS
TAKING OVER OUR OCEANS IT IS
TAKING OVER OUR BODIES. I CAME
INTO THIS CONVERSATION A YEAR
AGO THE BILL WAS INCREDIBLY
ASPIRATIONAL. EVEN FOR THE MOST
GRANOLA OF US. AND WE WORKED
AND LISTENED WE LISTEN TO THE
OPPOSITION WE LISTEN TO FOLKS
WHO HAVE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
AND WE FIGURED OUT A PATHWAY
THAT MADE SENSE. THAT WAS
REASONABLE. AND THAT PUT SOME
SKIN IN THE GAME FOR
MANUFACTURERS AND FOR
DISTRIBUTORS AND FOR THE STATE
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS IS. AND
SO IT'S ALMOST DISINGENUOUS FOR
FOLKS. TO WANT TO POOH POOH
THIS RECOGNIZING HOW MUCH WORK.
HAS BEEN PUT INTO MAKING
SOMETHING OUT OF THIS BILL THAT
IS REASONABLE THAT IS
MANAGEABLE THAT IS STILL
ASPIRATIONAL ASPIRATIONAL AND
STILL SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT
WE ARE DYING LITERALLY. FROM
OVERCONSUMPTION AND-OVERPRODUCTION OF PLASTIC.
WE'VE SEEN THE VIDEOS WE HAVE
OUR OWN STORIES WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MANAGE
PLASTIC IN OUR OWN HOMES. AND
LORD KNOWS WITH COAL BED WE
HAVE PROBABLY SEEN OUR FAIR
SHARE OF PLASTIC BOTTLES IN
CARDBOARD BOXES BECAUSE ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE GETTING
DELIVERED TO US WHEN WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO GO OUT. WE ARE
BECOMING PART OF THE LARGER
PROBLEM FAR QUICKER. THEN WE
ARE WORKING TO BECOME PART OF
THE SOLUTION IN SB FIFTY FOUR
IS A REASONABLE STEP TOWARDS
THAT SOLUTION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON S. NO NO
I CAN'T SAY THAT BUT I'M GOING
TO SAY YEAH YOU'LL NEED TO VOTE
FOR THIS WHEN THIS COES UP IT
WOULD MAKE NO SENSE NOT TO.
THANK YOU MATT CAGR MISTER
CARTER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AYE I JUST WANT TO
ADD THREE QUICK THINGS TO THE
TO THE DEBATE THE FIRST IS. IT
WHEN YOU LOOK. AT OUR KIDS
TODAY AND WHEN THEY COME AND
TALK ABOUT SO FAR AS MOTHER
EARTH AND THE PLASTIC. CRISIS
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR GLOBE THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW
WE'LL LOOK AT THIS ISSUE WILL
DEBATE LIKE WHAT WAS THE BIG
ISSUE. BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN I THINK LOOKING
BACK ABOUT THAT TIME KNOW THAT
WE HAD EASILY ADAPTED TO.
SECOND IF YOU LOOK AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE SAID
THE COSTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER I WENT IN
TOWARD. OUR TRANSFER STATION
AND THEY HAD THE PLASTIC BAGS
GETTING STUCK IN THE WHEELS AND
THEY HAD TO SHUT THEM DOWN.
EVERY TWO HOURS NOW SOMEBODY
CLIMB IN THERE AND PULL OUT THE
PLASTIC FROM THESE LITTLE
WHEELS. THAT ARE JUST WRECKING
HAVOC AND ASKED HOW MUCH IT
COST AND IT IS ONE SITE IT
THINK IT WAS LIKE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN LOST
PRODUCTIVITY. FROM SHUTTING
DOWN THE MACHINERY TO PULL THE
PLASTIC OUT SO WE ARE PAYING
FOR THAT COST TODAY. AND
LASTLY. AS OUR AS OUR FLOOR
MANAGER NOTED. THIS BILL SETS A
TIMELINE IN THE FUTURE AND I AM
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN. THAT THE
ILAN MOSQUE SAID THE WORLD
WHOEVER ELSE. CAN FIGURE IT
OUT. IF WE CAN MAKE STRAWS OUT
OF BAMBOO AND CONTAINERS OUT OF
THESE SWAY MATERIAL WILL LOOK
BACK ON THIS AND I'M I'M
ABSOLUTELY CONFIDENT THAT GIVEN
A NUMBER OF YEARS. THE RESOURCE
WERE PUTTING INTO THIS AND THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE WILL EASILY
FIND SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH
ARE. ARE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
WASTE OBSESSION AND PROBLEM IN
OUR SOCIETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CARTY SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE. I'M
NOT CLOSE WITH THIS I KNOW THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE I'M WELL AWARE.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WHIPSAWED ON
AMENDMENTS FROM THE DATE WE
INTRODUCED THIS- NO WE CAN'T DO
THIS- WILL JUST BE THERE IF YOU
DO THIS WE'LL GET THERE DON'T
ADD DON'T ADD THE GLASS WE
CAN'T HAVE GLASS ADD GLASS IF
YOU DON'T HAVE GLASS WE WON'T
BE THERE. TAKE OUT THE FARMERS-
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH SO MANY
FARMERS GOING TO CURBSIDE
RECYCLING YOU'VE GOT TO BE
KIDDING ME. I AM TIRED. OF
MAKING THE CASE YOU EITHER
BELIEVE THE PLASTICS OF THE
PROBLEM. THE GLOBAL WARMING IS
A REAL PROBLEM BECAUSE THIS
DOES CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE YOU EITHER BELIEVE THERE
IS A GARBAGE PATCH IN OUR OCEAN
AND WE NEED TO START TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT OR YOU
DON'T. BECAUSE WE SET OUT A
TIMELINE TO DO SOMETHING IN IT
WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH FOR THE
LOBBYISTS WHO BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO ANYTHING. I'VE
SEEN THAT WITH MY OWN EYES I
HAVE AMENDED AND WE HAVE
AMENDED THIS BILL OVER AND
OVER. TO TRY TO TAKE CARE OF
SOMEBODY'S CONCERNED WHO JUST
PUTS IN ANOTHER OPPOSITION
LETTER BECAUSE IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THIS IS IN THE FUTURE WE KNOW
WE CAN CREATE A MARKET WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN CREATE JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THIS IS A
REAL PROBLEM. AND IT'S NOT A
WHITE POST PROBLEM DON'T GOING
TO ME WITH THAT. BECAUSE I HAVE
A BROWN COMMUNITY THAT IS DIRTY
AS CRAP. WITH YOUR PLASTICS.
IT'S DIRTY BECAUSE THERE'S
NOWHERE TO PUT THEM. THERE IN
OUR WATER WAYS THEY'RE COMING
OUT OF OUR TRASH CANS ARE
COMING OUT OF OUR LANDFILLS ARE
LANDFILLS ARE PULLED UP HOW
MUCH IS YOUR CITY OR COUNTY
SPENDING. TO DO NOTHING WITH
THESE BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
TO DO WITH THEM HOW LONG CAN
THAT LAST. IF YOU WANT TO WAIT
TILL TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND LET
THE COMPANY PUT SOMETHING ON
THE BALLOT THAT'S GOING TO PASS
THAT'S FINE OR WE CAN BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK IN THE EYES OF YOUR KID
AND I PROMISE YOU IF YOU HAVE A
KID THEY KNOW THIS IS A
PROBLEM. THEY'RE COMING TO YOU
TO TELL YOU IF YOU'RE OKAY WITH
THAT FIND VOTE NO OR OR JUST
STAY OFF YOU KNOW I'M JUST
GOING TO WAIT AND SEE WHERE
IT'S AT THAT'S FINE BUT I'VE
HAD ENOUGH IF YOU WANT TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM. YOU BOTH
FOR TODAY. WE TAKE IT ON. WE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND WE DON'T
JUST SIT AROUND AND COMPLAIN
ABOUT A PROBLEM. THAT NONE OF
US WANT TO PROVIDE A FIX FOR.
THIS IS A FIX I HOPE YOU'LL
VOTE I. THE CLERK ILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
A- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
REGARD BOTH AS FAR AS.
FORTY
ONE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A.
IN THE OFFICE A CALL.
THIS AMOUNT IS PREPARED TO LET
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM FOR AB
THIRTY TO FOURTEEN THE CLERK
WILL HAVE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS
THOSE WHO THERE'D VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY
TWO NEW SIXTEEN SENATE MEMBERS
ARE COMPARED IN. MEMBERS WE ASK
THAT YOU STAY ON THE FLOOR WILL
BE LIFTING THE CALL ON TO
MEASURES AND WOULD APPRECIATE
YOU BEING ON THE FLOOR. MISS
CAREER WAS PREPAREDTO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM NINE AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
BOTH VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS EIGHT SENTIMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN. MISTER. STONE IS
PREPARED WITH THE COLUMN FILE
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TO THE CLERK WILL CALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
VERY VOTE SQUIRES. FORTY ONE.
WE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES IS
FORTY TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. MR
MCCARTY IS PREPARED TO LET THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM THREE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL POSE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FORTY ONE NO
SEVENTEEN SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THE MESSAGE COM
LONGER IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE A QUICK
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
SEVENTY ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR VOTE. CLERK WILL COOL
LOWS THE ROLE AND HOW THEY VOTE
IS FORTY TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN THE
CENTER PASSES. MS GONZALEZ IS
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE SB FIFTY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WITH REGARD TO THE CALL.
MISTER KALRA IS PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN THE
CLERK WILL POSE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE BOTH. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO THERE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTE WHERE TO VOTE.
YEAH.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES A
CALL. MISTER CHANG IS PREPARED
TO LET THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TO THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE IS FORTY THREE KNOWS
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS AMOUNT IS
FOR HER TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX SB NINE
FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE ME VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THAT HE'S OUT
OF A- YEAH YEAH. YEAH. THE
MONEY. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VOTE.
COMMERCE VOTERS ARE VOTING.
THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
ELEVEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER KALRA ESERVER TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN MCCORKLE
POST. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY ONE KNOWS
FOURTEEN. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MISTER KALRA IS
NOW COMPARED TO LIVE THE CALL
AND FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN SB
TEN SIXTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AYE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
COOL LOWS THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE HIS FORTY FIVE NEWS SEVEN
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
SEVEN
SEVEN YEP AND THEN. MEMBERS ARE
SENDING MY PREVIOUS REFERRAL OF
AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT EGGMAN TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
ALSO REFERRING. AB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE GRAYSON AND AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT Q. TO THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN
CALDERON THE UTILITIES AND
COMMERCE COMMITTEE IN AB TEN
SIXTY SIX AND SALAS TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA
A DEFAULT NOTICE CRIME TO ALLOW
THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO
MEET THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TODAY UPON
CALL THE CHAIRED IN ROM FORTY
TWO OH TWO. AB SIXTY NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR DALY AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE GRAYSON AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE GARCIA GARCIA.
A. B. THIRTY. EIGHTY EIGHT
DAVID CHIU THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
NINE THIRTEEN CALDERON IN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVENTY GARCIA
TODAY. UPON CALL THE CHAIR IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO AND- THE
INSURANCE COMMUNITY HERE AB TEN
SIXTY SIX GONZALEZ. AND AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE BORN HER
ABOUT FOUR BATH TODAY UPON CALL
pWITHOUT OBJECTION. THE REQUEST
IS GRANTED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW SOME
EMERGING TO TAKE UP AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BUDGET COMMITTEE
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE FILED
FOR THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS. MR FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE SIR WE WILL HOLD
UNANIMOUS CONSENT US FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES. AND MR TANG SECONDS. ON
THE ROLE SUSPENSION. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER
LARA IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AND I HAVE A. AND MR FLOORS
ASKING FOR NOBLE. THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
MR FLOOR NO.
CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR
KNOWS THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MEMBERS THIS IS.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACCOLADE THE RIVER
PROTECTIONS MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER TANK
EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS IS OUR- WORKER
PROTECTION TRAILER BILL LET ME
JUST START OFF BY THANKING ONE
OF OUR BUDGET THE STAFF PEOPLE
WHO IS MOVING ON SHE'S GOING TO
BECOME THE CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE SO WE ARE VERY SORRY
TO LOOSER BUT WANTED TO THANK
FOR BROCK FOR HER. HI
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OF THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS WE KNOW AREN'T LOST IS
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE'S
GAIN AND TODAY IS HER LAST DAY
SO WE JUST WANTED TO SEND HER
OFF WITH THE PROPER THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR OUR
FOR ALL YOUR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK. THIS BILL AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES COVED
NINETEEN FOR MIDDLE PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR FOOD SECTOR WORKERS
AND OTHER COVERED WORKERS THESE
WORKERS WERE EXCLUDED FROM PAID
SICK LEAVE PORTIONS OF THE
FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST
CORONAVIRUS THE RESPONSE ACT
PROVIDES TWO ADDITIONAL WEEKS
OF SICK LEAVE AND THE
PROVISIONS EXPIRE ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
OR UPON EXPIRATION OF ANY
FEDERAL EXTENSION WHICHEVER IS
LATER. REQUIRES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO ENFORCE THE
COVERED NINETEEN SUBLIMINAL
PAID SICK LEAVE PROVISIONS
ADDITIONALLY CREATES A FAMILY
LEAVE MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM
FOR SMALL EMPLOYERS WITH FIVE
TO NINETEEN EMPLOYEES ALLOWING
THE EMPLOYER OR EMPLOYEES TO
REQUESTED MEDIATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING PRIOR TO AN
EMPLOYEE FILING A LAWSUIT IN
COURT. THE PROVISION WOULD ONLY
BECOME OPERATIVE ONLY IF S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH
PROVIDES A BROADCASTING SYSTEM
FAMILY PROVISIONS IS ENACTED
THE PROVISION SUNSET ON JANUARY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK RICH CHIANG MR. OR
REX. THANK MISTER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A S. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THIS TRAILER BILL
WILL REQUIRE LARGE EMPLOYERS
AND FOOD SECTOR EMPLOYERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY HOURS OF
PAID. SUPPLEMENTAL DRAVID
NINETEEN SICK LEAVE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES. FIRST OF ALL THIS
BILL IS AN ABUSE OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE BUDGET. IT CONTAINS
BUT A SINGLE TOKEN
APPROPRIATION OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO THAT WE CAN
POINT AT AND SAY LOOK IT'S A
BUDGET BILL BUT THIS IS A
SUBSTANTIVE POLICY BILL AND
COLLEAGUES. WE HAVE BEEN
DEBATING CORONAVIRUS VIRUS
RELIEF LEGISLATION FOR THE LAST
SIX MONTHS IS UNCONSCIONABLE
THEY WERE USING THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO TRY AND FORCES
THROUGH THE LAST MINUTE. IF YOU
WONDER WHY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS AT. SIX FIFTEEN PM IT'S
BECAUSE IT WAS ONLY PUT IN
PLANT. ON FRIDAY EVENING. THERE
WAS HEARD FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
SECOND OF ALL ALTHOUGH I THINK
WE ALL SHARE THE DESIRE. TO
MAKE THINGS EASIER FOR THE
WORKERS OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
WRONG TO PUT THIS BOLD BURDEN
ON THE SHOULDER OF AN INDUSTRY
THAT IS ALREADY REELING. THE
FOOD SECTOR INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
SUFFERING SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE GOVERNMENT OPPOSE SHUT
DOWN FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS
AND IF YOU WANT PROOF OF THAT
JUST WALK AROUND SACRAMENTO
AMBROSIA. CLOSE PERMANENTLY TWO
WEEKS AGO. EMPRESS TAVERN
CLOSED PERMANENTLY TWO WEEKS
AGO. MAHJONG IS CLOSED
PERMANENTLY LAST WEEK. IF WE
TAKE MEASURES LIKE THIS AND WE
EXPECTING PLAYERS TO PICK UP
THE SLACK PARTICULARLY
EMPLOYERS THAT ARE ALREADY
DOING POORLY THE CONSEQUENCE
WILL BE MORE AND MORE OF THESE
BUSINESSES WILL CLOSE ARJUN
OVER. I THANK YOU MR OBERNOLTE.
I SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITIONMR TANG YOU MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I DO A
VERY MUCH RESPECT OUR COMMENTS
FROM OUR VICE CHAIR FROM BIG
BEAR. AGAIN IT WOULD BE COVERED
NINETEEN. DEREK WE ARE ALL
REACTING VERY QUICKLY- I DO
APPRECIATE HIS COMMENTS WE
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE THIS
BILL IMPROVE SOONER. BUT WE
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
THESE. WORKERS OUT IN THE COLD
AGAIN THESE WORKERS THAT WERE
NOT ELIGIBLE AND EXCLUDED FROM
PAID SICK LEAVE IN THE FEDERAL
ACT SO WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING THOSE WORKERS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WORKERS WERE
GOING TO WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY
TO FEED US TO MAKE SURE THAT I
SERVICES IN STORES THAT WE RELY
ON STAY OPEN WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
WITH THAT THE COURT LOCAL ROLE.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE. ALL MEMBERS ARE THERE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY THREE
KNOWS TWELVE. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'LL BE TAKING
A RECESS UNDER CALL. FOR DINNER
AND FOR COMMITTEES TO MEET. THE
COMMITTEES WILL MEET IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE. WELL MADE
FIFTEEN MINUTES FROM NOW IN
ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. WELL
MADE FIFTEEN MINUTES FROM NOW
IN ROOM FORTY TWO TO. FOLLOWED
BY THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL ALSO MEET
IN ROOM FORTY TWO A TWO
FOLLOWING THE ADJOURNMENT OF
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AFTER
THE ROOM HAS BEEN CLEANED.
FOLLOWED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL ALSO MADE
A ROOM FORTY TWO- TO UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THE UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE. AFTER THE
ROOM HAS BEEN CLEANED. THIS
HOUSE WILL RECONVENE UPON A
GERMAN OF THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS RECESSED
CENTER CALL THE SPEAKER.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE JOIN US ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SO WE CAN COMMENCE
BUSINESS WE WILL RETURN TO THE
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TO MOVE THESE
BILLS. OFF THE FILE INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK PLEASE JOIN US
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THANK
YOU THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
JOINED US ON THE ASSEMBLY FOR
MEMBERS WHO WERE IN THEIR
OFFICES WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
JOIN US ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
SO WE CAN COMMENCE THE FAMILY'S
BUSINESS.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN.
OKAY NO WE'RE NOT I'M SORRY MR
GRAYSON. THE MINISTRY READING.
MISTER CALDERON IS STILL IN
CHARGE FOR ANOTHER THREE HOURS
AND SEVEN MINUTES.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO TURN TO FILE ITEM.
SIXTY THREE SB EIGHT OH THREE
KERKORIAN SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
THREE BY SENATOR BILL AND
OTHERS AN ACCURATE THE MEDICO.
IS THERE ANY WAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
EIGHT OH THREE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR ABOUT. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A STATEWIDE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST AND ENABLES
THE STATE AND COUNTIES TO DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDING. OUR
SUPPORT SPECIALISTS ARE PEOPLE
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS WHO USE THEIR
EXPERIENCE TO HELP OTHERS
DEALING WITH HARDSHIPS. SUPPORT
IS A COST EFFECTIVE PRACTICES
USED IN FORTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES AND IS PROVEN TO REDUCE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
HOMELESSNESS INCREASE
PARTICIPATION IN TREATMENT AND
TO IMPROVE OVERALL SERVICE
EXPERIENCE. AS THE NUMBER OF
CORONAVIRUS CORONA VIRUS CASES
HAVE INCREASED WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT UPSURGE IN THE NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACROSS THE NATION AND THE STATE.
THE SHARP RISE IN MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS TRIGGERED BY COVERT
NINETEEN IS LIKELY TOTALING
LONG AFTER THE AFFECT OF THE
PANDEMIC ITSELF. SB EIGHT OH
THREE CREATES A COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THAT WILL INCREASE AND
DIVERSIFY THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
CRISIS AND PUT THEM ON THE ROAD
TO RECOVERY. SB EIGHT OH THREE
ADOPTED TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SB EIGHT OR THREE
ENJOYS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NARY A NO VOTE AND
IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND ADVOCATES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MILLER
THINKING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE A- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU VOTE ICE FORTY NINE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. FIFTY
THREE. IN FACT NEVER MY WE'RE
GOING TO TEMPORARILY VIOLATED
FIFTY THREE AND MOVED TO FILE
ITEM. FIFTY SIX. WE AT SB FIFTY
WITH NUMBER FIFTY SIX WHO MOVED
TO NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT. SB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE A QUICK READ
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR PAN AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. ALEX YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WOULD ARGUE THAT A
FEW MONTHS AGO. MAYBE IN
JANUARY NONE OF US EVEN KNOW
WHAT PP STOOD FOR. BUT WHAT WE
DID SEE OVER THE PAST MAYBE YOU
DID DOCTOR WHAT I'M SORRY YEAH
I GOT I SAW THAT LOOK BUT OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS WE SAW. WE
LEARNED WHAT IT WAS AND WE
LEARNED THERE WASN'T ENOUGH OF
IT FOR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
THIS BILL MAKE SURE THAT IF IN
THE FUTURE WE FACE THIS KIND OF
SITUATION THERE WILL BE A
STOCKPILE OF PP. THIS HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF MULTIPLE
NEGOTIATIONS NOW THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES THE REPRESENTS
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES ARE
NEUTRAL BECAUSE OF ALL THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THIS PROTECTS
WORKERS ALL WORKERS IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NINE ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS BOTH
VERY VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. WOBBLY ONE
COMMON NOTED THERE TO VOTE.
YEAH. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE INTO
THE I FORTY TWO NEW ZERO
MEASURE PASS.
FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE SB ONE FORTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL ONE
FORTY FIVE BY CENTER WIENER AN
ACCOLADE THE SEX OFFENDERS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
FIVE WHICH WILL IN
CALIFORNIA'S. HIGHLY
DISCRIMINATORY TREATMENT OF
SPECIFIC FACTS ACCESS BY OUR
STATE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY
LAW. BY GIVING COURTS
DISCRETION OVER ALL CASES
INVOLUNTARY INTERCOURSE BETWEEN
TEENAGERS. AND YOUNG ADULTS
UNDER CURRENT LAW FOR YOUNG
PERSON OF VOLUNTARY SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE WITH A MINOR. AGE
FOURTEEN THROUGH SEVENTEEN AND
IS NO MORE THAN TEN YEARS OLDER
THAN THE MINOR THE OFFENSE. IS
NOT AUTOMATICALLY REGISTRABLE
HOWEVER THE COURT HAS
DISCRETION BASED ON THE FACTS
OF THE CASE TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT TO PLACE THE DEFENDANT.
ON THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF ANY OTHER
SEX AT IS PERFORMED IN IT IS
MANDATORY THAT THE COURT PLACED
THE DEFENDANT ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY. REGARDLESS
OF THE FACTS OF THE CASE. THIS
DISPARATE TREATMENT OF THE SEX
SEX IS A VESTIGE FROM THE ANTI
LGBT LAWS IN THE NINETEEN
FORTIES. THAT CRIMINALIZED. GAY
SEX. TRAGICALLY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- LAW STILL MANDATE
THAT A YOUNG PERSON IN A
CONSENSUAL RELATIONSHIP WHO WAS
CONVICTED OF PERFORMING THESE
SPECIFIC SEX ACTS. MUST BE
PLACED ON THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY AND OUR COURTS ARE
BARRED FROM USING DISCRETION.
THE WORD WE LIKE SO MUCH TO
KEEP THEM OFF EVEN THOUGH A
SIMILARLY SITUATED YOUNG PERSON
CONVICTED OF STATUTORY RAPE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE SAME
RESTRICTION. THIS DISTINCTION
IN THE LAW IS IRRATIONAL AND
DISCRIMINATORY TOWARDS LGBT
YOUTH AS IT TREATS THESE ACTS
AND MORE AGREED YES. OF A CRIME
IN STATUTORY RAPE. SB ONE FORTY
FIVE IN BLATANT BLATANT
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST YOUNG
PEOPLE ENGAGED INVOLUNTARY
SEXUAL ACTIVITY BY GIVING
COURTS THE DISCRETION TO DECIDE
AT SENTENCING. IT REGISTERING
THE DEFENDANT AS A SEX OFFENDER
IS APPROPRIATE REGARDLESS OF
THE FACT THAT THEY PERFORMED.
TO BE CLEAR NOTHING IN THIS
BILL DE CRIMINALIZES ANY OF
THESE OFFENSES OR PREVENTS
ANYONE FROM BEING PLACED ON THE
REGISTRY IF A PROSECUTOR
RECOMMENDS IT OR THE COURT
ORDERS IT. SB FORTY FIVE AS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT SPONSORED. AND
SUPPORTED BAIL. I ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
CAMARGO MISS GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER I
UNFORTUNATELY I'M IN RISING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
WOULDN'T HAVE SPOKN EXCEPT
THAT PEOPLE HAVE MISCONSTRUED
MY OPPOSITION SO I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR. THE EQUITY ARGUMENT
THAT EQUALITY CALIFORNIA OTHERS
A PROMOTED FOR THIS BILL I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH IN FACT I
AGREE WITH IT SO MUCH THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THEY GAVE ME TO
TAKE IN APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
WHAT IS STILL CREATED A TWO
TIER SYSTEM I REFUSED TO TAKE
BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT EQUITABLE
SOLUTIONS. ANY SEX IS SEX I
DON'T CARE WHO IT'S BETWEEN OR
WHAT SEX ACTED AS THAT BEING
SAID I CANNOT IN MY MIND AS A
MOTHER UNDERSTAND HOW SEX
BETWEEN A TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
AND A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD COULD
EVER BE CONSENSUAL HOW IT COULD
EVER NOT BE A REGISTRABLE
OFFENCE I DON'T CARE WHAT KIND
OF SEX IT IS I DON'T CARE IF
IT'S- TRADITIONAL I DON'T EVEN
I YOU KNOW I'M NOT GOING TO.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHEN A
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD HAS SEX
WITH A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD IT IS
ALWAYS IN AND AN EQUITABLE
SITUATION MOST THE TIME IT'S A
TEACHER AND STUDENT IT MIGHT BE
A BIBLE STUDY INSTRUCTOR COACH
IN A STUDENT I'VE HAD FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD I'VE ASKED EVERYBODY
AS THIS IS THAT MY COMMITTEE
FOR TWO YEARS A MAN BOTH SIDES
OF THE BILL. ANAND THE CURRENT
SITUATION WHERE WHERE ONE SEX
ACT BETWEEN A TWENTY FOUR TO
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED CONSENSUAL BY A
JUDGE AND AMEND THIS SO WE CAN
HAVE EQUITY BECAUSE IT SHOULD
BE EQUITABLE. BUT WE SHOULD
NEVER GIVE UP ON THIS IDEA. THE
CHILDREN ARE NOT. IT SHOULD BE.
ANY WAY. SUB TO A PREDATOR IN
THAT'S WHAT IT IS I CAN NOT AND
I'VE NEVER HEARD IN A CHALLENGE
EVERYBODY GIVE ME A SITUATION
WHERE TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD HAD
SEX WITH A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
ANY KIND OF SEX AND WASN'T
PREDATORY ANY EXAMPLE AND I'VE
YET TO SEE IT. I HAVE BEEN THE
MOTHER OF A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND I'M SORRY INTEL YOU CAN
SHOW ME THAT I CAN'T VOTE FOR
THIS BILL AS MUCH AS I WANT TO
CREATE AN EQUITABLE SITUATION I
THINK THIS IS GO BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD I THINK WE NEED
TO TAKE A BOTH PORTIONS OF THE
CODE AND MAKE A DETERMINATION.
I UNDERSTAND IT LEAVES IT UP TO
A JUDGE IT LEAVES IT UP TO A
JUDGE I STILL HAVE NEVER SEEN A
SINGLE INSTANCE BY WHICH A
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD SHOULD BE
HAVING SEX WITH A FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER NO VOTE. THANK YOU MATH
GONZALES. MISTER TROY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND A MEMBER SOLVE GET SOMEBODY
I STAND TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. ONE FORTY FIVE. POLITICS
ARE AS A LIFELONG EDUCATOR WE
PLACE ALL DON'T START IN PLACES
SOLVE OUR TRUST. WITH A AND A-
IN ON AGE OF HISTORIC US SEX
TRAFFICKING AND A CHILD IS
TRAFFICKING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS SET
ENTIRELY IN APPROPRIATE. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY. TWENTY
FOUR YEAR OLD THE VOLUNTEER OF
COURTS. SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
REGISTER AS A SEX OFFENDER FOR
BEING UP WITH A FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD STUDENT. STATUTORY RAPE ALL
SHOULD BE OUR- REGISTER A MORE
OFFENSIVE EITHER WAY AND A BY
IMPLORING THIS OFFENSE
COLLEAGUES SO WE ARE SIGNALING
TO FAMILIES AND THE CHILDREN
EVERYWHERE THAT THE WE SUPPORT
THAT IS SO ABUSIVE WITH
SITUATIONS. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SUMMARY. OF THIS BILL IT TO
PROVIDES THAT THE PRESENCE OF A
CONVICTED OF LAW SODOMY ORAL
COPULATION WHAT SEXUAL
PENETRATION BY FOREIGN OBJECT.
ON THE SPECIFIED THE PROVISIONS
OF ONE ALL WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER SO. IF WHAT AT THE
TIME OF ALL FANS THE PERSON IS
ON NOT MORE THAN TEN YEARS
OLDER THAN THE MINOR. AND THE
CONVICTION IS SO OFTEN THE ONE
REQUIRING THE PERSON TO
REGISTER. I'M IN THIS IS SO
UNBELIEVABLE WHAT KIND OF A
BILL LEASES SO WHAT KIND OF OUR
LOW SO WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO.
AMERICA BY THIS BODY THIS IS
ARE INTOLERABLE. IT IS SOLVABLE
SINCE ABOUT AYE RESPECTIVELY
AYE BAG YOU'LL TO VOTE NO YES
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER.
CHINA'S FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. CERTAINLY THIS
IS A DIFFICULT BILL AND IT'S A
DIFFICULT SUBJECT. I'M ALSO A
MOM AND I AGREE THAT IT WOULD
BE PRETTY MUCH IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ME TO IMAGINE A SITUATION.
WHERE SEX BETWEEN A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD AND A FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD COULD BE CONSENSUAL I JUST
DON'T BELIEVE THAT EXISTS.
HOWEVER WHAT CURRENT LAW SAYS
IS THAT IT'S POSSIBLE FOR A
JUDGE TO DECIDE THAT SEX
BETWEEN A TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
MAN AND A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
GIRL IS CONSENSUAL. BUT SEX
BETWEEN A NINETEEN YEAR OLD
MAN. AND A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
BOY. MUST LEAD TO THAT NINETEEN
YEAR OLD BEING PLACED ON THE
SEX REGISTRY FOR LIFE. THAT IS
WHY THE CURRENT LAW IS NOT
EQUITABLE. IF THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH THE JUDGE'S RULING
THAT SEX BETWEEN A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD AND A FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD OF ANY GENDER IS ALLOWABLE
WE SHOULD PROBABLY TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT LAW AND CHANGING THAT
LAW. BUT THAT IS NOT THE
QUESTION THAT IS IN FRONT OF US
NOW. THE QUESTION THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US NOW IS WHY ARE WE
TREATING SEX BETWEEN TWO SAME
GENDERED PEOPLE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENTLY THAN SEX BETWEEN. A
MAN AND A WOMAN THAT IS THE
QUESTION IN FRONT OF US NOW AND
THAT IS NOT JUSTIFIABLE WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF OUR VALUES IN
THE STATE. AND YES THERE ARE
CASES. WHERE THEY STATE IS
WASTING RESOURCES MONITORING AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WHO'S ON THE
REGISTRY BECAUSE HE HAD SEX
WITH A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD-BOYFRIEND. THAT IS FACTUAL
CASES HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
IS WHY THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT IN BY
SURVIVORS ADVOCATES IN BY
CHILDREN NOW AND THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL
ASSAULT ARE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. BECAUSE WE HAVE DANGEROUS
SEX OFFENDERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT NEED MONITORING BUT A FOR
WASTING OUR TIME MONITORING
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WHO HAD SEX
WITH SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHICH
BY THE WAY IF IT WAS A- YOUNG
MAN AND A YOUNG WOMAN WOULD NOT
BE ON THE REGISTRY BUT IT IS
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE SAME
GENDER. WE ARE NOT USING
VALUABLE RESOURCES MONITORING
TRULY DANGEROUS SEXUAL
PREDATORS SO LET'S BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL IS AND
WHAT THIS BILL IS NOT BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF HYPERBOLE IN A
LOT OF EMOTIONS OVER IT THAT
ARE GETTING IN THE WAY. OF US
SEEING THAT THIS IS PURELY AN
EQUITY ISSUE IT IS NOT
DECRIMINALIZING STATUTORY RAPE
BY ANY EXTENT WITHOUT AYE
ORIGIN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. MISTER MERRETT CG YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS A FORMER CRIMINAL
PROSECUTOR I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE FORTY FIVE NOW I USUALLY
DO NOT RIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF A
BILL FROM SENATOR WIENER ON A
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRATION ISSUE
BUT- THIS IS AN EXCEPTION AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE POINTED
OUT THIS IS TRYING TO. RECTIFY
THIS OUTDATED INEQUITY BETWEEN
STRAIGHT SEX VERSUS GAY SEX I
COMPLETELY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO AS A PARENT IT
IS HARD TO IMAGINE. ANYTHING
THAT THE- WOULD NOT BE PROUDER
A GIVEN SOME OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE SHE
DESCRIBED. BUT AGAIN I MEAN
THIS GIVE THE JUST THE JUDGE
THE- YOU KNOW AND AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR I KNOW THAT- I HAVE
PROSECUTED CASES WHERE I FELT
BAD THAT. THERE WOULD BE A-
POTENTIAL LIFETIME DESIGNATION
THE SCARLET LETTER ON SOMEONE
L. AS A SEX OFFENDER REGISTER
FOR LIFE. YOU KNOW WHEN. IT
INVOLVED CONSENSUAL SEX I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS BILL
IS. COSPONSORED BY THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS. I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MURATSUCHI MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. HOME YOU KNOW I
THINK WHEN IT WHEN WE START
GETTING THESE QUESTIONS OF
EQUITY IN AND HOW WELL BALANCED
THIS IS FOR EVERYONE. YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE SOME GOOD
POINTS WHEN YOU BRING UP. THE
HANDFUL OF CASES. WHERE IT'S
WITHIN A FEW YEARS. BUT WHEN
YOU START TALKING ABOUT THIS
HILLIARD GAS. THAT THIS OPENS
UP. IT TEARS AT THE MORAL FIBER.
OF OUR STATE OF OUR COMMUNITY.
OF OUR FAMILIES. IN THIS BILL
JUST GOES TOO FAR. I ASK YOU
ALL TO CONSIDER THAT THINK
ABOUT IT. HOW WOULD YOU FEEL.
IF IT WAS YOUR FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD. IN SOMEBODY WAS TEN YEARS
OLDER THAN THEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS MR MAYS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. SOME THANK
YOU A MATTIS BEAKER AND
MEMBERS- I RISE SIDE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. BUT I DID NOT
LAST WEEK A SUPPORT- THIS BILL-
BECAUSE UNLIKE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE ATTORNEYS
UNLIKE SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE- WHERE PROSECUTORS SOME
OF WHOM DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
UNDERSTAND THE LAW SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO WERE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOMETIMES THESE
SORTS OF BILLS- ARE BILLS THAT.
ARE CHALLENGING FOR US BUT I
FOUND THIS ONE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WAS IN SUPPORT. AND
I THOUGHT WELL THAT'S
INTERESTING WHY ARE THE
PROSECUTORS. UP ACROSS THE
STATE THE ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTING THIS BILL SO I
THOUGHT YOU KNOW I'M GONNA
REACH OUT TO MY TWO D. A.'S SO
I CALLED OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND I
CALLED THE SALMON YOU KNOW
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SPOKE
WITH BOTH OF THEM. AND IT TURNS
OUT THAT ONE OF THOSE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S AS AN EXPERT IN THE
SEX CRIMES CASES. AND HE SAID
CHAD I NEED TO SPEND A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME JUST DIGGING INTO
THIS. AND AFTER HE DID HE
CALLED ME THE NEXT DAY SPENT
FIFTEEN MINUTES WITH ME GOING
THROUGH IT AND HE SAID THIS
BILL IS RIGHTEOUS AND IT IS
JUST THIS COMING FROM A
CONSERVATIVE. PROSECUTOR. THESE
ARE THE TYPES OF BILLS MEMBERS.
THAT IS VERY EASY FOR US
POLITICALLY TO TAKE A PASS ON.
IF YOU VOTE FOR THIS FOR SURE
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A HIT I'M
GONNA TAKE A HIT BECAUSE I'M
VOTING FOR TONIGHT. I GUARANTEE
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE A HIT ON
THIS BILL BUT AT SOME MOMENT IN
TIME IT'S OUR JOB WE SEE THIS
ALL THE TIME IT'S OUR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSIBILITY.
TO MAKE GOOD LAWS THAT'S WHAT'S
THAT THAT'S WHAT THIS SAYS JUST
IN FRONT OF US THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS YOU WILL TAKE A
POLITICAL HIT FOR. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IT'S RIGHTEOUS. AND
IT IS JUST THIS IS THE TIME TO
STEP UP. AND I URGE AND I VOTE
THIS EVENING. THANK YOU MR
MAYOR. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THIS CAMARGO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THE ROBUST. DISCRETION ON
THIS BILL IT'S ALWAYS HARD ON
THIS FLOOR TO TALK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I THINK SOME FOLKS
STILL JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO.
DEAL WITH IT I WANT TO MISS
CONNOR I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT
YOU BUT I DIDN'T SEE THEM AS
WEBER WITH TO GET RECOGNITION
DO YOU MIND IF WE COME BACK
HERE FOR CLOSE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER I APOLOGIZE
NO PROBLEM I WILL BE VERY VERY
BRIEF I THOUGHT THERE WERE
OTHER FOLKS WANTING TO TALK.
I'VE COME HERE OBVIOUSLY TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND THIS IS A BILL
REALLY ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY THAT'S WHAT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT AND WE HAVE SEEN
TIME AND TIME AGAIN EVEN ON
THIS FLOOR. BUT WE'VE SEEN
ACCIDENT OCCURRED IN THE PAST
THAT ARE MADE ASSEMBLY OURS
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES THAT WE
HAVE TO DISCRIMINATE. AND WE'VE
SEEN OURSELVES GRAPPLING WITH
THOSE ISSUES THAT OVERTURNING
PASSED POLICIES AND CELEBRATING
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD BEEN ABUSED
BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. WE DID THAT THIS%
YEAR WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE IT IS
NOW TIME THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE ISSUE OF THIS IS NOT REALLY
JUST THE OTHER ASPECTS OF THE
LAW. BUT REALLY THE ISSUE OF
FAIRNESS AND JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY AND NOT OUR OWN BIASES
WITH REGARDS TO SEXUAL
PREFERENCE AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND SO WE CAN CREATE
IMAGES THAT IT'S YOU KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING'S GOING A MONTH. BUT
WHEN WE HAVE OUR OWN DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
VERY CONSERVATIVE IN THEIR
POINT OF VIEW SAYING THIS IS AN
UNJUST TO PRACTICE THAT WE
HAVE. AND THAT THIS LAW NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED SO THAT WE CAN
TREAT EVERYONE WITH FAIRNESS
REGARDLESS OF THE SEXUAL
ORIENTATIONS I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT WE DO THAT WE-
VOTE IRELAND. ONE FORTY FIVE
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU THINK
IN YOUR OWN PERSONAL LIFE THIS
IS ABOUT NOT HAVING
DISCRIMINATION AND WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE DONE THAT. SYSTEM HISTORY
OF THIS COUNTRY IN EVERY NOW
AND THEN WE HAVE TO STEP
FORWARD AND MAKE IT RIGHT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOOK
ONE. THANK YOU DR ROBERT THANK
YOU MISS KAMAGRA FOR INDULGENCE
BACK. TO HER CLOSE. NOW ARE.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO JUST
THREE. THAT THERE IS. VIEWED
THIS. IN THIS. SOME FOLKS
MENTIONED THE TEN YEAR CAP. THE
TEN YEAR CAP IS ACTUALLY
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAW.
AND IF FOLKS ARE CHALLENGED
WITH THAT I ACTUALLY URGE. AND
NEXT LEGISLATIVE SESSION TO DO
A BILL THAT FOCUSES ON THAT TEN
YEAR GAP BUT THAT IS NOT THIS
BILL. SB ONE FORY FIVE DOES
NOT CHANGE THE OFFENSES FOR SEX
CRIMES WITH A MINOR. THIS BILL
DOES NOT DECRIMINALIZE ANY KIND
OF SEXUAL CRIMINAL ACTS. IT
ALLOWS PROSECUTORS TO CONTINUE
PLACING OFFENDERS ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY. AS WAS
MENTIONED IT IS SUPPORTED AND
IN FACT SPONSORED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I WANTED TO
SAY THAT IF. YOU KNOW A
NINETEEN YEAR OLD. HAS
CONSENSUAL SEX WITH A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD AND SOMETHING GOES
AWRY IN THE RELATIONSHIP. THAT
NINETEEN YEAR OLD. J. CHILD.
WILL BE PUT ON THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY IT WILL BE MANDATORY.
AND WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT HOW
WE SUPPORT LGBT RIGHTS. HOW
WOULD YOU FEEL. HAVING TO TELL
THE PARENTS OF THAT NINETEEN
YEAR OLD. THAT THEY DESERVE TO
BE ON THE SEX REGISTRY FOR LIFE
BECAUSE THEY ARE GAY. THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE WOULD BE
SENDING. AND THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE FIGHTING AGAINST WHEN WE
VOTE FOR SB ONE FORTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
DON'T CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. FIFTY
THREE SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTEEN BY SENATOR HILL
AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND FORM
OF YOURS THERE ARE STICK FACT.
MR DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YESTERDAY WE ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE AND
RELATED WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS FOR OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS FIGHTING THE COVERT
NINETEEN VIRUS THE VIRUS IS
MUCH MORE THAN ECONOMIC
CHALLENGE CALIFORNIANS THE
SCALE OF HUMAN SUFFERING IS
DIFFICULT TO OVERSTATE. THIS IS
WHY I JOIN SENATOR HILL IS THE
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL THE BILL EXTENDS FAIR TIME
LIMITED PRESUMPTIONS TO
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND TO
WORKERS AT A WORKPLACE WITH A
COVERT NINETEEN OUTBREAK. I
HOPE. YOU WILL JOIN THE BROAD
COALITION OF SUPPORTERS FOR
THIS BILL BY CASTING YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER DALY SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
NINE IS YOUR ON THE MEASURE IS
FIFTY NINE NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE BY
SENATE BILL AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE TRANSPORTATION
OF MAKING APPROPRIATION OR FOR.
MR DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. THIS BILL IS AN
ECONOMIC STIMULUS MEASURE THAT
WILL CREATE JOBS AND PUT PEOPLE
TO WORK IT COMES TO US AUTHORED
BY SENATOR BOB BELL THE MEASURE
PROPOSES TO ACCELERATE PROJECTS
IN THE APPROVED TWENTY TWENTY
STATE HIGHWAY OPERATIONS AND
PROTECTION PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE SHOP PROGRAMS. BY
AUTHORIZING THE STATE TREASURER
TO SELL BONDS THAT WOULD BE
PAID BACK WITH A FRACTION OF
THE TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
FEE THAT IS ALLOCATED TO
CALTRANS UNDER SB ONE THE BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY KEY
TRANSPORTATION STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GENERAL
CONTRACTORS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR JOBS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DALY
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY
KNOWS THIRTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. FOURTEEN I'M GONNA
TALK SLOW. MISTER FLORA HOW WE
OKAY. OKAY WE'RE GOOD I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU TO
TAKE UP AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
TODAY WITH OUR OF HIS FATHER
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENT
SENTIMENTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE REQUEST IS GRANTED.
THE
FILE AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SO WELL. YES
SENATE BILL THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
AND OTHERS AND I REALLY NEEDED
TO COVER NINETEEN RELIEF IN THE
PLAN THERE'S A CEDAR OF THICK
BACK IMMEDIATELY MISTER CHAIR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES. I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO AVERT A
TRULY LOOMING CRISIS. SINCE
THIS PANDEMIC BEGAN MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS DEPLETED THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS AND GONE INTO EXTREME
DEBT. AND AS A RESULT THEY'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO PAY THE RENT.
TOMORROW SEPTEMBER THE FIRST
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ENDS ITS
TEMPORARY VERSION MORATORIUM.
IF WE DON'T ACT BY MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT. ANY TENANT WHO'S BEEN
UNABLE TO PAY ANY AND ALL ON
PAID RENT WOULD IMMEDIATELY
HAVE TO PAY THAT RENT BACK OR
BE SUBJECT TO AN ADDICTION. A
WAVE OF MASSIVE EVICTIONS WOULD
BE CATASTROPHIC. CATASTROPHIC
FOR HOMELESSNESS AND COVERED
NINETEEN SPREAD. IT WOULD TURN
THIS RECESSION INTEGRATE
DEPRESSION. THIS BILLS
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE IS THAT IF
SOMEONE DUE TO NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN IS UNABLE TO PAY THE
RENT. AND IMMEDIATE EVICTION IS
NOT THE SOLUTION. AND EVICTION
WOULD MEAN THAT A TENANT WOULD
BE FORCED OUT ONTO THE STREETS.
AND THE LANDLORD WOULD NEVER
GET PAID. THIS BILL SAYS WE
SHOULD GIVE TENANTS SOMETIME TO
GET BACK UP ON THEIR FEET. SO
THAT THEY CAN EVENTUALLY PAY
BACK THEIR RENTS. UNDER THIS
BILL. IF YOU'VE EXPERIENCED A
COVERT ECONOMIC HARDSHIP AND
FOLLOW THE RULES. YOU WILL NOT
BE AFFECTED FOR INABILITY TO
PAY THE RENT. YOU WON'T BE
AFFECTED IF YOU MISSED PAYMENTS
DURING THE TIME PERIOD STARTING
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC THROUGH TODAY. AND IF
YOU PAY AT LEAST 25% OF THE
RENT. OVER THE NEXT FIVE MONTHS
THROUGH THE END OF JANUARY. YOU
ALSO WILL BE AFFECTED. AMONG
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE BILL. THIS
BILL REQUIRES TENANTS TO
DECLARE UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP. TO PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION IF YOU'RE HIRING
COME. TENANTS WILL CONTINUE TO-
THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE RENT TO
THEIR LANDLORDS AS RENTAL DEBT
IS CONVERTED TO CIVIL DEBT. AND
THEY CAN BE SUED FOR IT. THIS
BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE HOMEOWNER
BILL OF RIGHTS. THE SMALL
LANDLORDS TO PROTECT THEM FROM
FOR CLOSURE. AND ENSURE
MORTGAGE SERVICES WORK WITH
BARS ON LOAN WATFORD
MODIFICATION OPTIONS. TWO FINAL
POINTS FIRST. THIS IS A
TEMPORARY FIX. DURING THE NEXT
FIVE MONTHS WE WILL MONITOR THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
RECESSION AND WE WILL HAVE TO
REVISIT THIS EARLY NEXT YEAR. I
THINK I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MANY
OF US WHO BELIEVE THE ULTIMATE
SOLUTION IS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MUST STEP UP. STATES
WITH SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
DEFICITS CAN'T FIX IT ON OUR
OWN. WE NEED THE NEXT FEDERAL
MINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
ECONOMIC RELIEF FOR STRUGGLING
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS. MY LAST
COMMENT IS AFTER WEEKS OF ROUND
THE CLOCK NEGOTIATIONS WE
ARRIVED AT THE COMPROMISE
REFLECTED IN THIS BILL. IT'S
OFTEN SAID THAT THE SIGN OF
COMPROMISE IS BOTH SIDES ARE
DISSATISFIED AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE HERE. THIS BILL
ISN'T PERFECT BUT NECESSARY
SOLUTION TO AN ENORMOUS CRISIS.
WHILE THIS BILL WILL PREVENT OR
DELAY MANY OF ACTIONS IT PAINS
ME THAT IT WILL NOT STOP ALL
AFFECTIONS. THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE I WANTED TO SEE IN THIS
BILL SO MUCH MORE THAT I FOUGHT
FOR DURING THE NEGOTIATIONS SO
MUCH MORE NEEDED TO TRULY
PROTECT RENTERS. BUT THROUGH
THE NEGOTIATIONS IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THE CHOICE WAS NOT.
BETWEEN THIS PROPOSAL IN A
STRONGER ONE THE HOBSON'S
CHOICE WAS BETWEEN THIS
PROPOSAL AND NOTHING. WE HAVE
TO PASS THIS MEASURE TONIGHT
THE CONSEQUENCES OF DOING SO
ARE TOO DIRE TO COMPREHEND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR TO MR BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE OH EIGHT EIGHT NINE I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- ALL OF
HIS HARD WORK IN IN BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IT TO A TRULY HAS
BEEN A- A JOURNEY I THINK FOR
ALL OF US INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUE AND- I RISE IN SUPPORT
BOTH OF YOUR COLLEAGUE AND AS
THE SPEAKERS APPOINTEE TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND I.
THOUGHT THAT I WOULD PROVIDE.
SOME CONTEXT THAT- YOU HAVE TO
HELP YOU UNDERSTAND HOW WE GOT
HERE TODAY BACK IN MARCH THE
GOVERNOR MADE HIS EMERGENCY
ORDERS LOCKING DOWN THE STATE
AS A RESULT OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN OUTBREAK. AND THE
GOVERNOR SPECIFICALLY DEFERRED
TO THE COURTS THE ABILITY TO
ENTER THEIR OWN ORDERS WITH
RESPECT TO THE COURTS AS LONG
AS THEY WERE CONSISTENT WITH
HIS EXECUTIVE ORDERS. BECAUSE
THE COURTS WERE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME LOCKDOWN ORDERS OF THE
REST OF THE STATE. IT WAS
NECESSARY FOR THE COUNCIL TO
ENTER A NUMBER OF ORDERS
REGARDING COURT PROCESS IN
SEVERAL AREAS. AND AMONG THESE
WERE EVICTIONS AND FORECLOSURES.
SO WHY COULD THE COURT NOT
HANDLE EVICTIONS WILL
FUNCTIONAL COURTS REQUIRE. JUST
LIKE WE DO CORD EMPLOY A COURT
EMPLOYEES LIKE JUDGES CLERKS
AND BAILIFFS WE HAVE CLERKS WE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE NEED TO COME IN
AND OUT OF THE BUILDING. WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
ATTORNEYS AND LITIGANTS MUST BE
ABLE TO BE PRESENT. WELL THE
ONLY WAY FOR THE COURTS TO BE
ABLE TO FOLLOW THE GOVERNOR'S
LOCKDOWN ORDERS THAT THE COURT
REALLY HAD LITTLE CHOICE BUT TO
SUSPEND THEIR DAY TO DAY
ACTIVITIES. IN ORDER TO SAFELY
COMPLY. AND THIS RESULTED IN A
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ORDER STAYING
ALL EVICTION PROCEEDINGS. AS
THE COURTS BEGAN TO RE OPEN THE
RATIONALE FOR THE RULE BEGAN TO
SLOWLY ERODE AND THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL EVENTUALLY MADE A
DETERMINATION THAT EVICTION
PROCESS. COULD START UP AGAIN
BECAUSE THE COURTS WELL
FUNCTIONING AT A FRACTION OF
THEIR FORMER CAPACITY JUST LIKE
WE'RE NOT QUITE AT THE CAPACITY
WE'D LIKE TO BE. THE COURTS
COULD THEN HANDLE OBJECTIONS OR
AT LEAST BEGIN TO HANDLE THEM.
THIS WAS MATT WITH
UNDERSTANDABLE ALARM BY MANY
ADVOCATES AND THE COURT
DEFERRED ACTION HOWEVER
EVENTUALLY A TERMINATING ORDER
WAS MADE AND TOMORROW IS THE
DATE ON WHICH THAT ORDER TAKES
EFFECT. WHY TOMORROW. IT'S NOT
JUST A MATTER OF CONVENIENCE
DID YOU JUST WILL COUNCIL
WISELY GAVE THE LEGISLATURE THE
TIME REMAINING IN OUR SESSION
EVERY MINUTE OF OUR SESSION WE
NEEDED ALMOST OF ALL OF IT. TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN TO PROTECT
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS FROM A
CHAOTIC AND DAMAGING SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES IF WE WERE TO DO
NOTHING. FORTUNATELY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
HAD A BILL ALREADY IN PROCESS
HE'S AN EXPERT ON HOUSING. AND
THIS BECAME THE VEHICLE FOR A
VERY INTENSE AND COMPLEX ROUND
OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. THE ULTIMATE
RESULT IS THE BILL BEFORE US.
IT'S NOT A PERFECT DEAL
LANDLORDS HAVE QUALMS TENANTS
ARE NOT WOWED BY IT ADVOCATES
AND MEMBERS HAVE TAKEN ISSUE
BUT THE FACT IS THE BILL
PROVIDES BADLY NEEDED
PROTECTION AND STABILITY TO
POSSIBLY MILLIONS OF LANDLORDS
AND TENANTS ACCORDING TO TURNER
INSTITUTE. AND WILL HELP AVERT
CHAOTIC EKYC A CHAOTIC ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE SO I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB THREE AWAY DAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR LOW MR
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU BETTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS A BILL WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE TO DO AND I APPRECIATE THE
DILIGENCE IN THE WORK OF OUR
HOUSING CHAIR WHO HAS DEDICATED
THIS LAST YEAR. TO BE THAT
VOICE FOR TENANTS FOR THE SMALL
LANDLORDS FOR THE FOR THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE REALLY STRUGGLING
IN THIS PANDEMIC IN UNDER THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC. SITUATION BUT
WHAT'S MISSING FROM THIS AND I
KNOW THE LANDLORDS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THIS TENANTS
ARE LOOKING FOR SOME RELIEF.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING LIVELIHOODS
AND MONEY. BUT THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HELP HERE
THE MOST ARE NOT ACCOUNTABLE TO
ANYTHING UNDER THIS BILL AND I
THINK WE JUST NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT HERE. THAT ARE
SMALL LANDLORDS THAT WE WANT TO
PROTECT THE TENANTS WE WANT TO
PROTECT IT MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT LOSING THEIR HOMES
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO STAY IN
THE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THAT'S
GOOD FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S GOOD FOR THEM. BUT THE
BANKS WHO COULD BE HELPFUL HERE
AND UNDER ANY SCENARIO THE
BANKS WILL STILL GET THEIR
MONEY. BUT THEY COULD TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY. AND COULD HAVE
TAKEN SOME RESPONSIBILITY HERE.
TO HELP THE SITUATION OUT.
RATHER THAN JUST LOOKING TO
PROTECT THEIR SHAREHOLDER
INTERESTS. AT THE EXPENSE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES FALLING APART.
AND PEOPLE FACING THE
FRIGHTENING. CIRCUMSTANCE OF.
FINANCIAL RUIN. SO THIS BILL IS
SOMETHING WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
DO. IT'S NOT THE DEAL THAT HAD
BEEN CRAFTED OVER THE YEAR. IT
WAS PUT TOGETHER TO SATISFY OF
LOTS OF DIFFERENT INTERESTS.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE
VERY CAREFUL. WHEN WE'RE
PUTTING BURDENS ON PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY BURDENED AND THOSE
IN A POSITION TO HELP. GET AWAY
SCOT FREE. THAT PART TO ME IS
VERY DISTURBING BUT- WE HAVE TO
PASS THIS BILL TODAY WE ALL
HAVE TENANTS. SMALL LANDLORDS
OTHERS WHO ARE JUST HOLDING ON
IN OUR DISTRICTS. IF WE CAN'T
PASS THIS RELIEF. THERE IS NO
PLACE ELSE FOR THEM TO GO AYE
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MR STERN WAS WORKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. BEAR WITH
ME AS I TRIED THIS. LEGISLATURA
M. S. TWO SAYS LEISURE
CONDEMNING WHICH MEANS IT IS
THE DUTY OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENACT JUST LAWS THAT REPRESENT
AND PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
TO DO NOTHING IS THE MORAL. TO
SEE JUST RIGHT HERE ON THE GRID
OF SACRAMENTO ON ALMOST EVERY
CORNER SOMEBODY LINE. IN SOME
TYPE OF ENTRY WAY WITH BOXES
COVERING THEM WITH TRACHSEL
USUALLY AROUND THEM. SOME
BAREFOOT SOME HUNGRY. WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS FACED A
HOMELESS CRISIS WHAT CRISIS
WELL BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE
KNOW THAT LAST YEAR AT THIS
TIME WE STOOD ON THE FLOOR AND
FAT FOUGHT FOR RENT CAPS WITH
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND
THAT WAS A STEP WE STARTED THE
YEAR WITH THE GOVERNOR MAKING A
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE ON OUR WAY
TO TRY TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
COURSE THE PANDEMIC YET AND IN
MANY WAYS WE'VE INSTALLED. BUT
IMAGINE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF MORE PEOPLE ON OUR STREET.
WE DON'T HAVE THE SHELTERS WE
DON'T HAVE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND WE DON'T HAVE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR ALL
THOSE THAT MAY BE EVICTED IF WE
DO NOT SUPPORT THIS I CAN
GUARANTEE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO BE FLOODED WITH PEOPLE
WHO CANNOT FIND HOUSING SOME
MAY FIND HOUSING WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT WE KNOW IT'S GOING
TO BE FAMILIES. CHILDREN
SENIORS VETERANS THAT WILL ADD
TO OUR HOMELESS NUMBERS SO
MEMBERS. PLEASE DIG DEEP SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE
STEPS TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM BEING
EVICTED ONCE SOMEONE IS A
VICTIM IT IS MUCH HARDER FOR
THEM TO FIND HOUSING. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB. THREE ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
TELLING US RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM TO
OUR- MADAM SPEAKER I'M I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
THE MR MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO HAS DONE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING HOWEVER
THERE IS A POPULATION THAT WAS
LEFT OUT IN PARTICULAR I MET
WITH THE SENIOR GROUP. AND A
FEW OLDER LADIES ONE IN
PARTICULAR EIGHTY YEARS OLD WHO
IS- IN THE WHEELCHAIR HER
HUSBAND PASSED AWAY AND LEFT
HER THREE PROPERTIES HEARD
TAXES ARE TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR AND BY
DEFINITION OF MOST OF THE
ELDERLY HAVE PAID WELL MOST OF
THE ELDERLY FOLKS HAVE PAID
THEIR THEIR MORTGAGES OFF SO WE
LEFT THAT POPULATION OUT. SO I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT WE LOOK
FURTHER AND HOPEFULLY THE
GOVERNOR CAN HELP IN THIS
MATTER PROPERTY TAXES ARE DUE
IN DECEMBER AND WE ARE NOT
RETURNING UNTIL JANUARY SO WHAT
RELIEF TO THAT THOSE FOLKS GET
THOSE FOLKS ARE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR HOMES BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
PAY THEIR PROPERTY TAXES. SO I
URGE AND I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH BOTH MY COLLEAGUES- THE
AUTHORS OF THE BILL ABOUT
GETTING RELIEF FOR THOSE FOLKS
IT IS. GREAT THAT WE ARE TAKING
CARE OF LANDLORDS AND TENANTS
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE POPULATION
THAT. CANNOT PAY THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES SORRY URGE. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO PLEASE
LOOK INTO IT WE EXTENDED THE
PROPERTY TAX DEADLINE. OR THEN
SOME COUNTY THEY DID NOT IMPOSE
PENALTIES SO IF WE CAN DO THAT
AGAIN FOR THAT GROUP. PROPERTY
TAXES ARE DUE IN DECEMBER WE'RE
NOT COMING BACK TILL JANUARY
FOR THE OF THIS NEEDS TO BE
FIXED- HOPEFULLY THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. WITH THAT I
ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BANNISTER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I LISTEN TO THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE WHICH BY THE WAY WAS
ABOUT AN HOUR AGO. AND I HEARD
THE SAY THAT THIS IS A STOP GAP
MEASURE. THIS IS A FIVE MONTH
SOLUTION. I HEARD SEVERAL
MEMBERS SAY THAT THIS IS A
HIGHLY IMPERFECT SOLUTION BUT
IT'S THE ONLY VEHICLE WE HAVE
THAT IS THIS OR NOTHING. BUT
THAT'S NOT TRUE WE DON'T HAVE
TO LEGISLATIVE INTO AVOID. V.
OBVIOUS ALTERNATIVE IS TO KEEP
WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. EIGHTEEN OF US IN
THIS ASSEMBLY HAVE SENT A
LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR ASKING
FOR A SPECIAL SESSION. THIS
WOULD ALLOW US. TO DEAL WITH
ISSUES LIKE OF THE ADDICTION
CRISIS AS CONDITIONS WARRANT.
IN REAL TIME. IN A WAY WHERE
THE RELIEF IS TAILORED TO THE
DEMANDS OF THE MOMENT IN A WAY
THAT BALANCES THE EQUITIES. THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL JUST SAID IN
HIS INTRODUCTION THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO REVISIT THIS
EARLY NEXT YEAR ALL THE BETTER
TO REVISIT IT. IN OCTOBER AND
NOVEMBER TO SEE HOW THIS IS
WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE. WHO ARE
IN NEED. AND BY THE WAY IF
DURING. THIS EXTENDED SESSION.
WE DEVOTED THE FULL
INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO SORTING OUT THE
MESS OF THE EDT. WHICH
BASICALLY EVERYONE HERE HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED AND PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO GET THEIR
BENEFITS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THEN MAYBE WE WOULDN'T HAVE AS
MANY PEOPLE FACING ADDICTION.
IN THE FIRST PLACE. I HAVE SENT
A REQUEST TO THE SPEAKER TO
SIGN ON TO MY LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR. AND I ASK EVERYONE
HERE. TO DO SO AS WELL. I DON'T
REALLY EVEN SEE THE COUNTER
ARGUMENT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
WE DON'T HAVE EVENTS IN OUR
DISTRICTS TO ATTEND. THOSE HAVE
ALL BEEN CANCELED AND EVEN IF
WE WERE TO STAY IN SESSION A
FULL TWO MORE MONTHS WE STILL
WOULD END UP SPENDING LESS TIME
IN THE CAPITAL THIS YEAR. THAN
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY HAS BEEN. A
NIGHTMARE FOR MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. THE LEAST
WE CAN DO IS ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES. AND WORK AS HARD AS WE
CAN TO MAKE THINGS A LITTLE BIT
BETTER. THANK YOU MISTER PRIME
MINISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND BRINGING
THIS BILL BEFORE US TODAY.
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN AND WHAT IT'S DONE TO
OUR ECONOMY OUR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
SOARING UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS
HAVE LEFT THOUSANDS ON THE
BRINK OF EVICTION UNABLE TO PAY
THE RENT OR THE MORTGAGE AS THE
EXPIRATION DATE OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S EVICTION MORATORIUM
DRAWS NEAR VERY NEAR. IT IS THE
CENTRAL THAT WE STRIKE THE
DELICATE BALANCE OF PROTECTING
TENANTS WITHOUT FURTHER
JEOPARDIZING THE LIVELIHOODS OF
THE SMALL LANDOWNERS WHO RELY
ON RENT PAYMENTS FOR THEIR OWN
SURVIVAL A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT STRIKES THAT BALANCE. IT
IS A PRAGMATIC REASONABLE
SOLUTION TO THE CRISIS FACING
OUR STATE AND FOR THESE REASONS
I SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON.
MR SANTIAGO ARE YOU SEE
RECOGNITION YEAH OKAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR. THANK YOU A MAN
SPEAK I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TODAY L.
L. O. COLLEAGUES I'M STANDING
UP HERE TO URGE. A YES VOTE
BECAUSE WHAT'S AT STAKE IS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LIVING ON
THE STREET WHEN WE BEGAN THIS
SESSION WE TALKED ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS BEING THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES OF OUR
LIFETIME. AND IF WE DON'T MATH
WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS. YOU
COULD ALMOST ANY NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND WE BEGIN TO SEE TENTH.
WHERE PEOPLE LIVING YOUNG
FAMILIES ARE NOW ARE NOW
LIVING. THERE ARE CARS. WHERE
PEOPLE NOW LIVE IN THESE CARS
COULD YOU IMAGINE A WORLD WHERE
THERE ARE NO TEN A PROTECTION
AND WE CANNOT KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES. THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE TO GET ON A BUS ON THE
STREET IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT. THAT WE VOTE YES ON
THE BILL BEFORE NOW ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
OF THE AISLE SUGGESTED THAT WE
CONTINUE TO STAY HERE AND WORK.
NOW THAT'S A CLEVER IDEA TO
CONTINUE EARNING A PER DIEM THE
REALITY IS WE HAVE A VOTE
BEFORE US TO CONTINUE THE HARD
WORK THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH
ALL YOUR AND ENSURE THAT
TENANTS CONTINUE TO STAY.
HOLLISTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IDOL. THANK YOU MR
SANTIAGO. SB MON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THEIR THE TIMER.
THANK YOU WHEN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ASKED ME TO
PARTNER WITH HIM ON THIS EFFORT
I KNEW IT WOULD BE A CHALLENGE
AS WE HAVE HEARD THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT PROBLEM
FOR OUR STATE THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS AND THERE ARE
NO EASY ANSWERS. I SHARE THE
MANY CONCERNS RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
AND NEED TO FIND FINANCIAL HELP
FOR BOTH LANDLORDS AND TENANTS.
BUT WE ASK OURSELVES WHERE IS
THE MONEY. HERE WE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH NO ADDITIONAL
HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OUR OWN FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET GAP
TO DEAL WITH THIS IS THE
REALITY. EXCEPT FOR CASH
ASSISTANCE THE MOST VALUABLE
BENEFIT THAT WE CAN PROVIDE FOR
ALL OF THE FOLKS IS TO GIVE
PEOPLE MORE TIME TO PAY OFF
THEIR DEBT. MORE TIME TO BRIDGE
THE GAP. TO FUTURE WERE EITHER
THE VIRUS IS CONTROLLED OR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS STEPPED
UP WITH FUNDING. IN AN EFFORT
TO PROVIDE AND ROUTE TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO LANDLORDS AS THEY
PROVIDE RELIEF TO TENANTS I
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND ADVOCATED FOR
LEGAL PROTECTIONS RELATED TO
FORBEARANCE AND FOR CLOSURES.
WELL I HAVE BEEN ENCOURAGED BY
THE VOLUNTARY ACTIONS OF MANY
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS I STILL
BELIEVE. STRONGLY THAT WE MUST
PROVIDE A LEGAL FRAMEWORK THAT
PROTECTS ALL BUYERS REGARDLESS
OF THE- PATIENT'S OR GENEROSITY
ARE THERE SPECIFIC FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION. WE FOUGHT HARD FOR
STRONGER PROTECTIONS FOR
MORTGAGE BORROWERS AND I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I NOT THINK THE
STAFF FROM BANKING JUDICIARY IN
HOUSING OF BOTH HOUSES WHO WORK
TIRELESSLY TO FIND A SOUND
LEGAL APPROACH TO THIS PROBLEM.
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME DOES NOT
PROVIDE. ALL OF THIS
PROTECTIONS THAT BARS NEED WHO
MAY FALL INTO DELINQUENCY. IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE ALL THE LEGAL
PROTECTIONS THAT MAY BE NEEDED.
HOWEVER AS WE RETURN TO OUR
DISTRICTS. IT IS A CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US TO BE
AWARE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS AND BE
PREPARED TO COME BACK. AT A
TIME WHERE WE CHU CAN LOOK AT
THE EVIDENCE OF WHAT'S HAPPENED
IN OUR DISTRICT AND CAN CHANGE
SOME OF THIS AND CAN INTRODUCE
NEW LEGISLATION. AS WE KNOW.
THIS BILL ONLY GETS US THROUGH
JANUARY. BUT THERE IS LITTLE
DOUBT THAT OUR WORK CONTINUES
WHETHER WE ARE HERE OR IN OUR
DISTRICTS. IN CLOSING I KNOW
THAT THIS IS A HARD BILL BUT WE
DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY OF DOING
NOTHING. I CANNOT IMAGINE THAT
ANY OF US WANT TO SEE A WAVE OF
EVICTIONS AND FORECLOSURES THAT
HARM OUR COMMUNITIES. WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISLI MON
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER TO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER LET ME FIRST
START BY THANKING. ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS
YOUR CRITICS. AND SAY THAT I
AGREE WITH THE CRITICS. THIS
PROPOSALS IN PERFECT. I WISH IT
HAD MORE FOR TENANTS FOR
EXAMPLE WE SHOULDN'T BE
STARTING EVICTIONS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND SHOULD HAVE A
REAL EVICTION MORATORIUM. FOR
STRUGGLING LANDLORDS WE SHOULD
HAVE REAL MANDATORY MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE. FOR BOTH. WE NEED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY GONNA BE HAVING A
CONVERSATION THIS FALL AS WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT NEED
TO DO ENGINE NUMBER. LET ME
JUST SAY IN CLOSING IF YOU'RE
STILL ON THE FENCE. THANK ABOUT
HER CONSTITUENTS LAST MONTH
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
RENTERS REPORTED LITTLE OR NO
CONFIDENCE IN BEING ABLE TO
MAKE THE NEXT RENTS. THAT'S
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
EACH OF OUR DISTRICTS. THEY ARE
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WHO
CLOSED HIS SHOP. THE IMMIGRANT
FAMILY WHO LOST WORKED AT THE
RESTAURANT. THE SINGLE MOM
TAKING CARE OF THE KIDS WHEN
THE SCHOOL CLOSED. AND IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE FENCE.
THINK ABOUT THIS MOMENT. IN A
DECADE WHEN WE LOOK BACK ON
THIS TIME WE WILL REMEMBER.
THAT DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE
HAVE THE CHOICE TO DO
SOMETHING. OR DO NOTHING.
PASSING AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
IS THE LEAST THAT WE CAN DO. ON
BEHALF OF HUNDREDS OF TENANTS
PROGRESSIVE AND LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS LIVING
ON THE EDGE OF AN EVICTION. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND ASK
FOR IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE DO
YOU. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
SIX KNOWS EIGHT ON THE MEASURE
I FIFTY SIX KNOWS IT ON THE
URGENCY SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
ENROLLMENT.
MEMBERS WE WILL GO
TO FILE ITEMS U. S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN BY CENTER BRADFORD AND
OTHERS IN ACTIVATING TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. IT'S AROUND AS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN WHICH ITS JOB WHICH
IS A SMALL BUSINESS TAX CREDIT
A ONE THOUSAND PER ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYEE FOR A MAXIMUM OF ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR THE TAX CREDIT THE
SMALL BUSINESS MUST DEMONSTRATE
THAT IT HAD A NET INCREASE IN
JOBS WHEN COMPARING EMPLOYMENT
IN THE SECOND QUARTER. A TWENTY
TWENTY WITH EMPLOYMENT DURING
THE FIVE MONTH PERIOD OF JULY
FIRST TO NOVEMBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AS THEY FIGHT TO REOPEN AND
RECOVER FROM THE ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES BROUGHT ON BY KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIS CREDIT
IS ESPECIALLY VALUABLE BECAUSE
A SMALL BUSINESSES CAN USE THIS
TAX CREDIT TO EITHER OFFSET
INCOME TAX OR SALES TAX OR USE
TAX LIABILITY COLLEAGUES THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE A TAX CREDIT
TO SMALL BUSINESSES WHO HIRE
ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MESS AROUND
HAZING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS VERY VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS GO TO THIRD OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOUGH I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
SO WE
HAVE. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I'M SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TODAY WHATEVER
IT REFERENCE THE FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY ONE MEDINA SB SIX THIRTY
NINE CERVANTES AB EIGHT NINETY
WOOD A. B. NINE NINETY FIVE C.
GARCIA A. B. TWELVE NINETY NINE
SALAS A. B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BLOOM. AB TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR YEARS YOURS TRULY AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO KALRA
THANK YOU MR CLARK. WE WITHHOLD
EMAILS GIPSON ASTRAL CALL VOTE
YOURS TRULY. MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MISTER MULLIN SECONDS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. LONG
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. MEMBERS VOTER THERE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I DO YOU
KNOW WELL THE MOTION IS ADOPTED.
BETTER MEMBERS REFERENCE TO
FOR. THIS IS A THREE THIRTY ONE
MEDINA. CALGARY ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE THIRTY ONE BY ASSUME WE
WERE MEDINA ANOTHER STATICALLY
PEOPLE IN. MISTER THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB THREE
THIRTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS RECENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE INTENT FOR PUPILS
ENROLLED IN CHARTER SCHOOLS.
PUSH BACK THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE TO GIVE TIME TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
FINALIZE THE MODEL CURRICULUM.
ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO USE THE MODEL
CURRICULUM OR TO USE EXISTING
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES THAT
MEET THE A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENT. AND BECOMES
OPERATIVE ONLY UPON
APPROPRIATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA. SENIOR
DISCUSSION I'M SORRY MR BONTA
HERE RECOGNIZE. MISTER MONTE
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND IS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB THREE THREE ONE
THE RECENT PROTESTS AND
DIALOGUE AROUND RACE HAVE
PROVENTHE NEED FOR BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR OMMUNITIES. TO THE
LANDS OF ETHNIC STUDIES ASIAN
BUT ISLANDER STUDIES WITHIN
ETHNIC STUDIES HAS BEEN
CRITICAL TO DISPEL THE MODEL
MINORITY MYTH AND REVEALED THAT
VAST AND DIVERSE SUBGROUPS
EXIST WITHIN THIS UMBRELLA TERM
SUCH AS PACIFIC ISLANDER AND
ARAB AMERICANS TO ELIMINATE OR
DEFER MIGRATION HISTORIES AND
TO MAKE VISIBLE THE VARIED
OBSTACLES AND BARRIERS. THAT
EACH OF THE ETHNIC GROUPS
INCLUDED WITHIN A P. I. STUDIES
ARE GRAPPLING WITH THE BENEFITS
OF ETHNIC STUDIES CAN BE
MEASURED MULTIPLE STUDIES SHOW
THAT WHEN STUDENTS OF COLOR
LEARN MORE ABOUT RACE RACISM
AND CULTURAL IDENTITY THEY
RAISE THEIR GRADES AND THE
GRADUATION RATES. AND I'M MORE
LIKELY TO ATTEND COLLEGE-
EXACTLY AFTER AYE VOTE IS THE
PRIORITY BILL FOR THE PACK ON.
THANK YOU MR BONTA. MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
OFFER CONGRATULATIONS AND TO
SPEAK TO CERTAIN AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE ADDED TO AB THREE
THREE ONE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS. GIVEN THAT THIS IS A
BILL OF SUCH CONSEQUENCE WE
FELT THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
CLARIFY FOR THE RECORD AND FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE WATCHING AT
HOME. THE ORIGIN AND PURPOSE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS. WHEN THIS
BILL WAS FIRST INTRODUCED THE
IDEA THAT WE SHOULD TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES IN CALIFORNIA
WAS NOT A CONTROVERSIAL ONE IN
THE JEWISH CAUCUS OR IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. INDEED THIS
BILL ENJOYED THE SUPPORT OF
EVERY MEMBER OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS WHEN IT FIRST PASSED
THIS HOUSE. IT WAS OFFICIALLY
SUPPORTED BY MAJOR JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE ADL. AND
ARE CALLING FROM SANTA MONICA
WHO WE LOVINGLY REFER TO AS THE
DEAN OF THE JEWISH CAUCUSIS A
JOINT AUTHORS. INDEED IT WAS
NOT UNTIL THE INITIAL DRAFT
MODEL CURRICULUM WAS RELEASED
BY CD THAT OUR COMMUNITY
STARTED TO PAY ATTENTION. TO
PUT IT LIGHTLY THAT DRAW DRAFT
CAUGHT OUR COMMUNITY OFF GUARD.
AND OUR CAUCUS RAISED
OBJECTIONS TO CERTAIN PORTIONS
OF THE DRAFT WHICH INCLUDED
CONTENT ABOUT THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND ABOUT ISRAEL THAT
WAS INACCURATE BIASED AND VERY
OFFENSIVE. PERSONALLY
PROFESSIONALLY WAS A DIFFICULT
MOMENT FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND
FOR ME. WHICH STRUGGLE TO
RECONCILE HOW AND WHY A TIME OF
RISING ANTI SEMITISM WITH ****
MARCHING IN CHARLOTTESVILLE AND
ATTACKING JEWS AND HOW WAY.
ANYONE WOULD WANT TO TEACH A
CURRICULUM THAT INCLUDES
STEREOTYPES ABOUT JEWISH
CONTROL AND MANIPULATION OF THE
MEDIA THAT LITERALLY ACCO ****
PROPAGANDA. SINCE THAT TIME OUR
CAUCUS WHO STRUGGLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN SUPPORT IN
ETHNIC STUDIES KNOWING IT'S A
CENTRAL VALLEY AND INHERENT
VALUE IN A DIVERSE STATE. AND
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO OUR
SISTER CAUCUSES AND MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WHILE ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AREN'T TEACHING THE PROBLEMATIC
PORTIONS OF THE MODEL
CURRICULUM. OUR CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN HEIGHTENED BY THE EFFORTS
OF A SMALL GROUP OF FOLKS HAVE
GONE AROUND TO LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS TRYING TO RALLY SUPPORT
FOR THE ORIGINAL CURRICULUM.
FOR WORKING TO REINSERT BIGOTRY
AND DISCRIMINATION BACK INTO
THE TEACHING OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
AFTER CONSULTATION WITH
EDUCATIONAL EXPERTS WE
CONCLUDED THAT THE BEST
APPROACH WOULD BE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE INSERT SOME
GUARDRAILS. SO THAT ETHNIC
STUDIES CANNOT BE MISSED USE IS
A VEHICLE TO ATTACK OR DEFAME
JEWS OR ISRAEL OR ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY OR NATION. IN SO
DOING WE LOOK TO THE GUARDRAILS
THAT ARE EXIST IN THE EDUCATION
CODE AROUND SEX EDUCATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH UNBIASED. AND
MEDICALLY ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT SEX AND ABOUT SAME SEX
RELATIONSHIPS. AND WE TOOK
THOSE EXISTING GUARDRAILS AND
MODIFIED THEM SLIGHTLY TO APPLY
TO THE SITUATION. I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE AND DEEP
APPRECIATION TO OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE WHO AGREED TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED GUARDRAILS.
AND WHO AND WHO AFTER WE
EXPLAINED THE PURPOSE HAD BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE BILL AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS. FOR PURPOSES OF
CLARITY I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THE RELEVANT AMENDMENTS WHICH
MANDATE THAT ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM CALIFORNIA MUST BE
APPROPRIATE FOR USE WITH PEOPLE
OF ALL BACKGROUNDS. NOT REFLECT
OR PROMOTE DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY ANY BIAS BIGOTRY OR
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ANY
PERSON OR GROUP OF PERSONS. ON
THE BASIS OF ANY PROTECTED
CATEGORY SUCH AS RACE RELIGION
NATIONAL ORIGIN OR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND NOT TEACH OR
PROMOTE RELIGIOUS DOCTRINE. TO
BE CLEAR THIS LANGUAGE MAKES IT
UNLAWFUL FOR ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA TO USE THE
ANTI SEMITIC OR ANTI ISRAEL
SECTIONS OF THE ORIGINAL DRAFT
CURRICULUM. OR TO OTHERWISE
TEACHER PROMOTE ANTI SEMITIC
STEREOTYPES BDS OR ANY OTHER
CURRICULUM. THAT PROMOTES
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY ANY BIAS
BIGOTRY OR DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST JEWS. ISRAEL THE
ISRAELI AMERICAN COMMUNITY OR
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY. THIS
LANGUAGE ALSO PROVIDES HELPFUL
DIRECTION TO CD WHICH IS
CONTINUE TO REVISE THE MODEL
CURRICULUM. SO THEY CAN EASILY
SAY NO TO THOSE ARE ADVOCATING
TO REINSERT ANTI JEWISH AND
ANTI ISRAELI MATERIAL BACK INTO
THE CURRICULUM. SINCE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOW CLEARLY
WEIGHED IN ON THIS ISSUE. WELL
THAT DISCRIMINATE CONTENT IS
LIKELY ALREADY IMPERMISSIBLE
UNDER THE EDUCATION CODE. THESE
AMENDMENTS MAKE IT AIRTIGHT AND
UNAMBIGUOUS. ONE FINAL THOUGHT.
THESE GUARDRAILS ARE IMPORTANT
NOT ONLY FOR OUR COMMUNITY BUT
FOR COULD ARENTS AND STUDENTS
OF ALL BACKGROUNDS WHO CAN FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT NO CHILD A GROUP
OF STUDENTS WILL BE SUBJECT TO
BIGOTRY OR DISCRIMINATION IN
THE CLASSROOM. REGARDLESS OF
THEIR RACE RELIGION NATIONAL
ORIGIN OR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
FINALLY I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE.
FOR WITH. BY RECOGNIZING THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO MOVE THIS BILL
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK THIS IS
A HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENT. A LEGACY
<c.blue>EFINING ACCOMPLISHMENT. AND I</c>
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A HUGE
WIN FOR OUR SISTER CAUCUSES.
FOR A LOT OF FOLKS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR FOLKS IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
AS WE REFLECT ON THE- FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY THE CHICANO
MORATORIUM SOMEONE OFFER YOU A
HEARTY CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
YOU ONE OF KNOWLEDGE ON A POINT
POINT CONGRATULATIONS AND LET'S
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER. THANK
YOU MISS GABRIEL SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION TODAY MR
MEDINA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. I THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
DECIDE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS ARE
THOSE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
THREE KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE
PASS. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MEMBERS WE ARE ON A
VERY TIGHT DYKE'S TYPE CLOCK
AND NOTHING SAYS HOW YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE VOTE PLEASE LET
MEMBERS PRESENT THEIR BILLS
QUICKLY DO YOUR VOTE AND LET'S
GET ON WITH IT THANK YOU. THIS
IS AB SIX THIRTY NINE. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE SB SIX OR
NINE COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES CYCLE IN A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT MISTER MANTAS THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSITIONING TO A
LOWER CARBON ECONOMY WHICH
INCLUDES TRANSFORMING THE
STATE'S GOODS MOVEMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SB SIX
THREE NINE ESTABLISHES A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS GUIDED BY
AN INDUSTRY PANEL TO CONFRONT
THESE CHALLENGES AND DEVELOP
PRACTICAL GROUNDED
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD. AT THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA DEVELOP AN EQUITABLE
GAME PLAN THAT SUPPORTS AN
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY AND UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHILE ALSO ACHIEVING LOWER GHG
EMISSIONS I WANT TO ESPECIALLY
THANK OUR ON THE EFFORTS OF
THIS BILL THE INTERNATIONAL
LONG SURE AND WAREHOUSE UNION
WORKERS FOR ALL THEIR
ASSISTANCE ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MARTIN C. NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARPOOL OF
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS AB. EIGHT NINETY.
MY DOCTOR WOULD CORPORATE SOME
PEOPLE EIGHT NINETY BY SOMEBODY
RIVER WOULD AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS DOCTOR
WOULD THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS THIS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS STRENGTH IN THE BILL
REQUIRING MORE PATIENT
DISCLOSURE REFERRAL CRITERIA A
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION THE
REGULATORY BOARD WAS CHANGED
AFTER HE ADMINISTRATION TOLD US
IT WAS TIME NOT TIME FOR A NEW
BOARD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THEY ELECT WOULD
DOCTOR ARAMBULA MEMBERS AND
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO SPEAK
ON AB EIGHT NINETY. I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
ATTENTION TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
CARE HOWEVER I WOULD BE REMISS
ABOUT NOT RAISING MY CONCERNS
AS AN EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR
OVER THE BILL AS AMENDED.
ALTHOUGH THE DISCUSSION ON AB
EIGHT NINETY HAS CENTERED ON
INCREASING ACCESS TO PRIMARY
CARE THE BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO
PRIMARY CARE AND WOULD ALLOW
NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
WITHOUT ANY SUPERVISION. AND
EVEN WITHOUT A PHYSICIAN
PRESENT IN THE ER. IN THE E. R.
MINUTES EVEN SECONDS MATTER. A
REQUIREMENT IN THIS BILL THAT A
NURSE PRACTITIONER CONSULT A
POSITION. FOR A MERGING
CONSIDER CONDITIONS IS
INSUFFICIENT UNLESS THE
POSITION IS PRESENT WITH IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL HAS
BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED IN
THE SENATE AND I WOULD ASK THAT
WE INSTEAD CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THE LANGUAGE AND THE INTENT OF
THE BILL AS IT WAS WHEN IT LEFT
THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU. THANK
ARAMBULA SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. DR WILLIAM
BECAUSE WE WISH I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT HER
CLUB THE ROLE. RESIDE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
NINE NINE FIVE CORPORATE SOME
BUILD NINE NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND OTHERS NOT QUITE A
HAZARDOUS WASTE MR SEAH YES
MEMBER AB NINE NINE FIVE IS SIX
YEARS IN THE MAKING IT THE
FIRST A CRITICAL STEP IN
REFORMING THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS GARCIA
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARABLE. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY ONE KNOWS THREE SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE AB
TWELVE NINETY NINE COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
AND OTHERS NOT REALLY THE PEACE
OFFICERS. MR SALIHU MAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE AS PART OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POLICE REFORM BILLS ARE
MOVING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
THIS MEASURE WILL PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OFFICERS
THAT RESIGN. FOR HAVING THE
INVESTIGATION ACTUALLY
COMPLETED THIS IS A GOOD
MEASURE GOOD COMMONSENSE
MEASURE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CARCLUB
THE ROLE- ALL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF A RESERVE A. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PERFORMING SOME AGO SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AND OTHERS NOT CLEAN THE
PESTICIDES. MISTER BLOOM YOU
MAY THANK YOU THIS IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS EXAM
PHARMA AND LIFE SCIENCE
COMPANIES STATE AGENCIES FOR
THE PROTECTION OF WATERWAYS AND
INFESTATIONS AND INCLUDES A
PUBLIC HEALTH EXEMPTION IN CASE
OF A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
FOR THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY
AND FOR VECTOR CONTROL. THE
BILL IS BROADLY SUPPORTED BY
OVER SIXTY ANIMAL RIGHTS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS INCLUDING
SEVERAL CITIES IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND AG HAS WITHDRAWN ITS
OPPOSITION IS GONE NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. C.
THEIR DISCUSSION PART OF THE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
ARE DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS ELEVEN SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
THAT REFERENCE THE FILE AB TWO
THOUSAND FOR HER CAREER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
ANOTHER SNACK LATER PRIVACY
MISTER CALDERON RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I VOTING CONCURRENCY
SENTIMENTS THANK YOU.SENIOR
DISCUSS DEBATE. CARCLUB THE
ROLL. OUT OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE CHAU VOTE AS FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
R. CONCURRED IN. THAT REFERENCE
THE FILE THIS IS AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY TWO PRIMARY. SUMMIT WILL
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY KALRA OTHERS NOT LATER
PROCEED MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. FOR THE
OPTION TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO FOR YOU TODAY
HARMLESS ERROR IS A BIAS
STATEMENTS IN THE COURT OF
LARGEST CRIME HARMLESS ERROR IS
HOW PREJUDICIAL BUT BEHAVIOR IS
DESCRIBED. HARMLESS ERROR THIS
ALL RACISM IS DEEMED ACCEPTABLE
IN OUR COURTS OF LAW. THIS
BEHAVIOR IS CONSIDERED HARMLESS
ERROR IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. MEMBERS HARMLESS ERROR
BY HARMLESS ERROR OF THE BRICKS
UPON WHICH INSTITUTIONALIZED
RACISM IS BUILT BRICK BY BRICK
PERSON BY PERSON IS HOW RACISM
IS BUILT INTO OUR LAWS AND
PRACTICES THIS IS JUST BELOW
OUR FEET WERE BECOMES A
FOUNDATION UNSEEN BY SOME IT
EXTRAORDINARILY DETRIMENTAL TO
OTHERS THIS IS HOW THE SCALES
OF JUSTICE BECOME TIPPED HOW TO
BECOME IMBALANCED UNTIL TO AWAY
FROM JUSTICE AND TOWARDS AN
EQUITY HOW RACISM BECOMES
INSTITUTIONALIZED AND I'M NOT
JUST TALKING ABOUT MY
OBSERVATION. THIS IS THE LAW.
UNDER MORE THAN FORTY FIVE YEAR
OLD. U. S. SUPREME COURT RULING
ON AS THE KLASKY RULING IN OUR
COURTS NOT HAS BEEN NOT JUST
INSTITUTIONALIZE BECOME
LEGALIZED AS A RESULT PREJUDICE
BIAS OR RACISM IN OUR COURTS
WHERE PEOPLE SEEK EQUAL.
JUSTICE UNDER LAW ARE NOT
CONSIDERED INTO THERE'S C. AS
HARM ERROR AND EYES WERE
CANNELLA SYSTEM. AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY TWO WOULD UNDO THIS
INJUSTICE BY OVERTURNING THIS
THIRTY THREE YEAR OLD PRESIDENT
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH THE RACIAL JUSTICE
ACT. A LONG OVERDUE MEASURE
THAT WOULD MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
SEEKING OR OBTAINING A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION OR IMPOSING A
SENTENCE BASED ON RACE
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IS
PROHIBITED. IT IS TIME TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE POLLS
THAT MAKES IT UNLAWFUL TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE STATE'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AS MILLIONS
MARCH FOR RACIAL JUSTICE WE
CANNOT STAND STILL WE CANNOT
IGNORE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IT IS
CLEAR THE BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE THE
BRUNT. OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THIS IS NOT A FLUKE
THIS IS BY DESIGN THISIS WHY
WE DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY OF
TINKERING AROUND THE EDGES OF
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IT IS
CONTINGENT UPON US TO RESPOND
TO THIS BILL WHETHER MOMENT. TO
PREVENT THE RACISM EMBEDDED
INTO OUR SYSTEM FROM HARMING
ANYONE EVER AGAIN. WITHOUT. A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORPORAL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE.
ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY TWO. KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
OKAY MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEES AS
WELL AS THE SENATE HAVE
TRANSMITTED SEVERAL ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE BILLS TO THE DESK.
THE BILLS ARE LISTED ON
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER ONE AS
ITEMS TO A ONE THROUGH ITEM TO
SIXTEEN. THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
IS POSTED ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE AND HAS BEEN EMAILED TO
ASSEMBLY OFFICES. THE MEASURES
AND ANALYSES ARE ON YOUR
TABLETS. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO TWELVE. WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT TWO THREE. I'M ASSUMING
THIS IS MR TANG. KERKORIAN
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE
BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACCOLADE AT YOU CAN ALSO MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FORCE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTERTAYLOR
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
S. B. EIGHT TWO THREE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE PROPOSAL TO REFORM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE.
JUSTICE FOR TOO LONG WE HAVE
NOT DONE THE SERVICE TO ALL THE
YOUTH. IN FORTUNATELY HAVE
INCARCERATED IN OUR STATE. AND
THIS IS ABOUT TIME TO SAY THAT
WE AS A STATE ARE LONG OVERDUE
FOR SOME MAJOR REFORM. LAST
YEAR WE TOOK ACTION TO MOVE DJJ
INTO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND UPON
REFLECTION. THIS YEAR THE
GOVERNOR REFORM HIS PROPOSAL
TO. MOVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND ASKED THE
COUNTIES TO- HAVE A GOOD SENSE
OF THE JUVENILES TO THE
KILLERS. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED USED IN OUR
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW AND NOTHING
WILL BE HAPPENING TO ANY OF
THOSE YOU. THIS PROPOSAL IS HOW
WE WILL MOVE FORWARD IN THE
FUTURE AS MORE YOUTH BECOME
INCARCERATED AND WHERE THEY
WILL BE. WHAT WE REALIZE IS
IT'S REALLY MUCH BETTER FOR THE
COUNTIES TO BE WORKING WITH
THESE POPULATIONS. THEY CAN
PARTNER WITH THE STATE. WE HAVE
DECIDED TO PAY THE COUNTIES TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER USE. THE ME JUST
REITERATE THAT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YOU.
SO WE HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE WE
THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
IMPROVE THE TREATMENT FOR THE
YOUTH. AND ON TOP OF THAT IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THIS IS
BETTER WE DECIDED WE'VE WE'VE
CREATED AN OFFICE OF YOUTH
JUSTICE AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. TO PROVIDE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROGRAMS.
AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROPOSAL FOR REFORMING A LONG.
A LONG DO SYSTEM WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
FOR SB EIGHT TWO THREE. FAMOUS
CHIANG MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE THIS
TRAILER BILL WILL STARTING NEXT
YEAR DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE TO HOLD INTAKE
AND SHIFT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE HOUSING OF THOSE USED TO
THE COUNTIES IN WHICH THEY WERE
CONVICTED. COLLEGE THIS IS A
SUDDEN HAD MASSIVE CHANGE TO
THE WAY THAT YOU JUSTICE IS
HANDLED IN CALIFORNIA MOREOVER
IT'S BEING BROUGHT UP IN THE
LAST WEEK OF SESSION WITH VERY
LITTLE TIME FOR THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO WEIGH IN ON
WHAT IS AN INCREDIBLY LARGE
CHANGE IN THE WAY THIS ISSUE IS
HANDLED IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE LET US KNOW
THAT THE SUBSTANTIAL CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAVE CONCERNS. THE
ABILITY OF COUNTIES TO REPLACE
WHAT DJJ DOES FOR OUR YOUTH
RIGHT NOW. LARGE COUNTIES MAY
BE ABLE TO DO THAT BUT THERE
ARE MANY SMALL COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE JUST ARE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO OFFER. THE
QUALITY OF PROGRAMS A DJJ
OFFERS DJJ OFFERS CURRENTLY
PROGRAMS THAT SPECIALIZE IN
TREATMENT OF THINGS LIKE A GANG
AFFILIATION SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
SEXUAL PREDATOR. THOSE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT THE SMALL
COUNTIES ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THE MEANS OF THE FUNDING TO
DEAL WITH. IRONICALLY THE
STATED PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AMONGST CALIFORNIA'S
YOUTH BUT THE STAKEHOLDERS ARE
TELLING US THAT WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITE EFFECT I REGION OVER.
RAMOS OVER NOLTE MR COOPER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'LL BE REAL
QUICK- DJJ RIGHT NOW IS A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED SEX
OFFENDER PROGRAM APPS WON
AWARDS. TO HELP FIX KIDS.
SONORA TAKEN OUT OF DJJ IT'S IN
THE COUNTIES FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT COUNTIES FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. THE DAY HAS
COMMISSION PSYCHOLOGIST THAT
BUILT THE STUFF THEY'RE GOING
TO GET THAT THAT'S A BIG ISSUE
IN SMALLER COUNTIES DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH
THIS. SO HERE WE ARE FAILING
OUR KIDS ARE NOT GONNA GET
REHABILITATED. THIS IS A
FAILURE FOR AB ONE ONLINE THIS
IS NOW THE JUVENILE VERSION OF
THAT. THAT'S REALLY BEEN A BIG
ISSUE DJ'S BEEN THROUGH HELL
AND BACK. FOR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT'S WHY
CHANGE THE BALL THESE PROGRAMS
ON BOARD. SO ARE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON THIS. THANKS COOPER SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL. DESERVE
IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE TELL YOU THE SIZE FORTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS I AM
RESCINDING MY PREVIOUS
REFERRALS OF THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO.
AB FOUR SIXTY FIVE EGGMAN A. B.
A FORTY SIX BURKE AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX GIPSON AB THIRTEEN
OH FOUR WALDRON AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX MCCARTY AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE JONES SAWYER.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE THE FILE ITEM. TWO OH
SEVEN ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
ON THE PREVIOUS ADAM I MEDIA
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE. ON
THE PREVIOUS BUDGET ITEM. WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO OH SEVEN. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
GO EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
ACCOLADE ENFORCEMENT OF
JUDGMENTS. MISTER CHANG EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
IT'S PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
HOMEOWNERS CAN KEEP THEIR HOMES
DURING THIS VERY CHALLENGING
TIME OF COVERT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE MAKES THE
HOMESTEAD EEMPTION GREATER THE
GREATER OF THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE COUNTY WIDE
MEDIAN SALES PRICE OF A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME NOT TO EXCEED SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND MAYBE A TEENY
FIVE ALSO INCLUDES PROVISIONS
TO ADJUST ITS VALUE ANNUALLY
FOR INFLATION. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
THE BTD. FIVE THANK YOU MR
CHANG MR OBERNOLTE ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THIS BILL RAISES THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION WHICH IS
THE AMOUNT OF EQUITY THAT A
DEBTOR CAN PROTECT IN THEIR
PRIMARY RESIDENCE FROM
CREDITORS. THIS MIGHT BE A GOOD
POLICY I REALLY CAN'T TELL YOU
THAT BECAUSE- THIS BILL WAS
FIRST PUT IN PRINT. ON FRIDAY
EVENING THERE'S A REASON WHY
WE'RE HEARING IT NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME AT TEN THIRTY PM THE
DAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO ADJOURN
AT MIDNIGHT COLLEAGUES WE'VE
BEEN DEBATING CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF LEGISLATION FOR SIX
MONTHS AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THIS BILL IS EVER SEEING
THE LIGHT OF DAY WAS HEARD IN
COMMITTEE FOR THE FIRST TIME
YESTERDAY. I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
A HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION COULD BE
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHETHER OR NOT
IT SHOULDBE REYES I COULDN'T
TELL YOU HOW MUCH IT SHOULD BE
REYES BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT HAD
THE TRANSPARENCY TO ALLOW THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS PROCESS TO
WEIGH IN AND TELL US WHAT THEY
THINK. AND EDUCATE US ABOUT THE
WEATHER NOT THIS IS A PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE ABOUT IT. THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE'RE SHOWING
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA HERE
SHOULD BE TRULY ALARMING TO
EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER. BUT
THERE IS A FURTHER LEGAL
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL THIS
BILL IS LABELED AS A BUDGET
BILL THE REASON IT IS SO
LABELED IS SO THAT IT CAN TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT A
TWO THIRDS VOTE OF THIS BODY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE BUDGET.
NORMALLY BUDGET TRAILER BILLS
ARE MANY PAGES LONG THEY
CONTAIN MANY APPROPRIATIONS
THIS BILL IS TWO SENTENCES AND
CONTAINS ZERO APPROPRIATIONS. I
FEEL THAT THIS IS ALMOST
CERTAINLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
WILL BE CHALLENGED. IN THE PAST
WHEN BUDGET ARE LABELING A
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS HAS BEEN
CHALLENGED. OF WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S BEEN RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
POINT AT LEAST A TOKEN
APPROPRIATION IN THAT BUDGET
BILL. AS PROOF THAT IT WAS
INDEED RELATED TO THE BUDGET
AND THE COURTS HAVE RULED IN
OUR FAVOR THEY'VE SAID AT LEAST
IF THERE'S AN APPROPRIATION.
THAT MAYBE THE LABEL OF A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL IS
APPROPRIATE BUT THERE IS NO
APPROPRIATION IN THIS BILL. THE
AFFECTED PARTIES ARE GOING TO
TAKE US TO COURT AND WE'RE
GONNA FIND OUT FORSURE WHETHER
OR NOT IT WAS APPROPRIATE LABEL
BUT I'M ALMOST POSITIVE IT'S
GOING TO BE FOUND TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. SO COLLEAGUES
THIS MIGHT BE A GOOD POLICY BUT
I URGE YOU TO ABSTAIN ON THIS
BECAUSE IT IS NOT GOOD PROCESS
IT IS NOT TRANSPARENT. AND IT'S
NOTACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ELECTED US. THANK YOU MR OF
ANNOUNCING SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. I'M
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO GO. OFF
ALL MEMBERS ARE OF CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
TWO NO SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS.
R. CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
THE TOP OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM TO ONE.
A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
MAIENSCHEIN. OPERATE ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER REMAIN SHINING ACCOLADE
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE AND
SERVICE PLANS MR MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
RESERVATIONS APPLAUSE IS
WARRANTED. C. NOTIFICATION OF A-
OR CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE CEREMONY. WELL. THE
CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE. AS FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT IN FILE ITEM TO
A. B.
EIGHT TWENTY SIX. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY I'M
FILE ITEM TO A TO. FILE IN TWO
OR THREE IS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. CORPORATE SOCIAL
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY THE
SUMMER PETRIE-NORRIS AN
ACCOLADE AMERICA. MS PATRON
ARCHER RECOMMENDS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER NUMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THIS BILL RATIONALIZES
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR LABORATORY SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THEY WAS PETRIE-NORRIS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL. OUR TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE RESULT.
CLARK WILL CLOSER ALL. TELEVOTE
HIGH SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
YEAH THIS IS BACK IN FILE. THIS
ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO OR
TWO AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO AND OTHERS TACKLING
THE PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES IN
THE CLEARLY YEARS EITHER OF
SIGNIFICANTLY. HEY I'M A
SANTIAGO. MR SANTIAGO YOU MAY
OPEN I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE MUCH IS
MUCH NEEDED FOOD ASSISTANCE FOR
ANY INDIVIDUAL AT THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER PERSON OR SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER COUPLE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THEY
WERE SANT'AGATA. THOSE TOO FAST
FOR ME. SENIOR DISCUSSION OF A
CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARABLE. AND SEEING. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARABLE. EIGHT THIRTY
ONE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON
THE URGENCY. CLERK WILL CLOSE A
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY SIX
AS FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO THE
ORIGINAL CONCURRENCE FILE THIS
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE. MR GRAYSON
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL A THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
AN ACCOLADE HOUSING IN THE
CLEARING THE YEARS EITHER UP
SIGNIFICANTLY. MR REYES. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT WILL ENSURE THAT
QUALIFYING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS CAN BE EFFECTIVELY
MOVE FORWARD THIS BILL IS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANKS GRAYSON
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS VOTE A DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES. FIFTY FOUR. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE HIS
TWO. KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
BACK IN FILE ORDER ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. THIS IS.
FILE ITEM TWO OH FOUR AB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT. EGGMAN I'M
LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR. CORKERY
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS
NOT PLAYED A FLOOD MANAGEMENT
MISTER CALDERON YOUR- MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT VOTING
IN CONCURRENCE SENTIMENTS. SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CORPORAL. SARVER HOME VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARABELLA. GOOD CLERK WILL. WELL
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SIXTY SIX.
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO OH FIVE A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE I MISS GONZALEZ
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE BY SIMPLY MOVING
AND SALAS ANOTHER SNACK LEAD TO
EMPLOYMENT THIS GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE CAN
KERN THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MS CONVULSING NOTIFICATION
ABATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS THERE A VOTE ON MEMBERS
OTHERS ARABLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
RESERVED ABOUT.
WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED UP AS FIFTY KNOWS TEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO AWAIT AB
FIVE. I'M SORRY THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO OF SIX. FILE IN TWO OH
SIX A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR
LIMóN CORPORATE ASSEMBLY GO
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR BY
SUBLIMINALLY MOMENT ACTUALLY
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THIS
ALLOWED THAK YOU AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR IS BACK WITH
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE
RELATED TO FINANCIAL
PROTECTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. RAMOS AMONG
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK
WELL OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN SEVEN
MEMBERS ARE TO CURTAIN. WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM TWO OF
SEVEN. THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO OH
EIGHT. AB. FIVE FORTY FIVE.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW ANOTHER SNACK LADY CAMPUS
MISTER LOWE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. SEE NO DISCUSSION.
CORPORAL DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
A RESERVE A. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS A RETAIN. ON FILE ITEMS.
TWO TEN. THROUGH. TWO SIXTEEN.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM TO TWELVE. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
HOUSE CONCURRENT FILE. THIS IS.
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB TWENTY TO
SEVENTY THREE BY MR BELOW.
OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSUMING
YOU'RE BLOOMING OTHERS
SPECULATED HEALING ARTS MISTER
BELOW. THANK YOU ALL OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN REMOVED I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
WHO'S ARE VITAL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT TO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OUT AYE SIXTY NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP MISTER
MCCARTY'S. AB. FIFTEEN THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX MCCARTY CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH SIX BY
A SUMMER MCCARTY MACLAINE TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MR
MCCARTY EMAIL BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER REPRESENT. AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX THE CALIFORNIA
DEADLY FORCE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
THIS BILL IS FIVE YEARS IN THE
MAKING. WE HAVE HAD OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED DEADLY FORCE INCIDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE I FIRST
INTRODUCED THIS BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE ONLY ONE
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION WHICH
REALLY WASN'T THAT INDEPENDENT.
IT'S CERTAINLY TIME FOR A
CHANGE WE HAVE TOO MUCH
DISTRUST WITH POLICE POLICING
THEMSELVES WILL LOCAL DJS
CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS- TOO
MUCH. LACK OF CLARITY AND
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST IN THE
COMMUNITY THIS WOULD HAVE AN
AUTOMATIC PROCESS FOR ALL
DEADLY FORCE INCIDENTS OF AN
UNARMED CIVILIAN INTO AN
INDEPENDENT APPLICATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. I ASK
THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. RESERVE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY NINE DOES
ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
MEMBERS OF THE
REFERENCE THE FILE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
QUACKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY FIVE BY A SIMILAR EGGMAN
ACKERLEY TO MENTAL HEALTH
MISTER CALDERON. SPEC LAST WHEN
I GO. SEE NO DISCUSSION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS
THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ADEBAYO. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE EYES FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE AB EIGHT FORTY SIX
BURKE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY GO
EIGHT FORTY SIX BY SUMMER BURKE
AND ACRYLATE INTO PUBLIC
EMPOYMENT MISS BURKE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX WILL DEVELOP A
PROCESS TO EVALUATE NEW POLICE
OFFICERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS THAT
CAN MAKE THEM UNFIT TO PERFORM
THEIR DUTIES IT WILL ALSO
REQUIRE DEPARTMENTS TO DE
EMPHASIZE THE PARA. MILITARY
ASPECTS OF THE JOB AND
RECRUITMENT MATERIALS INSTEAD
OF HIGHLIGHTING COMMUNITY
INTERACTION AND COLLABORATIVE
PROBLEM SOLVING. MEMBERS
MILITARIZING THE POLICE NOT
JUST ABOUT WEAPONS ABOUT WHO WE
HIRE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT WE CONCUR IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. FAMOUS
FOR MR WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
I'M A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF AB
EIGHT FOUR SIX A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT WILL FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE HOW WE RECRUIT AND HIRE
PIECE OFFICES AT OFFICERS IN
OUR STATE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS IRWIN C. NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ESERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON AN
ACCOLADE TO OFFICERS MISTER
GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
HAPPY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. THIS IS
INTRODUCED TO IN RESPONSE THE
GEORGE FROM THE MURDER
EXECUTION GEORGE FLOOR THIS
BILL WILL BAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
STATEWIDE FROM USING CHOKEHOLDS
AND KARATEKA ORDER RESTRAINS.
THIS ONE TO MAKE MENTION THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT NEUTRAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
TAMES GIVES IN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS. DESIRED
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLE TIED UP EYES FIFTY A NOSE
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE MISS WALDRON
CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MARIE WALDRON ACCOLADE TO
PAROLE MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH FOUR CRATES
THE CALIFORNIA MATT REENTRY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS WITH TIME
CREDITS OFF THEIR PAROLE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT NOT ONLY
DOES IT SAVE LIVES IT SAVES
MONEY FOR EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED
IN THOSE. FOUR DOLLARS AND A
IT'S A VERY PERSONAL BILL TO ME
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE HIRED
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
IN MY BUSINESS FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND EVERYONE OF THEM
RESET DEVISE DUE TO OPIATES SO
THIS BILL CAN REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
AYE ORIGIN AYE. THANK THIS
WALDRON SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE OUR CLUB THE ROLE. THESE
ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER JONES SAWYER
ACCOLADE TO HARASSMENT MISTER
JOHN SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
MISUSE OF THE NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY SYSTEM AS A TOOL FOR
ASMAN AND FALSE POLICE REPORTS
AIMED AT HARASSING A PERSON
BASED ON THEIR SKIN COLOR OR
OTHER PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTICS. IT'S DANGEROUS
IT'S ABUSIVE IT'S WRONG AND IT
HAS TO STOP I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR LIFE BOOK. THEY WERE
SHOWS WHERE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. IS OUR VOTE ALL OVER
CENTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRABLE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS OR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS FROM THE ORIGINAL
CONCURRENCE FILE WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP MR BIGELOW'S. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX
CORKERY. SOME LEGAL TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX BY SUMMER
BIGELOW ANOTHER'S MEDICALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT MR BIGELOW
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION OF AN AYE
VOTE AND I HOPE THAT NO ONE
FAILED TO NOTICE THE PETUNIAS.
LATER TODAY. THANK YOU ISRAEL
SEE NOTE DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS URBAN. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLLTIDE DOT
I. SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPENDTHE RULES TO
ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE UP AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE CURRENT
SENTIMENTS ALL COME ON HE-
MISTER FLORA. WHILE HOLDING
THEM SINCE IT HAS ROLL CALL
VOTE. MR FLOOR AS WITHHOLDING
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MR BONTA
SECONDS. EVER SINCE THE
PROCEDURAL VOTE CORPORAL.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MR FLOORS ASKING FOR NO
VOTE THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLE HIGHS FIFTY TWO
DOES FOURTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE TANK. CORPORATE SOME
AGO EIGHT FORTY ONE BY SOME
REMITTING ACCOLADE TO ENERGY
MISTER KING THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FORTY ONE WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO ALLOW
OUR SCHOOLS TO REPLACE
INEFFICIENT H. FAX SYSTEMS A
WATER FIXTURES AS WELL EXPEDITE
THE INSTALLATION OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGERS A. B. FORTY
ONE WILL APPROVE AIR AND WATER
QUALITY OF SCHOOLS PRODUCE
SCHOOL UTILITY BILLS. BACK TO
WORK I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER TANKS SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM CORPORAL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESERVE A LITTLE MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. HARTWALL THE
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ON THE ORIGINAL
CONCURRENCE FILE. FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE AB EIGHT NINE
THIRTEEN. CORPORATION FOR SOME
AGO NINE THIRTEEN BY SUMMER
CALDERON ACCOLADE TO
ELECTRICITY MISTER CALDERON
EXPECT LAST WHEN I VOTE. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. THIRTY ONE.
WHERE. LOOKING FOR MR SANTIAGO.
HOWEVER THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE SANTIAGO CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE BY SOME WE WERE SANTIAGO
AN ACCOLADE FIREARMS MR
SANTIAGO THIS BILL BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE RESPECTFULLY OFTEN
EITHER. MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL
IT'S NOT A EVERY DAY- HIM AND I
CAN ACTUALLY AGREE ON A FIREARM
STILL. ASK YES FOR YOUR LIVE UP.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
CORPORAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. YEAH ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRABLE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCORD IN.
ON A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO OH NINE. AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
TO EMPLOYMENT DECLARE IN THE UC
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT IN THE
LEAGUE. THIS GONZALEZ THANK YOU
THIS IS ALL THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS TO AB FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A. DAVIS GONZALEZ C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. LOCAL OF THE
ROLE. WHO'S OUR TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. FIVE
YOU CAN DOLLARS. THE CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. MEDIA TRANSMITTAL
TO THE GOVERNOR.
SO THIS IS.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE MEMBERS.
THIS LOOKS LIKE THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE ON THE SENATE
EIGHTY THREE SB NINE. OPERATE
SENATE BILL NINE BY SENATOR
ALSO ANOTHER CYNICAL AND A
SURPLUS PROPERTY MS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS PROUD TO PRESENT SB
NINE WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR THE
SALE OF CALTRANS STATE ROUTE
SEVEN TEN PROPERTIES IN LOS
ANGELES. TO QUALIFY FOR HOUSING
RELATED ENTITY THAT THE
AGENCY'S ORIGINAL PERCHING
PURCHASING PRICE IN EXCHANGE
FOR A GUARANTEE OF PROVIDING
FIFTY FIVE YEARS OF AFFORDABLE
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I WILL.
THANK YOU REST ROOM. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION. OF IT ON THE ITEM
BURKE LIBERAL. RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SIX. SB FOUR NINE
CORKERY SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
NINE BY CEDAR ATKINS ACRYLATE
THE STATE HIGHWAYS MISTER
GLORIA MEMBERS ARE SEXUALLY ASK
YOUR HAVE A- C. NOTIFICATION OF
A CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS THERE TO VOTE.
WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOON JACKSON AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT THIS GONZALEZ YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LONG AWAITED BILL I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL LOOKING FORWARD
TO VOTING FOR THIS IT WAS PART
OF THE BUDGET DEAL WE NEED TO
GET THIS OFF THE FLOOR BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WORKERS ALL PAEAN
TO FAMILY LEAVE THEY PAY IN AND
YET IF YOU WORK FOR A SMALL
EMPLOYER. YOU CANNOT TAKE THAT
WITHOUT HAVING THE PROTECTION
OF COMING BACK TO YOUR JOB THIS
WILL ADD YOU JOB PROTECTION
IT'S UNPAID BY THE EMPLOYER THE
EMPLOYER DOES NOT PAY A SINGLE
CENT THEY HOLD YOUR JOB
EMPLOYERS UNDER FIVE ARE
EXEMPTED AND WE ALREADY VOTED
TONIGHT ON HISTORIC LANGUAGE
THEY GAVE MEDIATION RIGHTS TO
EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE UNDER TWENTY
EMPLOYEES THAT MEANS THEY
CANNOT BE SUED IN LEICESTER'S
MEDIATION THAT GOES TOWARD
FIRST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NAY VOTE. I THINK IT WAS HIS
ULTIMATE LIMóN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS JUST WANNA
TELL EVERYONE THAT THIS IS A
BIG WIN FOR WOMEN AND FOR MEN
IN CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU. MISTER KILEY ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THE BILLS THAT I TEND
TO BE MOST VOCALLY AGAINST HERE
ARE THOSE WHERE THERE'S NO REAL
LEGITIMATE POLICY ARGUMENT EVEN
IN THEIR FAVORS JUST INTEREST
GROUP POLITICS THROUGH AND
THROUGH BUT I DON'T THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS. WITHOUT
QUESTION FAMILY LEAVE IS A
SOCIAL GOOD THAT IS SO VITAL TO
THE HEALTH OF FAMILIES AND TO
MORALE IN THE WORKPLACE. IT'S
AVAILABILITY IS THE MARK OF A
MATURE ECONOMY AND A HUMANE
SOCIETY AND ITS EXPANSION
CONSTITUTES GENUINE PROGRESS.
THE DIFFICULTY LIES IN HOW THE
GOAL IS PURSUED WHEN IT'S
REQUIRED VERSES WHEN IT'S
DRAWN HOW BURDENS GET
DISTRIBUTED. IN THIS BILLGOES
ABOUT THE GOAL IN ALL OF THE
WRONG WAYS. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
OPPOSED TO IT TODAY IN FACT I
HAVE TO MAIN OBJECTION THE
FIRST IS THAT AS OFTEN HAPPENS
IN THIS BUILDING. A GENUINE
SOCIAL GOOD GETS TRANSFORMED
INTO A FEEDING GROUND FOR
INTEREST GROUPS AND SO THE DEAD
GIVEAWAY HERE IS THE INCLUSION
OF THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
WHICH WON'T DO MUCH TO SECURE
FAMILY FOR ANYONE WILL DO A LOT
TO ENRICH A CERTAIN SUBSET. OF
THE STATE BAR. BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO LINGER ON THAT POINT.
THE POINT I REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. IS THAT THIS BILL
WILL SOUND A DEATH KNELL. FOR
EVEN MORE SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I HAVE HERE
PAGES OF TESTIMONIALS FROM
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS. WHO ARE
ATTESTING TO THAT. AND I'LL
GIVE YOU JUST A SELECTION.
ROSARIO WHO OWNS A TALK URREA
SAYS DON'T LEGISLATORS
UNDERSTAND WHAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW WE ARE BARELY KEEPING
AFLOAT. JOHN WHO DOES PRIVATE
MUSIC INSTRUCTION SAYS OUR
SCHOOL HAS LOST 45% OF ITS
BUSINESS AND REVENUE. WE ARE
HOLDING ON BY SHREDS SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WOULD
SHUT US DOWN. KEVIN WHO RUNS A
SMALL INDEPENDENT URGENT CARE
SAYS I UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
BILL IS SUPPOSED TO DO MY
LARGER COMPANIES CAN AFFORD TO
DO THIS. BUT IN THE TINY
BUSINESS LIKE OURS THIS BILL
WOULD LITERALLY DRIVE US TO
BANKRUPTCY. JIMINEZ WHO ON A
CANDY STORE SAY IT'S HARD
ENOUGH IT'S HARD ENOUGH AS IT
IS TRYING TO KEEP THE BUSINESS
AFLOAT WITH ALL THE CODE
RESTRICTIONS. I HAVE FOURTEEN
EMPLOYEES SO IT SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE DEFINITELY WOULD
IMPACT US. AT THE WORST
POSSIBLE TIME. PHILIP WHO OWNS
A BAKERY SAYS PROVIDING TWELVE
WEEKS OF LEAVE. WOULD CRIPPLE
US OF MANY OF OUR EMPLOYEES
TOOK THIS AT ONCE. MIKE WHO
DOES PARTY RENTAL SAID IF THE
MINIMUM WAGE DOESN'T PUT US OUT
OF BUSINESS AND SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WELL. BOUNCE
AROUND THE NAIL SALON SAYS
TWELVE LEAST WEEKS OFF WOULD
DEFINITELY PUT A DEATH
SENTENCE. THE SMALL BUSINESS.
JOHN WHO I THE MANAGEMENT GROUP
SAYS PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB
THIRTY THREE. IT'S JUST TOO
MUCH FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE IN THESE UNCERTAIN TIMES.
JOEY WHO'S IN PERSONAL KERR
SAYS BY PASSING THIS BILL SB
THIRTY THREE. WOULD BE THE
FINAL NAIL IN THE COFFIN FOR ME
IN MY BUSINESS THAT I STARTED
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. MORE
THAN TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO. THE
NEEDS TO DOES BALLOON
DELIVERIES SAYS DON'T MAKE OUR
LIVES MORE DIFFICULT WITH LAWS
THAT HURT THE ECONOMY. AND THE
EMPLOYEES WHO END UP WITH NO
JOBS. RICK DOES FOR COVERING
SAYS WE ARE SIMPLY IN NO
POSITION TO TAKE ON ANY FURTHER
BURDEN. WE ARE ALL AFFECTED BY
THE PANDEMIC I HAVE WORKED AT
THIS LOCATION FOR FORTY SEVEN
YEARS IT HAS BEEN MY FAMILY'S
BUSINESS FOR NEARLY SIXTY YEARS
THE COMPANY HAS BEEN IN
CONTINUOUS OPERATION FOR A
HUNDRED AND FORTY YEARS. TODAY
WE ARE ON THE CUSP OF A
PERMANENT SHUT DOWN. JASON
WHO'S IN MANUFACTURING SAYS I
OWN A SEVENTY YEAR OLD
MANUFACTURING COMPANY WITH
FORTY FIVE EMPLOYEES AND I'VE
WORKED HARD TO KEEP JOBS IN THE
US AND COMPETE ON THE GLOBAL
STAGE BUT I'M NOT ABLE TO RAISE
PRICES FAST ENOUGH. TO KEEP UP
WITH BILLS LIKE THIS. JOSEPH
WHO RUN THE CONCRETE CONFERENCE
CENTER SAYS IF ANY OF MY
EMPLOYEES WERE PERMITTED TO
TAKE A TWELVE WEEK LEAVE US
PROPOSED BY SB THIRTY THREE.
OUR BUSINESS TO BE TOTALLY SHUT
DOWN AND WE WOULD BE OUT OF
BUSINESS. SHANNON WITH THE YMCA
SAYS ALTHOUGH WE ARE COMPLETELY
WILLING TO SUPPORT OUR STAFF
THE ABILITY TO DO SO IS NOT
FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE FOR ANY
LENGTH OF TIME. MARK IN
WAREHOUSING SAYS SERVICE WILL
SUFFER CUSTOMERS WILL LEAVE AND
BUSINESSES WILL CLOSE. MARK
WHO'S IN PHOTOGRAPHY SAYS
DURING NORMAL TIMES A FOURTEEN
WEEK LEAVE WOULD BE AN UNDUE
BURDEN NOW THIS MAY BE THE
FINAL NAIL IN OUR COFFIN
NOTICED THAT PHRASE AGAIN. THE
FINAL NAIL IN OUR COFFIN. JUDY
WHO RUNS IN A- CORE AS I
ALREADY LOST MORE THAN HALF OF
MY MONTHLY INCOME DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. I HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING
MYSELF BUT THIS WON'T LAST TOO
LONG AND SB THIRTY THREE
BECOMES LAW. AND I MUST BE
MANDATORY TWELVE WEEKS WE FOR
EACH EMPLOYEE I WILL HAVE TO
SHUT THE DOOR. AND GO OUT OF
BUSINESS THIRTY SECONDS. I HAVE
MANY MORE PAGES OF THESE. THAT
I HAVE MINUTES TO SPEAK. THESE
ARE VOICES CRYING OUT FOR MY
COMMUNITY CRYING OUT FROM YOUR
COMMUNITIES. PLEADING NOT THIS
NOT NOW I JOIN THOSE VOICES IN
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO. I
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY
CLOSE I'M GONNA BE HONEST THIS
IS A SIMPLE QUESTION DO YOU
THINK A WOMAN WHO JUST HAD A
BABY WHO WORKS FOR AN EMPLOYER
WITH NINETEEN PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SPEND TIME WITH THAT
CHILD AND NOT RISK LOSING HER
JOB. WITH NOT A CENT PAID BY
THAT EMPLOYER NOT A CENT SHE
HAS ALREADY PAID INTO THE
SYSTEM IT IS HER MONEY SHE'S
GETTING BACK THE QUESTION IS DO
YOU ACTUALLY BELIEVE A WOMAN
HAS A RIGHT TO STAY HOME WITH
HER CHILD AND NOT LOSE HER JOB
THAT'S WHAT THIS VOTE IS ABOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT. THE
CLUB THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS GONZALEZ MOVES A CALL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR EMOTIONS I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
OTHERS TO TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
CURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS AB
SIXTEEN IF I RAISE AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE CARILLO AB SIX NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR DALY
EIGHTY FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA A. B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. AND A GARCIA A. B.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE THUS FAR
HER BATH IN AB TEN SIXTY SIX
GONZALEZ. MR FOR. WITHHOLDING
ELSE CONSENT ASTRAL CALL VOTE.
MR FOR WITH HOLES CALDERON
MOVES AND MR TANG SECONDS. ON
THE REAL SUSPENSION THIS
PROCEDURAL VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- CONFERENCE ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE TO MR FLORA NO. THIS
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AYE VOTE.
MISTER FLORA NO. SIX FORTY ONE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL EYES
FIFTY THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE THIS IS A B.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE RAMOS. CORKERY
SOME PEOPLE SIX EIGHTY FIVE BY
SUMMER REYES AND ACCOLADES
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY METRICS.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS A COMMON
SENSE. MEASURE AIMED AT
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
LOWERING EXPOSURE TO COVERED
NINETEEN SPECIFICALLY EXPOSURES
IN THE WORKPLACE. CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO LAW THAT MANDATED
EMPLOYERS NOTIFY WORKERS A
POTENTIAL COVERT NINETEEN
EXPOSURE IN THE WORKPLACE IT IS
CLEAR THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND TO ENSURE
OUR EMPLOYEES AND MEMBERS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL ARE SAFE AND
PROTECTED. UNFORTUNATELY NOT
ALL EMPLOYEES IN THIS STATE
HAVE THAT LUXURY OR COMBINATION.
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING THE
REPORTING NOTIFY NOTIFICATION
DEPLOYS IF THREE WORKERS TEST
POSITIVE WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS.
WHICH IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
DEFINITION OF AN OUTBREAK THE
EMPLOYER MUST REPORT TO LOCAL
CLUB PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
I MET A NEGOTIATED IN GOOD
FAITH WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
AND I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THIS CONVERSATION IN
JANUARY SHOULD THE NEED ARISE.
ON BEHALF OF OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
SUFFERED GREATLY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MS REYES SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORPORAL. CONCERNED
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THEM ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. YEAH. BURKE WELL CLOSER ALL
TELL YOU THE- HIGHS FORTY FIVE
THOSE TWELVE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE MISS CARILLO
PERFORMING. SOME AGO FIFTEEN
TWELVE BY SOME AMERICA RIO. THE
MYSTERY OF. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY TO THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE WE CAN
BETTER PROTECT OUR WORKERS AND
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY BY PROVIDING
GUIDELINES AND GUIDANCE TO
EMPLOYERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CARRILLO C. NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CARCLUB THE ROLE. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERSOTHERS ADEBAYO KIRK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TYLER BUT I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN THIS IS
BUT I REFERENCE OF FIVE B.
SIXTY NINE CORPORATION. SOME
PEOPLE SIXTY NINE BY SIMPLY
REVERTING AN ACCOLADE LIKELY TO
HOUSING MAKING APPROPRIATION OF
FOUR. MISTER TECH THANK YOU AB
SIXTY NINE HELPS FILL THE GAP
IN THE MARKET FOR PROVIDING
HOMEOWNERS WITH BRIDGE LOANS TO
FINANCE EIGHTY YOU CONSTRUCTION
UNTIL THE QUALIFY FOR IS
EXTINCT LOAN PROGRAMS.
RESPECTFULLY AFRICAN CURRENCY
SENTIMENT. NAME IS TANK SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CARPOOL. IS THERE A VOTE ON
MEMBERS MEMBERS ARE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL.
CLOSE ROTH TALLIED. TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY NINE KNOWS
EIGHT SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE AB FOUR THIRTY FOUR OR
FOR REED SOME PEOPLE FOR THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME OF THE DAILY AN
ACCOLADE TO AN ACCOLADE HOUSING
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOR MR
DALY YOU MAY OPEN. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER DALY. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HARTWELL
OF THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO GO.
YEAH ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TURNING WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. THIS IS A BE. FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE. THE CORPORATION.
SOME OF A FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE BY
SOME MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AN
ACCOLADE IN LAND USE MINI
GARCIA THANK YOU AB FIFTY ONE
EXPENSE HOUSING ENTITLEMENTS
AND PERMITS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. AMOS CNC NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS WORK CURTAIN.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE A B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN CORKERY
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SOME WOMEN WANT TO GO SEE AN
ACCOLADE PUBLIC RESOURCES MR
GARCIA. HITTING YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN CALLING THIS WOULD
BE MY FIRST BILL PRESENTATION
OF THE EVENING THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME YOUR INTELLIGENCE
HERE. A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
IS A BILL THAT WOULD ESTABLISH
A WORKING GROUP WITH THE C. E.
C. TO LOOK AT THE FINANCIAL
OPPORTUNITIES OF LITHIUM
EXTRACTION AT THE SALTON SEA
REGION AND ALSO ALIGNED WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS. FOR PURPOSES OF MEETING
ARE 1100% RENEWABLE ENERGY
EFFORTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER
CMC NOTICE KASHER DEBATE
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. RESERVA.
BURKE WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MS GONZALEZ THIS IS AB TEN
SIXTY SIX. THE REFERENCE THE
FILE AB TEN SIXTY SIX
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY SIX BY SUMMER GONZALEZ AN
ACCOLADE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
THIS GONZALEZ. MISTER SPEAKER
OF. YEAH RIGHT MISTER SPEAKER
I'M THINKING THIS IS A BILL IT
IS A COMMON SENSE BILL COMING
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC ONE IT IS
AT TEN AB TEN SIXTY SIX I KNOW
IT'S NOT A FAIR YOU PROBABLY
HAVEN'T SEEN IT IT DOES TWO
THINGS IT ALLOWS FOR A
STREAMLINED AT PROVISION FOR
EDIE DEED TO BE ABLE TO PROCESS
CLAIMS EVEN IF THEY HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM THE EMPLOYER WHAT
HAPPENS NOW IS THE EMPLOYER
DOESN'T RESPOND EDT IS KIND OF
STUCK WE HEAR FROM THOSE
EMPLOYEES AND WE HAVE TO WAIT
WAIT WAIT AFTER TEN DAYS THE
SLOUGHS EDT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THOSE CLAIMS IF THE
EMPLOYER DOESN'T RESPOND. IT
ALSO ALLOWS THE AG TO GO AFTER
BIG CORPORATIONS THAT DID NOT
PAY INTO UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IN
TWO YEARS YOUR MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO ASK YOU
WHY WE'RE INCREASE AND THERE
YOU AYE PAYMENT AND IT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S BIG
CORPORATIONS WHO DID NOT PAY
AND WE NEED THE AG TO GO AFTER
THEM. I RESPECT LAST NIGHT
ABOUT. THANK YOU MS CONSULTS.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF A- CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. DESERVE A.
WELL. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ROLE KELLY
THE VOTE. HIGHS FORTY THREE
KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS BACK
ON THE FILE. THERE WAS A PAIR
TO LIVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
FIFTY FOUR S. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE JEFF CORPORAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHO WISH TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
MICHIGAN'S
ALSO PLACES THE CALL. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING BACK TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO. SB.
SEVEN SEVEN SIX. THE CORPORATE
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
BY CIVIL SKINNER AN ACCOLADE TO
PEACE OFFICERS THIS KAMLAGER.
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX. IF THE
NECESSARY FOLLOW UP TO SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE IT ALIGNS
CALIFORNIA MORE CLOSELY WITH
OTHER STATES BY EXPANDING THE
CATEGORY OF DISCLOSURE. TO
RECORDS OF OFFICERS WHO ENGAGE
IN UNLAWFUL ARRESTS OR SEARCHES
ON REASONABLE OR EXCESSIVE
FORCE IT IS A MODEST APPROACH
TO BRIBING POLICE RECORDS
SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR IN RESPONSE TO POLICE
CHIEFS PORAC AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS. INCLUDING
REVERTING RECORDS ON DISHONESTY
BACK TO CURRENT LAW SUSTAIN
CONSISTENT WITH RECORDS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND BUYERS
NARROWING THE FOREST FROM.
CHANGING RECORD RETENTION AND
DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION. UNTIL
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALL
MAJOR LAW ENFORCEMENT UNIONS
HAVE REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS KAMLAGER MR LACKEY
ARE RECOGNIZED. THE REASON WHY
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. IS BECAUSE
IT INCLUDES ALLEGATIONS THAT
WERE PROVEN TO BE UNTRUE. SOLA
IF YOU FEEL THAT'S OKAY-
WITHOUT ANY RECOURSE YOU THINK
DIFFERENTLY THAN ME I THINK
THAT'S AN UNFAIR PRACTICE THAT
THAT'S JUST NOT. THEN
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS SO I
OPPOSE THIS. LACKEY'S SEEM NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE MS
KAMLAGER YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH THANK YOU I WANT TO SAY
THAT THE INITIAL TAX FOR THE
BILL ALLOWED FOR ON THE SAME
FINDINGS- BUT THAT HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM BASED ON
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. LOW. CARPAL OF THE
ROLE. CREWS ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE T IS A TO THE-
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESERT OF.
BURKE WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
OF ICE FORTY KNOWS THIRTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
GOOD THIS
IS FILE ITEM. EIGHTY FIVE. SB.
TEN TWENTY FOUR. MISTER
O'DONNELL CORPORATION SENATE
BILL TEN TWENTY FOUR BY CENTERS
OWNED AND OPERATED VEHICLES
MYSTERON THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THE PURPOSE OFSB
TEN TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER JONES
BY CENTER JONES IS JUST SICK
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF OFF ROAD HIGHWAY
VEHICLES THAT CURRENTLY FALL
UNDER CARDS A RED STICKER
PROGRAM. BY LIMITING THE NUMBER
OF THE USE OF THESE VEHICLES TO
COMPETITION RIDERS ONLY- TO
KEEP IT SIMPLE IT WILL I CUT
DOWN THE NUMBER OF OFF ROAD
VEHICLES THAT POLLUTE THE AIR
WE HAVE WORK WITH KERR BY US
FOR AN IPHONE. MS BARRICADE
HANYU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WE HAVE GIVEN THESE
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS DECADES.
TO REDUCE THE EMISSIONS ON THIS
VEHICLE AND THEY HAVE FAILED TO
DO SO. SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
FIGHT TO MAKE THEM PAY FEES
WOULD GO INTO THE OPERA VEHICLE
FIND. WHICH THEN ALLOWS THEM TO
CONTINUE TO POLLUTE THIS BILL
IS NOT GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
IT'S TIME THEY GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER AND I REQUEST TO ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
BURKE HEY HAVE MISTER FLORA. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
THE MANUFACTURERS THE BILL
DESCRIBING OURS IS CENTRAL TO
OUR WORKFORCE EXPANSION IN OUR
CULTURE REGION. MANY TIMES
FAMILY FARMS HAVE OLDER FOUR
WHEELERS MOTORCYCLES- GOLF
CARTS THAT MAY HAVE ISSUES BUT
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY NEW
ONES SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO EXPAND THIS IS A
GOOD BILL AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE SUPPORT. THERE WAS
FLORA MISTER MATHIS YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM A RURAL
DISTRICT IN AN AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICT I STAND IN SUPPORT I
WANT TO THANK OUR CENTER JONES
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD ALL
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THAT HE'S
PUT INTO THIS BILL. YOU KNOW
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE WOULD WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE STILL ALLOWING THE
USE OF OFF ROAD VEHICLES AND
STILL MEETING SOME OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS THAT IS A
GOOD THING THAT IS A GOOD STEP
FORWARD. ON AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE GREAT SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WHO REPRESENTS ANOTHER
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT YOU KNOW
THIS ALSO IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE OUR FAMILY FARMERS
DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
ABILITY TO GO BUY ANOTHER FOUR
WHEELER OR ANOTHER GATOR OR
ANOTHER. OFF ROAD VEHICLE. AND
THIS GIVES US THAT OPPORTUNITY
THAT ABILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE INDUSTRIES THAT USE THESE
VEHICLES ARE ABLE TO STAY
VIABLE AND IT ALSO ALLOWS THE
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES THAT WE
ALL ENJOY SO MEMBERS WITH THAT
I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. C. NOTATIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MR DONNELLY BECAUSE
WE WISH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL IS A
PRODUCT A LONG COAT
COLLABORATIONS WITH A VARIETY
OF STAKEHOLDERS. INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON MR
JONES CENTER JONES BILL THANK
YOU. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE- WE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. MISTER
O'DONNELL MOVES A CALL.
RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM. FIFTY TWO. THIS IS
FILE ITEM. FIFTY TWO. SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY. SB ELEVEN TWENTY
CLERK WILL READ SENATE ELEVEN
TWENTY BY CENTER ATKINS
ANOTHER'S MEDICALLY THE LAND
USE MR RIVAS HE MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER PROUD RESENT
US SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
BEHALF OF THE SENATE PRO TEM
ATKINS AS WE ALL KNOW THERE'S
NO SILVER BULLET THERE IS NO
EASY SOLUTION TO SOLVE OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS. WE NEED
TO BE HAVING THIS PROBLEM FROM
MULTIPLE ANGLES AND CLEARLY WE
NEED TO BE CREATIVE. WE NEED TO
STAY FOCUSED ON OUR GOAL
HELPING THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
CANNOT AFFORD DECENT HOUSING.
EVERY DAY MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
IN OUR STATE ARE PUSHED INTO
HOMELESSNESS. AS WE ALL KNOW WE
NEED TO DRASTICALLY INCREASE
OUR SUPPLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THIS PROBLEM WILL ONLY CONTINUE
TO GET WORSE IF WE DO NOT.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY.
ALLOWS PROPERTY OWNERS TO BUILD
DUPLEXES GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBDIVIDE THEIR
LAND TO CREATE MORE HOUSING. TO
CREATE MORE HOUSING SO LONG AS
THESE NEW UNITS MEET EXISTING
COMMUNITY STANDARDS. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY BUILT ON OUR
SUCCESSFUL APPROACH TO
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. WHICH
HAS LED TO THE PERMITTING OF
THOUSANDS OF NATURALLY
AFFORDABLE UNITS STATEWIDE.
TURNER CENTER AT BERKELEY I WAS
RECENTLY FOUND THAT IF JUST 5%
OF ELIGIBLE PARCELLS CREATED A
DUPLEX. IT WOULD RESULT IN. SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW HOMES
THAT'S ALMOST A QUARTER OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
GOAL OVER THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS.
ALL WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT THESE UNITS ARE SO ARE
SMALL SCALE UNITS ARE EASY TO
BUILD. UNITS THAT WOULD ALSO
HELP CREATE EQUITY FOR
HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO HELP US
SOLVE THIS HOUSING CRISIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MYSTERY THIS MISTER
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY. SB ELEVEN TWENTY
IS TAKING AWAY LOCAL CONTROL.
FROM OUR CITIES TO BE ABLE TO.
PRESERVE AND PROTECT SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING. I ASKED FOR A NO
VOTE. THERE IS DIVERSITY MISS
FRIEDMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I KNOW IT'S
LATE AND EVERYBODY WANTS US TO
GET THROUGH THIS BUT I FEEL
THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT FOR ME
NOT TO SPEAK ON. OUR THE REASON
THAT THIS BILL HAS BEEN VERY
TOUGH FOR ME IS BECAUSE I HAVE
VOTED FOR I THINK ALL OF THE
HOUSING BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
FRONT OF THIS HOUSE PRETTY MUCH
ALL OF THEM AND VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF WHAT THIS
BILLS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND
BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN USED
AGAINST THIS BILL ARE
INACCURATE AND SOME CASES EVEN
INSULTING HOWEVER. I WILL SAY
VERY QUICKLY THAT I HAVE SOME
MAJOR CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL
HAVING TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT
I'VE ANALYZE THIS BILLAND I'VE
GONE THROUGH IT AND AS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
MORE DEVELOPMENT IN OUR WILD
FIRE AREAS. AND IN AREAS THAT
RIGHT NOW WE ALLOW SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSES BUT AN INFILL
AREAS ARE MOSTLY BUILT OUT
WOULD ALLOW FOR MORE
DEVELOPMENT IN A LOT OF AREAS
IN LOS ANGELES THROUGHOUT THE
HILLS IN LOS ANGELES WHERE WE
HAVE VERY AN ADEQUATE INGRESS
AND EGRESS NO I'M NOT UP HERE
TO CHANGE ANYONE'S MIND ABOUT
THIS. BUT I RESPECT THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL ENOUGH
TO GIVE THE REASONS WHY I CAN'T
SUPPORT IT TODAY MY- BIGGEST
CONCERN HOWEVER HAS TO DO WITH
THE FACT THAT WHILE I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL WILL CERTAINLY
OPEN UP A LOT OF NEEDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RENTERS AND I
BELIEVE THAT TRULY THAT THIS IS
NEEDED TO HAVE MORE HOUSING. IN
A LOT OF OUR SINGLE FAMILY
AREAS I AM VERY NERVOUS ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO BUY A HOME FOR
THEIR FAMILIES ARE NOW HAVING
TO. BID AGAINST SPECULATIVE
DEVELOPERS. GIVEN THE AMOUNT
OF. OF A PROFIT THAT COULD BE
CREATED BY WHAT THIS BILL
ALLOWS. I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS.
SUCH A RADICAL DEPARTURE FROM
WHAT WE HAVE THAT WE SHOULD
PILOT THIS BEFORE WE DO IT
STATEWIDE. I THINK THAT'S
PRUDENT. I'M WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IN AREAS IN OUR WE
AREAS SUCH AS- THEIR HOME
GROUND PROJECT. YOU HAVE SEVEN
THOUSAND UNITS ALREADY ENTITLED
LOTS ALREADY SUBDIVIDED. IN
WHAT IS OUR WILDLIFE INTERFACE
AREA. I'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
AND ASK QUESTIONS AND I BELIEVE
THAT THAT PROJECT IN TURN FROM
SEVEN THOUSAND UNITS. ID TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND UNITS RIGHT NOW
BY RIGHT WITHOUT REVIEW BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL. WE ARE TRYING TO
DEVELOP BUT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
SO IN AREAS THAT ARE NEAR JOBS
IN YOUR TRANSPORTATION. IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT'S CONSIDERED AN
URBAN AREA ON THE MAP. IT'S
ALMOST ALL OF L. A. COUNTY.
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S NEAR JOBS
NEAR AMENITIES OR WHETHER IT'S
IN A WILD PRICE INTERFACE AREA.
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT SPRAWL I'M
NERVOUS ABOUT WHAT THIS DOES.
TO PEOPLE TRYING TO GET INTO
THE MARKET AND FOR THAT I
RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO. TO NOT BE
ABLE TO. DAY THANK YOU. THANKS
FRIEDMAN MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YEAH COLLEAGUES
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL I WAS
ACTUALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF
FEEDING MY DAUGHTER WAS BILL
CAME UP AND I RAN DOWN ON THE
FLOOR TODAY BECAUSE I STRONGLY
BELIEVE WE NEED TO PASS THIS
BILL. WE ARE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOME SHOVEL READY TO BE
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE. AND
ONLY AGREES THAT WE NEED IT WE
NEED WE ACTUALLY NEED TO PASS
THIS BILL AND I KNOW IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR SOME OF YOU THESE
WERE. SOME OF YOU. BUT IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. AND I JUST
COME DOWN HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- TO MY
COLLEAGUES. IT'S THE SIMPLEST
WAY WE CAN HAVE. DENSITY BUT
STILL HERE SAID. CHARACTER SO
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE. FILL AND
I MEAN TO GO FINISH READING MY
DAUGHTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MAKES. MISS KAY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I COULD
GO ON BUT I'M NOT BECAUSE THE
HOUR IS LATE BUT- THE THINK
CLEAR ACTUALLY COMPROMISES THE
CHARACTER. AND IT'S CERTAINLY.
LIMITS LOCAL CONTROL I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING YES SUPPLY IS
IMPORTANT YES DENSITY WORKS IN
MANY AREAS. BUT WE CONTINUED TO
PUT FORWARD THESE BILLS AND WE
SAY THAT WE NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND WE'RE LIVING IN A
STATE WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN DUPED INTO THINKING. THAT
AFFORDABLE IS PAYING TWELVE
DOLLARS FOR A CUP OF COFFEE AND
A DOUGHNUT. THAT IS NOT
AFFORDABLE THE STATE IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY
UNAFFORDABLE. AND SO RATHER
THAN. CREATED CREATING A
DYNAMIC WHERE YOU SET UP.
ACTUALLY AN INVASION INTO SMALL
COMMUNITIES BY DEVELOPERS AND
SPECULATORS WE SHOULD ACTUALLY
BE HAVING SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW TO DEVELOP NON MARKET
PRICE GUARANTEED HOUSING
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
UNITS THAT ARE TEACHERS OUR
STUDENTS ARE GROCERY WORKERS
ARE CASHIERS ARE WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES. AND CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE NOT. THIS BILL WITH
QUITE FRANKLY THE KIND OF THE
FOLKS THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE THE LAND AND CREATE
THESE DUPLEXES AND QUAD. ARE
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT GOING TO
BE MULTI NATIONAL OR
INTERNATIONAL INVESTORS.
CHANGING. THE CHARACTER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THIS ISN'T SAYING
LET'S HAVE ALL BUILDERS LET
PEOPLE WHO ARE FROM THE
COMMUNITY. ACTUALLY BUILDING
LET'S PEOPLE WHO READ THEM
UNDER THE FABRIC IN THE
LANDSCAPE OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE FIFTY FOURTH LET
THEM PARTICIPATE IN THIS. I
COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED A HUNDRED PLUS YEARS
AGO. WITH ANGELA JOHNSON FORTY
ACRES AND A MULE AND BLACK
FOLKS HAVEN'T SOME LAND AND
THEN NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE IT
IN FOR CENTURIES FOR YEARS FOR
GENERATIONS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THE LAND BACK.
AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE
DEVELOPERS CALLING YOUR PHONE
EVERY DAY ASKING IF YOU'D BE
WILLING TO SELL YOUR PROPERTY.
AND THEN HAVING APPRAISERS COME
IN AND UNDER VALUE YOUR
PROPERTY SO THAT FOLKS CAN GET
IT AT THE CHEAP. AND HOW THAT
ALSO ACCELERATES AND
EXACERBATES GENTRIFICATION AND
DISPLACEMENT. BUT INSTEAD OF
TALKING ABOUT THAT I'M GOING TO
JUST TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
WHY DON'T WE LOOK AT LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ALTERNATIVES LIKE
BE INVENTORY OF LAND THAT THE
STATE. THE INVENTORY OF LAND
THAT OUR LOCALITIES AND OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE COULD BE
USING THAT INVENTORY TO BUILD
WE COULD BE LOOKING AT HOW
WE'RE TRANSFORMING. YES LIGHT
COMMERCIAL CORRIDOR. BUT I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE ASKING
FOR A INVASION BY DEVELOPERS
INTO COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. BECAUSE WE'RE TO LAZY
QUITE FRANKLY TO HAVE MORE
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE'RE PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES AND FINDING WAYS TO
BUILD HOUSING THAT PEOPLE TRULY
CAN AFFORD SO WITH THAT I HAVE
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON SB ELEVEN TWENTY.
MISTER MATHIS. ALRIGHT MISTER
SPEAKER THE MR MAYS WAS AHEAD
OF ME IN LINE YES MIKE UP FOR.
MEMBERS THERE'S A LOT OF POINTS
ON THIS BILL THAT I CAN AGREE
WITH I THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED
MORE WE NEEDED TO BE AFFORDABLE.
WELL I THINK A LOT OF US AGREE
THAT FAMILIES ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME. BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T
QUITE GET THERE. I THINK
THERE'S CONSIDERATIONS-
ESPECIALLY IN OUR VALLEY AREA
WHEN WE LOOK AT. QUESTIONS OF
WATER ACCESSIBILITY. WE HAVE
REGULATIONS LIKE SIGNAL THAT
ARE COMING INTO AFFECTS. AND
EVERY YEAR WE GET CUT OFF MORE
MORE SURFACE WATER. AND WE KNOW
THAT HOUSING PROJECTS ACTUALLY
CHIU OF MORE WATER THAN HOUSING
PRODUCT. WHEN WE GET INTO THE
CONVERSATIONS OF URBAN SPRAWL.
AND WE TALK ABOUT PAULINE
AGRICULTURAL LAND OFF. AND
HAVING HOUSING PROJECTS TO GO
UP. IN FOR ALL OF THOSE OF YOU
WHO LOVE TO TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE THINGS YOU WANT
TO DO CONSIDER THIS.
AGRICULTURAL LAND. THAT THESE
NEW HOUSING PROJECTS WITH
POSSIBLY CHIU OF. IT'S TEN TO
FIFTEEN DEGREES COOLER THAN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS. SO CONSIDER THAT
ONE. NOW THERE'S A LOT OF
PIECES ON THIS. A AND I REALLY
LIKE THE POINT THE THAT WAS
MADE BECAUSE IN MY COMMUNITY.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WE HAVE A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
VERY POOR. AND DISENFRANCHISED.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE INVESTORS
COME IN. AND OFFER THEM. MONEY
AND DO THINGS TO CHASE THEM OUT.
SO THEY CAN SPLIT UP THESE
HOMES. THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. NOW IS THE
HUSBAND OF A REALTOR I'M
PROBABLY GONNA HERE WHEN I GET
HOME FOR NOT BEING THERE ON
THIS ONE BECAUSE THEN IT'S LESS
UNITS FOR MY WIFE TO BE ABLE TO
SELL BOY. YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK
AT THESE THINGS. WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET THESE
THINGS RIGHT MEMBERS. NO I SAY
WE EVERY YEAR. YOU KNOW. FAST A
SLOW SLOW IS SMOOTH SMOOTH IS
FAST. AND. YOU ALL TRY TO SPEED
THROUGH THESE THINGS AND THROWN
TOGETHER IN YOU KNOW THIS IS
JUST MORE SPAGHETTI THROWN AT
THE WALL WE KNOW IT'S NOT DONE
COOKIN AND WE'RE SLOWLY
WATCHING. THIS BILL AND OTHER
BILLS JUST. QUITE NOT STICK.
SULM I URGE YOU MEMBERS LET'S
GET THIS ONE RIGHT LET'S GET IT
RIGHT FOR THE NEIGHBORHOOD
LET'S GET IT RIGHT FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA LET'S GET
IT RIGHT SO WHEN OUR CHILDREN
HIT THAT POINT. WHERE THEY GO
TO BUY A HOME. THEY CAN
ACTUALLY BY THAT NICE SINGLE
FAMILY UNIT AND HAVE A
NEIGHBORHOOD TO RAISE OUR
GRANDKIDS AND THANK YOU. THERE
WAS TRAVIS MISS CUNNINGHAM YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. LOOK WE HAVE A MASSIVE
MASSIVE HOUSING SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS
ROOM TODAY SITTING HERE KNOWS
WE HAVE A HOUSING SHORTAGE. SO
WE ARE EITHER SERIOUS ABOUT
SOLVING THAT PROBLEM OR WE ARE
NOT. IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
SOLVING THAT THEN WE WILL MAKE
GOOD USE OF EXISTING RESOURCES
WILL LET PEOPLE DIVIDE LOTS.
WE'LL LET PEOPLE BUILD EIGHTY
USE TO MOVE THEIR GRANDPARENT
IN NEXT DOOR TO THEM. THOSE ARE
COMMON SENSE THINGS WE CAN DO.
TO MAKE EXISTING USE OF
RESOURCES AND WE SHOULD DO THAT
AND YOU KNOW WHY WE SHOULD DO
THAT BECAUSE ALL OF OUR KIDS
WOULD LOVE TO STAY IN THIS
WONDERFUL STATE. ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN WOULD LOVE TO SUNDAY
WITH THEIR THEIR PARENT AND
LIVED OTHER GRANDPARENT BUT WE
HAVE A CALIFORNIA IF WE
CONTINUE ON THE PRESENT PRESENT
PATH THAT IS GOING TO BE
UNAFFORDABLE FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION TOTALLY UNAFFORDABLE
WE ALL KNOW IT. SO IF YOU'RE
SERIOUS ABOUT DOING SUB FOR
THAT DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
VOTE FOR THIS BILL. GIVES
PROPERTY OWNERS MORE FREEDOM
OVER THEIR OWN LAND. LET THEM
SUBDIVIDE LET THEM BUILD EIGHTY
YEARS. LET THEM DO THINGS THAT
SOME THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL LOCK NOT ALLOWED THEM TO
DO THAT WILL INCREASE SUPPLY.
THAT WILL INCREASE HOUSING IN
OUR STATE. AGAIN IF WE ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT SOLVING THE
HOUSING PROBLEM. WE HAVE TO DO.
WHAT IT TAKES AND THAT IS
INCREASE SUPPLY THIS BILL WILL
DO IT I URGE AND I BOTH. THANK
YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM MISTER
MAYES YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- I
RISE TONIGHT TO BE. JUST TO SAY
THAT I'M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED.
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS. MISTER
MAYES PLEASE PROCEED I'M A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED- IN THE WAY
THAT WE ARE WE BEHAVE TO THIS
YEAR I REALIZE IT'S BEEN A
PANDEMIC BUT THE BILL BEFORE US.
IS A MAJOR PIECE OF PUBLIC
POLICY I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE TIME IS RUNNING SHORT THIS
EVENING SO I'M NOT GONNA TALK
ABOUT THE MERITS THIS BILL AND
GET CONTINUE TO GO DOWN THIS
BUT THE FACT IS THIS IS A MAJOR
PIECE OF PUBLIC POLICY AND WE
SHOULD BE DEBATING THIS NOT FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES NOT FOR THIRTY
MINUTES BUT FOR SEVERAL HOURS.
WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS BILL LAST
WEEK MY STAFF SAID THAT I WAS
GOING TO BE AN AYE WHY BECAUSE
I SUPPORTED EIGHTY USE JUST A
LAST YEAR TWO YEARS AGO. BUT
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT ADDING
EIGHTY USE IT'S NOT. THIS WILL
CHANGE THE FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA.
IT WILL CHANGE THE CHARACTER OF
YOUR NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH IS WHY
ALL OF US BELIEVE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE BELIEVE IN LOCAL
CONTROL AND DECISION TO MAKE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT'S WHY A
MEMBER FROM GLENDALE.AND A
MEMBER FROM LA ARE ONE WAY AND
SOMEBODY FROM A MEMBER FROM
OAKLAND AND SAN LUIS OBISPO OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. AND IT
SEEMS TO ME. MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER MESS PLEASE PROCEED- I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THIS LAST
POINT. BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN
I'VE HEARD THIS FROM MEMBERS
OVER AND OVER AND OVER THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION BELIEVING
THAT ALL THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
HERE BEING MADE FROM THE TOP
DOWN. IN FACT I HEARD FROM OF
ONE OF MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES
YESTERDAY. TOLD ME FELT LIKE WE
WERE JUST BACK UP DANCERS. FOR
MAYBE FOR JUST A FEW LEADERS.
AND THE TRUTH IS IT ISN'T UPON
US AS MEMBERS OF THIS BODY. AND
COMING UPON US AS MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY TO PROPERLY.
INSTITUTE OUR WILL OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RULES BEING A CO
EQUAL BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT AND
A BILL LIKE THIS I COULD HAVE
SUPPORTED. I STILL COULD
SUPPORT MAYBE NEXT YEAR. BUT
NOT HIS YEAR BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T HAD THE TIME TO
PROPERLY DEBATED. MR THIS AREA
YOUR RECOGNIZE COLLEAGUES I'M
GONNA BE BRIEF BECAUSE WE HAVE
A FEW MORE BILLS TO GO I JUST
WANT TO SHARE SOMETHING WITH
ALL OF YOU. IN THE PORTION OF
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THAT I
REPRESENT. IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF THE ENTIRE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. IN THE ENTIRE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH THREE
OF US RIGHT HERE REPRESENT.
THERE ARE OVER TEN THOUSAND
HOUSES SINGLE FAMILY HOUSES.%
THAT ARE OWNED BY VENTURE
CAPITAL COMPANIES. NOW IMAGINE
IF ALL OF THOSE PROPERTIES WERE
SUB DIVIDED RIGHT NOW. AND PUT
BACK ON TO THE MARKET. CAN YOU
JUST IMAGINE THE LEVEL OF
CONGESTION AND IMPACT. I'M JUST
GIVING YOU ONE SMALL EXAMPLE OF
WHAT THIS BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL OF DOING SO WE CAN
TALK ABOUT HOW IT BENEFITS.
SMALL MOM AND POP INDIVIDUAL
OWNERS. BUT THE REAL BIGGER
GAME IS THE WEALTH COMPANIES
THAT THE MANAGEMENT COME WEALTH
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES THAT ARE
SITTING ON THOUSANDS OF
PROPERTIES WAITING FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROFIT. SO I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. DAVIS'S ARIAN. MR
OBERNOLTE. BUT MR ROBBIE BRIEF-
I RISE IN OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN
TWENTY IN COLLEGE I STRUGGLED
WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE
GENERALLY MY PHILOSOPHY IS
LIBERTARIAN AND I FIGURE IF
SOMEONE WANTS TO SUBDIVIDE
THEIR LOT IF SOMEONE WANTS TO
BUILD A DUPLEX WHY SHOULD THEY
NOT BE ALLOWED TO DO THAT BUT
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
THINKING IF YOU SUBSCRIBE TO
THAT PHILOSOPHY WIDELY NEWS
WILL DO LAND USE PLANNING AT
ALL WHY DO WE ALLOW. LOCAL
COUNTIES AND CITIES THE ABILITY
TO SAY WE WANT THIS BILL HERE
WE WANT THAT BUILD HERE. ALONG
WITH THIS BILL IS IT'S A HUGE
CHANGE. TO LAND USE POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA LITTLE THAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE LAST SIX YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE- HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
AFFECT. LAND USE PLANNING TO
THE EXTENT THAT THIS ONE
DOESN'T WE'RE HERE DEBATING IT.
AT ELEVEN THIRTY PM AT NIGHT
THE DAY BEFORE THE END OF
SESSION. OUR COLLEAGUES MISTY
THIS IS NEEDS MORE BAKING I
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MISTER RIVAS YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I GO BACK LEVEL THE
ROLE. REVERSAL DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
THE END. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS ARE DESERVE A.
MYSTERY THIS WAS A CALL. MISTER
CALDERON I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES
ALLOW US A MEMBER WEBER TO TAKE
A BABY THIRTY SEVENTY TODAY
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THE CURRENT
SENTIMENTS. MR FOR WITHHOLDING
EVIDENCE IN AS A ROLL CALL VOTE
MR FOR WITHHOLDS MISTER
CALDERON MOVES MR TANG SECONDS.
ON THE RULES EXPANSION
PROCEDURE OF CORPORAL. ADDRESS
ASKING FOR NINE MISTER FLORENCE
IS ASKING FOR NOW. MR FLOOR
NINE FOR ME MISTER FLOOR NOW
MISTER CALDERON AYE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE AS FIFTY FIVE
MINUTES THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. THIS IS DR WEBER'S.
THIRTY SEVENTY. AB THIRTY
SEVENTY CORKERY SOME AGO THIRTY
SEVENTY BY SIMILAR WEBER
ANOTHER SNACK LEDGERS JURIES DR
WEBER YES MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB THIRTY SEVENTY ON
CONCURRENCE BACK FROM THE
SENATE- THIS BILL IS A JOINT
AUTHORS WITH THE SPEAKER- THIS
BILL AIMS TO PREVENT RACIAL
BIAS IN SELECTION OF JURIES WE
WERE PROUD TO HAVE WITH OUR
SUPPORTERS BEAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS A NUMBER OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IT REPRESENTS A
MUCH NEEDED AND TIMELY CHANGE
TO FIX OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
LATER HOWEVER. MR GALLAGHER.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS- WE SAW THIS BILL IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. AND HERE'S
MY CONCERN. WE HAVE A PROCESS
SET UP FOR JURY SELECTION AND
IT IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS AN UNBIASED. JURY
SELECTION AND YOU WILL HEAR
FROM BOTH SIDES FROM BOTH
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND FROM
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS THAT IS
IMPORTANT THAT YOU BE ABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS THAT WOULD UNDULY
BIAS. THE JURY. AND
UNFORTUNATELY I KNOW THAT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS A GOOD
ONE. BECAUSE I KNOW THE AUTHOR
AND I KNOW WHAT HER HEART IS
ABOUT THIS BILL. BUT AS AS
COUNTLESS. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO ACTUALLY BROUGHT
THIS UP IN COMMITTEE. THAT MANY
TIMES HE HAS ASKED THESE EXACT
QUESTIONS. IN ORDER TO GET OUT
THE UNBIASED NATURE. OF THE
JUROR AND TO ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE IS NOT GOING TO BE
BIASED AGAINST THE CLIENT ON
BOTH SIDES. WHETHER YOU'RE A
DEFENDANT. IN A CRIMINAL CASE
OR- YOU ARE THE PROSECUTOR
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT JURY IS
GOING TO BE UNBIASED AGAINST.
AN OFFICER OR WHOEVER IS YOU
KNOW WHAT OR OR THE PEOPLE IN
THAT CASE. YOU'RE TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT A COMPLETELY
UNBIASED JURY WE HAVE THESE
THINGS IN PLACE FOR A REASON
THAT YOU CAN ASK THESE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU CAN DO
PEREMPTORY STRIKES. AND SO. I
KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
EMOTION BEHIND THESE TYPES OF.
BILLS THAT ARE BEING PUT
FORWARD BUT WE STILL NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS DUE
PROCESS WE DO NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT THERE IS AN UNBIASED FAIR
APPROACH. THAT YOU DO GET TRIED
BY A JURY OF YOUR PEERS. AND
THAT THOSE BECAUSE WHEN YOU ASK
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS WHICH
MIGHT BE. ABOUT YOUR HISTORY
WITH. LAW ENFORCEMENT YOUR
HISTORY IT MAY BE HAVING A
FELONY OR HAVING SOMEONE WHO.
DID HAVE A FELONY THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THESE NEED
TO BE I THINK THAT NEED TO DO
THIS. SO I WOULD ASK YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. C. NOTATIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE DR WEBER YOU
MAY CLOSE- MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YAGUDIN CONCURRENCE.
GLOBAL ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THEIR VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THEM ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
A ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MY RISOTTO WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR WHICH TO VOTE.
IT IS ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
THIRTY CLOSER ALL TIED UP HIGHS
FORTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES NON PREPARED TO
LIVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
FIFTY TWO SB ELEVEN TWENTY PARK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WISH TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OUT EYES FORTY TWO NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO. THE
NUMBER. FILE ITEM. EIGHTY TWO.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO SB NINE
NINE FIVE COVERAGE. SENATE BILL
NINE NINETY FIVE BY CENTER
ACKERMAN OTHERS NOT RELATING
VITAMIN A QUALITY MS GONZALEZ
THIS HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO
PARTY BUILDING TRADES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MISTER THIS. MISTER
MATHIS MISTER CALDERON WHEN I
MOVE THE PREVIOUS QUESTION.
WITH THE PREVIOUS QUESTION
TAKES FIVE. MR TANG MISTER GRAY
MR SANTIAGO MR GABRIEL. MS
FRIEDMAN MAJORITY PRESIDENT
BUSH THIS IS A PROCEDURE VOTE
OR CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO VOTE MAJORITY
PRESIDENT VOTING I MEAN THE
PREVIOUS QUESTION. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS. TEN
EVERYBODY ON MS GONZALEZ DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE. CARCLUB THE ROLE.
THERE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL TELEVOTE ICE FREE ONE
KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE HAVE ITEMS ON CALL MEDIA
TRENDS. IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE GOVERNOR. TO THE SENATE.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON CALL
PREPARE TO LIVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM. EIGHTY ONE SB FIFTY
FOUR PURPLE POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED WHICH. TO RIGHT WE
REPLACE THE CALL. JOHN PREPARE
TO LIVE THE CALL I TEN TWENTY
FOUR PORT POE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS SAID ABOUT. PART WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE NO SIXTEEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE. FOR POSTED FOR ME
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
THIRTY ONE BY SIMILAR
BOERNER HORVATH AN ACCOLADE AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO
CLEARING THE USES HEROES TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MS BERMAN
YES THANK YOU COLLEAGUES- THIS
BILL HAS AN URGENCY CLAUSE SO
WE CAN HEAR IT AFTER MIDNIGHT
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE SEEKS
TO STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR EASY TO USE WORK
SURE PROGRAM. TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
ALLOWING THEM TO RETAIN TRAYS
STAFF TRAINED STUFF AND AVOID
LAYOFFS COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
BILL SPONSORED BY BOTH THE
CALCHAMBER THE CALIBER FED.
IT'S A WIN FOR BUSINESSES IT'S
A WIN FOR WORKERS AS A WIN FOR
CALIFORNIA IT DOESN'T URGENCY
CLAUSE SO THAT WE CAN USE THE
MONIES ALLOCATED THE CURES ACT
WHICH WERE CURRENTLY NOT USING
VERY WELL IN ORDER TO FUND IT
TO THE END OF THE YEAR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR ROBERT.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOT I. SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO ON THE BILL
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
AB SEVEN THIRTEEN WORK
CONCURRENCE THE COURT AGREED.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRD
THIRTEEN BY SIMMONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN OTHERS ACTUALLY
TO CONSUMER PRIVACY IN THE
CLEARLY YEARS CEDAR OF TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MISTER MONEY
RECOGNIZED. FAMOUS CHAIR
MEMBERS AB SEVEN THIRTEEN WOULD
FURTHER HARMONIZE TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT OF CCPA WITH
EXISTING CONFIDENTIALITY AND
PRIVACY RULES FOR CERTAIN
HEALTH RELATED INFORMATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN DOES HE KNOW THE
MEMBERS WISHING TO SEEK
RECOGNITION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS IS A FIFTY FOUR VOTE
ITEM. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I SEVENTY. NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY I SEVENTY NO ZERO.
ON THE BILL. THIS IS A MINUTES
ARE COMPARED IN.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU RECOGNIZE YOUR
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS TO
PRINT A LETTER IN THE JOURNAL
FOR THE FOLLOWING BILLS AB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE GRAY A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE MCCARTY
ELEVEN NINETY SIX GIPSON AB
NINE THIRTEEN CALDERON AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
GONZALEZ. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE SANTIAGO AND A. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE GRAYSON AND AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION REQUEST IS
GRANTED. THIS CALL IS FOR YOUR
RECOGNIZED. MISTER CALDERON
YOU'RE GONNA RECOGNIZE PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY TO SEE A
MOVE TO ALLOW SOMEONE TO RAISE
TO PRINT A LETTER IN THE
JOURNAL FOR HER AB SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. MISTER FOR MISTER SPEAKER
WITHHOLDING AS CONSENT AS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. SIR FLOOR
WITHHOLDS MISTER CALDERON.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE CARPAL OF THE
ROLE. CALDERON IS ASKING. FOR
NINE. AND MR FLORA NO. MISTER
CALDERON IS AS FOR NINE FOR NOW.
WELL CLOSER ALL EYES FIFTY
KNOWS. THIRTEEN MOTION CARRIES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ABOUT. THE MAJORITY
LEADER. THIS IS A MAJORITY
LEADER IN CALL THE RUNS. LAST
SESSION. MISS GONZALES. WITH
THAT MR HOLDEN WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH YOU MISS GONZALEZ
WILL BE ON DECK MR HOLDEN OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE YESTERDAY. NOT
TOO LONG AGO. BUT IT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN. THAT THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND I WERE
SWORN IN AND BECAME SEAT MATES
FOR THE FIRST TIME. HE WAS A
STANDOUT IN OUR CLASS. REYES
YOUNG YOUNG AGE WELL KNOWN LAST
NINE I LIKE ME. IN FACT WE
ESTABLISHED A COMMONALITY ON
OUR FIRST WERE IN AND DAY AS
OUR FATHERS BOTH FORMER
LEGISLATORS SAT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER. WITH US ON THE FLOOR.
BUT SINCE THEN HE HAS SHOWN AS
SHOWN AS THE THOUGHTFUL
HARDWORKING STATESMAN HE IS AS
A PERSON HE IS A LOYAL. AND
DEMONSTRATES INTEGRITY TO THE
HIGHEST ORDER. IT ALSO IS A
GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR AND A
CONTAGIOUS LAUGH THAT BRINGS
JOY TO YOUR SPIRIT. HE IS
PROMOTED CAMARADERIE AS ONE OF
THE FOUNDERS OF THE DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS BASEBALL ANNUAL
BASEBALL GAME. UNFORTUNATELY
THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LAST ONE FOR.
HE LED LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO
GIVE PARENTS A PATIENTS THE
RIGHT TO TRY UTILIZE THE TECH
SECTOR FOR THE GOOD OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND ESTABLISH
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL SPORT
SURFING. WHILE SERVING HE
STARTED A FAMILY. WE SEE HIM
BEAM WITH PRIDE WHEN HIS WIFE
ELISE. AND THE THREE CHILDREN
CHARLIE HARDLY AND CREW ARE
NEARBY. THEY HAVE NOT JUST BEEN
HIS JOY THEY HAVE ALSO INSPIRED
HIS WORK AS HE LED THE EFFORT
ON DIAPER CHANGING TABLES AND
ALL PUBLIC BATHROOMS REGARDLESS
OF GENDER. AS MAJORITY LEADER
HAS MANAGED THE FLOOR WITH
PROFESSIONALISM. EFFICIENCY AND
FAIRNESS NEVER AFRAID TO RAISES
MY TO MAINTAIN ORDER ON THE
FLOOR. I KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE
THAT THAT JOB IS NOT AN EASY
ONE ESPECIALLY DURING THE LAST
FEW WEEKS OF SESSION. HE IS
MANAGED THESE LAST DAYS WELL
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS. BUT
DURING HIS PARTICULARLY
UNUSUAL I'M TRYING SESSION IS
DEMONSTRATED HE IS A TRUE
LEADER. MY ONLY REGRET IN IS
THAT WE NEVER HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON A BILL
TOGETHER. BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT YOU DO IN THE
FUTURE AND I KNOW IT WILL BE
GREAT. BECAUSE I KNOW YOUR
FUTURE IS BRIGHT GOD BLESS
AFFRONT. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
THIS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RIGHT.
THANK YOU. MY FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE I GOT SWORN IN AND
WALKED BACK HERE AND HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SEATED RIGHT
IN FRONT OF IAN CALDERON. AND
AT THAT MOMENT I REALLY DIDN'T
KNOW I JUST ASSUMED HE WAS SOME
RICH KID THAT USED HIS NAME TO
GET ELECTED IN THE OFFICE.
WATCHING SERVICIOS WHEN NO ONE
WAS LOOKING. BUT THERE WAS
SOMETHING ABOUT HIM. LIKE I'M
SURE WE ALL FELT THAT JUST MADE
YOU LOVE HIM. IN QUICKLY
BECAME. SOMETIMES I SAY LIKE
NINE OTHER CHILD BUT MORE LIKE
A LITTLE BROTHER. WE HAVE SOME
ROUGH PATCHES WE DIDN'T HAVE A
PATCHES BUT THERE WERE SOME
ROUGH PATCHES. AND WE REALLY
GREW CLOSE. IN AN IBM. HAD THE
GREAT PLEASURE OF BEING IN THE
DOGHOUSE TOGETHER FOR ABOUT A
YEAR. DECIDING THAT LOYALTY
MATTERED MORE. THE BEING IN A
GOOD POSITION IN THIS HOUSE AND
WE PAY FOR TOGETHER. IN IN THAT
YEAR HE TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT
DIPLOMACY. I TAUGHT HIM A LOT
ABOUT PUT YOUR PAPER. AND WE
WORK TOGETHER. AND WORKS TO
ENSURE THAT THE DIRECTION OF
THIS HOUSE WAS LED. BY SOMEBODY
WE PEOPLE AND SO MANY OF YOU
BELIEVED IN. I DON'T KNOW A
SINGLE NAME THAT'LL COME UP IN
A CONVERSATION ON THIS FLOOR IT
EVEN WON'T SAY. I GOT ITI'M
GONNA GO TALK TO THAT PERSON
WERE CLOSE. AND YOU NEVER
QUESTION IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW HE
REALLY DOES HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR YOU HE
HEARD JAIL. HE LISTENED HE- HE
TRIED TO FIX SOMETHING FOR YOU.
AND I DON'T KNOW MANY LEADERS
WHO DO THAT WHO SPEND MORE TIME
LISTENING THAN TALKING. WHO'S
BEEN MORE EFFORT TO FIX THINGS
THEY GETTING SOMETHING FOR
THEMSELVES WITHOUT FEAR. I LIKE
SO MANY OF YOU HAVE A GREAT
HONOR WATCHING HIM KIND OF GROW
UP. GET MARRIED TO LEASE. THE
MOST FABULOUS WOMAN IN THE
WORLD. HAVE THE MOST ADORABLE
CHILDREN. CHARLIE AND HEART
LEAN CREW. REALLY SAD WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO HOLD HER
YET. BUT ALL OF THAT I
REALIZED. LAST YEAR. IN
NOVEMBER WHEN HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO. SEVEN TIME A FAMILY
RATHER THAN RUN FOR REELECTION.
HOW INCREDIBLY SINCERE THAT WAS
HOW MANY PEOPLE RUN FOR OFFICE
THAT ARE SO INCREDIBLY SINCERE
ABOUT THEIR VALUES THAT THEY
SAY NO AT THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS WHAT MATTERS TO ME. I
WANT TO BE WITH MY FAMILY. AND
I THINK THERE WERE FOLKS YOU
KNOW OUT IN LA LA LAND NOT
AMONG US WHO THOUGHT THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON RIGHT THE
OTHER ISSUES GOING TO DROP. NOW.
HE JUST WAS DOING WHAT WAS BEST
FOR HIS FAMILY JUST LIKE HE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN DID WHAT
WAS BEST FOR THIS HOUSE DID
WHAT WAS BEST FOR ALL OF US.
MAKE SURE HE WAS THE ONE. THE
GOTCHA ALL TOGETHER ON A
SOFTBALL FIELD. MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY FELT INCLUDED MAKE
SURE EVERY BOOK EVERY VOICE WAS
HEARD. WE SERVE HERE FOR A
LIMITED NUMBER OF YEARS. YOU'RE
GONNA MOVE ON IT'S NICE THERE
YOUR COINS IS. BUT I REALLY
WOULD QUESTION HOW MANY OF US
ARE GONNA LEAVE TONIGHT SAYING
GOODBYE TO OUR REAL FRIENDS.
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE A REAL FRIENDS AS HE
LEADS TO. SOMEBODY WHO YOU'RE
GONNA WANT TO CHECK IN WITH.
HOW SELDOM DOES THAT HAPPEN. I
WANT TO AS HE LEADS TO. GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO HIS CHIEF OF STAFF.
TOM WHITE I KNOW THAT'S KIND OF
WEIRD BUT LIKE IF YOU GOT IT
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY. WHO ALWAYS SEEM TO
FIND ME WHEN I WAS LOST DIRECT
ME THE RIGHT WAY I KIND OF FEEL
LIKE EVAN ASSIGNED HIM TO I.
HAVE EVAN. AND INDIANA SIGNED
INTO FINDING ME LOST SOMEWHERE
ON SOME FLOOR. IN TELLING ME
WHERE I SHOULD GO BACK TO AN OF
TOM'S HERE. OR WHEN I'M
STANDING HERE LOOKING LOST SO
WE'RE TO HOPEFULLY NOT MISS TOM
HE'LL STILL BE HERE. BUT THAT'S
ALSO AN EXTENSION OF WHAT HE
AND HIS CREATED IN HIS OFFICE.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HELP US ALL.
IN THE BATTLE WITHOUT CRYING.
THAT. ZERO YOU'RE STILL GOING
TO GET MY MIDNIGHT TAX. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DAD JOKES. ASKING
FOR ADVICE. TELL YOUR REMAINS
ARE STUPID. BUT WISHING YOU
WERE STILL HERE. YOU HAVE DONE
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE JOB IT'S
BEEN SUCH AN HONOR TO BE YOUR
FRIEND INTO WATCHING GROW INTO
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE LEADER. THIS
INSTITUTION HAS BEEN CHANGED
BECAUSE YOU WERE HERE. I'M SO
PROUD TO CALL YOU MY FRIEND.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ MISTER
GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER- LET ME JUST SIMPLY SAY
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKED
ABOUT STORIES OF IAN I WANT TO
FOCUS ON A THREE HOUSE. ONE
FAMILY. I WANT TO SAY IN
CHARLES CALDERON OUR MAJORITY
LEADER I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
FAMILY. LET ME SAY LEASE
CHARLIE HARLEY AND CREW. OTHER
PRIORITIES OF YOUR FAMILY. YOU
HAVE MADE THAT VERY CLEAR. THAT
THEY COME FIRST I RESPECT THAT
IMMENSELY BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WATCH.
CHARLIE CHARLIE AND CREW GROW
UP. PACKING LUNCH. SEE THEM OFF
ONTHE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL. SAY
GOODBYE. AND PICK THEM UP.
FAMILY. EVEN SOMETIMES. TUCKING
THEM INTO BED AT NIGHT. AND
POSSIBLY SAYING THE PRAYER THAT
MY MOTHER USED TO SAY TO ME.
NOW I LAY ME DOWN TO SLEEP. I
PRAY THE LORD MY SOUL TO KEEP.
IF I SHOULD DIE BEFORE I WAKE I
PRAY THE LORD MY SOUL TO TAKE.
FAMILY HAS BEEN A PRIORITY FOR
YOU. FOCUS YOU ARE SO FOCUSED
ON FAMILY. IT IS APPARENT THAT
HEY ARE THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY FOR YOU. FOCUS ON
BEING A HUSBAND. FOCUSED ON
BEING A DAD. TO CHARLIE CHARLIE
AND CREW. YOU ARE NOW MAKING
THEM THAT THE FOCUS SO THAT YOU
WILL NEVER MISS THE PRECIOUS
MOMENTS. BECAUSE YOU WILL FOCUS
ON FAMILY. AND BECAUSE YOU'RE
FOCUSED. THE LAST HALF IS WERE
FUTURE. ENTHRALLS CALDERON WERE
RIGHT THE NEW NARRATIVE THE NEW
CHAPTER WORDS BEAUTIFUL LIFE.
FOR CHARLIE. HARLEIAN CREW YOU
ARE RIGHT THE FUTURE THAT IS
UNLIMITED. YOU WILL PAINT THE
BEST PICTURE. BETTER THAN ANY
ARTIST CAN NEVER PAINT YOU WILL
PAINT THE PICTURE THAT THEY CAN
GROW UP TO BE ANYTHING THAT
THEY WANT TO DO AND BE. YOU
ALSO PAINT THE PICTURE. OF THE
FUTURE THAT THE FUTURE IS
UNLIMITED. WHY IT BECAUSE YOU
SERVED IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. YOU MADE THE
DIFFERENCE AND WHEN YOU WRITE
THAT CHAPTER MY FRIEND
UNDERSTAND WHATEVER YOU DO FROM
HERE ON OUT THE BEST IS STILL
YET TO COME. THANK. MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS GEE I HOPE I DON'T
TERRIBLE- THERE'S BEEN A- LOT
OF MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT IAN AND
I FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT
IDENTICAL TWINS- WE LOOK A LOT
ALIKE AND WE'RE PROBABLY THE
SAME AGE. AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER AS LONG AS
SOME PEOPLE THINK. HE AND I
ACTUALLY MET THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN WE MET. AS CANDIDATES
WHEN A LOT OF US RECORDS I TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WAS A CRAZY
YEAR WAS THE YEAR OF THE-
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. AND
THERE IS A POINT WHERE IAN AND
I THOUGHT WE MIGHT RUN AGAINST
EACH OTHER. AND A FORMER
SPEAKER- SUGGESTED THAT WE SIT
DOWN TOGETHER. AND I DIDN'T
WANT TO WRITE THEM. I WANT I
WANT TO HATE HIM- I THOUGHT
THAT. THAT WE'RE BOTH GONNA RUN
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER. AND THE
FORMER SPEAKER ASKED ME TO- GO
SPEND SOME TIME WITH THEM. AND
WE SHOULD ALL DO WITH SPEAKERS
ASK IS THERE- SO. WHICH HASN'T
REALLY HAPPENED TONIGHT BUT- I
DECIDE TO DO THAT I SAT DOWN I
WENT TO A COFFEE SHOP IN WHO
YOU'RE REALLY CLOSE TO MY
PARENTS HOUSE. AND I WALKED IN
LIKE GOD I HOPE THIS LAST LIKE
TEN MINUTES BECAUSE I'M REALLY
NOT THE RIGHT THIS GUY. WE SAT
DOWN AND I WAS. IMMEDIATELY
STRUCK BY HOW INCREDIBLY OF THE
PROJECT HE WAS. WHAT'S AMAZING
ABOUT THIS JOB IS THAT. NONE OF
US HAS EXPERIENCES TO BE ABLE
TO FULLY REPRESENT FORTY NINE
PEOPLE NOT A STATE- THE BEST WE
CAN DO IS TO HOPE TO HAVE%
EMPATHY TO UNDERSTAND PEOPLE.
ANY IN DOES THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. AND I WALKED OUT OF THAT
COFFEE SHOP. AND I WENT TO MY
MOM'S HOUSE DOWN THE STREET.
AND I SAID MOM. IF I DON'T
REPRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY I MET
THE GUY. WHO'S GOING TO
REPRESENT YOU. AND SHE SAID
WHAT'S HIS NAME. AND I SAID IAN
CALDERON AND SHE SAID OH WE
DON'T VOTE FOR COUNTY ROADS IN
THIS HOUSE. IN IN MY HOME WE
ALWAYS VOTED FOR THE MORE
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE ON THE BALLOT. THEY
ALWAYS LOST TO CALDERON'S AND-
BUT THAT THE LINES WERE DRAWN
WE ENDED UP IN DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS AND WE ENDED UP HERE
AND THE REASON YOU VOTE THAT UP
IN THE DOG HOUSE WAS CAUSING ME
BOTH THAT. DECIDED EARLY ON TO
MAP THE SPEAKERSHIP RENDON
DIDN'T QUITE WORK OUT THE FIRST
TIME- BUT THEN THERE ARE THE
ORIGINAL SIX JANA WHO YOU ARE.
WHO ARE THE SECOND TIME AROUND
WE ALL SAT DOWN GOT A SHEET OF
BUTCHER PAPER. AND FIGURED OUT
AND EVERY THING THAT'S HAPPENED
I'VE SAID TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
OVER THE FOR FIVE YEARS- THAT
WE'VE BEEN HERE WE'VE DONE MORE
THAN ANY LEGISLATURE IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY WHETHER
IT'S GUN CONTROL WHETHER IT'S
TOBACCO WHETHER IT'S MINIMUM
WAGE WHETHER IT'S WORKER
PROTECTION WE'VE DONE MORE
THAN. ANY LEGISLATURE IN
HISTORY THIS COUNTRY AND I
WOULD HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT HIM
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE AS A
BODY. HAS BEEN BECAUSE OF- HAS
BEEN WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE. WITHOUT A YET AND I
WOULD LIKE TO REPORT. THAT IN
THE LAST FIVE ELECTION CYCLES
FOUR ELECTION CYCLES. THERE'S
BEEN A CALDERON SIGN ON MY
PARENTS FRONT YARD THAT MY
MOM'S BREATH. AND I REMEMBER
GOING. ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO TO
MY MOM'S HOUSE AND SHE SAID I
DON'T YOU KNOW ALL THESE THINGS
IANS DOING ABOUT POLLUTION
PROTECTION LAWS WE'VE HAD
ENOUGH THAT CYCLE REDUCE
COMMUNITY COFFEE LAST WEEK- MY
MOM IS A HUGE CALDERON FAN AND
IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF YOU. MY
ENTIRE FAMILY IS A CALDERON
FAMILY AS OUR FANS BECAUSE OF
YOU- I DIDN'T WANT TO LIKE YOU
HAD AN UNPLEASANT. EXPERIENCE.
MISTER CALDERON THE FLOORS.
IT'S GONNA BE HARD FOR ME. I'VE
BEEN SECOND ON MY WHOLE LIFE.
AND MY- YEAH IT WAS ELECTED NAY
TO OSBORNE EIGHTY FIVE. SO I'VE
A MY BIRTH WAS ANNOUNCED ON THE
FLOOR. I PLAYED TAG IN THE
SENATE ON THE FLOOR WHILE THE
SENATE WAS IN SESSION. SO HUGE.
HUGE PART OF MY LIFE. COMMENTS
IS HARDER THAN OBESE WATCHING.
WE DO A LOT OF AMAZING THINGS
APPEAR TOGETHER WHETHER WE
AGREE WITH EACH OTHER. OR NOT.
BUT WE COULDN'T DO THOSE
THINGS. IF YOU ARE IN IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
STAND BEHIND US. IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE PEOPLE. THAT HELP RUN
THIS INSTITUTION SO I WANT TO
START WITH A COUPLE. THANK YOUS.
BECAUSE JUST LIKE ME TO FIND
EVERY GREAT MAN IS A GREAT
WOMAN BEHIND EVERY GREAT NUMBER.
IT'S A GREAT STAFF. IT'S A
GREAT INSTITUTION. I WANT TO
START BY THANKING EVERYONE. BY
ME THEY ARE. ABOVE IN A WAY.
THE BEST THERE IS AT THEIR JOB.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME THINGS
RUN SMOOTHLY ON THIS FLOOR FOR
A LOT OF REASONS BECAUSE I
RESPECT YOU RESPECT YOUR TIME
AND WILL RUN FOR WE SHOULD BE
WORKING SHE DOING THINGS HOW TO
WASTE YOUR TIME. THERE'S ALWAYS
WORK TO DO BUT WE NEED TO GET
OUT SO WE CAN ALSO SEE OUR
FAMILIES BECAUSE THAT'S ALL
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US.
THINGS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS. COULD NOT HAVE GONE AS
SMOOTHLY AND AS A AND AS WELL
AS THEY HAVE IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE- CLERK. AND THEIR STAFF SO
IF YOU CAN PLEASE HELP ME. HUGE
ASSET TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
WE ALSO HAVE A FLOOR TEAM. THAT
WORKED REALLY REALLY HARD- AND
SO I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT%
TO THANK. BRIAN ONE. AND
BRANDON BECAUSE OF. HURDLES IN
THE GYMNASTICS OF THAT THEY'RE
PERFORMING BEHIND. BACK THERE
AT THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS IN
THE OFFICE IT IS AMAZING THEY
KEEP US MOVING AND THEY GIVE ME
EVERYTHING THAT I NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE GETTING A
WORK DONE SO IF YOU COULD
PLEASE JOIN ME GIVEN THEM
AROUND. I WANT TO THANK MY
STAFF. I'VE BEEN SO FORTUNATE
TO HAVE. SUCH AN AMAZING STAFF-
AND- FOR THE MOST PART
RELATIVELY LOW. TURNOVER RATE
WHICH I'M PRETTY HAPPY ABOUT I
FEEL LIKE PEOPLE RELATIVE HAVE
TAKEN BY HOUSES THAT I WASN'T
TOO MUCH OF A NIGHTMARE. SO
THEY STICK AROUND LONG ENOUGH
TO SEE TO SEE AT LEAST A YEAR
THROUGH. AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME THAT ARE IN MY OFFICE I
HAVE BEEN THERE FOR A LONG TIME
FROM. FROM DAY ONE BUT THEN
ALSO OTHERS. I HAVE GONE OUT
AND ARE DOING AMAZING THINGS
AND WAS ALWAYS SO IMPORTANT TO
ME- I WAS THAT I WANTED EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF MY STAFF MEMBERS
THAT WORKED IN MY OFFICE TO. TO
LEAVE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
MAKE A COMMENT- AND IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT TO ME TO HELP THEM.
DO THAT- AS IT IS FOR EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US IN- I HAVE AN
AMAZING DISTRICT STAFF EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT HAS EVER
WORKED IN MY DISTRICT. IS
AMAZING AND I HAVE AN AMAZING.
CAPITAL STAFF. THAT HAS BEEN SO
STELLAR AND SO STRONG. AND IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT BECAUSE NOT ONLY
HAS MY BILL PRIORITIES. IN
THEIR PRIORITY BUT- ALSO THE
PRIORITIES OF. THE NUMBERS.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM HAVE
ALSO BEEN. THEIR PRIORITY SO
THEY HAD TO TAKE ON A LOT.
THEY'VE DONE A LOT OF AMAZING
THINGS- SO IF YOU COULD JOIN ME
THINK MY STAFF. I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. I WANT TO DO A
SPECIAL CARVE OUT. FOR MY CHIEF
OF STAFF. TOM WHITE. HE IS. AN
AMAZING PERSON AND ONE OF THE
MOST AMAZING CHERISHED FRIENDS
I'VE EVER HAD IN MY ENTIRE LIFE
I AM SO HONORED AND PROUD. TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH
HIM. OVER THESE YEARS. THANKS A
LOT. EARLY ON I WITH A PRETTY
HARD TIME. NO FAULT OF MY OWN.
FAMILY WAS LIKE IDC FAMILY
FIFTY FIFTY THEY WOULD YOU
WOULD BECOME NECESSARY. YOU GOT.
BUT I WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN TO
THAT TIME. WITHOUT TOM WHEN
DIFFERENTIATE THINGS HAPPEN TO
YOU IF YOU WANT TO HIDE.
ESPECIALLY IN THIS POSITION
BECAUSE IT'S SO EMBARRASSING.
AND WHETHER YOU DID ANYTHING
WRONG OR NOT YOU STILL OWN THAT.
YEAH YOU CAN- GET BROUGHT UP IN
A- SOCKS. BUT THOMAS STRONG
MAYBE HELP ME- PUSHED THROUGH
IT AND RATHER THAN TOWERING
HIDING. YOU KNOW WE CAME UP
WITH THIS PLAN TO. SAY YOU KNOW
I HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING SO IT WAS. GET OUT
THERE MORE YOU SEEN MORE. DO
MORE THINGS YOU HAVE NOTHING TO
HIDE AND I HAVE A COMMUNITY
REPRESENT. NEXT ELECTION WAS
CLOSE BUT I WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
THERE WITHOUT SOME. HE HAS DONE
SO MUCH BEHIND THE SCENES FOR
EVERY SINGLE PERSON ON THE
FLOOR WHEN YOU REALIZE IT OR
NOT. HE WORKS EXTREMELYHARD-
HE IS THE MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE
PERSON. AND WHAT I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED ABOUT HIM IS HIS
RESPECT. FOR THIS INSTITUTION.
WHICH HAS BEEN SO IMPORTANT TO
ME. INSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT NOT JUST ME
BUT TO ALL OF US PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE FAITH IN THIS INSTITUTION.
AND THE STEWARDS OF THIS
INSTITUTION IN A DEMOCRACY. I
HAVE TO TRUST US THEY HAVE TO
TRUST THE WAY THIS INSTITUTION
WORKS. THAT INSTITUTIONS RUN BY
PEOPLE PEOPLE LIKE TOM. AND SO
I'M I'M HAPPY THAT TOM IS GOING
TO STAY- BEYOND ME CONTINUE TO
WORK FOR ALL ALL OF YOU BUT HE
IS AN AMAZING ASSET TO THIS
INSTITUTION IT'S BEEN AN
AMAZING ASSET AFFRONT TO ME. TO
BEGIN PLEASE JOIN ME.
WHICH
ACOSTA CRIME. YEAH I WANT TO
THANK MY FAMILY. HEY FOR THOSE
OF YOU SPENT TIME WITH ME
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT MY
FAMILY AS I KNOW THERE A LOT OF
US A LOT OF QUESTIONS A LOT OF
SPECULATION ABOUT WHY I MADE
THE DECISION I MADE. AND QUITE
HONESTLY IT WAS IT WAS ACTUALLY
A LEASE NOT BECAUSE SHE WANTED
ME TO LEAVE BECAUSE WE'RE BOTH
TERRIFIED ABOUT LEAVING BECAUSE
THAT'S UNCERTAINTY AND WE HAVE
A FAMILY YOU WANT CERTAINTY.
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS LEADING UP O THE
END OF LAST YEAR ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT WORK I MEAN
WHAT WAS ALWAYS MY PRIORITIES
FAMILY I WANT TO START A FAMILY
WHEN HAVE WHAT KIDS AS MANY
KIDS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN AS MUCH
AS YOU. IF YOU WANT TO HAVE AND.
AS MUCH AS SHE'S WILLING. IT'S
NOT MY CALL. AND YEAH AND YOU
KNOW I CAN I KEPT MAKING
EXCUSES BECAUSE I REALLY DIDN'T
WANT TO LEAVE THIS IS LIKE I
LOVE THIS AND I'VE ALWAYS
WANTED TO DO ALL TWELVE YEARS
BUT IT WAS. IT WAS ONE POINT
THAT SHE HAD MADE IT REALLY
BROUGHT HOME FOR ME AS YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW SHE- HAD JUST BEEN
PREGNANT CREW AND SHE HAD SAID
IN TWO YEARS. IF YOU STAY. CHAU
CREW WILL BE AS OLD AREN'T
GOING TRIAL WILL BE AS OLD AS
OUR OLDEST CHILD IS NOW. AND
THAT'S STRUCK ME BECAUSE MY
OLDEST I MISSED HER FIRST WORDS
I MISSED HER FIRST TIME SHE
CALLED AYE MR FOR STATUS I
WASN'T AROUND FOR THAT WASN'T
BECAUSE I WAS HERE. AND I'M
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT I'VE
DONE HERE. BUT THESE MOMENTS I
WILL NEVER GET BACK. YOU CAN
ALWAYS COME BACK HERE AS LONG
AS YOU'VE GOT TIME. YOU CAN
ALWAYS ADVOCATE EVEN IF YOU'RE
NOT HERE TO DO THINGS AND FIGHT
FOR CAUSES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO YOU. BUT THAT'S TIME ON
THEIR GIVE BACK AND THAT'S WHY
I MADE THAT DECISION AND- SHE
HAS BEEN THE NUMBER ONE.
PARTNER IN ALL OF THIS I COULD
NOT HAVE SERVICE ALONGSIDE
SERVE WITHOUT HER THE
SACRIFICES SHE HAS TAKEN ON. TO
ALLOW ME TO BE HERE. I CAN'T
SAY THAT I. COULD HAVE DONE THE
SAME I JUST DON'T I MEAN EVEN
WITH JUST ONE KID BEING HOME
ALONE ALL WEEK WELL I WAS GONNA
COULD HELP. THE AMOUNT OF
STRESS THAT IS IF YOU LOVE YOUR
KIDS. BUT THEY GET YOU. AND IT
THEY WEAR ON. AFTER A COUPLE
DAYS. ADD ANY SANE PERSON GOES
CRAZY. AND SHE- SHE TOOK ON A
LOT AND- I LOVE HER MORE THAN
ANYTHING IN THIS WORLD. SHE'S
MY NUMBER ONE ADVICE IN THIS
AREA EVERYBODY EVERY PERSON SHE
HAS. MY PERSON AND ELEVEN DEF
AND- LOOKING FORWARD TO A LIFE
IS GONNA LOOK LIKE FOR THE BOTH
OF US AND I KNOW SHE'S WATCHING
SIDE I LOVE YOU POLICE AND
THANK YOU. FOR EVERYTHING. NO
LET YOU KNOW. IF YOU RECEIVE
THE TEXT TO ME ESPECIALLY. A
BILL OR ANY SHE'S PROBABLY THE
ONE THAT TEXT YOU BECAUSE-
WE'RE DRIVING AND I CAN'T
EXCELLENT DRIVING SO SHE'S THE
ONE THAT'S ON THE PHONE SO. YOU
ALL TEXAS HER WHEN HE REALIZED
THAT. OR NOT- I'M PROUD OF THE
TIME I'VE BEEN HERE I'M PROUD
OF THE WORK THAT I'VE DONE. I'M
PROUD TO HAVE SERVED WITH EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU ALL OF YOU
ARE AMAZING YOU KNOW IT'S SO
EASY WHEN MY WHEN I GO OUT SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE SO WILLING TO
TALK **** ABOUT US AND HOW
GREAT WE ARE AND HOW WE'RE THIS
IN HOW WE'RE THAT. AND ALWAYS
TOLD THEM IS LIKE YOU KNOW YOU
THAT'S JUST A BROAD
CHARACTERIZATION YOU'RE JUDGING
US BY THE LOWEST COMMON
DENOMINATOR BUT YOU WOULD BE
SURPRISED. HOW MANY AMAZING
PEOPLE I WORK WITH HOW SMART
THEY ARE HOW COMMITTEDTHEY ARE
WHETHER WE AGREE OR NOT. SOME
OF MY CLOSEST FRIENDS AND I
WILL BE FRIENDS WITH FOREVER
ARE REPUBLICANS PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND. HOW BIPARTISAN WE
REALLY AREN'T DOESN'T MEAN WE
HAVE TO AGREE ON EVERYTHING.
BUT WE AGREE MORE THAN WE
DISAGREE WE'RE ALL HUMANS ROB
AMERICANS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE LOVE EACH OTHER WE CARE
ABOUT EACH OTHER WE CARE ABOUT
EACH OTHER'S FUTURE EASY TO GET
LOST AND IT'S EASY TO GET MIXED
UP IN ALL. IN THE WHOLE WORLD
OF WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND US
BUT WE'RE CALIFORNIA WE ARE
BEACON. WE SET A TONE WE SET AN
EXAMPLE AND IT'S SO IMPORTANT
AT ALL OF YOU CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND I HAVE FAITH IN YOU.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU WILL AND
I'M SORRY I CAN'T BE THERE TO
CONTINUE ON THE FLIGHT WITH
YOU. BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME. TO SERVE THANKYOU
SO MUCH FOR SHOWING THE DIGNITY
AND RESPECT ESPECIALLY COMING
IN AS AND FRESHLY. NEW TWENTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD ARE YOU REALLY
DIDN'T HAVE TO SHOW ME A LOT
OF. RESPECT BECAUSE HE'S A
YOUNG KID AND I'M CERTAIN YOU
KNOW I GOT A LOT YOU KNOW WHAT
DO YOU WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
LIFE YOU TO YOUNG. TO SURF SO.
BELIEVE ME I WOULD HAVE LOVED
TO. HAVE ANY DESERVE. ONCE THIS
YEAR BUT THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE-
THIS IS WHAT'S AND- THIS IS
WHAT MATTERS. I FEAR THAT I MAY
HAVE CAREER PEAKED. TOO SOON IN
MY LIFE BECAUSE- I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY ENJOY. ANYTHING ELSE
AS MUCH AS I ENJOY THIS- BUT I
AM GOING TO ENJOY SPENDING TIME
WITH MY FAMILY. SO THANK YOU.
FOR ALL YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR RESPECT IT WAS MY
HONOR TO SERVE. YOU TO SERVE
WITH YOU. CABELA'S. WE HAVE ONE
MORE. GLORIA MISTER MULLIN AND-
WE CALM DOWN MISTER SPEAKER YES.
DO YOU WANT TO PRESENT IN ALSO
YES MISS WALDRON AND DEPLORE.
WE WANT TO PRESENT THIS. IT
BEARS ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURES SIGNATURES
AS A TOKEN OF OUR APPRECIATION
OR GRATITUDE YOU ALWAYS
GOVERNMENT JORDY LEADERS TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SERVING
KNOW YOUR DISTRICT BUT ALSO THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANKS VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
OF THREE BY MR STONE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE HR ONE OH
THREE. SEPARATE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE OF THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA BAR EXAMINATION MR
STONE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS ONE LAST
HOPEFULLY PIECE OF BUSINESS
THAT'S ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
STATE BAR EXAM HAS SAID A
CERTAIN STANDARD FOR PASSAGE OF
THAT EXAM AND THROUGH COURT
RECENTLY PARTLY BASED ON OUR
ASKING THEM TO DO SO LOWERED
THE SCORE. WHICH INDICATES
PASSING WHAT THIS RESOLUTION
DOES IS ASK THEM TO LOOK BACK
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
BECAUSE IF THIS SCORE IS GOOD
ENOUGH FOR. TEST TAKERS NOW IT
SHOULD BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR TEST
TAKERS OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
THE FIVE YEARS IS THERE BECAUSE
THAT IS BY THEIR OWN RULES. THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THE SUPREME
COURT IS WILLING TO LOOK BACK
TO. LOOK AT WHO IS QUALIFIED TO
PRACTICE LAW IN CALIFORNIA AND
BY LOWERING THAT SCORE. THE
BENEFIT OF THAT IS THAT WE WILL
NOW SEE MORE. APPLICANTS OF
COLOR. IN CALIFORNIA COME INTO
THE RANKS OF PRACTICING LAW SO
FROM A VERY DIVERSITY
STANDPOINT. FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF BRINGING QUALIFIED ATTORNEYS
DID TO CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT RESOLUTION WE
CANNOT PASS THIS IS A LOSS OF
THE RESOLUTION IS ASKING THE
SUPREME COURT. TO RECONSIDER
THEIR DECISION AND I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON HR ONE OF THREE.
ENGLISHTOWN.
SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION. WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE. ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE HOUSE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE CAN
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME HANG ON JUST ONE SECOND
WAS MENTIONED. THIS IS VOTE
CHANGES. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOUR
RECOGNIZE. AT AB EIGHT FORTY
ONE I TO NOT VOTING. VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY ONE I TO NOT VOTING. MR
MATHIS. YES VOTE CHANGE AB
EIGHT FORTY ONE I TO KNOW.
MATHIS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY ONE I TO KNOW. MR LEVINE
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN NO
TWO I. LEVINE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN NO T<c.cyan></c>
MISTER FLORA. AB. SIX THIRTY
NINE. NO TWO HI. FLORA ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY NINE NO TÁI.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
WE STILL HAVE ONE BILL THAT WE
ARE WAITING. ACTION FOR ACTION
IN THE SENATE SO PLEASE STAY ON
THE GREEN CARPET WE'RE
ENTERTAINING VOTE CHANGES AT
THIS TIME. MS CLARK SILVA. SB
ONE FOUR FIVE I TO KNOW VOTE.
OR NON VOTE SORRY QUIRK SILVA
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY FIVE I TO
NOT VOTING. AND THEN ONE MORE-
AB TEN SIXTY SIX NON VOTE TO
BUY. KROQ SILVA ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN SIXTY SIX NOT VOTING T<c.cyan>.</c>
MISTER MURATSUCHI. MURATSUCHI
AB. TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE ALL
RIGHT TO KNOW. MURATSUCHI
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE I TO KNOW. MISTER
DAVID CHIU. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE I DO NOT VOTING. MISTER
GIBSON. GIPSON FOLLOW NUMBER
SIXTY SIX S. B. NINE OH EIGHT
FROM HEIGHTS AND NOT VOTING.
GIPSON SENATE BILL NINE OH
EIGHT I TO NOT LOADING. M. IS
REYES. RAY IS AB. EIGHT NINE
ZERO. I TO NOT VOTING. RADIUS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY I TO
NOT VOTING. MISTER RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE I DO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
I TO NOT VOTING. MR HOLDEN. SB
EIGHT NINETY OUR WORD. I DO NOT
VOTING. HOLDEN SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINETY I TO NOT VOTING.
DR CHEN. THANK YOU SPEAKER AB
THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT NO TO
NOT VOTING. CHEN ASSEMBLY GO
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT NO TO NOT
VOTING. SB ONE THREE EIGHT
THREE KNOWN TO NOT VOTING. CHEN
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE NO TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS
TO ENACTED VOTE CHANGES PLEASE
ALSO MAKE THOSE CHANGES AT THE
KIOSK. A PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT PLEASE. MAKE YOUR
VOTE CHANGES AT THE KIOSK AS
WELL WE HAVE AN ACCURATE RECORD.
MISTER CHANG CAN YOU PLEASE PUT
THAT MICROPHONE THANK YOU
WONDERFUL.
MEMBERS WE ARE
AWAITING ONE MORE BILL FROM THE
SENATE WHILE WE ARE IDOLING
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
AS WE CAN CONCLUDE THIS TWO
YEAR SESSION. AS YOU KNOW
MEMBERS THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED IN THE CHALLENGES
WE HAVE FACED WHEN IT COMES TO
CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT AS YOUR SPEAKER
PRO TEM TO RECOGNIZE BOTH. OUR
CHIEF CLERK IN ARCHIE SERGEANT
AS THIS YEAR HAS CONSISTED OF
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES. DURING THEIR
FIRST YEAR. IN THEIR NEW
POSITIONS FIRST I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO THANK OUR CHIEF
CLERK SUE PARKER AND THE REST
OF THE DESK STAFF. AS THEY HAVE
PLAYED A CRUCIAL ROLE. ALL
ACROSS. THE BOARD THE BODY OF
THE ASSEMBLY. PROCESSING
HUNDREDS OF BILLS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR IT WOULD SIMPLY NOT BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THEM MEMBERS A
FULL ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR OUR
ASSEMBLY CLERK'S STAFF. AND I
ALSO WANT TO GIVE OUR SINCERE
THANKS TO OUR NEWISH CHIEF
SERGEANT LISA BUCKLEY OF THE
REST OF OURS ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS
THE SERGEANTS HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO HELP US GET
THROUGH OUR WORK LOAD IN AN
EFFICIENT MANNER. AND KEEP OUR
CHAMBERS CLEAN AS WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC
HERE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THANKING OUR ASSEMBLY. FOR
MISTER CALDERON YOU HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL WORKFORCE. YES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST- THANK
YOU TO YOU YOU ARE THE BEST IN
THE BUSINESS- I SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN IS
ABSOLUTELY SECOND BEST. IN THE
BUSINESS OF PLEASE THANK YOU
JOIN ME IN THANKING OUR PRO
TEM'S. THEY'RE AMAZING WORK.
REBECCA AND SHE'S GOT THAT
SPEED HE'S GOT THAT SPEED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD GLORIA
WHAT I'D GIVE TO THIS
INSTITUTION VAST MAJORITY WHERE
WE HAD. MY COUNTERPARTS IS THE
MAJORITY OF THE GUY WHO TAKES
OVER WHEN I COULDN'T BE ON THE
FLOOR WHEN I COULDN'T BE IN
TOWN ESPECIALLY WHEN I SPENT
ALL THAT TIME AWAY ON- MY
PATERNAL LEAVE MISTER ROB BONTA
SYSTEM MAJORITY LEADER. WELL
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
ASSISTANT WHIPS TASHA- AS WELL
AS JESSE GABRIEL THEY DID A
GREAT JOB. WEAPON VOTES GET
EVERYBODY FLOOR ON TIME. WHAT
AMAZING FOURTEEN WE HAVE I ALSO
WANT TO THANK OUR REPUBLICAN
COUNTERPART IN MY REPUBLICAN
COUNTERPART HE FLORA HELLO YOU
OBJECT TO MANY OF MY MOTIONS
THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS BEING SO
EASY TO WORK WITH THE. AND
AGAIN NO THANK YOU TO ALL THE
FLOOR TEAM ALL FLOOR STAFF AND
ALSO SOMEBODY- THAT GOES I
NOTICED QUITE A LOT BUT CARRY
CORN WELL SHE DOES A LOT OF
AMAZING THINGS IN DEALING WITH
THE SENATE. HE PROBABLY HAS THE
WORST OF IT SO PLEASE GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
AGAIN WE ARE AWAITING
ADDITIONAL ACTION. WE MAY
ENTERTAIN ADDITIONAL VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME.FOR THOSE
WHO MISSED THE FIRST ROUND.
MEMBERS THE SPEAKER WILL HAVE
SOME CONCLUDING WORDS FOR US-
AND SOME ADDITIONAL BANK USE AT
THE END OF THE SESSION. IN THE
MEANTIME MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO MR
JONES SAWYER. MEMBERS WE HAVE
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE GIVE
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO MR
JONES SAWYER PURE GERMAN IN
MEMORY MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF IVAN
ESPINOZA. IVAN ESPINOZA WAS
BORN ON DECEMBER SECOND
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO
MARGARITA FERNANDES HE WAS BY
CONSTITUENTS A BELOVED CALL
CENTER AGENT AT THE PLANNED-PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES
HEADQUARTERS. ALSO LOCATED IN
MY DISTRICT. IVAN WAS DESCRIBED
BY HIS FRIENDS AND COWORKERS AS
ALWAYS HAVING A SMILE AND READY
TO GIVE 1100% HE WAS KNOWN AS A
PERSON OF POSITIVE ENERGY WHO
WAS WHO WAS GOAL ORIENTED AND A
PILLAR OF GRACE. AND LOVE. I'VE
BEEN WAS MURDERED DEFENDING
HIMSELF AT A BUS STOP. IN MY
DISTRICT JUST APPROVED A FEW
BLOCKS AWAY FROM MY HOME. FROM
HIS HOME. ON JULY TWENTY THIRD.
HE WAS AN AMAZING SON BROTHER
AND FRIEND HE WAS LOVED BY
EVERYONE HAD THE BIGGEST HEART
AND ALWAYS MAKE SURE EVERYONE'S
TAKEN CARE OF. HE WAS TRULY A
BIG BROTHER TO EVERYONE. I EVEN
HAD A KEEN ABILITY TO CONNECT
WITH EVERYONE HE MET AND LOVED
PEOPLE VERY MUCH HE WAS ALSO AN
ARDENT SUPPORTER OF THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MISSION. I WAS VERY
PROUD TO WORK AT. ENSURING THAT
PATIENTS RECEIVE THE BEST CARE
AVAILABLE TODAY WE ARE HIM HIS
DEDICATION TO HIS FELLOW
ANGELENOS AND SEND OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS MOTHER AND
FAMILY. HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
THE MEMORY OF IVAN ESPINOZA.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY MISTER FLORES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- I RISE ACTUALLY- ACT
NOT WANTING TO DO THIS TODAY.
BECAUSE KNOWING THAT I'M
STANDING UP TO ME AS A MANAGER
IN THE MEMORY OF A DEAR FRIEND.
SENATOR TOM BERRYHILL. CENTER
BERRYHILL WAS- A FRIEND TO SO
MANY OF US HE WAS MY SENATOR.
BUT MORE THAN THAT. HE WAS A
FRIEND. ANY OF YOU THAT HAVE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH CENTER BERRYHILL KNOWS THE
MAN HE WAS HIS HEART HIS
CONSTITUENTS AND LARGELY IN
PART BECAUSE HE CAME FROM A
FAMILY THAT KNEW NOTHING BUT
PUBLIC SERVICE HIS THAT CLAIRE.
SERVED IN THIS HOUSE AS WELL AS
THE SENATE CENTER BERRYHILL
THE SENATE HIS BROTHER BILL
SERVE IN THIS HOUSE. THE BERRY
HILLS HAVE HAD A LIFETIME OF
SERVICE. AND I'LL NEVER FORGET
THE LAST COUPLE TIMES I SAW TOM
AS WE ALSO TIME. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. HIS. HE WAS TOM HE
WASN'T MOVING AS FAST AS HE
ONCE WAS. BUT ONE THING THAT
NEVER WAS WAS HIS LIGHT NEVER
DIMMED. HIS BODY WAS FAILING
HIM. HIS MIND WAS AS SHARP AS A
TACK THOUGH HIS LOVE FOR HIS
COMMUNITY HIS LOVE FOR HIS
CONSTITUENTS HIS LOVE FOR THIS
INSTITUTION. COULD NEVER BE
FAULTED AND NEVER BE DENIED. I
REALLY GROWN CLOSE TO TOM OVER
A BILL THAT WEPASSED MY FIRST
YEAR. IT WAS SOMEWHAT
CONTROVERSIAL. TOM AND I
SUPPORTED IT TOGETHER HE WAS
THE ONLY REPUBLICANS CENTER THE
DEAD. AS WE ALL KNOW. WHEN YOU
GO THROUGH HARDSHIPS WITH
PEOPLE YOU BECOME VERY VERY
CLOSE YOU RALLY AROUND YOUR
PEOPLE AND TOM AND I BECAME
VERY VERY CLOSE WE TALKED A LOT.
AND I'M GONNA SAVE SOME OF MY
TIME FOR AND OVER THE COOLEY
WANTS TO SAY SOME WORDS AS WELL.
BUT I LOVE TOM BERRYHILL. I'M
GONNA MISS HIM DEARLY. A FEW
WEEKS AGO WE TRIED TO MEET HIM
AT THE GOLF COURSE WITH SOME OF
HIS OLD FRIEND FROM SACRAMENTO.
HE SIMPLY WASN'T STRONG ENOUGH
TO DO IT. AND SADLY HE PASSED
AWAY LATE LAST WEEK. ANOTHER
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE- CENTER
CANNELLA WHEN HE CALLED AND
SAID THOMAS PASSED IT BROKE US
UP A LOT. BECAUSE WE WERE BOTH
SO CLOSE AND THOSE TWO MEN WERE
POLITICAL MENTORS IN MY LIFE SO
TOM. WE LOVE YOU. WE MISS YOU
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVES A HAD A GRATITUDE TO
YOU AND WE'RE GONNA MISS YOU
AND FOR TO TOM'S FAMILY YOU HAD
AN INCREDIBLE HUSBAND.
INCREDIBLE FATHER GRAVEL
BROTHER AND HE IS GOING TO BE
MISSED DEARLY LOVE IT ON. THANK
YOU MISTER FLORIDA MISTER
CRAWLEY YOU TWO ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS IS GERMAN AND MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO RISE
AND REMEMBER TOM BERRYHILL. AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE RELATES HIS HE
THE BERRYHILL WERE EXCEPTIONAL
PUBLIC FAMILY. SO IN THAT SENSE
ON THIS NIGHT. WHEN WE FEEL
THAT OUR WORK IS CUT OFF. WE
CAN THINK ABOUT SOMEONE WHO
JUST THEIR LIFE ENDED. CUT OFF.
ALSO ON A NIGHT WHEN WE REFLECT
UPON JUST THE RICH PERSONAL
LEGACY OF OUR MAJORITY LEADER
HIS FAMILY IN THIS PLACE TO
REFLECT UPON THE BERRY HILLS
HIGH I WAS NOT HERE WHEN. CLEAR
BERRYHILL. SERVED IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT BY EIGHTY TWO
HE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
PROPER FOOD NAG. AND I WORK FOR
A GUY NAMED LOOP HAPPENED FROM
THE PENINSULA. AND WE'RE
PROGRESS TO BERRYHILL ON ISSUES
INVOLVING COAST SIDE. DOWN THE
PENINSULA ON THE PACIFIC SIDE.
ON BERRYHILL BECAME IMPORTANT
TO ME BECAUSE HIS
SENATE-DISTRICT A VAST VAST
SENATE-DISTRICT. WHICH TYPE ONE
AS FAR SOUTH AS SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. YES SAN BENITO COUNTY
CAROLINE INCLUDED FRESNO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT ALSO
INCLUDED. MAKE A REPORT IN
RANCHO CORDOVA. I BUILT THE
CITY HALL IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
AND THAT'S CITY HALL WAS IN
TOM'S DISTRICT SO IT'S TIME
CAME NTO THE SENATE. ARE IN
TWENTY TEN I WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF TIMES HE WAS IN
TOWN TO GET TO KNOW THE
NORTHERN END OF HIS DISTRICT
OUT IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SOUTHEAST SECOND COUNTY. ERRORS
I. NOW REPRESENT. AND JUST A
MAN OF GREAT DIGNITY VERY
FRIENDLY COURSE HE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE AND SERIES
WHICH IS RIGHT OTSIDE BUT
ESTO. FOURTH GENERATION.
FARMING FAMILY. FAMILIAR WITH
THE VALLEY IN THE FOOTHILLS.
ACTIVE IN HIS COMMUNITY AND ALL
THE WAYS YOU WOULD EXPECT WITH
FOR H. OF ROTARY. THE WINE
INDUSTRY IN THAT AREA. THE
LOCAL CHAMBER. JUST KIND OF
GREW UP AND WAS A COMMUNITY
FIXTURE. AND INVOLVED ALLIES IS
PEOPLE SO JUST TAKE A VERY
OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL. OUR NEW
AD BACKWARDS AND FORWARDS. AND
VERY DEVOTED PUBLIC SERVICE AND
A LIFE THAT IS NOW STILL. AND I
ASKED RICHARD AND TOM BERRYHILL
AND. THANK YOU MR COOLEY. AGAIN
MEMBERS WE ARE AWAITING
ADDITIONAL. LEGISLATION FROM
THE SENATE. AT THIS TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON FOR SOME
WORDS AS WE CONCLUDE OUR TWO
YEAR SESSION MISTER SPEAKER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS THE SPEAKER PRO TEM
SAYS WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL FROM
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES IT'S OVER
ON THE SENATE SIDE SHOULD BE
HERE SHORTLY. BUT I WANTED TO.
SAY GOOD NIGHT AND THANK ALL OF
YOU BEFORE WE GET TO THAT SO
THAT SO THAT WE CAN JUST CLOSE
OUT ONCE THAT BILL GETS HERE.
SO TONIGHT WE'RE CLOSING OUR
200-019-2000 TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION AND IT'S ONE THAT THIS
HOUSE- ARE AND NOT NOT NOT NOT
OF US WHO SERVE HERE WILL EVER
FORGET AT CLOSING THE WORK ON.
THE YEAR ON OUR LEGISLATIVE
WORK BUT I THINK A LOT OF US
FEEL AS THOUGH WE WISH WE WERE
CLOSING THE BOOKS ON TWENTY
TWENTY ALTOGETHER. IT HAS BEEN
A VERY PAINFUL AND DIFFICULT
YEAR FOR A LOT OF US FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR AMERICANS. I
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED WORK AND YOUR
DEDICATION THROUGH. SOME
INCREDIBLE OBSTACLES I WE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT THE SPANISH LOOTED
THAT. STRUCK THE PLANET A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO AND I. THINK
A LOT OF US. EARLY ON WONDERED
WHAT IT MUST HAVE BEEN LIKE. TO
HAVE SERVED- DURING THAT TIME
WE HAVE ENTERED SOMETHING OF.
OUR UNPARALLELED. IN OUR
HISTORY. AND WE DID IT WE DID
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL. R. E. N.
AND WHEN I SAY ALL OF US I MEAN
ALL OF YOU- EACH OF- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ALL OF YOUR
STAFF. WERE SPECTACULAR
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR UNDER GREAT
OBSTACLES. ARE THE YEAR SHOWED
SUCH INCREDIBLE PROGRESS WHEN
WE STARTED WE- FIVE AND DID
HAVE. A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
SURPLUS WHEN THE YEAR STARTED.
AND THEN IT GOT VERY VERY
WEIRD- IN IN- IN MARCH. AND THE
YEAR TURNED INTO SOMETHING THAT
WE COULDN'T HAVE ANTICIPATED.
WE DIDN'T EXPECT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO REWRITE THE HISTORY
BOOKS- ON ON HOW WE ARE GOING
TO GOVERN AS AN INSTITUTION. WE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO FALL
ILL I'M SADDENED BY WHAT WE'VE
GONE THROUGH- BUT I'M GRATEFUL
FOR WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IN TERMS
OF FACING THIS CHALLENGE. YOUR
WORK HAS HELPED TO EASE THE
PSYCHIC AND ECONOMIC STRAIN.
I'M CALIFORNIA AND ITS PEOPLE.
YOU SACRIFICE NOT ONLY YOUR
TIME BUT A LOT OF YOU
SACRIFICED KEY POLICY
INITIATIVES THIS YEAR HE POLICY
INITIATIVES THAT MEANT A LOT TO
YOU AND THAT YOU HELD DEAR. AND
YOU ALL DID THAT FOR THE FOR
THE GREATER GOOD SO THANK YOU.
MY THANKS AGAIN GOES OUT TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE. IT'S A-
PERHAPS A CLICHE BUT WE KNOW
THAT IT CAN'T BE DONE. WITHOUT
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF HELP AND
WE HAVE THAT KIND OF HELP HERE
IN THIS BUILDING- I WAS OUT
SICK I CALL IN SICK FOR THE
FIRST TIME. IN IN THIS JOB IN.
IN EARLY FEBRUARY AND I WAS
HOME. AND I MUST'VE BEEN REALLY
BORED ONE DAY BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY WATCHED THE ASSEMBLY
ON ON THAT TELEVISION- AND WHAT
WAS SO COOL WAS BEING ABLE TO
WATCH KEVIN MULLIN DO HIS JOB.
OUR KEVIN IS SO TALENTED AND SO
GRACEFUL IN ALL THAT HE DOES
THE WAY HE MANAGES THIS HOUSE
THE WAY HE KEEPS US GOING. YOU
ARE ONE OF A KIND KEVIN THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR. TV THIS
MUCH MUCH BETTER SOUTH PARK. I
ALSO WANT TO FAKE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM REBEKAH BAUR
CARE. FOR HER THERE SHOULD.
ALWAYS WILLING TO FILL IN AT A-
MOMENT'S NOTICE OF THANK YOU
REBEKAH. ARE ELDER STATESMEN
THE MAJORITY LEADER IAN
CALDERON THANK YOU. GOOD THINGS
INSTEAD OF THE UNITED OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH IT. I WANT TO
THANK MY BODY- MARIE WALDRON-
WE- MARIE AND I. HAVE A
STANDING FOR- FRIDAY MORNING AT
ELEVEN THIRTY AM CALL- IT'S ONE
THIRD HALF HOUSE BUSINESS ONE
THIRD CATCHING UP. YOUR WORK
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE IT'S BEEN
GREAT SERVING WITH YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MARIE. THE ALSO A
PLEASURE TO THINK SUE PARKER
WHERE IS. TO TWO TWO IS TAKEN
UP THE MANTLE OF CHIEF CLERK
THIS YEAR AND SHE'S SHOWN THAT
SHE'S DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB
THANK YOU SAM. I AM. YEAH
EXISTENCE. HEY WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO THANK ALL THOSE WHO
STAFF THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK. WE KNOW THAT THE DESK
CLERK FROM FLOOR UNIT THEY WORK
LATE AT NIGHT SO THAT WHEN WE
SHOW UP IN THE MORNING
EVERYTHING IS READY TO GO THEY
DO THE MECHANICAL WORK- THAT
DOES THE MAJORITY- THAT HELPS
TO MAKE THE MAJORITY. LEADER'S
JOB A LITTLE BIT EASIER SO
THANK YOU. ALSO STEPPING IN
THIS YEAR WAS CHIEF SURGEON
ARMS ALYSSA BUCKLEY THANK YOU.
MELISSA HAS NOT ONLY DONE A
GREAT JOB BUT SHE- TAKES.
SPECIAL CARE AND IT'S VERY
PERSONAL TO HER I THINK THERE.
HAVE BEEN PROTESTERS I BELIEVE
SIX CONSECUTIVE NIGHTS AT MY
HOME- AND IT THAT. DON'T
RELEASE ALMOST SORT OF
INTERNALIZES THAT DID IT YEAH
YOU CAN TELL. HOW MUCH IT
BOTHERS HER THAT SHOWS WITH A
CREDIBLE PERSON SHE IS THANK
YOU IT WAS A- GREAT ADDITION TO
OUR TO OUR TEAM. I HER STAFF
HAS BEEN REPEATEDLY TESTED OVER
THE LAST YEAR. AND HAS
REPEATEDLY COME THROUGH SO
THANK YOU. BUT APPARENTLY THEY
WERE. JUST GETTING. UP ALSO
WANT TO THANK OUR CHAPLAIN THE
REV AND PADDY O'SHEA THANK YOU
PATTY. ONE OF MY FRIENDS TO THE
CAPITAL C. H. P. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THANK YOU SEE H. B. AND GENERAL
FOR. THE SECURITY AND
MAINTENANCE FUNCTIONS ARE
EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO THE WORK
WE DO AS WELL MY SINCERE THANKS
TO DEBRA GRAVERT AND HER RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF THANK YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO GET DEEP THANKS TO
MY STAFF- STARTING WITH MY
CHIEF OF STAFF KERRY CORN WELL
THANK YOU SO. REALLY DOES
AMAZING WORK AND MY ENTIRE TEAM
MOST OF WHOM IS BACK HERE THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU
DO THANK YOU. SENATE DOING THAT
NOW. IT'S COMMON OKAY IT'S
COMMON- PLUS KEVIN DE LEóN IS
STILL GETTING HIS WRAP UP
SPEECH IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SO WE GOT TIME. OUR
WITH AT ALL I'LL BRING IT TO A
CLOSE OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SOME
FOLKS WHO ARE LEADING THIS YEAR
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BUT
WHEN WE COME BACK IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HOPE THAT
THE WORLD WILL LOOK SOMETHING
LIKE LIKE THE ONE THAT THAT.
THAT WE KNEW LAST YEAR- BUT IF
NOT I KNOW THAT WILL ALL BE UP
TO THE CHALLENGE WHAT WHATEVER
I TWENTY TWENTY ONE BRINGS.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
WILL DIGRESS THERE WHEN YOU GET
EMOTIONAL YOU FORGET CERTAIN
THINGS- WHEN YOU GIVE A SPEECH
AND I WAS PRETTY MUCH MY GET MY
TRIBUTE- BUT I WANTED TO ADD
ONE MORE THING IF I COULD JUST
FOR A MOMENT- AND THAT IS
MISTER SPEAKER- YOU TOOK A
CHANCE ON ME. WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE A CHANCE ON ME TO
MAKE ME THE MAJORITY LEADER AND
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKED.
PROBABLY TO ABOUT. ME IN THAT
pPOSITION- AND YOU HAD FAITH IN
ME. AND YOU BELIEVED IN ME. AND
THAT MEANT THE WORLD TO ME
BECAUSE I HAVE EVERYTHING THAT
I. COULD HAVE DONE IN THIS
HOUSE THIS IS WHAT I BELIEVED.
I WAS THE BEST SUITED FOR
BECAUSE I TRULY CARE ABOUT THE
OPERATIONS HOUSE AND HOW TO GET
IT DONE. BUT WE WENT THROUGH A
LOT OF THINGS DURING THAT
SPEAKERSHIP RACE AND GETTING
HIM TO WHERE HE HAS TO BE OUR
LEADER- BUT I WILL SAY THE
REASON WHY I SUPPORTED HIM
EARLY ON IT WAS WILLING TO DO
WHATEVER IT TOOK TO MAKE SURE.
HE BECAME SPEAKER. WAS BECAUSE
OF HIS INTENTIONS AND WHY HE
WANTED TO BE IN THAT POSITION.
IT'S EASY WHEN YOU BECOME- YOU
GET IN POWER TO LET THE TITLE
AND EVERYTHING THAT COMES WITH
THAT TITLE- THAT BE THE
MOTIVATION FOR YOU SEEKING THAT
POSITION- AND FOR HIM IT WAS
NEVER ABOUT THE TITLE WAS NEVER
ABOUT WHAT CAME WITH THAT
POSITION. THAT MOTIVATED HIM TO
WANT TO BECOME THE SPEAKER. AND
THAT WAS BECAUSE THAT WAS WHY.
I SUPPORTED HIM BECAUSE HE
WANTED IT FOR THE RIGHT REASONS
HE WANTED IT BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFERENCE THAT HE CAN MAKE BY
BEING IN. THAT POSITION. AND I
ALSO WANTED FOR HIM BECAUSE HE
WAS MY FRIEND. HE HAS A GOOD
HEART HE WANTS TO DO THE RIGHT
THINGS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STAND WITH YOUR
FRIENDS. AND HELP THEM ACHIEVE
THEIR GOALS AND HELP THEM
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS. SO I
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD THE SUCCESS
THAT I'VE HAD IN SACRAMENTO I
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD THE TIME
THAT I'VE HAD IN SACRAMENTO.
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT I'VE HAD
THE AMAZING TIME THAT I'VE HAD
UP HERE WITHOUT HIM. TAKING
THAT STEP TO BELIEVE IN ME AT A
TIME WHEN I KNOW. IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR HIM. TO MAKE THAT
DECISION TO BELIEVE IN ME. YOUR
MY FRIEND FOR LIFE. I WILL
RESPECT YOU ALWAYS. I AM HAPPY.
I'M COMFORTABLE LEAVING KNOWING
THAT THAT THE STATE AT LEAST OF
THIS HOUSE IS IN YOUR HANDS. I
LOVE YOU MORE THAN YOU WILL
EVER UNDERSTAND THANK YOU FOR
BELIEVING IN ME. THANK YOU
MEMBERS IF I COULD JUST BRIEFLY
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION I WOULD
LIKE TO- IT KNOWLEDGE MY STAFF
AND IN PARTICULAR LARA FITZ
GERALD. IN THE CORNER WHO IS MY
FLOOR TEAM. STAFF PERSON SHE
KEEPS ALL OF OUR TRAINS RUNNING
ON TIME THANK YOU LAURA. FOR
YEARS. MEMBERS WE ARE AWAITING
ACTION FROM THE SENATE. WE DO
HAVE THE BILL. AND WE ALSO HAVE
A PROCEDURAL MOTION. YOUR BILL
CHANGES MAY COME LATER MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ALL
RIGHT FROM MY LAST MOTION
MISTER SPEAKER AND I APPRECIATE
THIS. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW US IN THE MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY TO TAKE UP AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE MISS A YEAR
CURRYS MEASURE. AB ONE SIX
EIGHT CARBERY. ASSEMBLY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS FROM AN
ACCOLADE IN LAND USE TO CLEARLY
YEARS EITHER OF TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY PROJECT
TIMELINES AND TRIGGER SB THREE
THIRTY PROTECTIONS WHAT A
PROJECT UP A KID SUBMITS THEIR
NOTICE OF INTENT TO A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS BILL RESTORES
TRIBAL RIGHTS TO CONSULTATION
ON POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT WERE
ELIMINATED BY SB FIVE. THIS
BILL IS A CRITICAL STEP IN
PROTECTING INDIGENOUS CULTURE
AND RELIGION IN OUR STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEE
NO DISCUSSION OF BAIT ON THE
ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE MEMBERS
VOTE THEIR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THAT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WERE RESERVE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
AN ITEM ON CALL. LOCAL POSTS.
THIS IS SB FIFTY FOUR. CLERK
WILL CLOSER ROLE. TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN THOSE
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE FAILS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO JOIN ROLE
FIFTY ONE I MOVE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED FOR THE
FINAL RECESS TO BE ALLOWED BY
ADJOURNMENT SINE DIE A ON
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY PURSUANT TO ART ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION THREE A. OF THE
CONSTITUTION. YOU CAN HEAR NO
OBJECTION MISTER CALDERON MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
AND WILL CONVENE FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION ON
MONDAY DECEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
MATHIS VOTE CHANGE AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX I AM NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS ASSEMBLY GO FIFTEEN OH
SIX I TO NOT VOTING. THE VOTE
CHANGING FIFTEEN AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX FROM MIDDLE TO HIGH. D.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH SIX NO
TO ON. AGUIAR-CURRY VOTE CHANGE
AB EIGHT FOUR ONE I DID NOT
VOTING. AGUIAR-CURRY SOME BILL
IT ONE I TO VOTING.